hey everyone this is Shruti from Simply
learn welcome to this video on the
digital marketing full course for 2021
in this full course we'll be covering
topics like what is digital marketing
the tools used in digital marketing the
basic concepts on SEO Google tag manager
Google ads social media marketing
Facebook ads YouTube Instagram and
Twitter marketing content marketing
email marketing affiliate marketing
marketing hacks digital marketing skills
careers and much more for this video we
have our experts Rob and Rahul taking us
through all the topics so without
further Ado let's start by talking about
digital marketing before we begin make
sure to subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the Bell icon to never miss an
update from Simply learn
meet Joey a digital marketer he works as
the head of digital marketing for Amazon
but how did Joey get here a few years
ago Joey began to see a large number of
opportunities popping up in the field of
digital marketing to begin his entry
into the field he needed to understand
what exactly digital marketing was and
what was so great about it first Joey
learned that digital marketing was a
form of marketing through which you
could advertise to people digitally
digital marketing leveraged different
channels like search engines websites
social media platforms emails and mobile
applications it would give marketers the
opportunity to interact with and
understand their audience better and to
increase the trust in their Grant
digital marketing would also show
marketers advertisements to People based
on their actions and preferences on the
internet while being less expensive than
traditional forms of advertising after
understanding the main concepts of
digital marketing Joey realized there
was more to digital marketing than he
initially thought there are also many
types of digital marketing types like
content marketing search engine
optimization pay-per-click social media
marketing email marketing and affiliate
marketing and once he understood those
types he set up a digital marketing
campaign for his uncle's e-commerce
website let's have a look at what he
came up with first Joey created content
like blogs videos infographics and case
studies so that he could generate
audience interest in the Brand's
products or services
this was content marketing next he
needed his audience to actually see his
content the first step was to create
content on specific Search keywords that
were relevant to the target audience
Joey would make optimizations on the
website and have credible websites
linking back to the content and lo and
behold the website began ranking on the
first page of the search results
by continuous optimizations Joey would
continue to improve the ranking and
ultimately make the website rank at the
first position this was SEO or search
engine optimization and Joey could do
all of this without spending a single
penny he could also Drive traffic to the
website with advertisements but for this
he would have to pay a certain fee each
time the ads were clicked he could have
text ads that show up in search engine
results image ads and video ads that
show up in websites and much more
this was possible with the help of PPC
or pay-per-click however Joey wasn't
done yet to reach a larger audience he
needed to tap into social media
platforms
he would use social media platforms like
LinkedIn YouTube Facebook and Instagram
to advertise the Brand's content
he would use these platforms to
advertise the Brand's products or
services with posts images videos and
more to bring out the Brand's story and
engage with the Brand's audience who
spend a lot of time on social media like
PBC he could use the platform to
advertise the Brand's products or
services with text image and video ads
which needed to be paid for that's
social media marketing Joey realized
that a large amount of the audience
weren't visiting the Brand's website a
second time he needed to keep them
engaged nurture them to make sure they
purchased the product for this he would
send them emails that help them better
understand the products they visited on
the website and assist them in the
buying process he would also send emails
to advertisers products or services to
potential customers that is with email
marketing and finally although Joey was
able to grow the Brand's funnel he
wanted more traffic from third-party
websites this could be achieved with
affiliate marketing Affiliates would
promote the brand or product to their
audiences for a fee with the help of
email signups registrations conversions
subscriptions
Etc
after setting all of this up Joey had
the hardest part of the process to get
through the wait
although Joey had worked really hard on
each of these forms of digital marketing
he only had moderate success that's when
Joey realized he had to gain more
knowledge and experience so he decided
to get certified and get ahead in his
career with the help of Simply learn he
took up simply learns digital marketing
certification and got the skills and
training he needed to become an expert
digital marketer and now you know where
he is you too can do the same and grow
in your career by clicking on the top
right corner and with that we've given
you an introduction to all the major
concepts of digital marketing greetings
everyone this is Rob Sanders and today
we're going to talk about what is
digital marketing so thanks for joining
us here at simply learn and let's get
started let's start talking about why
digital marketing is important so let's
start there on the Y so if we're just a
fly on the wall and we're in an office
environment we're looking at two friends
having a conversation about digital
marketing so so really if we're
listening in everybody every marketer is
using digital marketing for his or her
business now does your marketing has
become more popular than traditional
marketing that's not a surprise so in
response hey over the past few decades
digital marketing has evolved at a rapid
Pace these days a lot of people spend
most their time on the internet so what
happens in the internet every 60 seconds
well a lot happens every 60 seconds so
according to Social Media today I mean
there's a lot of snaps there's a lot of
clicks there's a lot of text there's a
lot of videos watched there's a lot of
pictures being taken there's a lot of
voice activated activity going on a lot
of tweets emails swipes there's a lot
going on here in 60 seconds so there's a
lot of activity on the internet a lot
and and so the one gentleman says hey
can you also mention a few differences
between digital and traditional
marketing systems and then the expert
responds of course I can certainly
clarify a few differences between
digital and traditional and so he goes
on to say what the differences are
between traditional and digital and
let's look at that okay so on
traditional marketing we're talking
about print radio billboard newspaper TV
anything that's not on your mobile or
laptop so we know what traditional
marketing reaches limited with digital
marketing reaches maximum and what we
mean by that is hey when you print
something you're printed it for x amount
of people if you're trying to promote an
event and you basically create a
thousand Flyers okay you figure that's
going to a thousand people maybe it'll
share it so you're looking about 2 000
people maybe just to be generous well
digital marketing we're promoting that
we can promote it to a whole lot of
people depending on the platform so 2000
is nothing when you're targeting an
audience on Facebook or Google search
traditional marketing non-versatile and
with digital marketing very versatile so
again going back to our flyer printing
an eight and a half by eleven okay
that's it you know with with digital
marketing running display banners you
have 468 by 60 200 by 200 250 by 250 300
by 300 I mean the list goes on on the
types of different display sizes not to
mention text ads not to mention video or
multimedia so there's a lot you can do
to get your message out there okay with
traditional it's always delayed
communication okay so meaning if you're
trying to get that TV spot there might
not be a spot open until one in the
morning okay well with digital marketing
there is no hours okay you can certainly
get your point out there and have people
see it instantaneously so with
traditional marketing there's a lack of
real-time results I mean this seems like
uh it's obvious but you know digital
marketing that's one of the biggest
benefits instant real-time results
instant okay nowadays we're going to
analytics you can look at real time
reporting okay so we could see real time
results okay traditional marketing can
be very costly I mean if you're not only
doing postcards and printing postcards
but you have to mail those postcards so
there's postage fees we're with digital
marketing it's very very very cost
efficient I mean meaning you could pick
and choose who you want to Target one
you want to Target where you want to
Target what you want to Target and if
you're doing search you can put your
bidding in place you can put your hours
in place you can really control how much
you actually spend so that's amazing one
of the biggest advantages to digital
marketing not only do you get real-time
results but but you can control costs
and then obviously optimize based on the
amount of cost you're spending based on
those real-time results
with traditional marketing it's
difficult to reach a target audience you
know with digital marketing it's easy to
reach a target audience I mean you know
I don't want to bash traditional
marketing too much I mean if you're
going to put a TV ad in place you know
you're going to do it on a TV show that
tends to gear more towards your target
audience but that doesn't guarantee
anything here we can simply go to
Facebook or Twitter or LinkedIn and just
pick and choose specifically who we want
to Target when we want to Target them so
it just becomes a lot easier to reach a
targeted audience on a digital marketing
platform and then with traditional
marketing poor campaign measurement with
digital you have easy to measure and
optimize campaigns and what we really
mean by that is because you get instant
time results because you can control
costs because you can reach your target
audience more easily all those a result
of okay you can measure and optimize
based on what our audience is seeing and
how much they're spending to see it we
can quickly make adjustments in order to
optimize the campaign for better
performance so that's generally that
means that's a culmination of pretty
much everything that we've listed as a
benefit for digital marketing okay so
now why digital marketing has been
answered with all the benefits that it
carries let's talk about the what is
digital marketing so you know that you
know you want to do digital marketing so
how do we go about that what what is it
exactly well let's just Define it
digital marketing it's just the act of
promoting a company's product or an
individual's product or service with the
help of a device or technology and so
obviously when we talk about device
we're talking about maybe a laptop we're
talking about a mobile device and we
talk about technology it could be an app
it could be you know a cloud-based
platform okay it could be a piece of
software okay so a lot going on on the
digital side in terms of variations and
what you can do but that's in a nutshell
what digital marketing is you're really
just using technology to promote your
product or service so we know because of
the benefits in digital marketing you
can promote your campaign on different
platforms okay so all those benefits we
mentioned about instant real-time
results cost efficiency optimizing
campaigns you could do that on search
you could do it on social via email on
mobile apps Etc so that's what we mean
by with the help of digital advisors in
technology well these digital devices
and Technology come in the form of
search engines and emails and mobile
apps Etc so when we want to go and
promote our product or service using a
campaign we have different options so
there are different types of digital
marketing channels that we can choose
from and what's Cisco through that list
of digital marketing channels and the
first one is what I consider the king of
them all and that's SEO so SEO stands
for search engine optimization there's
search engine marketing there's email
marketing affiliate marketing social
content mobile and then we can get into
subsets of each of these digital
marketing channels but really we'll
start with SEO because that's the king
and to me that's basically increasing
the quality and quantity of relevant
organic traffic on the search engines
including Google so depending on where
you're located in the U.S market Google
tends more has a large market share so
you want your pages on your website to
be found and clicked on organically and
so that means that somebody types in a
keyword you want that relevant page to
show up first on Google so somebody can
click on that link okay and we know that
millions of people specifically in the
US but we're why do you search on a
daily basis so if you're ranking for
those relevant keywords you can imagine
how much traffic you can get okay so
that's SEO okay and here's an example so
you type in online shopping well you can
see the first listing here is a paid
search ad I'm going to get to that in a
minute the second organically is Amazon
okay so online shopping you think maybe
Walmart you think maybe Alibaba or
you're thinking probably Amazon okay so
no surprise Amazon's ranking for the
keyword online shopping and so if
somebody clicked on their listing that's
traffic for Amazon let's move on to
search engine marketing you know known
as sem or pay per click or cost per
click or PPC or CPC or sponsored search
or Google ads I mean there's a lot of
different names synonymous with sem so
search engine marketing is really just
using paid ads on search engines just as
we saw the previous example if you want
to be found for keyword you don't have
to worry about organic if you're willing
to pay for it you just bid on that
keyword and voila you have the
opportunity to appear number one in the
search results at the top of the page
for that keyword now when somebody
clicks on it you have to pay Google if
it's Google you're advertising on but
that's the beauty of search engine
marketing you can bid on keywords and
appear at the top of the search results
for that keyword example here if we go
back to online shopping well myus.com is
bidding on that keyword online shopping
so they're actually appearing above
Amazon's organic listing but that's what
they want to do they want to be found
for that keyword so if they're not
ranking for it organically well they're
bidding on it and if somebody happened
to clicked on that listing then and
myus.com is going to pay Google
something depending on what the cost per
click is and so that could be anywhere
from one penny to a hundred dollars it
depends depends on the keyword depends
on who else is bidding on the keyword
depends on the location depends on the
time of day depends on quality score
there's a lot of factors involved and
regarding what you pay however the
benefit of sem is visibility and getting
traffic to your website for keywords
you're not found for so that's why sem's
such a popular choice for a lot of
companies okay let's talk about digital
marketing that's it traditional type of
digital marketing channel it's been
around a long time you know we all send
emails on a daily basis and we probably
all receive emails on a daily basis this
is an effective way to capture leads and
convert them to customers because with
email you can personalize your emails
and you can send your emails to a
segmented audience okay so if you have
emails from females who are 35 years of
age to 44 that live and say this
southern part of the United States you
can segment that send them an email and
cater that email directly to that
audience and of course you can put some
nice call to action in there you can
design it really snazzy and you could
track it just like you can any other
digital marketing channel so email is a
very effective way to really reach a
target audience because everybody for
the most part
has a functioning email account
so basically here's an example about if
you're selling a product and the
products promotion is about to end well
you know get that email out to your
target audience let them know hey you
have until tonight to purchase a product
and if you purchase it you're gonna get
30 off and you can put the coupon code
right in there with a nice call to
action and you can measure how many
people click on that email go to that
web page and purchase the product using
that coupon code so that's an example of
email marketing okay we have affiliate
marketing so affiliate marketing is an
effective way for digital marketers to
basically create a sales force of people
so basically what you're doing is you're
getting Merchants to promote your
products and services and you're using
usually a third-party broker like
Commission Junction or cj.com as an
example to introduce you the the person
selling the product the merchant with
the affiliate so so that affiliate could
likely be a merchant him or himself and
they can basically be a good partner of
yours by publishing your product or
service on their website so that they
can sell in order to get commissions so
it's all based on a commission so you
basically are going to use a third-party
affiliate like CJ get all these
Affiliates to work for you they're going
to promote your product or service if
they do sell your product or service
you're going to pay them a commission
that's more or less how it works with
affiliate marketing and you know with
affiliate marketing to me it's a good
way to you know really promote your
product or service and you can pick and
choose the Affiliates or the Publishers
of whom you want to work with so here's
an example of affiliate marketing at
work okay you basically see a banner
basically you can see earn up to 12
advertising fees with a trusted
e-commerce leader okay so if somebody
clicked on that purchased for example or
joined you could pay off that commission
okay let's turn our attention to social
media marketing so social media
marketing you know I would say it's
fairly new I mean if I think about it
we're in 2019 and I remember talking
about Facebook back in 2006 so you're
talking about 13 14 15 years of social
media it's definitely evolved over the
years and but the concept Remains the
Same it involves creating different
types of content depending on the
platform okay so you could be on
Pinterest or Instagram and be dealing
with photos or you could be on Twitter
tweeting out certain characters up to a
limit okay so it really depends on the
social media platform uh that really
drives the type of content you're going
to promote but we know social media can
be effective because people use social
media I mean Facebook is one of the more
popular platforms and if you want to get
your product service out there you could
certainly pay to have an ad on Facebook
or you could just post your content
organically okay that's the beauty of
social most of your Social platforms
like LinkedIn and Twitter and Facebook
and Pinterest and Instagram they'll have
a paid form of advertising that you can
use to promote your product or service
or you can go the organic route and you
know post content organically in hopes
of driving traffic back to your website
so with social you do have two options
here but social is interesting because
in a lot of different social media
platforms out there it really depends on
your product or service okay so an
example of social media marketing
especially on Facebook with Facebook you
got mobile and desktop and you obviously
have the opportunity to post something
organically and have that liked or
commented on or shared or you can post
an app and get that liked commented or
shared or clicked and have people go
back to your website and fulfill the
goal of what you want them to do so
moving on to content marketing it's a
Content marketing is really an effective
way of really Distributing valuable
content online and when we talk about
content marketing you know we're talking
about different types of assets so it
could be simply text in the form of a
blog post or it could be a video or it
could be an infographic or it could be
an image okay there are lots of ways to
create content these days especially in
digital marketing and the great thing
about content marketing is you're
writing content for a targeted audience
so if you're trying to Target an
audience on say Instagram then you know
who your audience is and you know what
the type of content you're gonna post on
there so it could be in the form of a
video or infographic or just a graphic
and so that's the beauty of content
marketing really putting yourself out
there
um and depending on the platform putting
yourself out there with various types of
content so for example if we look at
YouTube you can see this video here
about digital marketing certified
associate well hey you don't need to
always write the content you can produce
the content in the form of a video and
post it on YouTube this is a form of
content marketing so that's content
marketing and then let's talk about
mobile marketing so content marketing
again different types but if we go now
to mobile marketing you can kind of
segue from content to mobile because the
only difference here is with mobile it's
strictly on mobile phone it's not
desktop so mobile marketing is really a
strategy on its own that helps you the
company promoting your product or
service to reach your target audience
through a mobile device and that
includes tablets and how you could do
that is via messaging you could do it
via email or you could be do it via an
app okay so you have different ways of
getting your content out there to people
okay so as an example you can use
basically SMS or instant messaging via
mobile devices to promote your product
or service here's another example of a
mobile marketing via app install and so
you can even compound that by running a
say Google ad as an example and running
your Google ad on say just mobile you
can do a bit adjustment just for mobile
and the goal could be app installs okay
so and you can even do a mobile or app
extension so there's lots of ways to
really promote your app or your product
or your service Via mobile marketing
okay let's talk about out the customer
life cycle so we know why we want to do
digital marketing we want to know we
want we know what the digital marketing
channels are because we just talked
about them from SEO to social to
affiliate to mobile to content to sem
okay you have a lot of different digital
marketing channels at your disposal so
now how do we go ahead and approach our
customers so that's what we're going to
talk about first so we're going to talk
about different stages of the customer
life cycle okay and the first one is the
awareness stage so we need to get our
customers aware of what we're selling or
what we're promoting okay so the
awareness stage is really what product
does your brand offer that's a question
we want to get out there and we want to
answer okay what does a customer need
your product or excuse me why does a
customer need your product that's a
question we want to answer with digital
marketing okay what solution does your
product provide okay that's an answer to
a question we want to make sure people
understand so these are questions that
we want to be able to answer in the form
of digital marketing whether that be
mobile or content okay so getting our
information out there that answers these
essential questions and if we could do
that then somebody's going to become
aware of our product or service okay so
what product does our brand offer why
does a customer need it and what
solution does it provide okay those are
some key questions that people tend to
ask themselves when they look at a brand
okay and when they look at a product hey
do I really need this is it going to
help me in my life okay and who who is
selling this I mean who is this brand I
mean that's those are just things that
run through people's mind intuitively
that with the right messaging the right
channel the right type of asset the
right targeted audience you can quickly
make somebody aware of your Brand's
product or service in this stage it's
helped potential customers discover your
brand with the help of these different
marketing channels so in the awareness
stage you know content is key so it's to
me if we have a website we need a Blog
because if somebody does come to our
blog from say organic search SEO then we
can write about that product or service
via blog and talk to our customer talk
directly to our targeted audience
through that blog and if we're not
ranking organically we can use paid
search to promote it because paid search
on Google for example basically we can
be right at the top of their search
results and so somebody can actually see
it when they do a search because we know
millions of people you search on a daily
basis you could do social media
marketing okay so you can publish that
product or service on Facebook while
you're building your community and you
can use affiliate marketing to help get
the word out by using cj.com as an
example build up a sales force of people
these Publishers that are going to put
your product or service out there so to
me in the awareness stage these are the
digital marketing channels you can focus
on now I will say one thing about
display ads display is part of search
engine marketing you could use display
because you can reach a large number of
people so even though it's listed here
low priority in the awareness stage
display ADS mean that if you're on
Google's Display Network you could pick
and choose your sites your demographics
keywords topics and audience you can
focus on all those different
demographics to really attract a large
number of people so low priority but
it's probably also good to focus on in
the awareness stage okay so content
marketing you must create a high quality
content that people are searching for
without content it's hard to get found
and so to me this is you know where the
blog comes in SEO take that content get
it optimized okay sem if we're not
ranking organically we can make sure
with the top of the paid search results
or the the search results for a
particular keyword we want to be found
for and then social media marketing
using different channels depending on
the channel we're selling you know
training like simply learn does you know
LinkedIn is a good platform for us okay
and then affiliate you know basically
building up a nice network of Publishers
to get the word out so these are all
good channels that we can focus in on so
traffic sources may include paid unpaid
social referral display email or direct
so they they could come in the awareness
stage from all different types of
channels even though you're focused on
content I mean you could still get
traffic from mobile or email so now that
we got the word out via all these
different marketing channels there's
that consideration stage so you know
people are aware of us now they're
considering us and that's kind of the
next stage in the process okay so a few
essential questions to address on the
consideration stage hey what features
make your product valuable to others and
how will I increase customer engagement
towards my product so those are answers
to questions you want to ask okay what
features make your product valuable you
want to basically separate yourself from
the competition basically that's what
you're trying to answer okay so if
you're promoting your product or service
on paid search and other people are
bidding on the same keyword how are you
going to stand out and then how will I
increase customer engagement towards my
product so for example if you're on
Facebook okay and you're trying to get
people over to your site to purchase
your product then how are you going to
improve that engagement you gotta create
something really snazzy or really it's
going to be attention grabbing or
something that's going to get them to
become aware of it that's going to set
separate your post from all the other
posts that are in somebody's Facebook
news feed okay so you really have to
work hard to really convince somebody to
get their consideration towards your
product or service so in this stage your
customer considers your product so help
them understand how your product is
valuable okay to me email works really
good here because if you have a targeted
audience this gives you the opportunity
to really answer these questions in that
particular Channel email you could
support that with a promotion and
display I think display is a good option
here too because even though you know
people are trying to become aware you
know you can really hone in and really
get them to take that next step okay
with display you can even do remarketing
so if somebody's been to your site
because they're aware of your product
they're curious you can cookie them and
remarket to them via display so display
to me is a good a good channel to use
okay so you have email mobile display
you know sem these are all you know good
channels to use on the consideration
stays especially on search because
somebody's looking for something and
they're aware of your brand then you
have the good opportunity to get them to
click on your ad especially if you're
offering a promotion and get them to
convert the goal here is to increase our
engagement so people are aware we're
moving them further along the funnel
with email marketing we have the
opportunity to promote the product by
sending an email directly to our
audience so with this stage plan your
campaigns around welcoming emails
newsletters we can talk about product
descriptions add ratings and reviews in
the email you know we really just want
to encourage people to purchase the
product that's we're trying to sway them
over so email is a good source to allow
us to do that okay so with mobile
marketing we can promote the products by
saying getting relevant messages to our
target audience display again
retargeting because we can retarget an
audience that has been to our website I
already did some research about our
brand our product or service and now
we're going to reach back out to them to
sway them so remember we want to
encourage customers to buy a product by
creating detailed articles about the
product that always helps and that's
content okay we want to opt for a
customer testimonial okay that helps
sway people and add some guest blogging
okay we can have ambassadors blog on our
behalf or we can go out and blog on
somebody else's site okay so blogging
works both ways it's ways of of showing
yourself and telling people hey we know
you're looking for this product here's
why you want to choose us okay moving on
from the consideration to the purchase
stage so they're aware of you they're
considering you and now we're on to the
purchase stage so the questions we want
to really make sure we address here are
how are my prices compared to my
competitors and is my brand more
credible than others okay so they're
considering you but that price point and
it may not even be the price it could be
the shipping for example the price could
be good but the shipping cost could be
high so you really want to do some due
diligence and research on what your
competitors are doing credibility that
goes back to the consideration stage and
testimonials you want to make sure you
have reviews and testimonials to really
Elevate what you're trying to tell
customers and that that is hey I have a
good brand I have a good product I have
a good service come buy my stuff come
buy my product and service but you
really need to support that claim you
just can't go out and say it and so
supporting that comes in the form of
what other people say and that could be
reviews that could be comments on a
social media platform it could be you
know no stars on say Yelp or Google my
business you know make sure you do your
due diligence and make sure you get
people to you know review you or provide
testimonials because people are going to
do their due diligence before they
purchase especially if it's on Google my
business or Yelp or TripAdvisor or
whatever it is you're trying to sell
they're going to be able to see those
reviews and so do your due diligence to
get the reviews and if it is a negative
review hey that's okay you can't please
everyone you're gonna get them that's
the world we live in just make sure you
show your upper hand and respond even to
the negative as well as the positive
reviews that you get that actually bodes
well to some people because hey it shows
that I made a mistake and you're willing
to correct it and so people actually see
that that could be the Tipping Point to
getting them to purchase say look hey
this brand really cares because they're
really responding people they're not
ignoring negativity okay just those
small things that can get people to
change their minds now with the purchase
stage according to e-consultancy 83 of
the online audience require
encouragement to complete a purchase
encouragement what does that mean well
it could mean providing a promo giving
them that extra incentive you know if
you don't offer promo consider it
especially on the email and the example
we looked at earlier sending out an
email means that if the promo is going
to end at midnight send that email out
and tell people they have until midnight
and if they purchase today you'll even
increase it to 20 percent and email is a
good channel for that mobile can reach a
lot of people through sms okay social
media reaching people instantaneously
and then you know really with the
purchase stage it gives prospects an
offer to help them make that purchase so
you have plenty of channels to from in
fact most of these channels the only one
really that doesn't fit the
instantaneous mode is SEO but you can
really focus on affiliate even though
that's a low priority here you can
really you know coordinate with your
Publishers who expressly those
Publishers that have proven their worth
and have sold your products in the past
you know get them to help promote it and
incentivize Their audience so let's move
on from the purchase to the purse post
purchase stage so this is after somebody
purchases
okay so some essential questions we want
to be able to address here so what
additional product could my customer buy
now that they're my customer what else
could I sell them what you know without
being too pushy could if they buy a coat
well a hat work or a pair of gloves or
you know blouse you know you want to be
able to you know push a product on your
customer but think about how you can
complement that purchases that
purchasers or customers product and then
how to improve the customer buying
experience so again this goes back to
you know what we just said about reviews
get somebody to offer a review and if
they don't give you a full complement of
five stars they only give you three and
a half stars then you know what that's
great feedback because then you can
learn from that and then the other
question is will the customer refer us
to others and if so why so that's
definitely something you want to be able
to address in the post purchasing say so
let's take a look here so with post
purchasing stage you know to me emails
at the top of this list because if
somebody purchases something you could
send a nice thank you email because if
they purchase they're giving you their
email in return because you're likely
going to be sending them the receipt via
email so email to me is a nice Channel
you can send in a nice message even you
know social media you know you can thank
your community for supporting you on
this recent campaign that you ran you
know even throw in an extra five or ten
percent on a future purchase as a thank
you and that's easily done on social
media you know you could even post a
blog you know promoting you know the
success of a product and then offering a
promotion okay so there's a lot of
things you could be doing here on the
post purchasing stage so to me even
looking at content again you could even
you know put a survey together you could
even put a survey together for for your
Affiliates okay you could even post a
poll on Facebook so it's just working in
with these different channels to get
some feedback about your product and
service so with email mobile you can
engage customers with follow-up emails
or customer care content you know with
mobile if you have somebody's mobile
number hey text them a simple thank you
goes a long way you know you could say
hey look if you're satisfied let us know
give us a call you can even in the ee
mobile text message you can put a link
to a survey send emails to active
subscribers give rewards for customer
feedback so if somebody does provide
feedback give them an extra 10 off you
know you want to be able to reward
loyalty loyalty comes in the form of a
partnership if you're giving somebody
discounts and you have a good product or
service then they're going to recognize
that they're gonna say hey look I really
like this product and they're giving me
10 I'm going to to go ahead and purchase
from these guys again so give those
discounts those active customers or on
the affiliate Network give referral
opportunities to your customers so if
it's an affiliate publisher hey if
they're getting people to your site you
know reward them or if it's an email and
you put a four to a friend get an extra
10 off it doesn't hurt because you're
incentivizing people to help you sell
your product so with social display and
content use those banner ads or use that
content that you display on social or
the blog you're gonna write to give
customers advice in order to maximize
the value of the purchase so again you
can use these platforms to also enhance
what they purchased so hey you just
purchased this product thank you very
much did you know you could do this this
and this with it and so that's the idea
of a post purchase stage is to maximize
these channels to be able to answer
those essential questions about what
else could they purchase you know do
they like how do I get these people to
become loyal customers okay so with the
first purchase stage if a customer has
bought a pair of sports shoes for
example running shoes you can recommend
cross product sale across sale it could
be a pair of shorts or a water bottle or
an accessory with an exclusive discount
so that's another example what you can
do on the post purchase stage today
we're going to talk about digital
marketing tools so fasten your seat
belts and let's get started so what
we're going to do is we're going to take
a look at some of the best digital
marketing tools for not only 2019 but
ones that have performed well in the
past that are popular and ones that we
foresee as being the go-to tools for the
future so past present and future
digital marketing tools is the way to
look at this uh with a good focus on a
lot of different marketing channels here
so we're going to focus first on SEO so
talk about some of the tools related to
on page and off page we're going to
switch over to paid search talk a little
bit about paid search tools we're going
to talk about email marketing and some
of the email marketing platforms and the
tools within those platforms the center
of it all is web analytics so Google
analytics is the tool we'll be taking a
closer look at in today's webinar and
all that it has to offer okay affiliate
marketing we'll talk about some of the
tools available to you in for affiliate
marketing we'd be remiss we didn't talk
about social media and all that it has
to offer and all the metrics and tools
available all the platforms available so
we'll hone in on a couple of examples
there and then we'll also talk about
some competition tools available for you
so there's a whole Suite of tools the
one caveat being hey if you have your
favorite tool continue using it fact if
there's a tool that we didn't mention in
today's webinar feel free to mention it
in the comment box below this video we'd
love to hear what you're using to manage
your particular digital marketing
channel okay and so the goal for today's
webinar is hey we hope you get something
out of this in terms of using new tools
there's some tools that I use some tools
that my colleagues use everybody uses
different tools so it'd be good to kind
of see what else is out there so if you
have something to share share it by all
means what we're trying to do is share
what we think are you know best
practices and some of the most popular
or most used tools out there in the
industry so that's what we're going to
do the goal is to get you to better
understand some of the tools we're using
a little bit more detail and what we're
going to do is start out with search
engine optimization okay so search
engine optimization or organic search we
have a mixture of paid and free so
there's a lot of different platforms but
if you're focusing on SEO you certainly
need to use an SEO platform so there's
sem Rush okay you also have Google
search console which is free so if you
don't have a SEO platform you definitely
need to be using Google search console
and so we'll take a closer look at that
there's Google Keyword Planner which is
actually situated under Google ads and
so if you're running Google campaigns on
Google search Network or even the
Display Network you have access to a
great tool called Keyword Planner and if
you know anything about SEO you'll know
that using Google's Keyword Planner is a
good tool so we'll take a look at that
Moz is a freemium tool meaning they have
a free trial that you can sign up for to
test drive it but it's another SEO
platform and it does cost money got a
great tool in screaming frog that's a
paid version again not too expensive
we'll talk a little bit more about that
and then we have you know a tool in
hrefs that help us with all aspects of
SEO primarily focusing on off page so
these are just some examples that we're
going to hone in on but this is just a
small subset of what really is available
out there in the market so let's go
ahead and dive a little bit deeper and
understand why we use some of these
tools well the first reason when we talk
about SEO is to find relevant keywords
not only do we want to find relevant
keywords we want to find relevant
keywords with high volume and low
competition okay we wouldn't want to
find non-relevant keywords with high
competition low volume that wouldn't
make sense so we need a tool to kind of
help us put it all together and so the
tool of choice for us is Google's
Keyword Planner and Google's Keyword
Planner helps us hone in on keywords we
may be interested and optimizing for
because not only one are they relevant
but two they're going to have high
volume and low competition so let's take
a look at an example in Google's
keyboard planner so here I am I'm in
Google's Keyword Planner and as I
mentioned before Google's Keyword
Planner is situated under Google ads
okay so you have to have a Google ads
account to use Google's Keyword Planner
and so when you're in Google ads you
simply go to tools and then under Tools
you're going to select Keyword Planner
so what we want to do is look for
keywords we're focusing on organic
search not necessarily paid search so
organic search we want to hone in on
some keywords so let's just use one of
the examples that Google's given us here
meal delivery so we're gonna just type
in mail delivery and get some results so
notice I can enter a domain as a filter
and so in other words hey I can say look
hone in on keywords related to this
website if I wanted to but I'm asking
Google hey just give me something
closely related to mail delivery because
that's my business so I'm going to click
click get results notice I can add
another key to it if I wanted to but I'm
just going to stick with one keyword but
there are certainly other keywords that
I can certainly hone in on if mail
delivery is my business and so let's
just hone in on that one keyword mail
delivery we want to be found organically
for that keyword so what Google Keyword
Planner does is not only give us the
keyword and other keywords relevant to
that but it gives us the average monthly
search volumes and this is an average
over the course of the last 12 months
and notice here I get a column for
competition so I'm able to see whether
that's a very competitive keyword or not
and then just to give you an extra Edge
when you're choosing keywords you can
get a sense of what the keyword May cost
if you wanted to bid on that for paid
search so for mail delivery I can see
it's anywhere between
7.46 and at the top of the page high
range
16.61 so that should alert me to the
fact that hey if I'm gonna try and
optimize for this keyword I know it's
competitive because not only Google is
telling me it's competitive by telling
me high competition but I know that the
cost per click seems a little bit high
and what is a little bit High well you
know I can see some other keywords here
that you know a dollar to three dollars
okay I could see some other ones that
are even lower than the seven dollars
they're suggesting so that's a
indication that the keyword is highly
competitive so the idea here using
Google's Keyword Planner is one we want
to get an idea of what other keywords
are out there that are relevant so it
helps stimulate some ideas for relevancy
to 2 we can get an average monthly
search volume so we want to know on
average over the past 12 months how many
search queries I can expect from this
keyword and then three I can get a sense
of the competition how competitive is
this keyword so if I try to optimize for
this keyword and I want to rank for it
organically is it competitive if it's
competitive then it's probably going to
take me a bit longer to be found for
this keyword on page one of Google so
that's the whole idea behind Google's
Keyword Planner and note that you could
change some of the settings here so if
you want to choose a different language
okay you can hone in on a longer or
shorter period of time you can even
choose a specific location so I chose
taxes I can certainly choose the entire
United States to get a sense of what the
volume would be for the total us so you
have settings that you can change and
manipulate to get you the data you need
to choose keywords so that's the whole
idea behind Google's Keyword Planner to
find relevant keywords high volume low
competition now alternatively I can
certainly use another tool to find
keywords so I have a Moz account so I
logged into Moz and Moz has a tool
called keyword Explorer so if I use that
same keyword I used in Google's Keyword
Planner mail delivery I'm going to ask
Moz to give me some data on that keyword
so this is for the entire United States
and again I can change that if I wanted
to okay so I can hone in on a specific
country or different country so what Moz
has told me hey for this keyword in the
entire United States I'm looking at
anywhere from eleven and a half thousand
to thirty thousand on monthly volume now
what Moz does is they give you a
difficulty score so a difficulty score
is a score between 1 and 100 and and so
I could say this is pretty much right
down the middle in terms of difficulty
okay so if it's zero it's an easy
keyword if it's not if it's a hundred
it's very difficult and then that means
you have a lot of competitors who are
optimizing for this keyword that are
ranking for this keyword and so Moz
gives us the volume they give us the
competition and they just like Google's
Keyword Planner gives us some other
keywords that we can potentially hone in
on so here I could see keyword delivery
plans delivery services
Etc so I can see a lot more suggestions
than what's listed here so Moz delivers
a bunch of other analysis related to the
keyword you know they also give you some
good keyword suggestions so Moz is a
good alternative tool and we'll be
coming back to Moz related to SEO for
some other of its features but for now
if you don't want to necessarily use
Google's Keyword Planner because maybe
you're not running Google ads you can
always use Moz don't remember Moz has
basically a freemium version I mean you
can sign up for a free account and you
can sign up for a free account as a test
trial and you could test it for a period
of days and leverage its tools during
that free trial to get a better sense of
how these tools work so we want to be
able to use Moz we want to be able to
use Google's Keyword Planner not only to
search for all those relevant keywords
available to you but we want to be able
to choose keywords with high volume and
low difficulty low competition we also
want to select primary and second
keywords wisely so remember when you
optimize you're optimizing a page for
more than one keyword so you want to be
able to have a nice portfolio of diverse
relevant keywords with high search
volume and low difficulty and then you
want to be able to identify those
keywords that your competitors are
ranking for so Moz gives you that
information and so we want to be able to
leverage the tools available to us to
choose the right keywords so if you need
any more information on this we got a
nice webinar on keyword research for SEO
so take a look at that video on YouTube
to get more specific details about using
SEO tools for keyword research and all
about keyword research in general for
SEO so let's talk about some other
reasons under SEO what we would use some
of these tools available to us well we
want to be able to understand the search
engines and how they crawl and index our
site okay we also want to check the
correct format of the site map and we
want to monitor backlinks okay we also
want to analyze linking to our web page
okay which ones are good which ones are
not good okay we also want to perform
some competitor analysis so these are
some of the reasons why other than
keyword research why we would reuse some
of these SEO tools so we have tools
available to us some Majestic hrefs
again Moz let's take a look at Google
search console and I want to hone in on
Google search console because it is free
and it's a must if you're going to work
on SEO you need to be working in Google
search console and so the whole key
behind Google search console is you have
a website you need to get that site
verified once it's verified once Google
can recognize that you are associated
with this website then you're going to
be able to see some important
information so here I'm looking at a
website and what am I looking at I'm
looking at something called coverage
under index so what does coverage mean
well going back to what we just said we
want to be able to understand how
Google's crawling and indexing our pages
and so what Google does is through
through this platform search console is
there letting us know once they go to
our website and start crawling it and
they pull these Pages back to their
server they're letting us know if we
actually have any issues so here I could
see I have some issues with 112 pages
and some of those issues are listed down
here so there could be a crawl issue a
4-4 you know redirect okay so you could
see there's some five unique issues
across 112 pages so here I can see
submitted URL Mark no index there's a
hundred of those pages we have some
redirect errors there's seven pages that
you know fall victim to this error and
so we can really hone in
um what the error is and address the
error okay so if Google's telling us hey
this is an issue and you want that page
indexed by Google then we should
probably address the error and so that's
the Great thing here about going into
Google search console is you can under
index go to coverage and get a sense of
what Google's indexing and what they're
not indexing so these are the errors I
can see they've certainly were able to
crawl and index
9115 Pages they were able to crawl okay
and they excluded 54
000 plus pages and then we also have
some pages with some warnings so this is
kind of an overview of what Google Sees
when they crawl our site so when they
say crawl they're coming to our site
they're following links on the site and
every link they follow they're either
going to index that page or they're
going to report to you an error or an
issue that they found if we want these
Pages indexed we need to address the
issues the errors and so that's the
beauty of this report here is Google is
telling us firsthand what the issues are
so we we also want to take a look at the
sitemap so you have an opportunity to
submit a site map and a site map is just
a formatted file that includes all your
website URLs and so you're going to have
this file sitting in your root directory
and you're probably going to call it or
should call it
sitemap.xml XML being the format so once
you have this file you're just going to
let Google know that that file exists so
you're going to enter in the sitemap URL
so if it's in the root directory all
you're going to do is type in
sitemap.xml and click submit so once
you've done it just like this site is
done what Google's going to do is say
hey look we see you've submitted this
and we last read it a couple days ago
and we could see that we discovered
1419 URLs so I can go back under
coverage and I can see some of the
issues that they found but if I go back
under sitemaps I can see that these are
the URLs they've discovered via the
sitemap and so the whole point of a site
map is we want to be able to get and
push the URLs to Google not have Google
come to our site and discover them so
this is a quicker faster more efficient
way to communicate with Google all the
URLs that you have on your site that you
want Google to index and so that's the
beauty of search console now while we're
in search console we might as well take
a look at some of the other features it
has and so one of the most important
features under search console is this
mobile usability report okay so Google
is a staunch believer in mobile first so
nowadays most people start and finish a
lot of their searches a lot of their
behavior on mobile so the beginning on
mobile and they may end it on mobile so
if they don't end it on mobile then you
know perhaps they'll go into a store or
perhaps they'll go via desk top but
Googled is a staunch believer and
definitely a lot of what's going on
today starts with mobile so they want
you to understand how your site fares
Via Mobile and when I say fares Via
Mobile is it mobile friendly is it
responsive is it loading quick enough
you know is it formatted to Google
standards and so if there are any issues
Google's going to let you know what
those issues are so here I could see
Google's recognized 206 Pages before
different issues okay so here I can see
what those issues are just like the
coverage issues we can see specifically
what they are and so here I can see for
206 Pages text too small to read click
elements to close together the viewport
not set to device with and then content
wider than the screen so there's 10
pages that fit under this error and if I
actually click on it the error I can see
what those 10 pages are and so so when
we're done we can actually when we
address the issues we can actually have
Google validate whether the fix has been
made so you can definitely use this as a
means of communicating directly with
Google telling Google look I see what
the issues are I'm going to fix them and
then I want you to validate them okay so
this is important because if you can
communicate with Google and let them
know hey we do recognize the errors we
are fixing the errors please validate
them you know it's going to draw
Google's attention Google's going to
validate them and get these Pages
indexed quicker so if you ignore the
issues then the errors especially for
mobile then you stand the chance of your
pages not getting indexed so the mobile
usability report to me is an important
report because we want to better
understand whether Google's picking up
issues on mobile and if they are we want
to address them get Google value them so
Google can index them quicker now
there's another report that is of
interest to you or may be of interest to
you in Google search console and that's
the links report so the links report and
Google search console shows us what
pages have the most links okay so here
we can see the home page has 26 000 plus
links if we hone in on interior Pages we
can see the links to those pages okay so
we can get a sense of what are the top
link pages from external links meaning
links on other websites pointing to
these pages I can also see internal
links so Google's recognizing links from
within my website from one page to
another so external links internal links
both factors for SEO when ranking so
then I can see top linking sites what
sites are linking to my site and then I
can see top linking text so Google
search console has given me kind of an
overview of what my leaking structure
looks like okay so externally I want
want links from other websites pointing
to various pages on my site and I
certainly want my pages linking to one
another on my site and so I'll be able
to better understand what that structure
looks like using Google search console's
links report okay there's one more
report that I think's of interest in
Google search console and that's the
performance report so the performance
report is a report that actually you can
link up with Google analytics so you can
see the same report and analytics if
you're able to link up Google search
console with analytics and you should be
able to do that all you need to do is
make sure you use the same email address
that you use for analytics and search
console so it needs to be the same email
address you could certainly link up the
two and have this data imported into
Google analytics so what is this data
that we're talking about well it's
called performance so what we can
actually see is the queries the actual
queries people are typing in to Google
so when they're typing them into Google
we can actually see how many Impressions
the keyword queries received and how
many clicks the keyword queries received
and then I can see click-through rate
and average position okay so here I can
see for this particular keyword on the
first line I could see over the course
of the last three months it received 209
297 Impressions so what does that mean
that means this keyword was used at
least or typed in as a query at least
that many times and that's how many
times my listing appeared and the Google
search results Pages based on this
particular query and so as a result of
somebody typing in this query 209 000
plus times this site received 120 000
plus clicks so to get a sense of the
click-through rate all you would need to
do and Google can obviously do this for
you is you would simply just divide the
209 297 into the 120
397. okay so that's really going to give
you that's going to give you your
click-through rate and the click-through
rate in this case is 57 so over half of
the clicks occur when this listing
appears for this keyword okay so we can
get a sense of the click-through rate
for each one okay and you could simply
just use the filtering here now we can
also see average position okay so we
could see a little bit more than that
too we can go from queries to Pages we
can go from pages to countries so we get
a sense of how many Impressions and
clicks I'm receiving by country and
importantly we can see by device so here
I can see a majority of the people who
conduct a search related to my website
primarily do it on desktop now I
mentioned and the beauty of the Google
search console performance report is
that you can link it up to Google
analytics and when you do that all you
need to do then is go to acquisition
Google search console and then from
there you could choose landing pages
countries devices or queries so I could
see the same data that I see in search
console but this time I'm looking at it
in Google analytics and so here I can
see what my search queries are my clicks
my Impressions my click to rate bike
search query and then the average
position so that's the great thing about
that performance report is that when I
link up Google search console with
analytics I'm able to see that data in
analytics so that's an added bonus so to
speak now let's talk about some other
reasons why we're going to use these SEO
tools available to us and so we already
listed a number of different reasons
ranging from sitemaps to keyword
research but we also want to hone in on
you know what domains are driving links
to our site so I showed you an example
in search console we also want to hey
maybe identify and disavow poor
backlinks so search console is a great
tool for that because if we don't want
to be associated with a particular
website we can certainly disavow that
link we could track a number of follow
and nofollow links okay we could track
our website's rankings we can measure
click-through rates and Impressions just
as we did with search console we could
track keyword ranking for desktop mobile
cross locations just as we just did with
the search console performance report we
can identify top performing gaining and
losing keywords again the performance
report so we could certainly look at the
Google search console report but if you
have a platform like Moz you can
certainly also look at a lot of that
data available so for example sample
rankings so if you have a Moz account we
can certainly go into rankings okay and
we can see for the keywords that we've
chosen that we want to optimize for we
could certainly see where they rank the
great thing about Moz is it's a great
tool not only for rankings and on-page
optimization but for off-page
optimization as well so if I go ahead
and take a look at a domain for example
I'm just going to type in this domain
I'm going to be able to get what they
call a domain Authority so a score out
of 1 and 100 I'm able to see how
authoritative my domain is and how
authoritative a domain is is based on
the quality of links pointing to it so
Moz gives me some good insights as to
how many linking domains how many
inbound links I have ranking keywords
and it goes into detail as well so here
if I click on the linking domains I'm to
be actual able to see the actual domains
pointing to my site as an external link
and not only can I see the domains I can
actually see the domain authority of
those domains so if there's a domain for
example that doesn't have a good domain
Authority and the site appears a bit
scammy per se then we can disavow that
so I can certainly look at all the
domains that are linking to me and then
I can highlight the ones that have poor
domain Authority what Moz even takes it
a step further they also give me a Spam
score so Moz is able to measure how
spammy a website is so if I have a
combination of say a low domain
Authority and a high spam score then I
probably want to disavow myself from
that site and so I can use this report
here you can see here as I keep going
down for example I can see this
particular website has a domain
authority of 26 and it has a Spam score
of 16 so not a good combination this
should alert me to the fact that hey
this particular site because it has so
many links pointing to me or it has at
least one link pointing to me that I
probably want to disavow myself because
it's probably hurting my own domain
Authority so that's the great thing
about this linking domains report is I'm
able to hone in on not only who's link
linking to me meaning domain but how
many linking domains does that domain
have what's the spam score of that
domain what's the domain authority of
that domain and then I can get into a
little bit more detail and actually see
you know all the links pointing to that
domain so it really goes into detail
about backlinks domain Authority spam
Etc everything you need to use in order
to measure off page SEO so that's the
great thing about Moz is they have not
only on-page SEO tools but off-page SEO
tools and Moz is a freemium so to speak
so here you can see if you just go to
mods.com free Dash seo-tools you'll be
able to use some of these tools
available to you not just for SEO but
also for local SEO as well so here you
like some of these tools you can start
your free 30-day trial so I use and lean
on Moz a lot for all that it has to
offer from choosing keywords to rankings
report to checking issues on my website
to even checking who's linking to me so
this fits in the mold with everything I
need to do for SEO so in addition to
that keyword research video you could
certainly lean on some other webinars
that we've done in the past on SEO so
we've done a webinar on SEO tools and
we've also done a webinar on SEO tips
and tricks so if you want any more
information about the tools we covered
or SEO in general take a look at those
two videos and check them out and that
should kind of complement what we talked
about with using some of the tools
Google's Keyword Planner Moz and Google
search console okay let's switch over to
email marketing tools and so with email
marketing tools we have a lot available
to us in the form of reporting in the
form of Platforms in the form of you
know tools that really help us go from A
to Z on our email choosing you know what
email to send out to creating a list to
measuring how the email campaign went
and so we could start with MailChimp
because mailchimp's a freemium version
when we say freemium meaning they have a
free trial available then you're
expected to upgrade but you know
MailChimp to me is a tool I I use I like
the interface very easy for beginners so
we're going to take a look at MailChimp
but there are certainly many others
available you know more cat is a good
tool you know Marketo is a good toll
because if you have a business and
you're trying to funnel people through
your pipeline so to speak meaning they
they sign up as a lead and you want to
nurture that lead from the beginning to
the end meaning at the end they're
actually going to turn around and
purchase well Marketo is a good tool for
you to use because you can then set up
trip campaigns or also known as email
campaigns you know so that you're
talking and communicating with that
particular Prospect through every point
in the funnel so that's the great thing
about Marketo it has drip campaigns
available along with some other features
there's a HubSpot a very powerful tool
it does a lot from creating landing
pages to a b testing to social to to you
know email so this is another freemium
tool that you could use you have another
freemium and send in blue email platform
and then you also have convertkit
another email platform there's more
Dimension that we can't even fit on this
screen now if you have a favorite email
marketing tool that you use Constant
Contact vertical response they're plenty
out there Emma you know feel free to to
note that in the comment section below
this video I'm curious as to how many
people actually use you know different
tools because there are so literally so
many email marketing tools out there why
because email marketing has been around
probably the longest amongst all the
other digital marketing channels and a
lot of people use email on a daily basis
so it's no wonder why there's just so
many tools available and so with these
tools you can certainly send bulk emails
now in the case of Marketo you can send
emails to a segmented audience and so
that's a actually what you want to do as
a strategy is always send emails to a
segmented audience you know you want to
use a tool where you're going to be able
to create campaigns then send those
campaigns to again segmented contacts
and then be able to design your email
around that particular audience so you
know you have a good tool when you can
do that when you can really segment for
your audience okay you want to be able
to use a tool that's going to be able to
segment your users you know use
transactional emails meaning hey look if
somebody go ahead went ahead and
purchased can you follow up with an
email and creating workflows just like I
mentioned with Marketo you want a
workflow set up where hey if somebody
does this you're sending email B Etc so
you want an email marketing tool that's
flexible enough to handle what your
business strategy and goals are okay so
you want to be able to also use a tool
that that you know has various email
templates available okay you don't want
to be stuck with just a vanilla template
again you want to be able to customize
an email for your audience you want to
be able to manage your list
appropriately meaning if you have 10 000
users or emails in a list you want to be
able to manage them accordingly you know
break them up or or have sub lists so to
speak and then most importantly you want
to make sure you have a platform that
not only does its tracking on its own
but will give you some detailed insights
meaning you know what percentage of
users opened your email what percentage
of of recipients clicked on your email
what links do they click on you know
which which emails bounce so you want
some detailed insights right in the
platform that you're using it just makes
it more simpler and easier and more
effective to manage you certainly want
to create that smart automated campaigns
meaning you don't even have to send out
the email and then you want to be able
to have some flexibility to set up email
delivery based on a specific time of day
so these tools also allow you to your
segment contacts based on geolocation
you want to be able to use a tool that
allows for multivariate testing again
you want to analyze performance and
optimize campaigns you want to trigger
automatic responses somebody purchases
something are you using a tool that will
automatically send that email out so
these are all the reasons why you would
use an email marketing tool so let's
dive in and take a look at an example
and we're going to use MailChimp as our
example today so let's dive in and take
a look at MailChimp so with MailChimp
once you log in you know you're going to
be able to see some historical campaigns
that you've sent out or are you going to
be able to create your own campaign and
so this is kind of under campaigns you
can kind of see an overview of the ones
you've sent out or or if they're in
draft mode you'll be able to see they're
in draft mode so you can go ahead and
edit them so here we have one that was
set up on August 26th and it's still in
draft mode so we can go ahead and edit
that so if we just click edit you know
we have the flexibility to you know pick
and choose who we're sending this to who
it's from what the subject line is and
then we can certainly design the email
so if we click design email again this
is important because with email
marketing you want to be able to cater
your email to your intended audience
so if you're selling men's shoes your
audience should be men okay so you don't
want men to receive an email about
women's shoes it sounds like it's common
sense but the point being you want to be
able to use an email platform that's
going to be able to allow you to put two
and two together the message and the
design with intended audience and so
here you can see MailChimp allows us to
do that okay you can see some of the
layouts here okay you also have themes
that you could choose from okay you
could search for different themes or you
can even just code your own so you can
just paste and error code in or you can
import it so MailChimp allows that
flexibility you're not stuck with one of
their templates and so if we go back to
the dashboard the one thing I like about
MailChimp though is the reporting okay
so yes it is easy to choose a template
and map that template to your audience
but I really like make the reports that
they have to offer so you know here you
can see there's some lists that we've
sent to and we choose one of our
audience lists then we can see some
really detailed reporting here and so
here I could see this email that was
sent out in June I could see it was sent
to 95 000 plus subscribers okay of the
subscribers I saw two thousand plus open
it and 157 clicks so I can view this
report in more detail just by clicking
on view report so again we want an email
platform that's going to be able to give
us some detailed information about how
that email campaign performed and so I
can get down really to the nitty-gritty
I can actually see you know on the
content what was clicked and what wasn't
clicked so here I sent two different
subject lines so I'm able to compare the
two against one another okay so I can
really go into detail about one of them
here so if I click view report I can
specifically see what the average for
this list is so here I'm able to compare
against the list average and it's 16 I
only had an open rate of 2.5 percent so
the industry average is 18 and so here
I'm able to see the list average for the
click rate and the industry average for
the click rate as well so then I can see
some specifics about it how many people
unsubscribed then I could see a graph I
could see the top links that were
clicked okay the top subscribers put the
most opens I can link social to it if I
want to and then I can see geographic
information so the point being is
MailChimp really goes into some nice
detail here about the email campaigns
and how they performed so the great
thing is too with the MailChimp you
could link it with a Google analytics
you can link it with e-commerce okay so
if you have an email and you're you're
selling products and somebody purchased
that product MailChimp is able to
integrate in with your shopping Commerce
platform for example woocommerce so if
somebody did purchase you can send out
that thank you email MailChimp even goes
a step further and if somebody did click
on a link go to your shopping cart add
something to the shopping cart and then
abandon the car you know MailChimp
allows you the opportunity to retarget
them via email so MailChimp is flexible
and that's what you want in a email
marketing platform you want something
that's flexible that you can cater to
your audience you can manage your
audience list and you can get detailed
reporting on your different campaigns
for that audience so that's MailChimp
and summary and so most email platforms
do a lot of similar features or have
some similar features but that's what
you ideally want to look for in an email
marketing platform so here's a tool that
doesn't get talked about enough when it
comes to email marketing and that's
Google's URL Builder and the reason why
we're going to talk about this tool
today is because most people in the US
use Google analytics as their web
Analytics tool and the one thing about
Google analytics is it allows you to
track different campaigns so if you're
doing pay-per-click campaigns outside of
Google you can certainly track the
performance right in Google analytics
and email is no different so if you're
using Google analytics and you're
sending out an email let's just say on
MailChimp or any other email marketing
platform you want to be able to append
your links with what we call UTM
tracking so for example if I have a URL
that says visit Florida and I'm going to
send out an email I have up to five
parameters that I can use Okay so here's
my email or URL that I'm using in the
email so I have up to five parameters
that I can use to track this particular
email so let's go through some of those
parameters so the first one is campaign
source so what's the source of the
campaign well we could certainly
identify MailChimp if we're using
MailChimp as the source now the the
thing about the URL Builders you always
want to use lowercase because Google
analytics is case sensitive so as a rule
of thumb just stick with a lowercase so
our source is going to be MailChimp
because that's the platform we're using
if you're using you know Constant
Contact or vertical response or you know
some of these other one convertkit then
go ahead and put in that platform as the
source now for the medium which is the
means in which we're driving traffic to
the site let's go ahead and put in email
because that's what we're using to drive
traffic to this particular page now
what's the campaign name well we're in
summer so we're going to call this the
summer promo so their summer promo here
is visit Florida beaches okay so we're
going to send this email out to the
masses and particularly not only the
masses but the masses in the north
because we're going to say hey look come
to Florida for the summer come visit our
beaches that's the point of the campaign
so that's what we're going to use for
the campaign name is whatever the
campaign is it's a summer promo now
notice I got an asterisk next to these
particular parameters so Google's asking
us hey these are mandatory so go ahead
and put something in there now for
campaign term and campaign content we
could certainly leave them blank because
they're not mandatory but since we're
talking about email I would certainly
recommend that you use the campaign
content parameter and why do I say that
because if we're sending an email out to
say you have 10 000 recipient pants I
want to be able to split out the email
into two segments one segment that's
going to get subject line one and one
segment that's going to get subject line
two so in this case I'm going to put
whatever subject line one is in the
campaign content field so now I have
four parameters and once I've entered in
my variables in this parameter Fields I
now have a revised or pended URL so my
original URL was visit florida.com
Florida Dash beaches.html my original
URL I've now appended that with some UTM
parameters and now I see my original URL
appended with the UTM parameters based
on those variables so I can copy it just
by clicking the copy URL I can go to my
browser I can paste that URL in there
and I want to check to see if it works
so here I could see this particular page
loaded Florida beaches with my etm
parameters appended to the URL so that's
for the first subject line that's for
the audience it's going to get the first
subject line I want to do another one
for the second subject line so now I'm
going to change my campaign content
parameter to subject line underscore 2.
I'm going to copy that URL I'm going to
check it okay so I could see that the
page loads with those U10 parameters and
so now what am I going to do I'm going
to use the first URL and the second URL
in my email okay so any link that I have
in this case I'm using subject line two
so for the email with the second subject
line going to that segmented audience
this is the link I'm going to use in the
email so if you have one or two or three
links in the email this is the URL
you're going to use because when
somebody clicks on that link you're
going to be able to see that that click
in Google analytics so if I jump over to
Google analytics after I send out my
email I'm going to go to acquisition I'm
going to go to campaigns I'm going to go
to all campaigns now based on the
variables I put into my parameters
meaning Source medium campaign name
content or term that's what I'm going to
look for in Google analytics so we could
start with source and medium so if I
click on source and medium as my primary
Dimension here I can see MailChimp and
the actual dates was used as part of the
variable for for source and then what
can I see the medium being email so now
I can see for this email that was sent
out in MailChimp in May I could see how
many users how many sessions and more
importantly how many conver versions so
we could certainly hone in on that
particular email if we wanted to if we
choose some of the other parameters
available to us so here I could see the
campaign name okay so I could see
exactly what campaign what source what
email drove in traffic and conversions
and if I'm doing subject line testing I
can choose content as my parameter so
here I'm going to change it to content
and now I can see the subject lines in
this case if I go back to my source
medium I'm going to be able to see what
subject lines from my emails generated
the most traffic and not only the most
traffic but also conversions so that's
the whole point behind using the URL
Builder again you're taking a URL that
you're going to use an email and then
you're going to pan that URL with
different parameters campaign so Source
campaign medium campaign name and then
optionally campaign content or campaign
term okay once you've entered variables
into those parameters you're going to
get it appended URL which you can then
use in your email so when the email gets
sent you're going to go back over to
Google analytics and you're going to
look at the results of that campaign of
that source of that Medium of that
content IE subject line and so that's
why the URL Builder is so important
because MailChimp gives us some good
insight as to how the email performed in
terms of open and click rates but what
we really want to see is how that
campaign performed once it drove traffic
to my website so that's the whole idea
behind the URL Builder if you're using
Google analytics you'll be able to use
the URL Builder with whatever email
platform you're using so let's move on
to web analytics tools and this is an
important section because web analytics
tools kind of the central focal point of
all digital marketing and it starts
really with Google analytics Google
analytics is a freemium meaning that
they have a free version that you can
use there is also a paid version of
Google analytics but given the Advent of
Google its popularity especially in the
United States a majority of users are
using the free version of Google
analytics so it's a very popular tool
especially for marketers but there are
also other tools available so it's not
just Google so we have Adobe analytics
which is also freemium you have kiss
metrics you have spring metrics you have
YouTube analytics which is part of
Google but YouTube has its own separate
analytics insights so a lot of these as
you can see are free to use they're
available no reason why you should not
be using uh an Analytics tool to measure
your marketing campaigns or website
behavior and why would we want to use
these tools again well again we want to
really measure Behavior we want to
measure what's going on with our website
so we want to be able to identify the
location of where our website visitors
are coming from and a lot of these
analytics tools use IP address to
identify the location of a website
visitor so if you're trying to Target a
specific country then you want to be
able to see that the visitors to your
website are coming from that specific
country or location we also want to
measure the engagement of our website
Behavior so we get traffic to the
website what are they doing how long are
they staying what pages are they
visiting so this is the overall nature
of really why we want to use is web
analytics to measure how successful our
website is at treating our website
visitors with the same courtesy you
would if you had a brick and mortar
store somebody comes into your store you
want them to find what they're looking
for quickly you want them to be happy
with their experience you certainly want
them to pay for the products very
quickly and easily and efficiently and
you want them to come back and that's no
different than a website so we want our
website to perform in a manner that's
going to suit our audience and that's
why we want to track engagement so why
else well we want to really look at
who's coming are they returning visitors
or new visitors you know ideally you
want a nice mix between 50 new and 50
returning because you know returning
visitors are loyal there's some loyalty
to that they already know your brand
they're coming back to your website new
visitors are curious and you want new
visitors because that means more traffic
so you want a nice balance between that
analytics tools will help you measure
that you want to be able to measure
organic traffic whether you like it or
not whether you know it or not but
Google and other search engines are
indexing your pages and your pages are
being found via the search engines and
so you want to be able to measure how
much traffic you're actually generating
from those search engines we talked
about this with email marketing UTM
tracking so if you set up email
campaigns or non-google campaigns you
want to use UTM tracking and Google
analytics and other analytics tools but
specifically Google analytics will help
you see the results of your campaigns if
they're tracked with UTM tracking so
that's another good reason why to use a
web Analytics tool probably most
importantly amongst all these bullet
points is our goals our website
conversions we want to be able to see
how much traffic is coming to our
website and not only the engagement of
the traffic but how much of that traffic
is actually doing what we want them to
do I.E are they converting and we want
to optimize our sites and channels
performance so the whole idea of
collecting all this information is that
you could turn around and improve
performance so if your bounce rate is
high well how do you lower bounce rate
well we need to do something about that
and analytics tools will help us
identify what's not working from our
site perspective and from a channel
perspective and we can take action to
improve performance so that's the whole
idea behind optimizing our site's
performance so let's jump into Google
analytics and let's take a look at
everything we just talked about in those
bullet points so about improving website
performance measuring engagement looking
at our goals and conversions measuring
campaigns with UTM tracking all those
good things that we can can get and a
good Analytics tool so Adobe mix panel
spring metrics you know they all work in
a similar fashion and that they're
really measuring website behavior and so
if we're in Google analytics really what
we're doing is we're measuring the
performance of our website broken down
into four components audience
acquisition behavior and conversions so
what do we want to do well we want to
look into each one of these sections so
let's start with audience and so
audience and Google analytics tells us
who is coming to our website now they're
not going to specifically tell us hey
Rob Sanders came to your website but
they are going to say that somebody from
San Francisco California came to the
website and these are the pages they
looked at and this is the language and
they came from this device
and they're a returning users so they're
painting a picture for you okay so
they're not giving you a list of names
that would not be legal but they are
providing you with a good picture of who
is coming and when I say picture we have
to paint that picture and so if we look
at say demographics for example and I
got a demographics overview here's a
picture I'm painting well I could see
that 25 to 34 year olds are the majority
of the age group that is coming to my
website okay I can see on the gender
side of it I can see that 63 percent of
my traffic and again this is year to
date that I'm looking at is coming to my
website so two-thirds of my traffic is
female one-third Mount and they're
between the ages of 25 and 34. so I'm
painting a picture about you know gender
and age coming to my website well I can
also look at Geo so where specifically
might these people be coming from so if
I go to location under Geo I'm going to
be able to see a breakdown of country or
I can even hone it down to city or
specific location and here I can see
United States is the primary driver but
not by much so we have 16 almost 17
percent from the US and then 16 from
Argentina 13 from Mexico 10 percent from
India so we have a nice mix of traffic
from different locations in the world
coming to our website so that's Geo but
more importantly let's take a look at
mobile so if we go to mobile overview
how are people coming to our website are
they on a desktop or a laptop are they
using their mobile device are they using
a tablet and so Google analytics breaks
it down very nice for you and so we
could see percentages in actual numbers
by device category and so in this case I
could see year to date I can see 62
percent are coming from desktop 30 35
percent are coming from mobile and so
that's important because most people
start their Journey from mobile and that
is growing and that's going to continue
to grow so you want to keep an eye on
mobile so to me this is one of the more
important reports under audience because
people who come from Mobile have a
different not only experience because
the website should be responsive to the
mobile device but their mindset is going
to be different they're actively looking
for something they're probably going to
either then follow up on their desktop
or follow up in person at your store or
they're probably looking for directions
or they may just call you so the
experience is a lot different on mobile
so we want to hone in on the growth of
mobile okay so to me this is one of the
more important reports in Google
analytics especially under audience so
let's move on to acquisition so
acquisition reporting tell tells us how
the traffic was driven to the website so
if audience tells us who is coming to
the website acquisition tells us how
that traffic got to the website and so
really what you want to do is get a
sense of what channels what marketing
channels are driving traffic so remember
we talked about organic search well
those search engines are indexed in your
pages well how much of that traffic from
the search engines is actually coming to
your site and I'm a Believer in if
organic search is the primary driver of
traffic then you have a pretty healthy
website because that means the search
engines or indexing your pages people
are searching for something related to
your business you're being found you're
getting clicked and that represents the
majority of the traffic so that's always
a good thing so here we could see it
broken down by Channel if I go to all
traffic channels report I can see in my
Dimension that organic search represents
72 percent of my traffic and this is
year to date then I can see paid search
then I can see direct which means
Somebody went directly to the site I
could see referral email social then I
could see more paid search broken out so
these are the different marketing
channels now analytics allows you to
look at a specific source and medium so
the source would be the actual website
or search engine in the medium would
differentiate how that traffic actually
got to the site so if we're talking
about a search engine did they come to
the site via paid search or do they come
to the site via organic search and so
all we need to do is change our primary
Dimension from default Channel grouping
to source and medium and we could see
specifically the breakout of the
different sources and mediums driving
traffic to the site so here I can see
Google organic it's 71 percent and and
then Google CPC or cost per click at 15
16 of our traffic so then I can look
down I can see email in here being
organic I could see some referring sites
I could see some social in terms of
mobile Facebook okay so we could see a
mix of the different sources of mediums
driving traffic to the site okay so you
don't always have to look at Channel per
se you can look at it via source and
medium and if you're running Google ads
under acquisition analytics has a whole
section of Google ads reporting so if
you're running campaigns on Google ads
remember we looked at the Keyword
Planner and Google ads so if you're
running campaigns on Google ads you can
certainly see the performance of those
campaigns just by clicking on campaigns
we can also see campaigns other
campaigns that we're running so remember
that UTM tracking that we set up for
email well we want to be able to track
the performance of email and any other
non-google campaign with UTM tracking so
when we do that we'll be able to go to
campaigns all campaigns and we'll be
able to see the campaign performance if
we look at source and medium we'll be
able to see what campaigns drove traffic
to the website so here I can see
vertical response email as a driver of
traffic so that's the campaign reporting
and then also if you have search
consoles so we looked at search console
earlier we talked about SEO tools well
remember I said you can link up search
console with Google analytics well
here's search console and we could see
queries devices landing pages countries
so all the performance metrics that we
could see in search console because we
have it linked up with analytics we can
see it right here so this gives us a
nice snapshot of what what keywords are
driving traffic to the site organically
I could see The Impressions I could see
the clicks then I could see the clicked
array and then the average position so
in theory the higher something ranks the
more traffic you're going to get so
that's the idea behind it we want to
make sure that we're ranking for our
coveted keywords and if we are we want
to be able to measure how many times our
listing was seen and how many times it
was clicked so that's the great thing
about you know Google they have a family
of products and those products tend to
talk to one another in the form of
Google search console and Google ads you
can connect them directly to Google
analytics so let's move from acquisition
to behavior so here in Behavior we have
a number of different reports so
Behavior tells us what's the traffic
actually arrived at the website how are
they behaving and so really what I would
do do is from there go to site content
all pages and so this gives us an idea
of how many pages were actually viewed
so site content all pages tells us what
page and how many times it was viewed
during a period of time and again we're
looking at year to date so I can see
engagement related metrics associated
with a page so this particular page here
on line one I could see how many pages
unique Pages which is equal to sessions
so I can have a session come to the
website and look at a page multiple
times in that session I could see the
average time the person has spent on a
page and I can also see the bounce rate
so a bounce rate indicates that they
arrived on the page and didn't go any
further they left the website from that
page that they arrived on and so I can
also see percentage of exits meaning
what page did people exit the site for
from so these are all engagement related
metrics so here is where I want to react
and optimize my website performance so I
if I see a page now performing well
meaning it has a high bounce rate or
maybe low time on page then I'm probably
going to optimize it meaning test it or
change it to improve performance so
these are all pages but I could
certainly look at landing pages okay so
landing pages tells us the behavior of
the page when somebody landed on it so a
landing page means that somebody came
from organic search or paid search or
another Channel landed on this page so
here I could see this particular page on
line one had
4970 sessions okay and I can also see
the performance of that page so
measuring engagements against pages is
definitely important because page isn't
performing in terms of Bounce rate or
time on page then we want to be able to
make changes to that page to improve
performance okay there are some other
great reports under Behavior so we want
to go to site speed we want to look at
how fast or how slow our Pages load so
this is important from an SEO
perspective because if a page isn't
loading very fast then chances of it
getting ranked in Google are not very
good so Google's organic search
basically takes page load time seriously
so if a page doesn't load very fast then
we need to be able to fix it so we can
go to page timings I can get a good
sense of the average page load time of a
particular page and what Google does
here is under speed suggestions they
actually will give me some ideas and
speed suggestions on how to address a
page that's loading very slow and so
when we load up the speed suggestions
report what Google does is say hey we
know that this page is loading very slow
the average page load time is 15 seconds
here's some suggestions we're going to
give you seven suggestions so if you
click on that what's actually going to
happen is you're going to go to another
tool called page speed insights and Page
speed insights is analyzing the page as
you can see here and when it's done
analyzing the page it's going to give
you some feedback on how to improve page
load performance not only for desktop
but for mobile so here I can see if I
scroll down this is desktop and these
are some of the opportunities that I can
address when trying to improve the page
load time of that particular page so
here I could see there's some server
response time issues image sizes
probably need to be resized I can remove
unused CSS okay so there are a lot of
different things I can do to improve the
page load time on this particular page
okay this is for desktop I can also see
mobile so mobile a lot of the same
issues so if we address these these
opportunities then we could see a lift
in page load time we see lift and Page
load time we're going to probably see a
lift in organic rankings or even user
engagement because if a page takes a
long time to load a user is probably not
going to stay on that page very long so
to me site speed is an important report
under Behavior now one more report here
that I want to point out under behavior
is events and to me events are important
so if you're trying to measure
engagement on your website you need to
make sure you have event tracking set up
and when we talk about event tracking
we're talking about measuring things
that analytics doesn't measure by
default so if you have a button on your
website if you have a PDF download if
you have a submit button on a phone form
submission if you have a subscribe
button if you have a video if you have
an external link anything that is going
to trigger engagement on your website
you need to measure with event tracking
and event tracking is simply set up by
breaking out the event into a category
and action and a label and so here we
could see for our particular website we
have categories already set up for event
tracking so here for example I can say
on line six video I could see how many
people actually watched our video okay
so here's the action video Start okay so
over this period of time I could see I
had 49 unique events 50 total so that's
how many people actually watched the
video and you can always report to label
and that'll tell you what page people
watched in this case the video so event
tracking is important because we want to
be able to measure engagement so if we
go to events under behavior and you
don't see any events listed you probably
need to get that set up and that is set
up through Google tag manager so what
you want to do is you want to be able to
set up your events through Google tag
manager which is another Google platform
but you certainly want to do that so
that's where you set up your events when
you set up your events for your website
with a category in action and label
you'll be able to measure those events
in analytics under Behavior under events
and the important thing here is you'll
be able to measure engagement so I'll be
able to see how many people came to the
site and how many people clicked on a
button downloaded a PDF submitted a form
played a video did whatever we wanted
them to do so events are important so
let's move from the Behavior to
conversions and this is important
because we want to be able to measure
conversions on a website so analytics
has four types of conversions so if I go
to admin down at the bottom and then I
go to goals I could see that I have four
different types of goals that I can use
now right now I have event related goals
set up for the website for this
particular website so we just talked
about event tracking so if you're
measuring a button click on your website
you can certainly turn that into a goal
and so all you need to do is tell
analytics hey this is the particular
category this is the particular action
so for example if I click on this
particular goal and take a look at it I
can see that we have a category set up
that anything that resembles donate now
okay or donate go ahead and fire this
event as a conversion okay so event is
one type of goal another type of goal is
destination so somebody goes to a
specific page like a confirmation page
we can turn that into a goal so here I
could see if somebody goes to donation
Dash confirmation then analytics is
going to fire that goal as a conversion
and we're going to see a conversion
against a different metric or different
dimension like Channel or audience okay
so destination is the second type of
goal the third type of goal is duration
so how long did somebody stay on my
website so in this example if they
stayed at least one minute and 30
seconds or more then analytics is going
to count that as a goal conversion okay
so duration is the third type and then
the fourth type is pages per session
okay so if I look at this example here
if a user came to my website and looked
at more than three pages in that
particular session then analytics is
going to fire a goal conversion so four
types of goals you don't have to set up
all four different types my
recommendation is at least have one goal
set up if you're not sure what goal to
set up then at least set up a duration
or pages per session okay so at least
you can measure how long somebody stays
on your website or how many pages they
went to okay so when you actually do
have these goals set up you can go back
into conversions we can go back into
goals we can go back into overview and
we can measure our goal completions over
this period of time so here I could see
313 goal completions total with a goal
conversion rate of 1.88 and then I could
see it broken down by goal type so
remember the only goals I have available
and set up all are event related goals
so 69 newsletter signups 156 donate
click buttons I have 32 contact form
submissions 37 email click completions
and then 11 phone number click
completions so I can measure engagement
as a goal and so goals generally are
important to the business so you want to
make sure that if you have a goal for
your website then you want to be able to
set that up as a goal in Google
analytics so that way when you're
looking at example channels if I go back
to my channels report I can then measure
Channel by goal conversion so these are
all goals but if I want to look at for
example how many people from organic
search clicked on the Donate Now button
I could see that I could see
year-to-date 10
887 users which meant 11 1000 sessions
76 clicked on that donate Now button and
that comes out to 0.65 conversion rate
okay so that's important so you want to
be able to measure any Dimension whether
that be Channel Source medium keyword
campaign mobile device could be
demographic gender or age you want to be
able to measure any Dimension against
the goals you have set up so you can
measure performance and that also
includes Pages or landing pages as well
so that's a quick overview of what you
can expect to see in Google analytics
again audience acquisition behavior and
conversions so a lot of data in Google
analytics but you want to be able to
take advantage of the data in order to
improve website performance now let's
jump over to YouTube analytics because
if you have videos on YouTube If you you
have a channel set up some playlists
you'll be able to get some really good
insights as to how your video is
performing and so here I could see I'm
in YouTube all I did was I went to my
account then I went to the beta the
studio version of YouTube and then from
there I went to analytics so my account
YouTube Studio analytics and analytics
here is going to give me all sorts of
information about my videos okay so here
I could see over the last 28 days my
videos produced over 8 600 views my
watch time in minutes totaled over 17
000 and I've netted 48 subscribers and
this is an overall okay so I can
actually see when I publish videos and I
can see the date they were published and
here I'm looking at you know total views
over this particular date range I can
also see specifics on a particular video
so I could see the top video in terms of
minutes here I could see this particular
video had 602 minutes over the last 28
days so here I could see views on a
particular video so this is just an
overview I could certainly look at some
other information if I click on reach
viewers I could see the total impression
so how many times my video was viewed or
how many people looked at it okay and
then the click-through rate so here I
could see the different traffic sources
so 29 came externally okay here I could
see 25 came within YouTube itself I
could see how many times the video was
viewed and played via playlist via
suggested video so I could see different
ways in which the traffic found my video
and actually watched it here I could see
externally how people were able to find
my video us and I could see 46 percent
found it via Google search see some lots
of information here about sources of
traffic how the traffic got to these
videos so I could see then once the
traffic found my videos how many times
they actually saw it and viewed it and
then watched it so that's how many times
I was able to reach viewers via
different sources and then their
reaction to that how many times they saw
it and watched it here I can click on
interest viewers so again I could see
the top videos in terms of watch time I
could see the top playlist so here I
could see my partners playlist was the
top playlist so I could see some
interest here in terms of average view
duration and then here we have build an
audience so we can look at specific
audiences if we have them built in
YouTube to see how many people actually
watch my videos so here I get see 88
percent of the people who watched my
videos over the last 28 days were not
even subscribed so that tells me a lot
of people are finding my videos spending
some time watching them if they're not
subscribed so we're trying to get them
to subscribe to our channel so they can
watch more so a lot of information here
in YouTube itself about how our video is
performed again this is good Insight
because ideally what you want to do is
you really want to take a look at a
specific video see how it's performing
so if I just click on one particular
video I can actually see the audience
retention over the course of the video
itself I could see the ways in which
people found the video okay again
externally or via YouTube search I could
see how many people liked it or disliked
it I could see all sorts of information
on a particular video itself or an
overview of my channel so that's all all
available to you in YouTube analytics
under YouTube studio so take advantage
of us if you're publishing videos on a
regular basis you want to hone in on how
your videos are performing so if you
have any additional questions about
YouTube analytics or YouTube in general
take a look at our video that we created
earlier this year about how to create a
YouTube channel we go into some in-depth
insights into YouTube itself especially
YouTube analytics so take a look at that
video and if you have any other insights
about YouTube analytics or analytics in
general go ahead and put a comment below
this video so let's turn our attention
to competitor spine tools very important
to keep tabs on what the competition's
doing and there are a lot of tools out
there so when it comes to social we can
use a freemium tool like Sprout social
to listen in on our competitors we can
use another freemium tool all social
blade there's a popular tool out there
called spyfu that's freemium as well Moz
we looked at Moz earlier for keyword
organic Moz is a great tool for also
leveraging our competitors in terms of
backlinks and buzzsumo so that's another
Freeview tool get there lots of tools
out there these are just examples of
some of the tools that we use here at
simply learn I use personally and
professionally to get a sense of what
our competition's doing so why would we
want to use a competitor spine tool well
it may sound like a very straightforward
question but there are lots of reasons
why and so let's look at some of these
reasons and the first reasons we really
want to identify you know our
competitors backlinks and monitor
changes in the ranking so the reason why
we have this is the top bullet point is
because SEO organic search is a
long-term strategy on page off page
website very tactical and creative
there's a lot going on with SEO a lot
going on and sometimes it takes a long
time to rank for something and a lot of
SEO does depend on relevancy relevancy
being how many quality backlinks are
linked to you so it's always good to
leverage what your competitors are doing
so you can see how you stack up and so
that's why this is up there as number
one we want to be able to really take a
look at what our competitors are doing
another example would be hey how much a
traffic a competitors gaining on certain
keywords this could go either way for
paid search organic search what are
competitors bidding on are they really
getting traffic from those keywords so
there are tools out there that help us
leverage what our competitions doing
okay we can also identify our
competitors top performing content for
Relevant topics okay we can determine
what our competitors website referral
traffic is okay we can pull our compare
editor's data and compare it with their
own campaigns so lots of tools out there
to help you do this and we may want to
track the total amount of clicks a
competitor receives and how much they
pay for each keyword so let's go ahead
and take a look at a few examples how we
can leverage all these bullet points
that we just discussed and so we're
going to start out with Sprout social
and Sprout social is a tool I use it's a
social media platform there's a lot of
things you can do with Sprout social
definitely generate reports for your
social media platforms you could set up
post that get published at a certain
time and day but there's also one
particular tool in here called listening
and so what we could do is we just put
in for example RV rentals in Twitter so
what we're doing is we're actually
listening to see who else is tweeting
about RV rentals so we could do this for
Twitter we could do it Facebook some
other social media platforms the whole
idea here on Sprout social is to get a
sense of what our competitors are doing
so we could have easily put in a brand
name we're just going General here
because we want to rank for the keyword
RV rentals and so here we could take a
look at you know what some of these
particular brands are doing like go RV
rentals Cruise America RV we could see
just scroll down and we can get a sense
of in particular what people are
tweeting about what other companies are
tweeting when it comes to this
particular keyword RV rentals now if I
want to hone in on a particular
competitor I could just really refine my
search for that competitor's brand name
so RV share so here I can take a look at
you know what they're doing when they're
posting or tweeting how long ago the
time of day get an idea of what they're
actually saying what campaigns they're
promoting okay I can get a sense of
everything about out this tweet and so
here I can scroll down and I can see
what's been shared by other people for
this particular brand and I can see a
lot of people are as an example
retweeting this particular giveaway and
so to me it just gives me a sense in
this particular example on Twitter as to
what our competitors doing okay let's
start our attention to SEO so remember
that first bullet point we want to get a
sense of what our competitors are doing
when it comes to backlinks and so Moz
has a great tool called link Explorer
and Link Explorer there allows us to
actually compare link profiles so for my
domain I can go ahead and put my
competitors domains in there and
definitely get a sense of you know how
many links my competitors have external
Intel internal I can get a sense of the
domain Authority I can get a sense of
page Authority linking domains so I can
really do a uh comparison across my
domain and my competitors domains to get
a snapshot of how I compare against my
competitors so this gives me an overview
of everything I need to know organically
now Moz also has a another great tool
under link Explorer called link
intersect and I like link intersect I
use it a lot because if our competitors
really have a number of external links
and domains pointing to their site and
they have a better domain Authority and
Page Authority then you know I want to
be able to you know see what they're
doing where they're linking who's
linking to them I want to get be able to
get a snapshot of why is their domain so
much better than ours in terms of
authority and so the link intersect
actually allows me to do that so I can
go ahead and put my competitors domains
in there and then I can find
Opportunities and so you just click on
opportunities and you can see where my
site intersects with their site and if
it doesn't actually intersect then I
have an opportunity to actually try and
get a link on that particular site so
that's what the link intersect report
does it allows me to see where my links
intersect with my competitors and if it
doesn't intersect then I have an
opportunity to generate a backlink so
that's ideally what the link intersect
tool is in mods it allows me to really
get a sense of you know where I'm
linking and where my competitors linking
now what we can also do is also take
advantage of another report under moz's
link Explorer and the discovered and
lost report so we could put in our
domain or we could put even our
competitors domain in there and we can
get a sense of what domains were found
and linked to them so really within mods
we can get a good snapshot of what
websites are linking to our competitors
we get a good snapshot of the overall
links to our competitor sites and
specifically what sites so the whole
idea is if it's good for our competitors
meaning they're linking from a site that
has good domain Authority and low spam
score then it's probably a site I want
to be able to tackle as well okay so you
have discovered and lost okay you have
comparing link profiles and you have
link intersect so those are three good
reports you can leverage right in moz's
link Explorer tool now there's one more
report we can leverage in Moz and that's
the inbound links report and so we can
go ahead and type in our competitors
domain here and again we can get a
snapshot of what their domain Authority
is Page Authority for the home page but
really this is what we're after linking
domains so this particular domain has
over 9 000 linking domains so what we
can do is actually go through and see
based on domain Authority I could sort
by domain Authority where these pages
are being linked from and so here I can
see Reddit
so a lot of Reddit here which is a good
site for backlinking New York Times so
you know there's a lot of different uh
sites here Washington Post so I can get
a good snapshot of my competitor by
seeing every link that's pointing to
them now of course I don't want to go
through 9 000 links I can really just
hone in on a specific link Source or
link type or link state so I can really
filter it if I wanted to I can export
the report and do some further analysis
but really the whole idea here as I
could see what URL is linking to this
particular competitor site what the
anchor text is with the page and domain
Authority is so this gives me a really
really good Insight on all the
backlinking that my competitor has and
again if I'm trying to catch my
competitor it's probably not a bad idea
to look at what they're doing and even
copy what they're doing in terms of
backlinking so if we're not on Reddit
then we probably need to be on Reddit
because if that's where our competitor
is and they're getting good link juice
from Reddit which has a domain authority
of 90. then hey if it's good for the
goose it's good for the gander so they
say so inbound links is a just another
good report you can leverage in Moz
under the link Explorer reporting tool
now if I want to get a good snapshot as
to what my competitors doing on search
exactly well look no further than spy
food so spyfu is a another tool that you
can leverage from a PPC SEO perspective
you know from an SEO perspective you got
some backlinking data as well just like
you did in Moz from a PPC perspective
you can get some good keyword insights
and so here I just went ahead and typed
in the domain and what this is going to
do is just give me an overall snapshot
but for my competitor's domain so here I
could see you know how many organic
keywords they're found for the estimated
monthly SEO clicks they're getting based
on the volume of those keywords okay I
could see here the keywords their top
competitors also rank for the rank
history 12 years so this particular
domain's been around a long time okay so
that's on the organic side I can flip
over to the paid side and I could see
that they are doing paid search I could
see 5000 plus keywords they're bidding
on okay based on that what they're
actually paying and then I could see you
know some of the other competitors
listed here from a paid perspective and
an organic perspective I could see the
shared keyword overlap okay now again
you can pay for this because it's
freemium and get some really good
insights as to how your domain compares
to your competitors so I'm using the
free version and here the free version
spy Fusion just giving me some overall
data on the specific domain I entered in
and so I entered in my competitors you
can certainly enter in your own domain
to get a sense of organic keywords and
paid keywords so you can see top
keywords top paid keywords okay this is
Google ads okay so this is what
recommendations as to what to purchase
okay here you can see some even some at
Google ads history I could see exactly
what ad copy my competitor actually
wrote and for what keyword and then I
could see some organic ranking history
here as I keep scrolling down this
overview report so I can see for RV rent
where they rank and then I can see
inbound links just like I did in Moz spy
Foos providing me with some insight as
to hey what links are pointing to them
and what the domain strength is and how
many clicks they expect to receive so
this is all free data take it or leave
it but it's all free data available to
you under spyfish spy view gives you
kind of an overview for free some really
in-depth analysis if you actually pay
for it and it just really hones in on
what your competitors are bidding for
paid wise and what they're ranking for
organic wise and so spy food is a really
good tool to leverage if you just want
to get a snapshot of how your competitor
uh overlaps with you so let's turn our
attention to Google analytics because in
Google analytics under audience I can go
to benchmarking and basically the
benchmarking reports allows me to see
what the industry as a whole is doing
compared to my own website now the
caveat here on this particular report is
that it's all Anonymous data so I can't
exactly see what competitor is doing
what in this report but if I hone in on
my industry in this case autos and
vehicles and I hone in on a specific
country or adjust the size of the daily
sessions that I get then I can see hey
analytics in this case in this example
I'm sharing
8863 web properties okay so they're
sharing the data for over 8 000 web
properties and I can compare those web
properties against my own so if we're
all in the same industry it gives me a
sense here as to how I stack up against
the industry as a whole in this case as
it pertains to channels so you can see
here red not good green is good so in
the industry we're not doing as good as
others in the same industry who are
receiving the same amount of sessions
now we could certainly adjust and we can
adjust our Locale and if we do that
Google's going to be able to adjust how
many web properties are actually
contributing to the report and so when
analytics makes that adjustment it we're
going to be able to see in this case
just New Zealand so we're going to
adjust for New Zealand and we're gonna
go with the
4999 and so we could see there are about
you know 300 something web properties
contributing 47 web properties now
contributing to this report so for
focused on the New Zealand region and
this is the amount of traffic we get
we're now comparing us against 47 other
Anonymous web properties so now if I go
back to the report after I've honed in
I'm looking at channels and I can see
how many sessions we're getting by
channels and how I compare against the
competition I can also measure up
against percentage of new sessions new
users pages per session average session
duration bounce rate but that's just
channels I can also do location and
devices so the whole idea behind this
report is yes you're not honing in on a
particular competitor but you're honing
in on your your industry so you're
getting a good idea as to how you
compare against your industry just by
making some adjustments in the
benchmarking report you obviously want
to make sure you're looking at the same
industry adjust for your country or
region adjust for the site size meaning
how many sessions you actually get on a
daily basis and then analytics will do
the rest they'll compare you against
those in your industry and so I find
this to be a good tool because it allows
me to stack up our site against those in
the industry and obviously if we're not
driving as many sessions especially say
from organic then we have our work cut
out for us okay so that's the whole idea
behind the benchmarking report now if
you want to get some good insight as to
what the competitors are doing and you
don't want to use a tool well look no
further you can always go to google.com
Okay so this is how we used to do it
back in the day before all these tools
became available you just typed in a key
word and we're going to type in RV
rentals and now we're going to be able
to see who's bidding on that keyword so
we could see we have a number of
different uh companies bidding on the
keyword we're interested in okay here I
can see some featured Snippets okay and
then I could see some organic search
results okay if I scroll down I'll be
able to see some other companies bidding
on that same keyword meaning they're
paying for RV rentals so if I clicked on
somebody's link here they're actually
going to pay Google for the click and so
this just gives me a good sense of you
know how many people are actually trying
to rank for this keyword or trying to be
found for this keyword so that's all I
did I just did a search now if I'm an
organic perspective if you really want
to hone in on your competition you can
always do the syntax all in title colon
and then hit enter so now I could see I
have 163
000 results and when does that tell me
that tells me that I have a 163
000 websites with RV rentals in the
title tag so if you're trying to
optimize for the keyword RV rentals as
an example then you know that you have a
000 different listings ahead of you that
you need to jump over in order to rank
for the keyword RV rentals so using the
All entitled syntax and the keyword
right after that actually just gives you
a more accurate picture of how many
sites are actually ahead of you for a
particular keywords so that's the whole
idea so if I get rid of the syntax and
you can see for RV rentals I have 132
million but that's not really accurate
because not all these listings have the
keyword RV rentals in the title Tag and
Title tag if you're working on organic
search is one of the key important
factors for ranking so you need to have
that keyword in the title tag so that's
the whole idea behind you using the All
entitled syntax it gives us a good idea
as to what our competition is doing and
how many sides we have to jump over to
get to number one on Google Now if
you're running Google ads just as we did
with RV rentals we went up there and we
saw we typed that in as a query and we
saw how many advertisers there were for
RV rentals now if we are running our own
campaigns Google ads actually has a good
report that I really like it's called
auction insights and so you can get to
auction insights just by clicking on
campaigns and then from campaigns click
on auction insights and when auction
insights allows us to see is what
competitors or domains are bidding on
the same keywords we are and so what
Google does here is it allows us to
actually see where we stack up against
our competition for all the keywords
we're bidding on and so here I'm looking
at year to date and here we could see us
and I can see our competitors okay so I
could see impression share so for if
we're talking about one key word every
keyword has a hundred percent impression
share how much of that impression share
are you getting and when we say
impression share meaning eyeballs when
we talk about eyeballs are we getting a
majority of the eyeballs or our
competitors get a majority of the
eyeballs so we can see our average
position I can see how often I overlap
with my competitors okay I could see how
often I'm above a particular competitor
I could see what percentage I'm at the
top of the page versus my competitors
the absolute top of page rate and then I
can see how often I outrank my
competitors and vice versa how often my
competitors outrank me so I could see
all this good insight as to what
competitors are bidding on the same
keywords I am okay so this is if you're
running Google ads okay so if you're
running Google ads okay you can just
click on the auction insights report you
can find them at the top navigation just
by clicking on campaigns and by doing so
you'll be able to gain some insights as
to where you stack up from a paid search
perspective against your competitors so
let's turn our attention to paid
marketing tools so if you're doing some
advertising on Google Bing LinkedIn you
probably want to work within those
platforms as the tool of choice so you
know if you're doing paid search on say
googlesearch.com or display you could be
doing display advertising on you know a
network like adroll or Google or you
could be doing social media paid ads say
on Facebook so whatever it is you're
doing you probably want to work within
that platform itself to get the ideal
data that you need okay so here are some
of the tools some of the places you can
go of course if you're working Google
ads you also have Google ads editor that
you can leverage okay and I'll show you
that in a couple minutes you have Google
ads Keyword Planner of course both of
these are paid if you're running
campaigns okay so Bing if you're running
campaigns on Bing okay you get all this
good data that you can digest through
some reporting okay you also have some
third-party tools out there that you
also have to pay for and word stream
okay so word stream is a third party
tool that you can leverage Bing and
Google our actual advertising Network so
you would advertise on the platform
itself and get all the data you need
right in the platform and leverage a lot
of the tools that they have available in
the platform as I mentioned you could
also use Google ads editor so Bing also
has their own editor as well so and as
well as Facebook so you can use an
editor type version and I'll show you
that here in a couple minutes but let's
talk about why we want to use the tools
in the platform itself well we want to
be able to monitor how our ads
performing so which ad receives the most
traffic as an example we want to
identify keywords that are performing
for us okay so our keywords converting
not converting are they cost us a lot of
money and not netting a high enough
return for us so we want to keep an eye
on that because if we want to monitor
our cost okay across different locations
and devices not only costs but we want
to also monitor how our ads are
performing across different locations of
devices keywords across different
locations and devices so we want to be
able to measure by device okay so we
also want to analyze competitors data
and as we showed you in the competitor
section Google as an example has auction
insights reporting analytics has
benchmarking so Google itself does
provide some information in the case of
auction insights as to how your
competitors are performing against you
on Google search so that's on the page
search side then you have display okay
so display advertisements okay you're
across a different network so they're
different types of networks out there
for example Admiral okayo seltra is
another paid version of or pay tool you
can use in wide orbit so these are some
of the paid marketing tools you can
leverage of course I like to stay if I'm
advertising on Google I like to stay on
and Google ads and measure my display
performance that way but if you're on
adroll for example then you want to
leverage ad roles reporting platform and
some of the tools they have to offer so
if we look at display why do we want to
leverage some of these tools well just
like search for example where we want to
look at keyword and AD performance same
kind of concept here we want to be able
to monitor whether we have the right
keywords and write customer engagement
so when when it comes to display we want
to be able to to make sure we're
choosing the right audience of course
that means looking at not only audience
insights but our Target insights as well
are we reaching the Right audience when
it comes to display and Google has a
good breakdown that I'm going to be able
to show you here in a couple of minutes
okay so we want to improve our campaigns
by monitoring our competitors display
ads as well so there are tools available
that'll help you do that and that's on
the display side and if we look at
Social okay why what tools can we use on
social well you got Facebook ads manager
okay you got ad espresso quiet tweepy
you get all these cool paid search tools
again I usually stick with where I'm
advertising so if I'm advertising on
LinkedIn or Twitter I'm going to
leverage that platform but just know
that there are other tools available for
you so a social like display it's all
about targeting our audience so for
these some of the tools like on Facebook
we can review and relaunch our ad
campaigns based on target audience we
can measure conversions and gain
insights in this example about Facebook
users how are our users interacting with
our ads and then we want to Target
People based on their activities such as
purchase intent device usage travel
preferences Etc so social allows us to
do that and then with Facebook as an
example we can monitor any a B test we
run for example if we're running call to
action tests we can measure the results
that right in Facebook and I'm going to
show you an example of that here shortly
so let's jump right into Google ads and
look at some tools available to us from
the search side of the house so if we're
running search campaigns right in Google
ads we could see campaign data we can
see keyword data we could see add data
so for example if I want to see what ads
are performing I'm just going to click
on my ads and extensions okay and here
are my ads and now I could see what ads
are performing in terms of clicks
click-through rates
Etc and so that way I can go ahead and
pause ads activate ads so that's right
here in the Google ads platform itself
now if I want to look at specific
keywords I can do that so I can see what
keywords are driving traffic and clicks
here I could just sort by clicks and now
I can see not only what keywords are
driving clicks I could see what the
click-through rate is I can see the
Impressions how many people actually
viewed my ad after click typing in a
keyword query that I'm betting on I
could see how much I've paid by keyword
and more importantly I want to be able
to see conversions or conversion rate
and then with Google ads you have
qualities for so we want to be able to
measure qualities for so so this is a
Google ads keyword reporting and so the
great thing about the keyword reporting
is that there's some other features
available to me here so here I can add
negative keywords okay just by clicking
on negative keywords I can also see a
Search terms report and so when it comes
to search terms I can actually see what
specific keywords people typed in and
based on the keyword that somebody typed
in as a query I can see what match type
triggered that particular ad and so if I
see a keyword query that I don't
particularly care to be shown for or I
want my ad shown for then I can go ahead
and just select it and I can add it as a
negative keyword okay so that tool is
available to you right in Google ads
okay and then you have the auction
Insight so we've reviewed the auction
insights when we're looking at
competitive analysis and so here if we
look at the auction insights we'll be
able to adjust our date range and we'll
be able to see basically you know who
else is bidding on the keywords and what
the impression share is what their
average position is what their overlap
rate is position above rate top of page
absolute top of page right now ranking
share so once we have Google has data
then they'll be able to share that
information with you okay so that's just
key words but there's a cool tool that I
really like and I leverage it for SEO
and pay-per-click and that's Google's
Keyword Planner so if you click on tools
and then you click on Keyword Planner
we'll be able to Leverage The Keyword
Planner and the whole idea behind the
Keyword Planner is do we want to
discover new keywords or for the
keywords we have selected we can get
volume and forecast on that so here
let's type in a keyword mail delivery
and if I click get started okay so
Google's going to give me some other
keyword ideas and they're going to give
me what the average monthly searches are
for that keyword they're going to let me
know the competition they're going to
give me a range in terms of how much I
can expect to pay for that keyword so if
I happen to click on that keyword I can
add it to a plan and then once I've
added to a plan then I can go ahead and
look at that plan and measure what kind
of volume I'm going to get and how much
I can expect to pay so now once I've
added my keyword to that plan I can go
ahead and see how many clicks and
Impressions and costs and click the rate
and average cost per click I can expect
to spend so and this is based on a
maximum CPC of two dollars so I can go
ahead and adjust my plan accordingly if
I want to in order to see basically how
much I can expect to spend so that's the
whole idea behind the keyword plan
Banner in terms of choosing new keywords
and once you choose keywords you're
interested in bidding on you can
actually do a forecast to see exactly
how much you can expect to spend how
many clicks how many Impressions you can
expect to get and if you have conversion
set up how many conversions you can
expect to receive so that's all part of
Google's keyword plan that's viewing
forecast as well as choosing keywords so
there are so many different tools and
features within Google ads we need a
whole whole segment just on this so
really I'm just going to highlight some
of the more important tools and features
so I've mentioned the Keyword Planner I
imagine the campaigns keywords and ads
reports another thing I would look at in
Google ads again we mentioned this as
one of our key defining why would we use
it bullet point and that's because of
devices so we mentioned devices why
would we use Google ads reporting tool
because we want to look at devices and
we want to be able to see what devices
are driving traffic from what campaign
and then the cool thing about Google ads
is right in Google ads platform you can
go ahead and do a bit adjustment so if I
increase my bid adjustment for example
on mobile phones then my particular ad
in this particular campaign is going to
show more than on computer so I can
always decrease it for example do a bit
adjustment on computer and that means
I'm going to show my ads less so I can
go ahead and do bid adjustments based on
device that's the cool thing of working
right in Google ads platform is you can
make adjustments right here in the
platform based on devices well you also
have locations too so we mentioned that
as one of the reasons why we want to use
some of these tools and if I see a
particular location I'm not interested
in advertising well I can always select
it and I can always just pause it or
remove it so or I can change the bit
adjustment on a location as well so I
can make a lot of different changes
right in the Google ads platform for
those seasoned and search advertising
paid search advertising especially on
Google ads you can always use Google ads
editor all you need to do is just do a
search for Google ads editor you can
download it so basically what Google ads
editor is it's a it's a tool it's the
software that you work your ca with your
campaigns on locally so you're making
changes to your campaigns on your
computer and basically when you're done
making changes you can always upload
them to Google ads to the account on
Google ads in the cloud so to speak so
that's the whole idea behind Google ads
editor it's a great tool for you to use
if you want to make household changes
really quick for example I'm looking at
an account with a bunch of campaigns so
now if I click on one of those campaigns
I could see the ad groups here okay so
for example I just wanted to turn off
all these ad groups I can just highlight
them all and just click status enable to
paused and I can revert back if I want
to okay so you can make household
changes so here I could see the campaign
the ad group level if I choose an ad
group then I can see some keywords and
again I can make changes at nauseum here
I can copy I can paste I can delete okay
so I can make a lot of changes really
quick write in Google ads editor and
that's the whole point of editor is to
go ahead and work locally while somebody
else is working locally on the same
account you could both be working
simultaneously and being more efficient
on getting things done in the campaign
now if you are working with somebody
else on the campaign you want to make
sure that you get recent change changes
so if I say get recent changes to all
campaigns what Google editor is going to
do is contact Google ads in the cloud
and download all those changes so here I
can see the changes being download and
editor from Google ads and when it's
done it's going to highlight all the
changes that have been made and so once
I'm done reviewing those changes I can
go ahead and click done and now I know I
have the recent latest changes in editor
so now I can go ahead and continue to
make some changes and when I'm done
making changes I can go ahead and post
them so that's the beauty of Google ads
editor Bing has a version Facebook has a
version it allows you to again go with
the keyword level the ad group level
okay you can look at ads itself and make
changes to the ads okay you could do a
lot of different things write an editor
in fact you could do pretty much most of
what you could do in Google ads you can
do in Google ads editor and so that's
Google ads Editor to me I would
recommend it if you're experience with
Google ads again it's software you have
to download it you're going to use it on
your computer as software but when you
make changes all you need to do is post
those changes or get recent changes that
have been made on Google ads and so
that's Google editor ads editor in
summary now let's go back into Google
ads and talk about display advertising
because display is a different network
but the platform's still the same and
some of the same tools are available
from the search Network as well as for
the Display Network right in Google ads
so if I want to take a look at a
campaign and AD group on the Display
Network I could just click on that ad
group and I can look at the ads that are
running for that particular ad group on
the Display Network so here the
difference being on the display network
is you can use image ads on the search
Network you can only use text ads so
here I can look get image ads and I
could see how they're performing in fact
you could even go a step further and use
responsive display ads so Google has
responsive display ads meaning it's
going to respond to what's performing
best okay and so now I can see clicks
Impressions click through rate Etc right
on on my ads and extensions report in
Google ads platform now this happens to
be retargeting campaign so if we click
on audiences we'll be able to see what
audiences we're targeting here okay so
when this report loads when you run
retargeting campaigns you're targeting a
specific audience and so we want to be
able to see okay of the audiences we
have set up what audience is performing
best okay so here I can see a Breakout
by audience again I could see the same
metrics I could see on the search side I
could see clicks and Impressions click
the rate more importantly I want to be
able to measure conversions okay so
that's the whole idea when you're in
these platforms and you're paying for
ads is you want to be able to measure
against conversions and you can also
measure against cost per conversion
conversion rate okay so those are some
key metrics to measure up against
whether it's audience keyword add
whatever the dimension is so here on the
Display Network we can get a sense of
demographics okay so unlike the search
Network the Display Network allows us to
see demographic data and so now I can
see an age breakout or an age range
breakout that Google provides us and I
could see again based on the age range
breakout which age range has the most
clicks Impressions
Etc including conversions so you also
have the opportunity on the display
networked at keywords you have the
opportunity to add topics and you have
the opportunity to see placements or run
placements so here if I click on where
ADS have shown I can actually see where
my ads have shown up for this display
campaign and Google ads allows you the
ability to go ahead and you can exclude
it from the ad group exclude a specific
placement from a campaign so you could
take action on a specific placement and
I could see the type of placement
whether it's a mobile app whether it's a
site I can go ahead and see exactly
where that placement was so that's the
placements report you have demographics
you have audiences you have keywords you
have all these different reports
available to you on the Google ads
platform so before we jump over to
social media paid search advertising I
just want to remind you we do have you
know a nice tutorial on Google ads okay
so take a look at the Google ads
tutorial we have set up on on YouTube
okay if you search for Google ads
tutorial 2019 this is a good uh tutorial
on everything related to Google ads so
check out this video because in today's
webinar we're just mentioning tools
across the board and if you are
advertising on Google ads as most people
do then you could see just how powerful
it is and all the different features
that are available so take a look at the
video it's a nice complimentary video to
this one this digital marketing tools
and this will give you a nice and deeper
insight into everything that's available
on Google ads and if you have any tools
or features on Google ads whether it's
the search Network or whether that's the
Display Network then feel free to
comment below this video happy to hear
your comments about what tools and
reports and features you specifically
use in Google ads so let's move into to
uh Facebook ads manager and show you how
the platform looks when you're running
ads on Facebook so we can look at all
the different tools and reports
available here so here we could see if
we're in the Facebook ads manager we
could see our campaigns we could see our
ad sets and we can see our ads so just
like on Google ads you have less side
navigation so we can drill down so if we
want to see ad sets for example we could
just click on ad sets that are showing
up in this particular account and here
we can see we have two ad sets that are
live so if I click on one of these ad
sets I'll be able to see an actual ad
that's running here and so for the
actual ad that's running I can then see
the results of that ad and how it's
performing for example you know how many
clicks it's received what the reach is
what the impressions are so Impressions
similar to Google ads how many people
are actually be looking at the ad and I
can see the cost per click here at one
dollar as an example and so now I can go
in and I can go ahead and look at the ad
performance and go ahead and change out
that ad if it's not performing to my
expectation so if I click on more tools
and then creatives I can just simply
click on creatives and then I can
actually see the create is I actually
have running for that campaign I
selected so now I can see all the
creatives that are running and I can see
the results of those creatives so
Facebook ads manager also has a
different reporting so if I click on the
reports pull down menu you can see here
I could see some standard reports by add
ad set age and gender and then I can see
all reports here listed out by placement
by placement and device time of day
country Etc so if we just look at age
and gender will be able to get a
breakout age and gender here so you can
see by campaign I'm looking at all
campaigns here and I'm looking at just
age and gender I can certainly deselect
one of these and I can look at a
specific time range so now I could see
who's looking at my ad specifically so
here I could see 35 to 44 female I can
see the reach Impressions and how often
they're actually seeing my ad now this
is key for Facebook because if
somebody's seen your ad a lot they're
probably going to tune out to it so
that's what makes the frequency metric
so important on Facebook because then we
can go ahead and you know turn off that
particular age and gender if we needed
to and we could see how much we spent so
this just gives you some idea of the
type of reporting that's available in
Facebook ads manager now the great thing
about phase Facebook reporting and ads
manager is you know I can group or
ungroup uh my Dimensions if I needed to
I could change the view and arrange
columns I can get rid of columns just as
you would in Google ads reporting very
similar stature here so I have a lot of
flexibility here on how I review the
reports you know you got different
metrics that you could pick and choose
as well okay and you got lots of
different flexibility when you're
looking at the reports on how your
campaigns are performing now here I can
pick and choose I can choose campaign ad
set ads objective again I can choose
different demographics so I have a lot
of options available to me in terms of
how I want to you know view the
performance of my campaign view the
performance of my ad set or my ad now
remember if you're in Facebook you can
always go in and edit the campaign you
can edit the ad set remember in the
asset that's where a lot of your
decisions are going to be made including
how you want to drive the traffic okay
what your budget is okay you can
basically choose your audience here so
you're going to be able to choose what
type of campaign it's going to be and
based on the campaign you're going to go
ahead and choose the kind of audience
you want to focus in on you're going to
be able to choose the location the age
range the gender so all of this is going
to be set up in the ad set or the
campaign or the ad if you go ahead and
edit an ad remember you can do a b
testing as well so you have a lot of
different options and features available
to you writing ads manager when you're
managing your paid search campaigns on
Facebook so if you want some more
information about all the different
features and tools and Facebook ads
manager check out the Facebook ads
tutorial tutorial 2019 a webinar that we
did earlier this year in addition you
can also look at another one that we did
on Facebook called Facebook advertising
tips and strategies so that should give
you some sense of everything related to
Facebook ads and how to take advantage
of the Facebook ads manager platform so
if there's anything on social that we
may have missed or that you use feel
free to add a comment below the video
we'd love to hear your feedback okay
let's talk about some affiliate
marketing tools let's turn our attention
affiliate marketing a lot of affiliate
marketing platforms out there the number
one probably is Commission Junction also
known as CJ they're an affiliate
platform they have a freemium model
meaning you can have a free trial but
basically you're gonna have to move on
and pay for the platform likewise for
house offers you have volume you really
when it comes to affiliate marketing a
lot of platforms out there click Inc A1
so a lot of these are Brokers per se and
when I say Brokers like for example with
CJ you as a merchant or you as a
publisher can get in touch with a
merchant you as a merchant can get in
touch with a publisher meaning CJ helps
bridge the gap between you finding
somebody to build your network with okay
so that's what really affiliate
marketing is and you really need a
platform to kind of put it all together
and and so a lot of a lot of affiliate
marketing platforms we're actually going
to take a look at CJ and go through some
of the features in the platform here
shortly but let's just take a look at
why we need these affiliate marketing
tools well these affiliate marketing
tools identify you know Affiliates
influors employees other Advocates you
want to partner with so again you can be
on the merch inside you could be
actually selling a product and you're
going to want somebody to help you sell
that product somebody with a website
who's an influencer who drives a lot of
traffic to their own site who you know
does sell reputable brand Etc so you
need somebody to help you introduce you
to these sites okay so CJ and some of
these other marketing platforms
affiliate marketing platforms do that
okay so these tools are there to do the
introductions the brokering the
relationship so the other benefit here
is you can contract with Affiliates and
track the traffic and conversions well
what do I mean by that well if you do
use cj.com by no means am I only
endorsing that platform there are plenty
others out there but whatever platform
you use You're Gonna Want to be able to
set up terms and conditions with that
particular affiliate so you can set up a
terms and conditions for say 10 off all
sales as an example okay well you're
getting a platform that will help you
broker that contract okay contract terms
or program terms furthermore you're
gonna need a platform to help you track
hey is this affiliate helping me drive
traffic or is this affiliate driving
traffic to my products and is this
affiliate helping me sell so you the
these platforms help you do just that
okay so you can gain High website
rankings with the help of your affiliate
meaning that hey your affiliate can be
promoting your product and if they're
promoting your product you have a chance
to show up via paid search organic
search off other websites so social so
you have a lot of benefits to working
with affiliate marketing in itself and
the tools available will help you gain
website rankings as one example we want
to be able to track certain metrics Okay
so so an affiliate marketing you have
earnings per click EPC as an example
most platforms measure EPC from a seven
day period to a three month period okay
you can also figure out what the actual
cost per click is just like you do on
say Google search you can actually
measure that in affiliate okay you want
to eliminate fraudulent clicks
Impressions and conversions so any
affiliate platform worth its weight is
going to help you understand you know
how many Impressions and clicks and
conversions you're getting and help you
manage that in terms of fraudulent
clicks or hey if you're getting a lot of
Impressions and no clicks that's a
problem too so these platforms are
really built on helping you manage your
relationship with the affiliate by
offering uh all sorts of reports and
tools you know the other big benefit
here to affiliate marketing tool is hey
we can influence our customers
throughout their buying Journey so we
could set up different promotions based
on hey did somebody go to the website
did somebody see our product does
somebody click on a product did somebody
go into the shopping cart with our
product did somebody purchase our
product so there's all sorts of steps in
the funnel so to speak and hey you can
work with an affiliate a publisher to
influence your customers throughout that
purchasing funnel throughout that
Journey so let's go ahead and log in
here so when you log in like any other
digital marketing tool any other
platform you're going to have your own
settings and whatnot so really the whole
idea behind any affiliate marketing tool
is really there to manage your
Publishers who do you want as a
publisher who do you want selling your
product you obviously want somebody
who's relevant somebody who's going to
be able to sell the product somebody who
has a targeted audience that's similar
to yours okay so we go into cj.com we're
going to log in and here you can see a
Publisher's link so we're going to click
on the Publishers link and remember when
you sign up Publishers you have to have
program terms and so if we click on
Publishers program terms we're going to
be able to see all the different program
terms available so here we could see the
different program terms we have set up
for certain Publishers so we just click
on that we'll be able to see that's the
default program term so remember you
could set up your own program term for
any publisher so as a best practice if
you have Publishers who are actually
performing well who are selling your
products maybe you want to offer them a
little bit more on the commission side
maybe you want to sweeten the deal maybe
you know These Guys these Publishers get
better program terms versus say other
Publishers who don't and so here we can
see the program terms basically you
could see what the terms are the action
and the different policies here so
everything you need to do to manage that
publisher in terms of payment is done
under the program terms now if the
program terms are met the publisher
actually sells your products CJ is the
broker they're the ones who are going to
initiate the payment based on the
program terms so be careful in the
program terms you want to be able to set
them appropriately CJ has templates CJ
has some default program terms that you
could use and offer up to different
Publishers So based on the program terms
that's how your Publishers are going to
get paid and so here you can have as
many different program terms as you want
There's No Limit here you want to be
able to align and reward program terms
again based on performance and so here
we can see what Publishers are under
what program terms so again if your
publisher is performing well sweeten the
deal offer them a better program program
terms and so you can align Publishers
with different program terms and so
that's the whole idea behind program
terms is you want to be able to align
Publishers with that so when you sign up
a publisher they're going to get a line
with the program term meaning what are
they going to get paid for selling your
product now if we want to manage by
status instead of by program terms we
could see all the different
organizations we have in our Network
these are our Publishers we're the
affiliate we're the ones selling the
product we want to know who's selling
who's not selling and so we can look at
all our Publishers by program terms or
by status okay so basically you can see
here the term status whether it's active
or not earnings basically what they've
sold over the last basically seven days
or three months so you could look at
basically how your Publishers are
performing just by clicking on manage by
status here in cj.com so when you're
looking at reports in cj.com or really
any other affiliate program you might
see the acronym EPC this stands for
earnings per click actually it's a
little misleading it's actually earnings
per 100 clicks so basically CJ
calculates you know how much are
publisher is actually making per click
you know just like paid search we're
paying Google X amount per click it's
the same thing here we can't or these
Publishers can't make any money if they
don't generate clicks so that's why you
have an EPC model or metric so to speak
so you can measure earnings per click CJ
does it over seven a period and over a
three month period so you could sort
based on seven day or three months to
see who's earning the most per click and
in terms of Publishers now you can
select under Publishers groups now you
can group your Publishers okay so if you
have say a group of Publishers in a
specific region like the United States
or India or if you're just focused on
the United States and say you have
Publishers in different states like
Texas California Missouri Arkansas well
you can group those Publishers into
different groups and you can look at
your different group names here so here
we could see Canada and so we have our
Publishers grouped into a group called
Canada why because they're based in
Canada makes sense so you want to be
able to organize your Publishers because
the whole idea Beyond affiliate
marketing CJ is you want to be able to
get the best Publishers available for
your network and so as you get more
Publishers for your network you'll be
able to basically start grouping in them
where it makes sense now the example I
gave you is by geography you could do by
geography or you could do by publisher
status meaning my best performing
Publishers go into a group if they're in
a group then they get a line with a
certain program term so you could group
your Publishers Any Way You Want by
status meaning they're selling more
these are our best performing Publishers
or by region or you know by promotion I
mean how you group your Publishers is
totally up to you however take advantage
of the option to create publisher groups
because the whole idea again I'm gonna
repeat it is you want to get Publishers
and you want to start building your base
of Publishers because the more
Publishers you have the more chance you
are to sell your product remember if
nobody clicks on your product then
nobody's gonna buy your product so if
you have Publishers who are promoting
your product for you then you have a
good opportunity to sell it so the more
Publishers you have on board the better
the opportunity so now once you have
Publishers you can start grouping these
Publishers accordingly to whatever makes
sense is a business decision just know
the options available in CJ to group
Publishers let's turn our attention to
social media marketing tools social
media always a great topic to talk about
so we're going to finish up all our
digital marketing tools with social
media we talked about SEO paid
competition affiliate email you know web
analytics it's just appropriate to
finish up with social media because
social media has so many tools available
so many okay the first one I can think
about it here is HootSuite HootSuite is
a great social media marketing tool to
use okay it's a freemium okay you can
set up a free trial here you basically a
base account and then you can use
HootSuite to do a lot of things anything
from setting up landing pages to
actually publishing content to listening
HootSuite to me is one of the most
powerful social media marketing tools
available you got buffer buffer is a
paid version but you can actually set up
a low cost or free account actually on
Buffer and then move to a paid account
okay you got tweet deck it's been around
a long time that is actually free and I
would recommend tweet Tech and we're
going to take a look at that here in a
couple minutes okay and then you got
Sprout social Sprout social is another
social marketing platform summer to
HootSuite do a lot of reporting a lot of
publishing you can a lot of listening
and so we're going to take a look at
Sprout social today as well before we do
that let's go over why these tools are
important to us from a social media
perspective you're pumping out a lot of
content so you need to be able to
smartly efficiently you know schedule
and manage your post okay so you're not
just working likely with just one
platform like Facebook you're probably
on a number of different platforms
depending on your business depending on
your bandwidth depending on what you're
selling your products Etc your audience
obviously has a lot to do with it you
know it could be Instagram Pinterest you
want to be able to consolidate all that
and manage it in one place and that's
what social media marketing tools do
they allow you to manage everything in
one place so if you can manage
everything in one place then the social
media marketing platforms need to be
able to make it easy for you to add and
manage different accounts okay so a lot
of them have the ability for you to add
you know not just one Twitter account
but multiple Twitter accounts and not
just one social media platform but
multiple social media platforms and a
good social media marketing so worth its
weight will help you monitor the results
so monitor social media posts that help
Drive leads and sales in other words
you're going to have a lot of different
metrics associated with each social
media marketing platform okay which one
is actually doing its job okay so you
want to be able to easily manage these
platforms applications and websites very
efficiently okay so instead of having to
log into each platform is log into one
place get a sense of what's been posted
what the engagement is did they purchase
Etc and what you want to do is be able
to individually customize every social
media post across different platforms so
it just makes it a lot easier to do that
in these social media marketing tools
okay you don't want to send out a
blanket message across different
platforms you want to be able to go
ahead and customize a post depending on
what that post is depending on what the
product is what time of day what target
market what target audience so
customization is a lot easier using
these social media marketing tools you
want to be able to engage with brand
Advocates so listening is a good thing
with social media marketing tools using
the listening functionality so you can
actually see who is a brand Advocate
who's not a brand Advocate who's an
influencer who's not an influencer and
then of course you want to analyze the
behavior of your audience and optimize
individual posts on real-time data so if
for example you post something using one
of these social media marketing
platforms and you see it go viral then
you want to be able to react to that in
real time so you're going to be able to
see that in real time on these social
media marketing tools these platforms
like Sprouts social and HootSuite and
then you're going to be able to react to
that behavior and then of course
monitoring website traffic and
conversion rates that's key we always
want to monitor conversions based on our
kpis our business goals so there are
also a few important digital marketing
tools that can help you in different
ways okay so without further Ado let's
jump in and take a look at what's
available in terms of social media
marketing so just a quick reminder if
you are running ads on Facebook or
you're posting on Facebook as an example
or any platform in general that
platform's going to have its own metrics
if you will so for example Facebook has
something called Facebook insights
you'll be able to actually see you know
what's been posted based on you know the
last seven days in this example how many
page views you're getting engagements
recent posts so just to let you know yes
you can go into any one of these
platforms on its own and look at metrics
just like you can do if you're running
Facebook ads okay you can go right into
Facebook ads manager and view data there
okay so the whole point here though on
using a social media tool is that you
can and measure all that in one place so
if we log into sproutsocial I can set up
these accounts right into Sprout social
so I don't have to log into Twitter
individually or Facebook individually I
can link them up all within Sprout
social and then I can go to reports just
like I can with Facebook insights and
then once I'm in Facebook excuse me once
I'm in Sprouts social reporting then I
can go ahead just like I can in Facebook
insights except it's all right here for
me I can jump into you know Facebook and
dig a little bit deeper as to what's
going on with my account so I don't have
to log into Facebook directly I can see
you know the Impressions the engagement
the clicks over a period of time I can
see my audience growth I can see my
publishing Behavior how often my
publishing I can see the top post
individually I could see Impressions by
day you know a lot of this same material
same information is our ready and
Facebook insights so if it's available
on Facebook insights you know you're
definitely going to have it available in
a tool like Sprout social so you want to
be able to just efficiently log in and
jump from one platform to the other so
here you know I can go to Instagram you
know and look at Instagram data or I can
look at Twitter information so you want
to be able to efficiently jump from one
platform to the other using in this
example Sprout social now as I mentioned
as part of one of the benefits of a
social media tool is that you can
publish content you want to be able to
publish content because you want to be
able to organize and schedule
accordingly you don't want to be
submitting and Publishing content right
after one another okay you want to be
able to spread it out efficiently and
effectively and so here we could see you
know we could publish and schedule
content accordingly so all we have to do
is Click compose select a profile write
whatever we need to do you can schedule
it for tomorrow at a specific time and
there you go voila scheduled so this is
on Twitter okay so you know we could
choose another platform here it's just
that easy to schedule so you want to be
able to schedule accordingly because
again when you schedule something then
you want to look at the behavior of it
so it's just as simple as going from
publishing to reporting and then based
on when something got published you
could see the reaction of it and react
to it so another thing here that I like
about it's about social HootSuite a lot
of these other platforms do it really
well you got listening tools so you can
listen in on conversations that are
being had for example uh mail delivery
you know if we do mail delivery and
Twitter search we'll be able to see
what's been tweeted about mail
deliveries you know if that's the
business we're in we can refine our
search and choose a specific location a
radius to hone in if we're local Okay so
this is Sprout's social's example of
listening here let's take a look at
another example I'm in later.com so
later very similar Sprout social in that
it does a lot of the same things you can
actually schedule content on a
particular platform and one thing I like
about later here you can actually see it
visually you can see a calendar and
what's been scheduled so I could see
today I have scheduled something
scheduled at 1 15 local time and again I
have five profiles set up for this
account so I can pick and choose the
profile that I want to publish to so it
just makes it that much easier and I can
visually see it and that's important so
here I can click on media library so the
one thing about later.com is that you
know you have a library of images that
potentially you can reuse so if I click
on this image here okay I can get a
sense of when it was used and I can view
it on a calendar I can add label for it
so that's another benefit later is that
they have this media library here they
have conversations so I can actually
connect to a platform and listen in on
conversations that are being hacked
similar to The Listening tool in Sprout
social and they have analytics so you
can actually see right in later.com how
your particular social media platform is
performing so I could see it here over
seven days I can see the number of
followers have increased I could see the
growth rate I can see the number of
Impressions that I've received okay so I
want to be able to see how my particular
platforms performing over a period of
time so I can look at reach the law
profile views website clicks okay so I
can get a lot of good insights here
right in the analytics platform of later
you can look at specific post
performance so if we posted something I
could see basically how many likes it
received how many comments impressions
the reach and then if I wanted to I can
click on details and get more specific
information on it engagement rate okay
Discovery actions comments saves Etc so
later.com goes into some nice detail
about post performance they even have
data on hashtags so if you use an
hashtag you can actually see how many
times the hashtag has been used or saved
how many Impressions it's received okay
so they really go into some nice detail
here about how your post and how your
accounts are performing and here's a
tool I really like I've been using for a
long time and that's tweet Tech so what
tweet deck does is connect with your
Twitter account so you can see in a
different visual so to speak of how your
Twitter account looks in terms of your
feed here I can see this is my feed here
okay I can see some notifications I can
see specific messages then on this
column I can see activity okay so I can
add different columns here if I wanted
to and basically by adding columns you
could see I can look for what's trending
as an example so I'm going to add in a
column that says trending and so now I
can go in and see okay these are all the
different things that are trending on
Twitter uh so you can actually add a
column and pay attention to something
really specific okay so for example
search okay so right now I have men's
health but I could type in let's just
say World Cup okay so I could see the
you got the qriket World Cup you got you
know the soccer football World Cup going
on so you know we could pick a
particular topic to follow if we wanted
to so again here I'm following Men's
Health so I can now see you know
everything that's been posted on men's
health now if I click on for example one
of these hashtags here that's trending I
can actually see who's tagging or you
using that hashtag Friday feeling in
their tweets and so the whole idea
behind you know tweetdeck it serves up a
interesting overview so to speak of not
only your account but you know a
specific topic or what's trending or you
know other things that are being said so
if you really want to pay attention to
your brand or something really specific
like you know your competitors or a
specific product then you can just do a
search on that and so that's the great
thing about tweaktag it allows you to
kind of just look and listen in on
everything going on in Twitter now we do
have a good video out here on YouTube
how to start social media marketing so
if you haven't had a chance to look at
it take a look it goes over some of
these tools that we cover today like
Sprout social later.com you know
Facebook insights so it does cover in
more detail some of what we covered on
these social media marketing tools so
take a look at how how to start social
media marketing so we covered a lot of
different marketing Tools digital
marketing tools everything from SEO to
email to social to paid to affiliate to
competitor but there's also a few other
digital marketing tools that you can use
in different ways like video SEO for
example so vid IQ you know we want to
use vid IQ to get a good sense of how
particular video is performing so here
if we go into YouTube you can see vid IQ
is a browser extension or browser a
plug-in if you will so I can go and take
a look at a specific a specific video
and see how many hours it's been watched
how many views minutes watch subscribers
Etc you know the great thing here I can
look at the entire entire account so I
can get good insights into my video or
my entire account here just by adding in
the vid IQ extension into my Chrome
browser so vid IQ actually does give you
some really really good insights into
not only your account but the video and
so recommend vid IQ because it's good
for video SEO okay there's also tools
related to content optimization so you
know if you're doing SEO and you have a
lot of content in your site well you
know what we want to be able to use a
tool maybe a third party tool to give
some objective reasoning as to what more
we can be doing so you got tools like
SEO site checkup or site analyzer these
are pay tools but you know if you're
really heavily invested in SEO then they
may pay dividends for you you want to be
able to make sure your content is fully
optimized to the fullest according to
you know Google's algorithms and so you
maybe you know want to invest in that
third-party tool so these are good tools
to use for Content optimization you know
there's also other key writing it but
you know this Keyword Planner uh in
Google there's also uh word stream
there's a lot of different keyword tools
out there so you may not have a Google
ads platform and so if you don't have
Google ads then you may not be able to
gain access to Google's Keyword Planner
so having a third-party keyword tool
will pay divins and say well because
those dividends pay off in the form of
not only pay-per-click but also SEO and
if you're heavily invested in content
heavily invested in Social then you may
want to take a look at the keyword tool
keyword it and it's primarily used for
Reddit we talk about page load time so
we looked at that in Google analytics we
know that it heavily impacts SEO so
there are other tools available you got
a third-party tool here that's free
solarwinds pingdom you actually have
page speed insights by Google so these
are free tools that you could take
advantage of and deter determining how
you can improve your page load time my
favorite topic conversion rate
optimization so you got a couple in here
crazy egg and zarget okay so I'm gonna
show you another tool called hot jar so
here if you log into hotshot.com you can
set up an account it's actually free and
with the free account you can have hot
Char measure the heat map not only the
heat map but the click mapping the
scrolling of a particular page and so
here you can see we're looking at a
particular page here so hot jar allows
me to you know see on that page where
people are clicking
um I can also see where people are
moving I can also see you know the
scrolling of a particular page okay so
you can see here on the page I could see
people are moving over here to the right
that's where they're clicking mostly if
I switch over to move mode then I can
see on that particular a page where
people are actually moving their Mouse
and then I have my scroll analysis so I
could see you know how far down people
actually scroll on the page and so again
with a paid account you can measure up
to 10 000 page views with the free
version you can measure up to 2000 pages
and so 2 000 Pages allows you to get
some insight as to what people are
clicking on or where they're moving or
how they're scrolling on a particular
page and so I definitely recommend a hot
jar they also do funneling they also do
forms polls lots of other tools
available in hot jars so hotjar.com is a
tool I would recommend as well so one
final tool and I'd be remiss if I didn't
mention it and that's Google optimize so
Google optimize is a Google platform
that allows you to a B test and so a b
testing means that you have an original
page and you're changing one element on
that page page to see which one performs
better and so with Google optimize it's
just very easy to set up to run and the
whole point of Google optimize and a b
testing is to improve website
performance so here you can see I have
an account set up and optimized you can
see we're running one test here and
we're just testing one element versus
the original so we move photos to the
top of the page the original didn't have
the photos to the top of the page and so
we can go into reporting here Google
optimized does all the heavy lifting and
so here you can see we can look at
bounces or we can look at you know
basically a measure the test up against
the metric that's important to our
business and again the whole point is to
improve website performance and so
definitely take a look at Google
optimize we'll have another webinar in
the future on the topic but you know to
me Google optimize is free you can run
up to five tests okay and if you can run
up to five different tests and that
means you have the ability to really
improve website performance okay so
Google optimizes a tool that I would
recommend
call has a website on cake recipes
unfortunately his website on Google is
not ranking well
moreover when searching for cake recipes
keyword his website ranks way below than
his competitors
this can be due to various reasons but
one that sticks out is SEO to solve this
issue I have a few important tracking
factors that Carl needs to know and
apply if he wants his website to rank
well before we get started with the
ranking factors let me first explain
what SEO is SEO is the practice of
getting traffic from organic search
results on a search engine like Google
Bing Etc depending upon the keywords
search engines rank websites based on
what content they consider most relevant
to users without further Ado let me tell
you the top 5 ranking factors which can
help Carl to rank his website
first is content quality then its page
speed of a web page after that its
website structure next is SSL
certificates and finally its backlinks
which is the most important ranking
Factor let's have a look at good content
quality a good content quality is an
essential factor that helps a website to
rank on Google Google ranks content that
completely answers a user's query in our
case key recipes
also longer content rank higher on
search engine results
apart from longer content you can also
optimize your content with few
techniques such as you can start with a
comprehensive introduction this article
on the best vanilla cake I've ever had
is a good example of having a
comprehensive introduction
ensure to write content relevant to the
chosen keyword
for example if your keyword is cake
recipes ensure to write a content on how
to bake a cake rather than focusing on
cake decorating ideas
always create a click-worthy title and
include LSI keywords in your content
so LSI stands for latent semantic
indexing they used to drive content
traffic and create more visibility on
serps an easy way to look for LSI
keywords is on Google serp some of the
LSI keywords for cake recipes are easy
cake recipes vanilla cake recipes
chocolate cake recipes and a lot more as
shown on the screen
ensure your heading and subheadings
consist of keywords for example all the
heading and subheading for this article
have the keyword cake
build a comprehensive internal linking
structure of web pages it helps in
spreading link Equity across the site
important to create a simple internal
website link structure in the below
example a bot crawls on web page 2 by
following internal link of the web page
1. next add suitable images with
descriptive alt text here using relevant
images can help search engines
understand what your content is about
and this method helps in site ranking
for example for Carl's website on cake
recipes he should use suitable images
like wedding cakes birthday cakes Etc
incorporate call out boxes as it will
highlight the important information and
increase the dwell time for example if
Carl wants to sell his cake he should
place call out box with contact details
immediately after the cake recipes
ensure your web page is completely
crawlable for pots as it will enhance
website ranking here as you see this
website is high up on the Google serve
because every web page in it is
crawlable by Bots
next opt for mobile friendly designs it
will result in good use experience for a
mobile-friendly design always prefer
short and crisp sentences for easy
reading
a poor example and a good example of
mobile-friendly designs are shown here
importantly update the content regularly
by doing this search engine rearranges
your site's ranking for example the
Sally's Baking Addiction cake recipe
blog ranks at number one on Google the
reason it updates content regularly
next we have page speed
page speed defines how fast the content
of a web page is displayed on the screen
it is important to ensure that a paid
speed isn't slow otherwise it will
result in high bounce rate
page speed can be optimized through
improving your server response time
this can be done by fixing major issues
like slow database queries slow routing
or a lack of adequate memory
use a simple website design and reduce
the image size that is larger than 150
bytes
[Music]
next use a Content distribution Network
as it distributes the load of delivery
content and multiple geographical
locations
you can also optimize your code Minify
files if your website has numerous CSS
and JavaScript file you can Minify and
combine them
Google says slow page speed results in
high bounce rate as you can see here
next comes optimizing title tags and URL
title tag summarizes the website's
content and URL is a web address
title tags are displayed on serps it is
a clickable headline for a given result
for example chocolate cake recipe cake
recipe callcake.com is a title tag of a
website where chocolate cake recipe is
the primary keyword cake recipe is a
secondary keyword and car geek.com is
the brand name
backlinko recommends writing a relevant
keyword in the title tag is important as
it gives an overview of what your
content is about
[Music]
now talking about URLs always refer a
well-structured short and simple URL
according to backlinko analysis short
URLs tend to rank better than long URLs
moving on to our fourth ranking Factor
let's talk about SSL certificate
websites using https server have a
higher chance of boost and rankings
https is used for secure communication
over a computer network
as you can see here Google confirms
https as one of the ranking factors
there are two ways to improve site
security you can protect your domain by
enabling DNS SEC protocol or use hsts to
add an extra layer of security over
https whereas hsts protects from
hijacking
the next ranking factor is website
architecture the famous digital marketer
Neil Patel says the better your site
structure the better your chance of
ranking higher in the search engines
also backlinko confirms that an
optimized website architecture helps
Bots to find and index all of the web
page a good site structure results in
good use experience some of the ways to
optimize your site structure are
creating a logical hierarchy structure
which means a good site architecture not
only makes content easier to find but
also helps to gain traffic
[Music]
include site Maps so that the Bots can
easily access and index the content
code your site navigation in CSS or HTML
because these two languages are easy to
quote and understand
the comprehensive structure of internal
linking as it improves indexing of a
website and helps in spreading link
juice coming to our last rifling factor
that is backlinks
backlinks is an online navigation of
hyperlinks from other websites to your
own website
in this way we can drive referral
traffic and increase the website's
Authority
in SEO the more backlinks in a web page
receives the better it will rank in
Google
backlinks enhances search engine
rankings brand awareness and referral
traffic
backlinks can be gained through
influencer marketing
engaging with audiences on multiple
social media platforms like telegram
LinkedIn Etc participating in high PR q
a sites like quora and post answers to
the questions related to your business
today we're going to talk about why you
would want to rank using SEO and SEO as
search engine optimization also known as
organic search you also May us here a
say organic listings where we're going
to talk a little bit about why you'd
want to rank your website in organic
search okay what is search engine
optimization then we're going to follow
that up with how does Google rank
websites so why does it rank one website
over another and how do we get our
website to rank number one then we're
going to talk about the different types
of SEO or search engine optimization
techniques so you can get your website
ranked number one and then we're going
to finish that off with the do's and
don'ts of SEO so let's get right to it
and talk about why SEO so we're going to
use a basic example and let's just say
you have a Blog you're a food blogger
you're passionate about food and your
Niche is ice cream and let's just say
you have a lot of ice cream recipes you
want to get traffic to your blog you
want people to read your blog and you're
curious why am I not ranking for my blog
why when people type in ice cream
recipes and say Google my blog posts
don't appear at the top of organic
rankings and there's a number of reasons
why you wouldn't be ranked for your blog
post or your ice cream recipes and the
main reason would be your competitors so
there could be somebody else out there
who is also passionate about ice cream
and has been blogging along longer than
you and they have more content and more
blog posts and more pages for Google to
rank so that's usually the number one
reason the other reason is improper
usage of keywords and we're going to
talk a little bit or actually a lot more
about you know keyword usage in your
content so what kind of keywords do you
want to rank for that's really what
we're talking about when we talk about
usage of keywords what keywords do you
want to rank for and how do we work
those keywords into the content another
reason is poor link building practices
and really that means our other blog
posts or other websites linking to you
also are you linking to other pages on
your website and so it's all about link
building and with link building it's
internal linking so are we linking from
one blog post to another and it's
external linking are other websites of
high quality linking to us and so that's
what we talk about when we talk about
link building and then another reason is
web page load time so you could be
running your blog post on say WordPress
for example and your blog post isn't
loading fast enough well if you look at
it this way think about it if you're
Google would you really want to rank a
website site or blog post in this
example number one on Google rankings if
that particular page loaded very slow no
you wouldn't because when somebody
clicked on that link in organic search
and went to your website they're going
to have a bad experience because the
page is going to load slow so Google
doesn't want their users to have a bad
experience you don't want your users to
have a bad experience and so that's why
web page load time is a critical factor
for ranking so we need to make sure that
our web pages load fast and then your
user experience is not good enough so
Google again based on my example about
the web page load time Google wants
people to have a good experience when
they go from their search engine to your
website and there's a lot at play there
specifically web page load time but also
you know Google doesn't want any spam
content Google doesn't want any pop-ups
or overbearing ads on the web page they
want people to are searching for
something in particular let's just say
ice cream recipes and they want to find
a relevant website that has ice cream
recipes they want to be able to click on
that link and read some good content
about ice cream recipes it's that simple
and that's really what Google's trying
to create in their environment and
that's you as an end user as a website
owner you want your users to have a good
experience and then last but not least
your website is the indexed by mistake
and really what we mean is the indexed
is Google needs to be able to index all
the pages on your website so if you have
a Blog with a hundred recipes you want
Google to have access to all 100 recipes
so we're going to talk a little bit
later about how to get your pages ranked
or indexed on Google organic search so
let's move on to what is SEO so sticking
with our ice cream Blog theme really SEO
search engine optimization really is the
practice of increasing your pages that
Google has indexed up the rankings so
the end result result is we want all our
pages to be ranked number one for
particular keywords so if you want to be
ranked for ice cream recipes well
there's certain things you need to do so
that's generally how it works we need to
apply search engine optimization to
increase a page for keyword we want to
be found for so let me give you an
example so let's just say there's a
hundred students that participated in an
essay competition and so the competition
in this particular case is evaluated on
the basis of is the content relevant are
they using suitable titles for their
essay do they have structure when
they're participating in this essay or
talking about the essay and do they have
a suitable synopsis and is the content
neat and readable these seem all logical
for an essay competition well guess what
they seem logical for SEO because that's
exactly how SEO works it's exactly all
those points I just mentioned about
structure logic readability organization
title all those things are what's
important in SEO and so we need relevant
content we need titles for our Pages
Google needs to be able to see structure
we need to have synopsis of what the
page is about and that's called The Meta
description and then again the the
content needs to be readable and that's
important and so in order to be readable
again we're going to talk more about
site speed because site speed is
important okay and when we talk about
responsive design when I say responsive
design that means your site your page
needs a load both on desktop and also on
mobile and so all these things are
important just like an essay competition
Google is the judge and they need to be
able to determine what page is best to
rank number one number two number three
Etc on Google Search and then link
building remember I mentioned link
building a moment ago well link building
internally and externally also plays a
vital role and so we're going to talk
about that a little bit later in the
class when we talk about off-page SEO
how does Google rank website and
basically Google follows three basic
steps to rank a website they need to
crawl your website they need to take
what they call back to their servers and
when they take it back to their servers
your your web pages they need to you
know have them available for indexing so
when somebody actually types in a
keyword into google.com it'll be
available to be found on organic search
so that's what indexing is all about and
then Google's job when somebody does
type in a search query is to basically
rank those pages that they've indexed
from number one to Infinity depending on
how many pages are relevant to that
search query so really it's about
crawling indexing and ranking so praline
is simply a process done by which Google
has Bots and what these Bots do is they
go to your web server and they're going
to crawl every page that they can find
and how do they find these Pages well so
they basically follow links you might
have heard the term spidering but that's
what they call search engine spidering
so basically what Google's doing is
they're building a web so to speak all
the links that they're following and so
when they can follow all these links on
your website they're going to be able to
crawl them and when they crawl them
basically they're going to take that
content and store it on their servers so
it's available in their index So based
on this method Google finds out which
websites have relevant content and which
ones don't based on certain keywords
that are typed into Google because if
they can't crawl your website you're not
going to be found and if you can't be
found then they're not going to show up
for Relevant keywords so we need to make
sure your site's available to be crawled
and we'll talk about that a little bit
later okay but let's show you an example
so let's just go to Google Search and if
I type in the keyword simply learn okay
I could see I have one way in 10 000
results okay and that's how many results
are showing up for simply learn okay now
they may not all be simply learned pages
but nonetheless simply learned is ranked
number one here organically and there
are 1 million 10 000 Pages related to
the keyword simply learn now when it
comes to organic search we don't want to
get it confused with paid search so
anytime you see paid search you're going
to see something that says add next to
it okay so we could see that there are
paid ads here but when it comes to
organic search those are generally below
paid ads and so that's where Google
counts the one million 10 000 results
and so that's the whole idea behind
crawling and indexing Google's able to
cross simply learns website and based on
all the pages that they gather they're
going to make those pages available in
organic search so if you type in a
keyword and your web page is not
available for indexing then you're never
going to show up for that keyword so
that's why it's important to make sure
your website is available available for
crawling and indexing and so when a user
types a query on search Google search
the most relevant websites that are in
Google's index are going to pair in the
search results so in the example I gave
I was simply learn well simply learn is
the brand name of the company simply
learned so there's a lot of relevancy
there so that's why you see simply learn
show up here organically number one like
we mentioned about what is SEO and why
SEO we talked about that user experience
so there's a lot of factors that go into
ranking relevancy being one of them so
in the simply learn example simply learn
is relevant to a lot of the simply
learned Pages because that's who they
are simply learn however simply learn
also needs to make sure that you know
for their Pages the page load time is
fast meaning these Pages load very fast
for the end user and Google also takes
into account other factors like how long
someone is staying on a website or are
they bouncing meaning are they going to
one page that they land on and then
leaving the website okay and so the user
experience is very very important there
are other factors also like language and
location and so for example location if
you do a search say in India the results
are going to be a little bit different
than say the results of the United
States why because Google is indexing as
many web pages as they can find so if
somebody's doing a search in India their
results may be a little bit different
than the results show up in the U.S
because Google has different Bots and
these Bots are crawling different pages
at different times and so Google's index
is updating continuously but it's not
real time syncing so if you do a search
in India you may not say exactly the
same thing because both search engines
the Google in India and the Google in
the US are may not be exactly synced up
so an example would be you know if
you're looking for Cafe so if you search
a cafe and say San Francisco you're
going to see different results now if
you do a search for cafes in Mumbai
you're going to see different results
there's going to be local search here at
the top there may be some paid search
but again you may see different results
because one location but two Google
search engines in India and United
States google.com aren't exactly synced
up exactly at the same exact time you do
that search so location is important
language is important and relevancy is
important along with user experience so
all those are important factors in how
Google ranks websites okay so we're
going to talk about the types of SEO now
so if we want to rank for a particular
keyword on Google we're going to have to
apply search engine optimization and so
there's two strategies to search engine
optimization on-page SEO and off page
SEO so first we're going to talk about
on-page SEO so on page SEO is nothing
more than optimizing your own website
and so when we say optimizing your own
website there's certain elements on your
website and on your web pages that we
need to take into account and so some of
those elements are headers meta
descriptions title tags linking so all
of those elements are something we can
control as an end user who wants to rank
our web page and our website on Google
and before we do anything with our
website the first thing we need to do is
understand what keywords we want to rank
for in order to understand what keywords
we want to rank for we need to do
keyword research and if you do anything
in SEO keyword research is the most
important activity that's the most
important thing you can do for SEO and
why do I say it's the most most
important because you need to understand
if you choose a keyword that you want to
rank for you need to understand how much
traffic you're going to get from that
keyword if you're ranked organically say
number one on Google so how much traffic
will you get if you're ranked number one
on Google so you need to understand what
the volume is and then number two we
need to understand what the competition
is for that keyword that you want to
rank for so if you choose a keyword and
there's not much competition for it then
chances are you can rank for that
keyword for a web page on your website
quicker than say a keyword that has a
lot of competition so we need to
understand those two basic factors
volume and competition before we choose
a keyword and it's it's simply the
practice of going through the motions of
getting your volume and getting your
competition data so you can choose the
keywords you want and then once you
choose the keywords you want then you
can go and apply on page SEO you can
change the title tag the math data
descriptions the headers all those
elements can be changed but first you
need to choose your keywords and so
again the primary components we're
looking for are how much traffic you can
get or the search volume how much
competition there is for that keyword
and of course relevancy okay you need to
be able to choose a keyword that's
relevant to the web page you're trying
to rank for and so let me show you
example how to go through this so the
first thing we want to do is we want to
use a tool and the tool I would
recommend is Google Keyword Planner and
why do I choose Google Keyword Planner
because if we're trying to rank on
google.com or Google search engine we
want to be able to get the data right
from the source so Google's going to be
able to give us information about how
much volume a keyword has and how much
competition it has so let me show you an
example so if I want to use Google's
Keyword Planner and I want to rank for
the keyword how to become a digital
marketing specialist then I'm going to
type that keyword into Google's Keyword
Planner and what Google is going to do
is they're going to give me some Trends
about how much volume this particular
keyword gets over the course of a year
and so for that particular keyword I can
see that there are trends that appear
for both desktop and mobile so mobile is
important because people start their
search process a lot of times on their
mobile device so we want to be able to
get data from mobile as well as desktop
and so we could see a trend here that
for each particular month over the last
12 months we can see how much volume
this particular keyword how to become a
digital marketing specialist gets per
month and so on average on average over
the past 12 months I could see how to
become a digital marketing specialist is
averages 30 searches a month and this is
on google.com and so Google gives us the
volume what they also give us is the
competition and so here I can see Google
says for that particular keyword the
competition is medium and so in the
Google's Keyword Planner what they also
do is give me other relevant keywords
that I might think about optimizing for
because you don't want to optimize for
just one keyword so how to become a
digital marketing specialist they're
going to also offer up other types of
keywords that are relevant so just
digital marketing Specialists social
media marketing specialist so for those
keywords I can see the volume so for
example digital marketing specialist I
can see the average volume is 1000 per
month on average of the last 12 months I
can also see the competition is medium
but for some other keywords I can say
the search volume being high like
digital marketing course at 2900 per
month but also the competition is high
and so what I would recommend is a best
practice is to collect all your relevant
keywords okay and put all your relevant
keyword words in a spreadsheet and when
you put all these relevant keywords in a
spreadsheet you want to get the data on
those keywords and the data I'm
referring to is the volume and
competition so in this case we have
volume from Google planner Google's
Keyword Planner and I have competition
from Google's Keyword Planner and so if
I go into a spreadsheet and I put all
that information in here I'm going to be
able to see the volume and competition
and so that's important however one
thing to note here is that Google's
Keyword Planner if I go back just gives
us low medium and high and if I want to
compare numbers to numbers maybe I want
to be able to get exactly the
competition number for the keyword how
to become a digital marketing specialist
what I can do is go into Google and I
can type in that keyword so if I type in
the keyword how to become a digital
marketing specialist I can see there's
76 Million results so I could see 76
Million results 76.1 actually and for
the keyword how to become a digital
marketing specialist now that's a whole
lot of results for this particular
keyword especially when the volume is
only 30 per month on average and so what
I want to do is get a more clear picture
of the competition and so what you could
actually do is type in the syntax all in
title and then colon and then your
keyword how to become a digital
marketing specialist and when I do that
I get a different result here I can see
only
136 listings for how to become a digital
marketing specialist but that's not just
136 that's 136 with that particular
keyword that we want to rank for in the
title tag okay so the title tag is what
you see when you type in a keyword or
search query in Google search and the
title tag is what you see at the top of
every search result and so now I can see
I typed in how to become a digital
marketing specialist with the all
entitled syntax and now I can see every
listing every one of these 136 results
have that particular keyword in it so I
could see every one of them how to
become a digital marketing specialist
and why is that important because now
that tells me I only need to climb over
136 listings to rank for that keyword
how to become a digital marketing
specialist and so the idea here is you
want to get your volume from Google's
Keyword Planner but you want to get your
competition from Google search and again
that's simply typing in the syntax all
in title and then your keyword in this
example how to become a digital
marketing specialist once you get those
two numbers you're going to plug them in
to your spreadsheet and then once you do
that for number of different keyword
queries and these keyword queries again
have to be relevant once you do that
that then you can go in and pick the
keywords you want to optimize for and
that's important because again if you're
not sure about a keyword then you want
to do the keyword research so you can be
sure of how much traffic you can get and
how much competition there is those are
two important three important factors in
starting the process for on-page SEO
it's okay you want to
create content for say a keyword like
digital marketing
but digital marketing may seem a little
bit broad so you want to probably stay
away from broader keywords because
broader keywords tend to have a lot of
volume which is great but they may also
tend to have a lot of competition but
that's the whole point of doing the
keyword research maybe it doesn't maybe
there's more volume than competition
that's what you need to find out when
you do the keyword research you need to
find those keywords that are relevant to
your content that have a lot of volume
and low competition and then once we
identify those keywords then we are free
to go in and start optimizing our web
pages for those keywords and the first
place we want to start is the title tag
so if you remember my example going back
here to our search how to become a
digital marketing specialist we saw that
every one of these listings had that
keyword in the title tag and the title
tag is important because that's what
users who use Google search see first
when they talk type in a query and get
results so they're going to see the
title tag so the title tag is the most
important element for on-page SEO it's
the most important factor because that's
what people see and so ideally when we
choose our keyword we want to make sure
that keyword is in the title tag because
that's what shows up in Google search
and that's what makes that particular
web page relevant for that keyword query
so the idea behind a title tag it's
between 50 and 60 characters and so we
want to make sure we stay within that
limit no more than 60 characters because
what happens if it's beyond that then
Google will truncate the title tag so if
I go back to my search you can see here
on this particular title tag Google
trunk handed it meaning they added the
ellipses after the title tag because it
exceeded the 60 character limit so you
want to stay within those character
counts and so the title tag is the first
place you should start when optimizing
your website because when we have the
right keyword in the title tag and
somebody types in that keyword then
chances are it's going to be relevant
they're going to see it and they're
going to click through to your website
and that's the whole idea behind ranking
we want to get clicks so that's how the
title tag appears so when you optimize
it you're going to update the title tag
and this is how it shows up it's going
to show up at the top of your listing
okay and it's going to be bigger and
Bolder than anything else Google
displays so the second thing you want to
optimize is the meta description and The
Meta description is simply just a brief
description up to 155 I would say about
155 to 60 160 characters but probably no
more than that and so the meta
description is nothing more than a
summary of the web page itself so if I
go back to my Google search results I
see my title tag and I see the page that
this particular listing belongs to and
underneath that is where I can see my
meta description so in this particular
keyword query how to become a digital
marketing specialist I see the meta
description an ultimate guide on how to
build a career in digital marketing and
the skills required to become a digital
marketing specialist note that it's a
well-written meta description within 155
characters and it includes the keyword
digital marketing specialist so we're
trying to rank for how to become a
digital marketing specialist and here
you can see become a digital marketing
specialist so there's a lot of relevancy
between not only the title tag and the
keyword but the meta description and the
keyword so when you're optimizing a
keyword you want to start with the title
tag but you also want to update the meta
description because if you don't update
the meta description and you leave The
Meta description blank then you're
leaving it to Google to add in copy that
they deem relevant and so for on-page
SEO we want to take control of the copy
and we want to optimize it for the
keywords we want to be found for so the
meta description is a powerful tool at
our disposal it gives us more characters
to work with it gives us more to talk
about so for that particular page and so
if the title tag is only 60 characters
maximum it's not a lot of information to
try and get somebody to click so the
meta description helps us in identifying
what that page is about in order to get
the click so the two working in tandem
will hopefully increase your
click-through rates so when you're found
organically we want to get the click and
then the third element that's important
is the URL and URL stands for uniform
resource locator and why is the URL so
important because that's what people see
so if I go back to my search result how
to become a digital marketing specialist
notice that the URL also includes how to
become a digital marketing specialist
article okay so it's very relevant the
URL is very relevant one we can see it
in the search results but two you know
it's is relevant to the keyword query
and that's important for the end user
and Google Google wants to know hey is
this the page that's relevant to the
user's query and if it is then this user
is likely going to have a good X user
experience after they click on the
listing so the URL is an element that
helps not only with the click-through
rate but with ranking and having a poor
URL structure doesn't help at all
because not only does Google not
recognize the URL as being relevant but
the end user may not want to click on
that page given the the way the URL
looks so you want to try and avoid a
poor URL structure so the rule of thumb
is this if you don't understand what the
URL is then Google is likely not going
to understand what the URL is and so we
want to try and keep our URL structures
clean and when I say clean ideally you
want to make sure that whatever keyword
you're trying to optimize that's the key
word that's in included in the URL
nothing included that is not
understandable so again going back to
our example how to become a digital
marketing specialist it's very clean the
title tag is the keyword The Meta
description is cleanly written has the
keyword and then the URL is the other
element that the end user can see and
that URL includes the keyword in it so
after we've done those three elements
the title tag The Meta description and
the URL then we want to start optimizing
the page itself so ideally when we say
optimize the page itself the page
remember needs to be structured and when
we say structured it needs to be
structured in terms of you know headers
and subheaders and organized in a manner
in which the end user can read the
article read the content clearly and
concisely without being confused and so
that's the job of headers they add they
add basically an organization structure
to the content and with headers there's
a hierarchy so you have anywhere from H1
which is the top of the hierarchy to an
H6 and so you're free to use any one of
those headers when building out a page
in order to organize the content but
ideally you probably want to stick with
an H1 or an H2 because those are at the
top of the hierarchy and what those do
is they actually stress to Google that
hey this header with this particular
keyword in it is important so if you use
an H6 with the keyword in it it's
telling Google hey this is an H6 but
it's not as important so an H1 and an H2
tag show importance and so let's look at
an example of what that is so here you
could see an H1 is going to be at the
top of the hierarchy so that means it's
going to be bigger and Bolder then you
have an H2 which is going to be bigger
and Bolder than an H3 but not as big and
bold as an H2 so with headers not only
are you organizing the con content
accordingly but you're also signaling to
Google how important that particular
header is and of course the header needs
to include the keyword we're trying to
rank for so let's take a look again at
that example so if we go to how to
become a digital marketing specialist if
I click on that page I can look at the
content and I can see that there are
headers in here so the headers are there
to organize the content and that's what
we want we want to be able to organize
the content and if you look at the other
example I'm showing here how to become a
digital marketing specialist a learning
path Explorer you can see that's an H1
but below it's a subheader the growing
digital marketing job market so that's
an H2 and so we're not stressing to
Google that that's more important than
nh1 but nonetheless we're stressing at
Google that it's important nonetheless
so we want to be able to use headers we
want to be able to use keywords in our
headers in order to stress to Google
what's important and also to organize
the content because Google likes content
organized okay the next element we want
to focus on is internal linking and so
internal link and if you remember
earlier in the presentation it's
basically links from one page on your
website to another and so here we can
see on this particular article how to
become a digital marketing specialist
there's also links to other pages on
simply learns website and so for this
particular content it also links to SEO
specialist PPC specialist social media
marketing specialist and digital
marketing specialist so the whole idea
behind internal linking is to link from
one page to another where it's relevant
and in this case it's relevant because
we're talking about how to become a
digital marketing specialist that's what
the whole content is about and so what
simply learns doing here is offering up
other pages on their web website that
are relevant to becoming a digital
marketing specialist and so this is a
best practice when you're optimizing a
web page so you want to be able to have
internal linking on your site and the
whole idea behind internal linking is it
also allows users to navigate through
the site naturally so when I say
naturally they don't always have to
refer back to the top navigation they
can naturally and seamlessly go from one
relevant article or page to another and
so that's the whole idea behind link
building and internal link building it
allows Google to identify you know pages
that they want to crawl and index
because they're linked to one another
but it also helps the end user because
it allows the end user to go from one
page to another and it's signaling to
Google hey this particular page is
linked to this page so we're going to
also index that page and so that's the
whole important part of internal linking
it's about the end you user experience
and it's about allowing Google to find
the pages on your website so they can
crawl them and index them so you can be
ranked for them and so also in addition
to internal linking we want to be able
to use natural language and so what do I
mean by natural language or natural
language processing so what Google does
is in terms of natural language
processing they're looking for the
content and the keyword it needs to be
relevant so when your website is about
digital marketing you don't necessarily
want to rank or try to rank for the
keyword digital marketing one it's too
broad two there might be some
competition but three you're probably
not going to write something as broad
like digital marketing so ideally what
you want to do is you want to choose
other relevant related keywords that's
going to be more natural and so that's
what we mean on natural language
processing we want to choose keywords
that are more natural to the content
you're writing so instead of the key
keyword digital marketing maybe we want
to talk about the types of digital
marketing or digital marketing examples
or what is a digital marketing strategy
or how to become a digital marketing
specialist so those are all relevant
keywords to digital marketing and more
relevant to the content because if you
try to rank for the keyword digital
marketing again it's probably going to
be a little bit broad probably more
competition and not as relevant to your
content and as a result probably not a
good user experience so think about some
other keywords that you could optimize
and rank for and that goes back to the
keyword research that's why the keyword
research is so important because it
allows us to identify other keywords and
the natural language process what
keywords are more relevant for the
content and then another element to
on-page SEO is the sitemap and so with a
site map it's basically a list of all
the pages on your website and the whole
idea of listing all the pages on your
website in one document is it helps both
users and search engines understand the
structure of your website so there are
two types of sitemaps one's an HTML
sitemap and that's designed for humans
so if you have a website with a lot of
content at the footer or the bottom of
your web page you probably want to have
a link to sitemap so if somebody clicks
on that side map they're going to be
able to see all the pages on your
website structured in an organized
manner well an XML sitemap an XML is
just a different format it's designed
for crawlers and so the whole idea
remember is Google likes to crawl
content when they crawl content they
bring it back to their servers and index
it and so we want to be able to create a
sitemap for Google or other search
engine crawlers and so XML is the format
so let me show you example of how that
looks so if I go to simplylearn.com and
simply we type in say sitemap.xml just
as an example I'm going to get this
particular page in this particular page
displays two XML sitemaps so these site
maps are there for Google to go ahead
and crawl and nothing more than a list
of all the pages on your website and so
this is a quick and easy way for Google
to get a hold of all those pages so that
they can index them and that's the whole
idea behind SEO you want to be able to
have Google index all the content you
want to be found for for the keywords
you want to be found for so it all
starts with the sitemap so let's go from
on-page SEO which in recap is basically
optimizing certain elements on your
website so that you are relevant for a
particular keyword and that meant
updating the title tag The Meta
description the URL the headers choosing
the right keywords to put into the
content having internal linking chain
and also updating the sitemap well those
are elements that you can do on your
website so we're going to switch gears
and talk about a different strategy
off-page SEO because without on page or
off page you can't have a page ranking
so the two work together so you can do
as much as you want on on page but you
still need off-page SEO and you could do
all the off-page SEO you want but you
still need on page so both of these
strategies have to be in full effect in
order for you to rank so let's now
switch gears to off-page SEO and so
off-page SEO is simply the process of
linking or promoting your website using
link building and so if you remember I
talked about this earlier on there's two
types of links internal and external
linking and so for on-page SEO we used
internal linking for off-page SEO we're
going to talk about external linking and
external linking allows us to improve
our website sites recognition or
relevancy or credibility and why do we
want to improve our relevancy and
credibility and trustworthiness and
Authority because we want Google to know
that our web page is trustworthy it is
recognized by other websites and it is
relevant for a particular keyword and so
if we can do that using off-page SEO
methods then Google's going to rank our
web page for the keyword we want to be
found for so it's really off-page SEO
synonymous with link building and
there's plenty of opportunities to do
link building it just comes down to
creating a strategy so again some of the
benefits to off page well we talked
about you know being credible and
trustworthiness and relevant we need to
do that in order to rank but there's
some other benefits there so if we're
have a link on another credible website
then it's likely going to increase the
traffic to our own website it also
creates high domain Authority and so
what I mean by high domain Authority is
if we have basically links to other web
pages pointing back to us then basically
our domain Authority is going to improve
and when our domain Authority improves
other websites are going to want to link
to us so the higher authoritative we are
for our website than other web pages are
going to want to link to us and so the
more external linking we have the higher
the domain Authority so it all starts
with linking to other high domain
Authority websites so linking to a high
domain Authority website for example
have any link on Wikipedia that points
back to our web page creates high domain
Authority for us and it helps Drive
traffic so some of the other benefits of
off-page SEO are in credibility so if
we're linking from Wikipedia to our web
page it does create credibility for us
it also helps us increase our page rank
so remember that external linking helps
build domain Authority helps build
credibility
trustworthiness and it's going to in
turn help us rank for that particular
page and then certainly not last having
a good off-page SEO link building
strategy increases our brand awareness
because if we're on other high Authority
websites Wikipedia or say a social
platform it's going to increase our
brand awareness and increasing our brand
awareness increases our trustworthiness
and so if somebody is looking to say
become a digital marketing specialist
then likely instead of typing in digital
marketing Specialists on Google they may
type in our brand name in this case
simply learn and so these are all the
benefits to off-page SEO so it's nothing
more than having links on other websites
that are pointing back to ours and again
there's lots of benefits its drives
helps Drive traffic and increases our
Authority so those are things that we
want to take advantage of when we want
want to rank and the key behind off-page
SEO or link building is always going to
be content so from an on-page SEO
perspective having quality content
allows that content to be optimized for
Relevant keyword and ranked but also
from an off-page SEO strategy having
high quality content allows us to have
other sites and it doesn't necessarily
have to be a website it could be a
social platform or can be another
blogging platform or blogging website
link back to ours why because the
content is original it's natural it's
well structured it reads well and so
that's the whole idea behind off page
you can't have links on other websites
if you don't have quality content so one
of the ideas behind off-page SEO is not
only do you want to create good content
but you probably want to spend a lot of
time or a bit of time on others websites
so remember the example I used earlier
in this presentation about having an ice
cream blog and ice cream recipes well it
probably wouldn't be a bad idea to say
spend some time on other blogs related
to desserts related to cakes related to
food in general related to vegetables or
other items that people could link from
so the whole idea is understanding who
else is out there who has relevant
content that you could share so you
could share your content with them they
can share their content with you and
generally that's how it works naturally
anyway in the web sphere if somebody
likes your content they're going to link
to it they don't necessarily have to
wait for you to ask them but it might
not be a bad idea to understand who else
is out there that has content someone or
yours so that you can you know get a
link on that particular website or blog
post and so some other ideas behind
having external links pointing back to
your website is social media so social
media is not just Facebook or Twitter
here but it expands beyond that there's
there's core there's media there's all
sorts of content generated websites like
Reddit so the list goes on and on you
just need to find what's relevant for
your content if it's relevant for your
content then it's worth putting or
trying to get the external link on that
social media platform and then again
going back to my ice cream blog recipes
blog post yeah if you find a particular
blog that you want to have an external
link on there's nothing wrong with
reaching out to that particular blogger
you know in some cases very flattering
but in other cases if the content is
relevant then why not it's only going to
help your end user experience if you add
somebody who has a say a Blog about
cakes having their link on your blog
post so there's nothing wrong with it
because it also adds to the user
experience and if you're going to ask
somebody to put an external link on
theirs you might want to be open-minded
and make sure that you're are able and
willing to put an external link on your
blog post or website pointing to their
content that's how the web Works
especially if the content's a quality
relevant and of good nature okay so
let's move on and finish up with the
do's and don'ts of SEO so we talked a
lot about why SEO what is SEO how do we
rank for SEO what is on page SEO what is
off-page SEO and so let's just wrap up
with some of the things you again want
to do to rank your page for a particular
keyword and some of the things you don't
want to do so the first thing on the
list is optimize for white hat
techniques and what I mean for opting in
for white hat techniques is basically
everything I just mentioned today you
want to do keyword research you want to
choose a natural language processing
form format so you could choose keywords
that are going to be relevant natural to
the content and you don't want to opt
for black cat techniques and blad hat
techniques are probably not even worth
going into detail but one example is
choosing a keyword arbitrarily like say
digital marketing and just stuffing that
keyword into the content so that's
probably not something you want to do
because again it's not going to be good
for the end user so stay away from black
hat and focus on some of the techniques
we talked about in today's presentation
the other do we want to do is get
backlinks from relevant sites so that's
off page SEO again it's what I mentioned
earlier it's about linking your quality
content to another person's website that
also has quality content we don't want
to have a backlink from an irrelevant
site why because it's not going to be
relevant and it's also going to hurt our
Authority because if it's on a site
that's not of good quality then Google's
going to look at us and say well this
site is linking to your site but it's
not relevant so therefore you know we're
not going to look at you in the same
same way as if you were on a quality
website we do want to use our keywords
naturally because title tags are what
people see first on organic search but
you don't want to use the same title tag
on every page of your website so we want
to stay away from doing that so you want
to have a unique title tag for every web
page on your website and ideally what
does that mean that means using our
keyword research to choose one of two
keywords per page and optimizing your
web page for those one to two keywords
so you ideally what you want to do is
have one to two different keywords for
every page on your website we definitely
definitely definitely want to write
engaging content so the content should
be engaging remember user experience we
want users to stay on our website we
want them to enjoy the content that
they're reading and we want them to go
from one page to another naturally we
definitely don't want to leverage or
play plagiarize or just copy content
from others websites because it's not
one probably going to be relevant to
what you're writing about two it's
duplicate content and it's somebody
else's so that's a black cat Technique
we want to stay away from I can't
emphasize this enough we need to do
keyword research first before you do
anything else you need to find relevant
keywords and not only that you need to
understand the volume and the
competition for each of those keywords
okay you don't want to choose a keyword
that has low volume High competition you
want to choose a keyword that has high
volume low competition but above all you
want to choose keywords that are
relevant to your content we want to
avoid keyword stuff in so don't take a
keyword and just stuff it everywhere on
the page it's not going to be natural
and Google's going to be able to pick up
on that so we want to maintain some
level of quality with our content and
quality with the keywords that we choose
so reminder when you have quality
content it's always going to link
internally to another page on your
website with quality content but it's
got to be natural and don't just build
site-wide backlinks meaning don't just
have an internal link to the home page
or don't have every page on your website
linking to just one page so internal
linking should be natural naturally
linking from one page to another not
only does it help Google understand and
crawl all the web pages on your website
but it's good for the end User it's good
user experience and certainly last but
something I didn't talk about does take
time to rank your content so remember
the process you're going to write your
content you're going to choose keywords
you're going to change the elements on
that page for those keywords and all the
while you're going to make sure Google
can crawl that content and when they
crawl they're going to index it the
process take next time especially if you
choose a keyword that's competitive so
just be patient if you have quality
content and you've optimized for on-page
SEO and off-page SEO then you will rank
for that keyword and then make sure your
website's user friendly and mobile
friendly so we talked about responsive
content earlier so remember most users
today start the process of search on
mobile so we want to make sure your
websites are mobile friendly search
engine optimization starts with the
keyword because we want to be found for
Relevant keywords and so the first step
in search engine optimization is always
going to be keyword research so it is
the most important step and so what is
keyword research all about well it's
process of identifying keywords we want
to be found for on the search engines so
millions of people use search engines on
a daily basis we want to be found for
those keywords that people type in that
are relevant to the content we want to
be found so going back to the Italian
restaurant example if we're writing a
blog post about Italian restaurants or
somebody types in the best Italian
restaurants or Italian restaurants in a
specific City we want to be found for
that content if it's relevant to what we
wrote about so keyword research should
be done based on two factors really it's
fat based on the factor of how much
traffic or volume a particular search
engine query has and it's based on
competition and really the underlying
Factor here is that all keywords in your
keyword research should be relevant so
you need to understand what those
keywords are so are they relevant to the
content that you want to be found for if
they are then really the two factors you
want to look for is the volume how much
volume or traffic each keyword has
associated with it and then the
competition how many other other
websites are trying to be found for the
same keyword so those are the factors
involved with keyword research you
always want to choose relevant keywords
and then once you find or choose those
relevant keywords you want to be able to
find out exactly how much volume and how
much competitions associated with each
of those keywords and so when you look
at keywords you're always going to
choose relevant keywords but there are
two types of keywords there are short
tail keywords and there are long tail
keywords and we're going to talk about
both of these here so let's start with
short tail keywords so short tail
keywords are generic keywords generally
they're less than three words in a
keyword phrase for example Italian
restaurants so short tail keywords
generally have very high search volume
that means that if somebody types in a
tang in restaurants then there's going
to be a large amount of volume with that
meaning that generally a lot of people
type in the keyword Italian restaurant
us however with high volume always comes
High competition so if you want to be
found for Italian restaurants know that
if you are ranked number one or number
two or even on page one of Google you're
going to get a lot of traffic however to
get to page one of Google or even
position one or two it's going to take
you a while because there are probably a
lot of websites who are in front of you
who want to be ranked and found for the
same keyword so the whole idea with
short tail keywords is it's a lot of
visibility it's a lot of traffic a lot
of volume but also a lot of competition
and generally the underlying Factor here
is that if you are ranked for very broad
or short tail keyword like Italian
restaurants then chances are it's not
going to be as relevant so if you get
the traffic to your website then chances
are the conversion's not necessarily
going to happen because we don't
necessarily know the mindset of somebody
typing in a very short tail generic
keyword like Italian restaurants they
could be doing research on Italian
restaurants they could be a chef who's
trying to get recipes for Italian food
it could be a tourist looking for
Italian restaurants in a different city
or it could be a person just looking for
Italian restaurants near their location
or where they're living and so there's a
lot of different factors with short tail
keywords so you just don't know because
it's so generic and because it's so
generic if you do get the traffic for
that generic keyword then the chances
that conversion are going to be lower
than say if it's a more specific
relevant keyword so let's take an
example of a short tail keyword let's
just stick with Italian restaurants so
I'm gonna go to a tool called Moz and
while Moz has a tool called the keyword
Explorer and within Moz so if you go to
moz.com and then use the keyword
Explorer you can get an idea of how much
volume and competition are associated
with a particular keyword so in this
example we're using Italian restaurants
it's a very broad keyword we could see
that the monthly volume is between
seventy thousand and a hundred and
eighteen thousand per month okay so that
means for a particular keyword in the
United States on a search engine you're
going to get about 70 000 to 118 000
people who type in that keyword and so
if we were look at the difficulty of
that keyword you could see that it's
fairly difficult because out of 1 to 100
it's got a score of 43 so it's fairly
difficult however if you notice the
click-through rate is very high so Moz
estimates that we'll have a forty
percent organic click-through rate for
that keyword if we're rent for it so if
it's relevant to us and we want to get
some visibility to our site then yeah we
want to use that generic short tail
keyword however if we're interested in
conversions then we really want to turn
our attention to longer tail case words
however if you want the visibility then
you want to use short tail keywords if
you want the conversion then you want to
switch over to longer tail keywords so
longer tail keywords are more specific
they usually consist of more than three
keywords so tie in restaurants very
generic if we add a few more keywords
that keyword phrase it then becomes
longer tail so compared to short tail
keywords longer tail keywords are
generally less competitive and the
search volume is not as high okay some
point so if we go back to Moz and then
we look at the keyword Explorer and we'd
actually type in Italian restaurants and
let's just say Orlando Florida
Moz is going to generate some monthly
volume for us and they're going to allow
us to understand how difficult that
keyword is and so here you can see very
very little search volume in fact so
little volume there's 11 to 50 okay so
that means on average that this keyword
generates 11 to 50 queries a month so
very low compared to our short tail
keyword Italian restaurants the
difficulty here didn't necessarily
lessen but it is less uh competitive so
if you're interested in conversions and
you have an Italian restaurant in say
Orlando Florida then this is the keyword
you may want to use so there's a
trade-off between longer tail and
shorter tail but when visitors land from
longer tail keywords they're usually
ready to make a purchase they're usually
more specific intent there's more intent
involved with a longer tail keyword so
best restaurants in Italian in Florida
Florida branded shoes in Florida
something very specific is going to
generate probably a higher conversion
rate than something more generic so
that's the trade-off and so I went to
use long tail keywords well we want to
use long tail keywords and for targeting
pages with a product or specific article
so for interested in that particular
conversion then longer tail keywords are
likely more the way we want to go versus
something more generic which means if
you're using a generic shorter tail
keyword you're more interested in the
visibility and the traffic not
necessarily the conversion when you're
setting up your brand and you need to
make sure it reaches the Right audience
and provide the best results there's
really only one place to turn to it's
one of the largest online advertising
platforms really in the world and that's
on Google and so today we're going to
talk about how to advertise on Google
and let's get right to it and talk about
Google ads and its effect with
advertising so we're going to start out
with what are Google ads well Google ads
used to be called Google AdWords and
it's been around a good while almost 20
years now so really Google has grown at
a really rapid Pace it's become one of
Google's main sources of revenue uh you
could say probably in the 90 percent
tile of its Revenue comes from Google
ads and when we say Google ads we mean
people who pay for advertising on
google.com so Google ads really what it
does is it provides services that fall
under the category of PPC which stands
for pay-per-click UA Also may hear
Google ads or PPC referred to as cost
per click or CPC or sponsored search
really what it comes down to it's a
model so when you advertise on
google.com com and somebody clicks on
your ad basically you're paying Google
for the click okay so it's just really a
business model where an Advertiser pays
Google to have their advertisement on
google.com but they only pay Google when
they get the click so that's really in a
nutshell how it works for advertisers if
I want to advertise my business I can go
to Google ads and say Google place my ad
on google.com and then if my ad does get
shown on google.com somebody clicks on
it it's just as simple as I pay Google a
fee so Google ads is just an online
advertising platform developed by Google
with which advertisers can pay to
display ads that can offer up their
services there's video involved there's
obviously mobiles involved so you got
all the necessary devices and platforms
available in Google's ecosystem so for
example if I go to Google Search you
even if I type in you know what is
Google ads here I could see a total of
1.8 billion results for what our Google
ads as my search query so in search you
got a lot of different things going on
here you have organic results you have
videos that are being pulled from
YouTube you got a Knowledge Graph here
you got feature Snippets you got an
organic listing but really at the top
this is what we're going to focus on
today we're going to talk about
sponsored search so you can see here for
this particular keyword query that I
typed in what are Google ads really two
sponsored search or pay-per-click ads
appeared now if I happen to click on any
one of these two and go to that
particular advertisements website
they're going to pay Google a specific
cost per click so that's how it looks on
google.com it really depends on your
query and what ads show up but the great
thing about you know Google ads is they
make it known for the user who's doing
the search query what the ad is so here
I can easily pick out what's an ad a
sponsored search or pay-per-click ad and
what's not because if it's a
pay-per-click ad or an Advertiser
advertising on google.com I'm going to
be able to see this little box here that
says add next to the listing and so by
displaying that little logo their ad
it's letting the end user know the
person who's searching know that hey
this is an Advertiser who is advertising
their product or service on google.com
Okay so that's how you can differentiate
between paid search and organic search
organic search here or even down here
doesn't have a little ad box next to the
listing so you know if it doesn't have
the little ad box you know it's a paid
search ad now why do we want to
advertise on Google ads because it
increases visibility to high quality
audience so what I mean by that is you
know search is really a great place to
advertise because because you're meeting
the consumer halfway meaning somebody's
typing something in and your ad is there
to help them find what they're looking
for so Google ads advertises your
product or service to the relevant
audience to ensure the users perform the
action required of them so it's really a
great way to get quality audience to
your website because if somebody types
in something and you happen to offer
what they're looking for basically your
ads going to show up somebody clicks on
it you pay Google for the click and you
get quality traffic and return so the
other great benefit to being on Google
ads is increases brand awareness so it's
a great way to get your product and
brand out there Google has a vast
network
uh also known as the display network but
even on google.com the search Network
itself the search engine itself means
that people use it every day in fact
here in the United States it's been said
or study that you know people over the
age of 18 use search at least once a day
at least once a day here in the United
States so you can figure that's millions
and millions of people so it's a great
way to get your brand in front of a
large captive audience okay so top of
Mind awareness refers to a brand of
product being the first one that comes
to a customer's mind when thinking about
a particular industry or category so it
really does provide top of Mind
awareness another benefit to being on
Google ads is retargeting so when we say
the word retargeting in marketing that
means you know showing our ad to
somebody who's already been to our
website so we can use Google's Display
Network or we can run remarketing lists
for search ads right on google.com to
ensure that we're targeting those folks
who have already been to our website and
have not performed a function that we
want them to perform such as converting
or buying something or downloading
something or such subscribing to a
newsletter or visiting a certain page
okay so if somebody doesn't do what we
want them to do it's okay maybe they're
ready to commit to our product or
service and that's why Google offers up
retargeting so it allows us to reach
that audience a second time so they're
going to be familiar with their product
they're going to be familiar their
website because they've been there and
so we can offer up a very unique
specific ad to that audience so that's a
really good benefit to being on Google
ads so some other benefits here
increased intelligence so you know we
can certainly get data about who is
coming to our audience so we can look at
what device what you know browser Etc so
we can really gain some information
about who's coming to the website we
could certainly measure our performance
so with Google we're paying cost per
click and So based on that model you
know we can certainly measure what
keywords what ads are generating traffic
to the website and how much we're paying
for that okay and if that traffic turns
out to be a lead we can measure that
against that specific keyword or ad or
campaign so we can certainly measure our
performance all the way down the keyword
level and we can measure up against how
many conversions or what we're paying
for those conversions so Google ads is a
very highly quantitative approach to
advertising because there's lots of
numbers involved and you're constantly
collecting information about your
advertising on google.com and its
Network and another benefit really is
this High flexibility so Google ads has
a number of different options so we can
customize our ads based on an audience
based on a keyword based on a specific
website based on retargeting so we
really have a lot of options not to
mention the number of options in terms
of the ad format text ads Dynamic
responsive ads video ads display layout
so Google ads has very flexible options
in terms of advertising and we're going
to talk about some of those as we move
along here today so another big benefit
here and this is what I always suggest
is if you're not ranking organically
then you might want to consider Google
ads because as we've shown here in our
example if I go back to our example a
couple minutes ago you know if you want
to bid on the keyword what are Google
ads why would you bid on that well it's
relevant to your business maybe you're
in the digital marketing industry and
you want to help folks who need help in
advertising on Google ads but what if
you want to be found for that
organically well if you're not found for
it organically then you can bid on it so
it definitely is a good option if you're
not ranking for a particular keyword
organically so it serves as almost an
option I always say that you know search
is like a froopal okay you have apples
and oranges in that fruit bowl well the
Orange is organic search and the apple
is paid search they're different
approaches but they share the same fruit
bowl the same real estate so you can
really really help yourself by using
Google ads to complement what you're
doing organically so if you're not
ranked organically for keyword you can
certainly use Google ads if you are
ranked for specific keywords and it's a
highly competitive industry then you can
use Google ads to help you leverage the
amount of clicks you get from that ad so
it's okay to be organically listed and
have a paid search listing at the same
time so if we go back to our example
here we could see wordstream.com has a
paid ad and here we can see just two
spots below organically they're showing
up with an organic listing so you could
certainly be in both positions to try
and maximize your clicks so it's
definitely a good strategy to run with
Google ads on top of everything we
mention in terms of measurement
flexibility Google ads does offer up a
really good incentive to advertise and
let's not lose focus that again search
is really the only medium in which
you're meeting somebody halfway based on
what they're looking for and when I say
halfway meaning your ad is going to
appear for somebody who's looking for
something whether that be food a cafe a
plumber a doctor or directions search is
there to serve that that person needs
there's no other advertisement platform
or another Channel out there in terms of
advertising that reacts the same way
whether that be TV or radio or email
marketing or affiliate marketing search
is unique in that regard so search
engine results pages are the pages that
are displayed by search engines in
response to an ad so that's serp and so
you could certainly you know be listed
in the serps OR also known as organic
search but the great thing is Google ads
is there to help you get your brand or
product in front of that user looking
for a specific need or service so let's
shift Focus now and talk about the
various formats and Google ads on Google
search we have text ads so text ads are
the only ad format on Google Search and
so here you can see in this example you
have a headline so not only do you have
one headline you have three headlines in
one ad so JBL headphones one headline
wide range of headphones second headline
amazon.in third headline so you have
three headlines and the great thing
about Google ads with with this text
format is that you can have up to two
descriptions of 90 characters so the
headlines are up to 30 characters the
descriptions are up to 90 characters and
so you can really write some specific
information about your ad about your
product about your service okay and the
ad is also going to contain what we we
call AD extensions so here you can see
shop by category in-ear headphones
on-ear headphones those are all site
link extensions meaning they're going to
link to something on your website and so
the purpose of the extension is to help
get the click so the reason why you're
running Google ads is to get the click
you want to generate the click you want
to get that traffic to your website so
by writing three headlines and writing
to description lines and adding
extensions to your ad all help you get
that click yes you're going to pay
Google for the click but that's the
whole purpose is to generate the click
from search because remember search is
there to respond to somebody's need or
query and so if you get the click on
your ad chances are it's going to be a
highly relevant visitor to your website
so Google offers up a lot of opportunity
for you to write a lot of information in
your text that on google4 google.com so
Google also has other formats and so
they also have responsive display ads so
when we say responsive we mean Google
can serve up a specific image from your
website based on what somebody's looking
for based on the page that they went to
so these ads are responsive they adjust
their size appearance and format
depending on the space available so
responsive can also be text text and or
image and so the whole point of response
is if you have a large website let's
just say with a lot of different
products and categories like Amazon well
it's hard to write static ads for
thousands of particular categories and
products so why not let Google do the
heavy lifting why not let Google serve
up the images and ads based on what
somebody looked at on your website and
so that's the whole idea behind
responsive ads is it allows Google to
you know show the particular that's most
relevant to that user so it's a really a
great option when you're advertising on
Google you have image ads as well so
image ads are as we mentioned part of
responsive or they can just be static
and so here you can see an example from
slack okay you can see just an image app
but the great thing about image ads is
you have a lot of different size options
so 468 by 60 250 by 250 160 by 600 all
these are pixel sizes so you have a lot
of different size variations when you
run image ads okay so you don't have to
run a small image ad let's just say in
comparison to Facebook where you have a
thumbnail okay and one size for a
particular image ad on Facebook versus
Google you have multiple multiple sizes
that you can choose from in terms of
running image ads so image ads are
really a great option if you're going to
advertise on Google okay you also have
app promotional ads these ads are used
to drive app downloads and engagement so
here you can see an example for Uber so
that's another option too if you have an
app and you really want to drive
engagement for that app and then you
also have video so Google owns YouTube
so you can run advertisements video
advertisements on YouTube so they could
be Standalone or they can be inserted
into other streaming video content as
say a pre-roll meaning people are going
to look at your ad before actually
watching the actual video they went to
YouTube for so you have a lot of
different options with video
advertisements on YouTube so the other
AD format you have on Google are
shopping ads and shopping ads are really
a great way to get your product in front
of the right user so somebody's looking
for shoes or running shoes it's an
opportunity for you to run shopping ads
so you could put that particular shoe
with a description with the price with
your brand name in front of that user
and so with a cost per click model if a
user clicks on your shopping ad then
chances are they're probably going to
convert because they could see the
product they could see the price they
could see the product name they could
see the brand and so it's an opportunity
for you to really drive high quality
traffic to your site with the
opportunity to convert somebody at a
very high rate so shopping ads are
really good because it prevents unwanted
clicks if somebody clicks on that ad
they're definitely interested so let's
take a look on search to see how that
looks so if I go to Google Search and I
just type in running shoes so my search
results are going to list not only some
paid ads but a lot of different options
on shopping ads so here I could
certainly scroll around and see all the
different brand names I could see the
price point if I hover over it I can
actually see you know some other
information about it like reviews return
policy so so if I actually click on this
ad chances are I'm going to buy it
otherwise why would I click on the ad as
an end user and so that's the great
thing about shopping ads it gives you
the advertiser an opportunity to really
get your products in front of people who
are looking for your product or service
and given that you're listing the price
if they like the price and they click on
your ad they're probably going to go
ahead and follow through with the
conversion so it doesn't necessarily
have to be running shoes it could be
anything that you have to offer a user
so running shopping ads on Google is a
good strategy if you have products okay
so you can showcase these these shopping
ads on Google search by certainly really
giving Google access to your product
inventory connecting in some reviews
connecting in some information
connecting in the pricing points and
voila it's really very fairly easy to
set up Google shopping ads within Google
search and the great thing about
shopping ads is it also pairs under
images and also pairs under shopping so
if I'm on Google search you know I can
go to shopping or I can go to images and
I'll see those same image ads show up
here at the top and I will certainly see
those under shopping as well so shopping
ads allow you to really showcase your
products on Google search to those
looking for that particular product so
it's really a great option with Google
okay you also have call ADS so when we
say call ADS really call only ads are
great for mobile so when you run
advertisements on Google if you have a
phone number associated with your
business you can certainly add that
phone number to the ad so if somebody's
searching on their mobile device and
your ad is displayed along with your
number if they click on your number
they're actually going to call your
business and Google can track that they
can track how many people click on your
number and even turn that into a
conversion in for you so if you have a
phone number associated with your
business it's wise to go ahead and set
up you know what we call a call
extension as part of the ad because if
somebody sees that ad with that phone
number on mobile it allows them to
easily just click on the number and call
your business and so Google can track
calls as well so keep that in mind if
you have a phone number and you want to
associate that phone number with an ad
okay so let's move over to where is
Google showing your ads I showed you an
example of Google search so we looked at
text ads we looked at shopping ads on
Google search networks so Google search
Network really allows you to advertise
on Google search so with Google search
if I go back to Google search and I go
to all I typed in running shoes okay
here I can see shopping ads here I can
see a couple of text ads so you have the
opportunity if you're running only text
ads to show up the top and and if you're
not at the top then Google will place
you at the bottom so it really depends
on the keyword that somebody's querying
in Google search so it really depends on
how many people are advertising and so
what Google does if I didn't have any
shopping ads here Google will list a
maximum of four text ads at the top and
at the bottom any other ads that weren't
shown at the top will get placed at the
bottom so ideally if you're running text
ads on Google you want to make sure
you're always at the top and I would say
between positions one and three you
always want to make sure you're at the
top okay so you can certainly measure
that remember Google had has measured
performance so you can measure
everything about your ad so if you're
going to advertise on Google with the
text ad you want to make sure you're
always at the top so let's have a look
at the different types of search
networks that Google ads is affiliated
with so the first is Google search Okay
so let's focus on Google Search and so
basically when we say Google search or
search sites we really mean google.com
or all Google search engines for that
matter so if you want to advertise to a
mass audience you want to probably start
with google.com because again millions
of people use it on a daily basis and so
if you're advertising on google.com your
ads will appear basically below or above
the search results on a Google search so
if somebody searches for something
depending on the search query they're
going to see results now depending on
the device Oswald so they could be on
mobile or on desktop they could see
sponsored ads or paid ads they could see
local listings and they could see
organic search results so for example
this is what an ad would look like so
let me show you what that looks like on
Google search so if we go for example to
google.com and type in the keyword
classes on digital marketing we could
see some search ads here these ads
appear above some featured Snippets and
the organic search results okay so
depending on a lot of different factors
again I've mentioned this throughout the
webinar there are a lot of factors in
showing up in the top position second
position third position and so forth
okay if I scroll all the way to the
bottom you may even see ads down here
depending on how many people are
actually bidding on the keyword phrase
classes on digital marketing so we could
see simply learn here in the second
position why because again I can see the
logo add here okay so I can see simply
learn using three headlines I can see
simply learn using their two description
lines here and I can see simply learn
using some other extent tensions with
the ad now all of this is geared towards
getting the click so when you're on
Google search the whole idea is
somebody's looking for something you're
offering that up and so it doesn't even
matter if you're in the top position
ideally you want to be in these top
three positions in order to get the
click okay so that's the whole idea
behind being on Google search if you're
on Google search you have the
opportunity to be at the very top of the
search result or in the top three above
local listings and above organic results
now if I change my search query and
typed in coffee in San Francisco my
search results are going to be
completely different I'm going to see
local listings here okay so this is tied
to Google my business not Google ads
okay so this is completely different so
don't don't mix this up with running ads
on Google search so Google my business
is tied to local listings or Google Maps
and again and with desktop which is what
I'm showing you the search result on
you're going to see likely Google local
listings above organic results okay and
if I go back to my previous query of
classes on digital marketing I'm going
to be able to see paid search results
above local and organic listings so in
other words if you're running ads ads
are going to Trump any other type of
results on Google search if you can be
in positions one through three now in
addition to google.com google also has
something called Google search Partners
so if you set up an account and you set
up a campaign in Google ads you have the
option to choose Google search as your
network and then as an alternative or an
additional option you can advertise on
Google search partner sites and so some
of their search Partners can range so
basically these are sites that that have
partnered up with Google that's allowing
Google to show ads on their site so the
sites can range anywhere between YouTube
to Amazon to New York Times let's take a
look at an example it could even be
another search engine so if I go to say
ask.com and type in classes on digital
marketing it's a completely different
search engine but I can see the same ad
for simply learn so I can see same I
could see a different headline here
actually but I can see the description
and I can see some site link extensions
and so notice the ad is still at the top
in this case it's in position one and I
can see multiple companies running
advertisements why because they could
see ad next to it and I could see those
over over organic listings so these are
Google search partner listings so you
can opt in to be be on other partner
sites that Google or other sites that
Google has partnered up with so you have
options outside of Google search and
that option is Display Network so
Display Network allows you to advertise
elsewhere which is outside of Google
search and if you're going to advertise
on Google's Display Network you have
more ad formats Available to You
including image and including a video
for example your ad can be found on a
specific website if you choose to
advertise on the newyorktimes.com or
WebMD or marriott.com you could
certainly do that okay you just need to
tell Google hey this is the site I want
to advertise on so some of the
advantages of being on the Display
Network so if you don't want to
advertise on Google search Okay
google.com you can certainly go to
display and on the display if you're
running display ads or or even video ads
you're going to grab the attention of
potential customers because of the form
I'm out of the ad okay so putting your
ads in front of people early on in the
buying cycle can have a very positive
effect so you're basically reaching out
to a large number of people on Google's
Display Network and giving them an
opportunity to see who you are as a
brand and giving them an opportunity to
see what your product is all about so
for me the display network is a good
opportunity to get your product and
service in front of a lot of people
because this way the display network
works is it's a millions of websites who
want to have advertising on their site
and so you can really pick and choose a
specific site where your audience is
going to be and get your ad in front of
that audience so you can really retarget
to potential customers so retargeting as
we said earlier is really reaching out
to people who have already been to your
website and didn't perform a particular
function that you want wanted them to
perform meaning somebody came to your
website from Paid search on google.com
and they went to page a and then they
left so you really wanted them to go to
page B add a product to a shopping cart
and check out and purchase that product
however if they didn't do that you could
certainly run ads knowing that they've
been to page a and Page B and you can
offer up that specific ad to that person
who's been to your website and so that's
what retargeting really is all about and
you can retarget on Google's Display
Network so remarketing your product to
people who previously visited your your
website or even your app allows you to
really get your ad in front of a
qualified audience and so you could take
advantage of analytics so Google's ads
has all the information you need so
let's actually take a look at some of
these options in Google ads for the
Display Network so if I actually go to
Google ads and I actually go to display
campaigns I can see I have a lot of
different options available to me so if
I click on keywords for example okay I
can choose keywords for my display
campaign so what Google does if you
choose keywords basically what they're
doing is they're going to contextually
place your ad based on the keyword okay
so that's an option for you if you're
not sure what websites to be on with the
Display Network you can certainly just
add keywords and based on those keywords
Google will place your ad on websites
that they deem relevant to the keywords
you choose so you can also choose
demographics so on the Display Network
you can say hey Google I only want to
advertise to say 18 to 24 year olds or
25 to 34 year olds and So based on that
Google is going to place your ads on
websites related to that age demographic
you're interested in on the Display
Network you can also choose choose
topics so if there's a specific topic
that you want your ad to be associated
with you can certainly do that so Google
has a number of different topics at
their disposal so here if I just choose
a particular ad group now I have
specific topics that I can choose from
arts and entertainment food and drink to
news to pets and animals and so under
each one of these topics I can get
really specific so if I go under science
I could see sub categories under the
topic science I can see chemistry and
physics and scientific institutions and
equipment so I can really pick and
choose specific topics where I want my
ads to be shown as I mentioned already
you can pick and choose specific
placements okay so if you have a
specific website that you want your ad
to be shown on you can certainly let
Google know okay you can also advertise
on Gmail you can also advertise on
YouTube so you can really pick and share
choose where you want your ads to be
shown so you have all these different
options available to you to me that one
of the best options for advertising on
the Display Network because when you
tell Google you have a specific audience
you want to Target and that audience
could be somebody who went to a specific
page or somebody who went to your
website and didn't convert you can
associate that audience with the
campaign and when you associate that
audience with a campaign you can
re-target them with an ad so the display
campaign is very powerful with Google
because you have all these different
options available to you so with Google
ads you can also determine how well
you're reaching your goals which
websites you're running your ads on
which ads are bringing in clicks and
which site gives you maximum value for
the minimum cost so you can see all that
in Google ads so when I actually pick
and choose how I want to Target I can
certainly measure that so for example
audiences or or demographics for example
if I go back to demographics I have all
this data uh that Google's collected on
my advertising so I can see for example
by age range based on my campaign how
many clicks how many Impressions
Impressions or how many times my ads
been seen click-through rate meaning the
rate at which people see my ad and are
clicking on my ad how much I'm paying
per click CPC is cost per click total
cost and conversions how many
conversions am I getting so I could see
all this data available to me in Google
ads so it's a very powerful platform for
measuring performance imagine it's the
year 2004.
this is Phil Phil's looking to release a
book and set up a Blog he's sure that
it'd be successful but he's only worried
about one thing he doesn't know how to
ensure that his book reaches the right
target audience who could enjoy his book
during that period of time however there
were only a few forms of advertisement
available like print ads Billboards
radio Direct Mail direct sales and the
television all of these options were
pretty expensive their effectiveness
couldn't be accurately determined and
they didn't let him advertise his
content to the appropriate audience
Phil's book would never find the
audience it deserved now let's have a
look at the same scenario in the present
day alongside traditional forms of
advertising Phil would have access to
digital marketing the form of marketing
that's a lot more lucrative inexpensive
and configurable marketing that would
enable marketers to advertise Their
audience digitally using channels like
search engines websites social media
platforms emails Etc among these types
social media marketing cotfield's eye
social media marketing would give Phil
the opportunity to take advantage of
social media platforms to advertises
content to a highly targeted audience it
would help more people learn about this
book increase the interaction with his
audience It's relatively inexpensive
unless he goes into advertising and will
help him get Marketplace insights that
might help in understanding his audience
preferences better Phil started by
taking up a certification to learn about
social media marketing since he was
already familiar with the concept of
social media marketing his next step was
to learn about the different types of
content he could post on social media
some of the most common forms of content
that Phil could post would be images
text posts polls and videos
but over time Phil begin to notice that
not a lot of people were being exposed
to his content Phil needed to advertise
his content for that he would need to
use the advertising options provided by
the social media platforms like Facebook
Instagram YouTube LinkedIn and Twitter
most advertising platforms offer users
with a number of different options like
image ads these ads involve the use of
single or multiple images that are
attractive and have the optimal amount
of text they also have a call to action
that encourages user interaction Phil
could use images from his book advertise
websites that sell his book and more
then there are text and post ads these
ads could advertise posts or excerpts
from Phil's blog or his book further
garnering interest from an interesting
audience
you could also use video ads Phil could
use video ads that feature favorable
reviews and customer testimonials to
advertisers books Phil could also use
lead ads through which he could collect
information from users who are
interested in a Weekly Newsletter or
regular updates from his blog but that
wasn't the only thing Phil could do with
social media platforms he could create a
brand for himself and drive audience
interest to it engage with them create
an identity engage with content finding
content that works for him social media
platforms also allowed him the
opportunity to Target audiences based on
demographics like their age location
gender and much more and in time Phil
began to see an increase in the number
of viewers coming to his social media
page and by extension his blog he also
saw an increase in the number of people
who bought his book greatly increasing
his audience here are some things he
learned one to set goals that were
quantitative smart and follow a constant
deadline two to understand his audience
by engaging and connecting with them
three to set up a social media calendar
to plan competitions polls surveys
videos and more
4. using tools like buzzsumo IFTTT
buffer and more for lead generation
creating email lists setting buyer
personas and more
5. to perform visual storytelling with
the help of images and videos but how
did Phil get so good at Social Media
Marketing Phil taken up simply learns
digital marketing course it was thanks
to this course that Phil had the skills
and training to get good at social media
marketing and now you can too by
clicking on the top right corner and
with that we've given you an
introduction to all the major concepts
of social media marketing the world we
live in now it's highly digital place
but that wasn't always the case until
four years ago so if we rewind letting
people know about your products was a
little harder then so even if you go
back say five or ten years promoting
your products wasn't as easy as it is
today I mean people had to resort to you
know good old-fashioned newspapers
putting in an ad or those big thick
books called The Yellow Pages that
usually sat in your closet and wait a
ton I mean those were the ways to get
your product a message out there a lot
of advertising in those Yellow Pages
then you have Billboards you know
driving down the highway you see that
billboard on the side of the road you
wonder who are those people that are
actually advertising this stuff of
course you have television that's been
around for decades a good source of
advertising but costly and then facts
facts ads uncommonly known way to
advertise by the way who has faxes now
but people did advertise via fax just a
few decades ago so these were all the
ways in which people had to get their
product and service out there it seems
like so archaic looking at it now but
back then that was legitimate that was
the way to do it and then one thing made
our lives a lot easier so if you're a
marketer you're thinking to yourself man
I'm glad I'm a marketer in today's day
and age because it's social media
marketing social media marketing has
made everyone's lives better from the
company that's selling the product or
service to the marketer promoting the
product and service to the end user who
wants to see that product or service and
engage with that product service so
social media is a good source of getting
your product and service out there and
it just makes everybody's lives a heck
of a lot easier so we're going to answer
that million dollar question and what's
that million dollar question it's how
can you Rise Above the Rest and so
today's session is going to be how to
start with social media marketing so you
can Rise Above the Rest leveraging this
great platform that we all take
advantage of today so let's start by
asking the question what is social media
marketing social media marketing
involves increasing website traffic it
centers around engagement it offers you
the ability to increase your brand
awareness and it has other marketing
goals you know so you can create various
forms of content for different social
media platforms so that's really in a
nutshell with social media marketing is
so again if we want to increase our
traffic or we want to increase our
engagement like likes or comments then
look no further than social media
marketing if we want to engage with our
users our customers our potential on
prospective customers we can really put
a personalized experience in place using
social media marketing we want to create
different forms of content like videos
and blogs and infographics and other
types of graphics with the potential to
actually go viral what we mean by viral
is spreading like wildfire one user
sending it to another as rapidly as can
be and before you know it you get you
know millions of views and millions of
likes I mean that's the power of social
media marketing so why do we want to do
social media marketing and I think we
just answered some of those questions
but let's dig a little bit deeper we
mentioned in our definition of social
media marketing that we have the
opportunity to really build our brand
awareness and that is no more truthful
well then with social media marketing
more so than any other digital marketing
channel social media marketing allows us
to really put our brand in a good light
in a good position in front of the right
eyeballs so it allows us to really
improve our brand by pushing out the
appropriate content in front of the
appropriate people social media is a
great channel for that we can look to
conversion rates so if we are pushing a
product and service in front of the
right eyeballs and we are building up a
funnel of prospective customers who then
turn into customers who then turn into
loyal customers who then turn into
lifetime customers we could see at every
step in the process that our conversion
rates may increase we can certainly
leverage social media marketing for SEO
for search engine rankings it's about
off-page SEO it's about posting content
on social media platforms to build up
some link juice okay so there there is
some inherent benefits to working SEO
and social media side by side it's cost
effective well if you're posting content
on Twitter or Facebook it doesn't cost
you anything it just takes a little bit
of time and creativity now if you want
to go ahead and do some advertising on
these platforms yes it's going to cost
you but you'd be surprised not going to
be as costly as say other search
platforms like say Google or Bing where
you're actually paying for keywords and
paying per click for those keywords so
social media marketing can be very cost
effective and then increase top funnel
traffic so it goes all the way back to
Brand experience and brand awareness if
you're putting yourself in position to
get seen by your target audience okay
your target audience goes from senior
brand for the first time to getting to
know your brand a little bit more to
maybe buying a product or service from
your brand then returning to buy another
product inside service and then
continuing to buy that product or
service I mean that's increasing the top
funnel traffic and not just the traffic
but the conversions so at every step in
the process social media allows you to
build that funnel depending on where
somebody is whether they're seeing your
brand for the first time or actually
returning to purchase the product or
service again so that's the inherent
benefit these are the inherent benefits
of social media marketing today we are
going to talk about all the different
ads that Facebook has to offer so
introduced back in 2007 the Facebook ads
platform has grown tremendously over the
last few years almost four billion
dollars of Revenue in one year so what
does that mean that means there's a lot
of advertisers why is there a lot of
advertisers because a lot of people use
Facebook it's a popular platform so not
only is it popular but it's popular with
advertisers because if you're
advertising on Facebook work you have
the opportunity to share your product
and your brand with users who you think
are going to buy your product or
associate with your brand and on
Facebook you can do that a number of
different ways specifically in
somebody's news feed and specifically
that person's new feed that again is
interested potentially interested in
your brand your product so there's a lot
of ways to advertise and a lot of
reasons why you want to advertise so I
just mentioned one of the reasons hey
it's an opportunity for you to reach out
to people who are targeted who are
specific to your product and your brand
so not only that but you combine that
target audience with the amount of time
that people spend on Facebook okay
people spend a lot of time on Facebook
in fact not only do people spend a lot
of time on Facebook there's a lot of
people on Facebook in fact 2.27 billion
in the third quarter of 2018. and so
when we say spent a lot of time we mean
going to that Facebook profile at least
once a day okay so a lot of eyeballs
throughout the day checking their news
feed on Facebook Facebook also enables
you the advertiser to find the perfect
audience and so that's the great
combination a lot of people on Facebook
and targeted audience so it's a platform
that allows you to put your product in
front of people based on specific
interest specific demographics specific
location so you're really really putting
your product out in front of the right
people at the right time and so the
other positive and pro about Facebook is
it's lesser spend greater reach and what
do we mean by that well traditionally
Facebook is a little bit cheaper than
other online advertising models it is
definitely a lot cheaper than your
traditional advertising models and
Facebook has been known to have good
return on investment because it's cost a
little bit less than other advertising
models and other advertising platforms
so that's the other benefit to being on
Facebook so if you're into building a
brand you want to be on Facebook why
because it helps you increase your brand
awareness it's going to help you allow
users to know what your brand is all
about because remember you're putting
your brand in front of like-minded
people or people you think that are
going to associate with your brand that
are going to associate with your product
so you put your brand out there you
incorporate your your advertisement and
somebody's news feed it's going to add
value it's going to establish trust and
credibility especially if that person's
friend is associated with that brand so
instant credibility already if friends
and family members of a person on
Facebook are associated with your brand
so it has the opportunity to really lend
a lot of credence to somebody who is on
Facebook active on Facebook and is your
targeted demographic and the great thing
about Facebook is it also has other
features other advertising features such
as retargeting so you could Target
people who've already expressed an
interest in your service of product but
if they didn't go through the conversion
process meaning they didn't go all the
way through and and buy your product you
can certainly reach out to them again
just like your traditional retargeting
options on say Google or some other
advertising platform Facebook works the
same way we want to be able to reach out
to people who aren't fully committed at
a point in time but we can reach out to
them at another point in time and so
Facebook's advertising platform allows
us to do that so it's a great feature
that we could take advantage of that
will talk about more throughout this
session and then it helped helps
increase Revenue sales and leads and and
that's primarily what most advertisers
are after you know more Revenue more
sales more leads so Facebook allows us
to educate our audience again a target
audience about a specific product we
have to offer so the more our audience
knows about our product especially for
their friends and family members and
colleagues are using the product then
the more likely they're going to
purchase so if you go back to the other
feature higher Revenue less spend this
is the primary reason because you have a
chance to influence somebody who's very
targeted who's very active on the
platform and who may have like-minded
people in their life associating with
your brand and product so it's a perfect
combination for advertising perfect
combination and so today we're going to
talk about all the different types of
Facebook ads and we're going to start
out with the single image ad in the
single image ad or just sing single
image advertisements that have an
optional text on top and a link
description that links to the website so
single image ads are probably the most
popular you can see them on probably
your own Facebook feed if you look so in
fact I'll just jump over to my Facebook
feed right now and if I go there what do
I see I see a single image ad here and
it's from Shopify Partners so become a
Shopify partner at eCommerce to your
list of qualifications so Shopify must
be you know a brand that is trying to
woo my business okay so they know that
somebody that I'm associated with or
maybe I fit their demographic so they're
targeting my newsfeed with a single
image ad so that's what a single image
ad looks like it's simply just one
single image with some description and
the great thing about this single image
if you ever noticed is the pixels are
pretty large it's 1200 by 628 so it kind
of stands out a little bit it's not your
traditional thumbnail it really pops
when you look at the news feed so again
if I go back to my news feed here you
can see it just really stands out within
the news feed so I can't miss it if I'm
a targeted part of their targeted
audience it's hard for me to you know
not see the sad interact in some way
especially again if I know somebody in
my network on Facebook or either that be
a friend or family members associated
with that product okay in addition to
the single image ads Facebook also has
multi-product ads or also known as
Carousel ads and so what the carousel
ads do is allow you and in Carousel form
allow you to rotate different ads with
different messaging and different call
to action and so here you can see simply
learn has a example of a carousel ad
where they're showcasing their different
courses so this allows users to view to
a range of all your different products
and services if you have multiple
products and services to offer then the
carousel ads would be a good option for
you so in addition to the Carousel ads
and single image ads it gets a little
bit more sophisticated in terms of
Technology where Facebook allows us to
offer up video ads and so video ads are
interactive it's a good way to really
showcase your product your brand your
service and the great thing about the
video ads is they can go from just a few
seconds all the way up to you know two
minutes or excuse me all the way up to
120 minutes and so you can really really
put a lot of time and effort into the
video ads to really put your brand out
there and so the one thing about video
is it is interactive most people engage
with video and they tend to get about 10
to 30 percent more views than other
forms of ads so the video ads are really
a popular way for you as an Advertiser
to put your brand or product out there
so you can put your brand and product
out there in not just a few seconds but
you know really tell a nice complete
story to get the engagement to get the
person to take the action you want them
to do so that's why video ads have
become very popular because they tend to
get more engagement more interaction
than your traditional single image ad or
say your Carousel ad so Facebook also
allows us to advertise something called
lead ads and what lead ads allow us to
do is obtain user details okay so we can
acquire or get an email address or phone
number from somebody whose interest in
our product or service and that person
doesn't even have to leave Facebook so
if you look here on the example here we
have the ad somebody clicks on sign up
and they get this form submission and
the great thing about the lead at is
that it can sync up with any CRM or most
of your popular serums I should say for
example Salesforce as a good example of
a CRM where somebody fills that out the
information goes directly to Salesforce
and so lead ads are really good if
you're trying to generate you know leads
for your business and the form itself
the interaction stays right in Facebook
and so that's the great thing about it
they don't really have to leave the
platform another form of advertising on
Facebook are slideshows okay so unlike
the carousel ads which rotate and the
carousel ads remember rotate and
showcase different products or Services
these ads are are interactive but
they're rotating different imagery so it
allows you to really put your best
images out there with a really strong
call to action just like you see here
with the simply learn example okay so
they're showcasing you know their
different classes is and then they have
the get started today call to action a
really punctuate the slideshow ad so
what's interesting is you can really
gauge a person's interest by throwing
different products or images out there
you know you can really immerse a user's
experience here by showing different
different images and then the last type
of ad on Facebook is called The
Collection ad and so these ads combine
basically your video your slideshow or
your product images taken from your
product catalog okay so if you're an
Advertiser who wants to advertise
several products at once then this could
be a great option for you the collection
ad so here you can see the simply learn
example here they're showing you know
not only you know some some good
slideshows and imagery with some good
messaging below that
Instagram is a social media platform
that needs no introduction with nearly 1
billion monthly active users and 500
million daily active users Instagram is
a platform Rife with marketing potential
more than 7 billion dollars Revenue has
been generated from Instagram mobile and
it's home to more than 2 million
advertisers
not only that marketing on Instagram has
the following advantages too
you have increased conversions according
to research more than one-third of the
people using the app have used it to
purchase products which means by
marketing your products on the app
there's a higher chance of conversion
you also have advanced targeting options
this is in part thanks to Instagram's
parent company Facebook Instagram has
access to just about all advertising
features offered by Facebook ads with
this you can advertise to People based
on their age location gender interests
and much more
you can also build better brand follower
relationships you can stimulate
conversion with your followers and build
a connection with them you'll also get a
greater understanding of what your
followers like and dislike based on
their engagement this enables you to
make content they enjoy more and
increase the chance of converting a user
to a consumer
so let's have a look at how marketing is
done on Instagram
let's start with number one optimize
your bio
your bio is the first thing people
notice when they get to your page that's
where they make the first impression of
your brand and that's why it's important
for your bio to be informative
captivating and engaging
use your bio to provide a brief
description of your brand or product the
type of content you'll be posting brand
hashtags links to other social media
platforms and more
your bio should also include a URL to
where you want to drive traffic to be it
your Brand's website or a page for a
particular product make sure to track
this link as well to see how much
traffic it brings
here's an example of how Samsung uses
its bio effectively
you can see it's a very straightforward
it's got a branded hashtag it talks
about all the services Samsung offers
there are links to other pages and a
link to the website as well it's to the
point and covers everything you need to
know about it
next up at number two we have create a
Content calendar
now if you ask anyone who works with
social media one of the most important
things they'll tell you is to have a
Content calendar
a Content calendar enables you to keep
track of your posts it'll help you plan
ahead and automate the process of
publishing your posts when your audience
is most active a calendar helps you
decide what content caption hashtags
videos goes live on what day date or
time a consistent post schedule will
enable you to make the most out of
Instagram it'll also keep your audience
engaged and also give you access to
historical posts if you want to repost
your older content
next up we have number three get greater
reach with ads
paid ads can enable you to get more
followers engagement leads and
conversions
the caveat here being that you'll need
to pay for it too the ad options are
pretty similar to what you have on
Facebook like audience segmentation
based on likes interactions buying
habits and more you also have a variety
of AD formats to choose from like story
ads image ads video ads collection ads
and more
moreover they can also be set up from
Facebook ads manager here's an example
from an ad from body shop in which they
are using a single image ad the
advertising works because of its
interesting creative and attractive ad
copy that attracts the customer to
interact with the post and click on the
link let's go to number four have a
visually consistent feed Instagram is a
platform in which people gravitate
towards aesthetically pleasing content
two authentic expressions and diverse
perspectives the objective is that your
feed needs to match with your Brand's
identity and must appeal to the audience
within your industry what works nowadays
are candid shots muted Earthly tones
with a low key editing style your
content must feel down to earth and your
brand approachable
as you can see in the images all of them
have aesthetically pleasing images and
are somewhat blue or underwater theme
and that's the kind of thing you should
aim for your content following an
understandable and interesting aesthetic
depending on the product you're trying
to sell now for number five tell a story
the images videos and stories you post
need to tell stories that can Captivate
your audience and establish a connection
with them this makes it more likely that
they feel closer to your brand and buy
your products your captions can tell
stories that can help your brand appear
more human and build deeper connections
with your audience
your content needs to align with what
your audience cares about or solves
problems they face
here's an example of how the page
Patagonia talks about forests in America
each of their posts tells stories about
a different tissue that affects nature
their brand on Instagram revolves around
bringing awareness to such issues that's
the kind of stories you should tell with
your brand
next up number six use the right
hashtags
using the right hashtags can make the
difference between your post showing up
on the explore tab for everyone to see
and it getting lost in a sea of content
your hashtag shouldn't be too generic
like hash New Year or hash style since
they'll have too much competition
instead mix up trending and Industry
specific keywords to connect with your
followers
research on successful hashtags and
limit yourself to less than seven in
each post
the more the hashtags in your post the
more likely it seems spammy untargeted
and unprofessional
find out what and how many hashtags your
competitors use and how you can do
something similar
you could also create a hashtag for your
brand these need to be short easily
memorable and involve your brand name in
some way
let's now go to number seven take
advantage of ugc
ugc or user generated content gives your
followers to further involve themselves
with your brand
ugc altered by them as well regardless
of the field your brand belongs to ugc
can be used to convert followers into
Advocates of your brand
here's an example of how Starbucks uses
user generated content and takes
advantages of Their audience to
advertise their products
in this post here they are attracting
customers with an image of happy
children dressed in products stalled at
Starbucks
the post posted by another user would be
appreciated by the audience and improve
brand loyalty
next up number eight
take advantage of video ads most
instagramers state that users have
visited websites searched or told a
friend after being influenced by posts
even though photo ads are still the more
popular form of advertising we do
advertisements aren't too far behind
there are three key video formats when
it comes to Instagram ads single video
ads that can create 60 second ads
carousels are a combination of images
and videos and Instagram stories that
enable you to combine images and videos
to create visually attractive ads
here's an example of the brand Pizza 73
using story ads to advertise their
pizzas
it's successful because you're showing
off the product they are advertising
with well shot videos and captions
now for number nine partner up with
influencers
connecting with influencers will enable
you to connect with thought leaders
within the industry and enable you to
show off your brand to a larger audience
by connecting with them your brand will
have greater authenticity and Authority
influencers need to be given new tools
resources and guidance to carry out
their role effectively and to work
together as partners
micro influencers are also considered to
be more affordable and they have a
closer connection with their audience
here we can see how Ralph Lauren have
collaborated with an influencer to
advertise their products the influencer
showing off the latest Ralph Lauren has
to offer this encourages his interested
followers to check out the page and buy
something for themselves
next for number 10 host contests and
giveaways contests enable your audience
to engage with your brand with 3.5 times
more likes and 64 times the comments you
can give away a product or a service
which enables you to boost engagement
and brand awareness
contests and giveaways need to be
planned Brands need to be partnered with
Contest rules need to be identified
posts need to be created and much more
monitoring the contest and then running
it is also really important you would
need to track your contest performance
and promote the results on other social
media platforms as well here's an
example of a contest run by Domino's
Pizza which encourages people to
contribute their own short stories and
connect better with the brand
number 11 take advantage of stories and
igtv
stories enable you to create a
combination of photos and videos that
disappear after 24 hours
stories can greatly influence your reach
and engagement rates even giving your
story the chance to show up in the
explore section it can also help make
your brand seem more approachable and
authentic
adding links to the Instagram stories
can also help with driving traffic to
your website
igtv on the other hand although now
seemingly on the decline still has a few
advantages to offer to The Savvy
marketer igtv provides you a unique
mobile-friendly layout that serves as an
evergreen content very well like
featurettes and interviews another new
tool they have introduced is Instagram
reels Instagram's answer to tick tock
Instagram released reels through which
users would be able to upload 15 second
clips and since it released very
recently it's a Rife with marketing
potential
finally we have number 12 track and
learn identify effective hashtags visual
Styles and the best times to post doing
this you can develop the best practices
for your brand social listening and
analytics will help you fine-tune your
marketing strategy and increase
Instagram engagement
[Music]
Instagram how to section
Instagram is one of the fastest growing
social media networks it's appealing
format and functionality have driven
people and businesses away from
traditional networks like Facebook video
content is the most popular content type
on Instagram so it's obvious that we
need to dedicate one lesson to how to
create optimize and promote your video
posts on Instagram we will start this
lesson with showing you how to make
great Instagram videos and talk about
the different types of videos for
Instagram and we will then demo you how
to use the various video capturing and
editing tools you will find in the
Instagram app we will close this lesson
with how businesses can use Instagram
and how you can make money with it
Instagram has extensive features to
create and promote videos particularly
with the growing appetite in using
Instagram stories video is the most
important content form on Instagram it
is important though to make sure that
before you start creating your video you
have a good idea of what you want to
achieve with it is it to create
awareness to generate leads or are you
answering questions that clients may
have utilize the video editing features
that Instagram has or use some external
apps if you want to go beyond what
Instagram has to offer there are enough
tools for you to make your Instagram
video a visual Feast as you can only
create that on Instagram
shooting and editing a great video
is now the most shared content type on
Instagram where in the early days
Instagram video was only 15 seconds long
nowadays you can upload 60 second videos
and turn multiple videos from your
camera roll into one video clip and
today Instagram has lots of different
options within the app to create videos
and optimize them for the news feed or
for stories recently Instagram announced
igtv they're trying to take on YouTube
with a dedicated video sharing app for
vertical and Landscape videos with a
maximum length of 60 Minutes for
verified accounts or accounts with a
large audience however anyone using the
app will be able to upload up to 10
minutes of content to the platform
all in all Instagram today is a
fantastic Network for Brands to build
brand awareness and to Showcase their
products or services
to shoot great videos for Instagram you
need to be aware of a few things
first of all you need to shoot the video
for Instagram and Instagram has its own
video formats video for the news feed
tend to be square whereas video for the
stories must be vertical the aspect
ratio for vertical videos is 9x16 which
gives you a perfect 90 degrees flip for
normal widescreen video
it's also better to use your phone's
native camera this will give you better
control over exposure and focus
Instagram will allow you to upload
multiple clips and then edit them within
the Instagram app also think about short
form versus long form videos
stories are good for short clips whereas
igtv lends itself for longer videos
short videos are great for explaining
things that can be chopped up in steps
like recipes or how-to videos long
videos are good for brand experiences
and interviews
additionally it goes without saying you
always need to think about what you want
to achieve with your video what's your
end goal do you want new followers do
you want to get into engagement with
your followers
or do you want to drive traffic to your
website
all questions you need to think about
before you start shooting your video
editing in external apps
once you have shot your video you can do
some basic editing within the Instagram
app
you can also edit your video outside
Instagram the best environment for
editing your video is on your desktop
computer
apps like Adobe Premiere from Microsoft
or iMovie from Apple will give you an
extensive range of video and audio
editing options you can then save the
edited file and move it to your phone
via Google Drive for instance after
which you can import the video file into
Instagram
there are also many video editing apps
for your mobile they won't give you as
many features as to desktop video
editing but they come a long way
one of my favorite apps is video show
what I like about video show is that it
has a wide range of templates you can
use as a format for your edited video
it also comes with an extensive song and
music library
video categories
so what type of video would work best on
Instagram Instagram lends itself for
what we call snackable videos a
snackable video is short compelling and
entertaining and they are designed to
drive the viewer to some sort of action
like driving them to a landing page or
to a fill-in form
here are some examples of topics for
your next Instagram video
it can feature your product features to
show your followers what product you
carry and why those products are unique
you can show your product in action this
is great for breaking up the monotony of
staged product features
you can also give a sneak preview in
these type of videos you announce news
with a teaser which gives your followers
a sneak peek of what is to come
behind the scene videos work very well
on Instagram they are great for building
a more personal relationship with your
audience think of office tours staff
introductions a day in the life of
tutorials
will show your how to use your product
and finally video series they are great
for building a community and for
engaging with them once your community
has seen an episode and they like it
they may want to come back for more
video types
besides different topics for your videos
you can also think about different
formats for your videos looping videos
can be created within the Instagram app
looping video Start automatically from
the beginning after the clip finishes
they can be very creative and work well
to Showcase movable product features
stop motion video is an animation that
is captured one frame at a time with
physical objects that are moved between
frames
when you play back the sequence of
images rapidly it creates the illusion
of movement both IOS and Android have
lots of apps to create stop-motion video
in a Time Lapse video you capture lots
of photos of a scene over a period of
time
these images are then put together to
create a seamless sped up video time
lapse videos work very well to show how
something is built or made and finally
hyperlapse videos these are videos that
allow you to squeeze several minutes of
film into the one minute maximum set by
Instagram they are a bit like time-lapse
videos but the camera is moving these
videos are great to show behind the
scene footage
how to use Instagram video options
there are various ways that you can make
a video on Instagram so let me show you
how to do that if you go to the
Instagram app it takes you to the news
feed where you can browse
to make a quick video you just click on
the plus button and that takes you to
this shot of my phone for instance you
need to make sure you activate video
if you click on the button you can then
make your video
you click again to stop recording and
your video is ready
you can now play the video and if you
are happy with it you click next and
then you can add a filter if you want to
I will come back to filters and editing
later then you just click next write a
caption tag people add a location and
share it your video is now posted on
Instagram
this is the simple way there's also a
more advanced way of making your video
so let me discard this video go back to
the news feed we're now in the news feed
the creative way to create a video is go
to your Instagram stories
to access your Instagram stories you can
swipe to the right or you can also click
on the little camera on the top left of
your screen that takes you to the same
video screen
and now you see that you have more
options you can see that here at the
bottom
you can do live video you can do normal
video you can select Boomerang video you
can do super zoom you can focus on your
video rewind your video and record
hands-free
so let me explain these in a bit more
detail
for normal video you just click on the
video button and then you can see that
it's recording and when you're ready
with the recording then you let go of
the button and what you see now is that
you have some extra options at the top
where you can add effects stickers
drawings or text
so this is the simple way of making a
video with added effects
you can also go for live video and this
is just like Facebook live when you
click on go live then Instagram will
announce it to your followers and then
you can start your live broadcast when
you're ready with your live broadcast
Instagram will ask you if you want to
post it on your stories or in your news
feed and then you're done with your
broadcasts a very creative way of making
videos is using boomerang
Boomerang was a separate app which
became very popular it was then acquired
by Instagram
a boomerang video is a video that
repeats itself
if I click on Boomerang I'm going to get
the phone and I will turn it
then when you look at the video I
created you see how the video repeats
itself all the time
you can do a lot of creative things with
the boomerang effect you can make people
move back and forwards you can make
objects move up and down and then post
them as short repeating videos
you also see that you can change the
camera into selfie mode and you can add
some special overlay effects as well
so there's different filters I quickly
scan through those
when you're in selfie mode you can have
funny face alterations as well so lots
of different effects that you can create
here
so now let's look at the super zoom
video
the super zoom is a bit like Paparazzi
video also with different effects that
you can add to it so for instance I want
hearts on this video click on it and
then it will zoom in and you will see
hearts popping down
and here is the stamp effect click on it
and there you go when I do a focus video
it makes the background blurred with
rewind video you can make the video
playback by itself
and then finally there's the hands-free
video if you click on hands-free you
don't have to keep on pressing the
record button so you have more freedom
in camera movement when you choose this
option
so these are the different types of
video that you can make on Instagram
how to use Instagram video options and
filters
show you how the effects work on
Instagram I can go to Instagram and then
into the story creation mode and here I
can just make a normal video
I can pan and move the video around a
bit so the video is ready now and here I
am in the screen where I have the
different options to add creative
effects to my video so this is what I
can do
first I can download the video on my
phone by clicking the downward Arrow
I can then get different effects I can
add stickers I can play without sound I
can draw on the screen and I can add
text there are many different options
and when you click on the effect button
at the bottom you see the effects that
you can add to your video
there are effects that can be added when
there is a face on the screen but there
are also effects that can be added as an
overlay over the video
we can also add stickers like a location
sticker and a mention or a hashtag
sticker
interesting thing about these text type
stickers is that when you add these
Instagram will actually understand the
text and will add them to the index for
search
you can easily move the stickers over
the screen you can add a time or a date
and you can also add quizzes so you can
ask a question for instance do you like
this
and then people can actually answer by
dragging the slider you can do a poll
and there's a whole range of other
stickers that you can add to your video
you can draw as well you can have a thin
line or a thick line you can change the
color you can do special effects and you
can erase as well so you can do many
different effects with this you could
create an effect where you wipe out the
whole screen and then with the Eraser
you can refill sections of the video you
can get text and then when you're done
with it you can add a video to your
stories or save them as highlights on
your profile page or you can share it on
your news feed
monetizing your Instagram videos
there are many different ways to make
money with Instagram you can make money
as an influencer by creating sponsored
video posts these are videos where you
promote a product from a brand and the
brand will reward you for giving them
access to your followers tap influence
is an excellent app to connect brands
with influencers you can also sell your
videos Instagram is a great place to
Showcase your content 2020 is an
excellent website where you can promote
and sell your video content and of
course there is affiliate marketing
where you can promote your products from
your affiliate partners and get a
commission on each sale share sale is a
website where you can search for
potential affiliate Partners or why not
sell your Instagram account if you no
longer want to manage it fameswap is the
place where you can do this finally
Instagram can also help you indirectly
to make money you could use it to
promote your YouTube channel and as we
have learned in this course there are
many ways of making money through
YouTube
takumi is one of the leading online
platforms where small influencers can
get connected with big Global brands
when you have more than 1 000 followers
and you have good content you will be
able to use this network to identify
Brands to work with
here are the takeaways of this lesson
video has become the top content type
shared on Instagram and today Instagram
has a whole range of options to create
and optimize your videos for the news
feed and for the stories
short videos of Maximum 60 seconds are
best for Instagram
uses looping videos they start
automatically from the beginning after
the clip finishes use looping videos to
Showcase a fun or versatile product
feature
Instagram has many different video
Styles in the stories camera and once
you've shot Your Story video you have
plenty of options to customize them
takumi is an online platform where micro
influencers can connect with big Global
Brands to sell their original content
now let's get started
first off let's have a look at
look at Facebook was first launched in
February 2004 and was initially known as
the Facebook
in 2005 it removed thee from its name
and it has now become the Facebook we
all know today
it is now the world's most popular
social media and social networking
service
next let's have a look at Instagram
it was launched in 2010 for iOS and then
in 2012 for Android by Kevin Systrom and
Mike Krieger
Instagram has now evolved to become one
of the fastest growing social media
Platforms in the world
in April 2012 thanks to its popularity
it was acquired by Facebook for
approximately one billion dollars in
cash in stock
now let's compare some stats between
Facebook and Instagram
first let's have a look at the worldwide
stats first off Facebook like I
mentioned earlier Facebook is the
largest social media platform in the
world reaching almost 60.6 of the
internet it has 2.5 billion monthly
active users and approximately 1.6
billion active users in fact as of Jan
2020 the US has approximately 190
million and India is approximately 280
million Facebook users an indication of
a market that's still ripe for the
picking
now let's have a look at Instagram
although having released significantly
later earns its title of the fastest
growing social media platform with 1
billion monthly active users and 500
million daily users
in the United States there are
approximately 120 million and India has
close to 88 million Instagram users
next up let's have a look at the next
statistic age group of the user base
first off Facebook
although there's a general opinion among
the younger population that Facebook
isn't hip or is induced all that much
anymore this statistic has something
different to say
turns out more than 65 percent of
Facebook users are between the ages of
25 and 34.
for Instagram it's no surprise that 71
percent of the user base are under the
age of 35.
next let's compare the usage time of
both these platforms
let's take Facebook first in the United
States users spend approximately one
hour on Facebook every day in India
users spend an average of three hours a
day on Facebook
shockingly High numbers for a platform
that's assumed to be dead isn't it
on the other hand in the United States
users spend 23 minutes on average on
Instagram in India users spend
approximately 45 minutes
now for the most important stat
marketing
for Facebook 86 percent of marketers use
it for advertising
Instagram is used by 71 percent of
businesses for their marketing
requirements
now let's have a look at some industries
that will work well on both these
platforms
if you do belong to any of these
industries if you're not taking
advantage of these platforms you're
missing out
so let's have a look at some industries
that can capitalize on Facebook
food and beverage companies news and
media e-commerce automobile
and packaged Goods
next time you're on Facebook take a
closer look at your feed there's a good
chance you'll see most of these
industries is post on it
next up Instagram we have Industries
like fashion
Ecclesia Cosmetics Automobiles and food
and beverages
I can guarantee that if you take a
closer look you can find all these
industries advertising on Instagram now
let's take a closer look at how Facebook
can help with marketing
first off let's have a look at Facebook
business pages
now these are basically platforms where
you can create an online presence for
your organization for free
moreover they've got some great
advantages to offer you as well
first off your business page can keep
your customers or potential customers
informed it can be about a new product
launch a webinar a live broadcast a new
store opening anything whatever it is it
can go on your Facebook business page
it connects people with your products
and services with your page you get
greater visibility letting people know
about the products and services that you
offer you can offer customer service as
well in fact according to American
Express 90 of users use customer service
as a deciding factor for whether or not
they continue to do business with an
organization so customer service is
pretty important like I mentioned
earlier your business page provides a
place where you can offer your followers
offers and other advantages
and finally the page lets you build a
community
a highly targeted community that has a
higher possibility of buying your
products and services
next we have Facebook groups with
Facebook groups you can build a
community of like individuals
some of the advantages that come with us
are it provides a highly targeted
audience I mentioned earlier that
business Pages provide you with a highly
targeted audience groups take that to
the next level it enables everyone to
learn from one another
with a large community there's a good
chance that some members know things
that others don't
your group will enable them to
communicate with each other and learn
these new things
you also get honest feedback your
customers who are also likely part of
the group will be able to give their
feedback on how they like your product
and perhaps even give you tips on how to
improve now since your group is filled
with a community that's highly
interested in your brand you can also
increase engagement in an organic manner
and as an extension of the previous
point you also get more leads and
conversions
next Facebook has events with Facebook
events your organization will be able to
mobilize your brand and enable online
consumer marketing basically meaning
that you have a platform for letting
people know about important
announcements not to mention there's
also the opportunity to get some free
advertising done events also help you
increase brand awareness most people get
to know about your brand by attending
the event or just seeing the promotion
for it now let's have a look at Facebook
Stories for groups and Pages a feature
that is available for both groups and
Pages it provides you the ability to
appropriately represent your brand or
business directly from your mobile
device or desktop
now some of its advantages
are that it helps you engage with your
audience with stuff other than the
usuals like articles videos and other
similar posts this way you can also vary
the kind of content that you post
moreover stories can help you humanize
your brand
rather than seeming like you're
pandering to your audience or seeing
them only as potential leads or
customers stories help your brand show
that you're generally interested in your
audience
you can also reach your appropriate
audience with greater frequency next
Facebook has Facebook Messenger
with messenger you can connect and
interact with your audience at a
personal level
in the last few years messenger has
proved itself to be a great marketing
tool it helps require more customers now
people are more loyal to a brand that
generally cares about them and by
directly interacting with them through
Messenger their loyalty towards you is
certainly set to improve
and as an extension of the previous
point you also get a greater number of
transaction
and even if a customer doesn't give you
a transaction at least you're increasing
your brand awareness
then we have Facebook live Facebook live
gives you a platform to interact with
your audience in real time it can be
used to diversify your content providing
your audience with something different
from what they've received from your
brand initially live can also be used to
show what happens behind the scenes in
your organization further helping
humanize your brand
and finally you can also provide instant
questions and answers to your audience
increasing engagement with them
next we have the Facebook shop
the Facebook shop is a business page tab
application that enables your customers
to purchase your products directly from
your store it also has the following
advantages firstly you can use the shop
to drive new sales you can give the
customers who are on the fence about
your product a small Push by engaging
them and how can you do that with deals
and promotions you can also reward
Advocates of your brand with special
benefits to be availed from your store
and finally you can build brand
awareness and recognition now let's have
a look at Facebook ads
Facebook ads help spread product or
brand awareness in the news feed of a
specific targeted audience on Facebook
now some of the advantages of Facebook
ads are that they help increase brand
awareness
they enable you to advertise your
products and services to the appropriate
audience
and it provides you with greater reach
while making new spend lesser amounts of
money it also helps you re-advertise or
retarget your products to an existing
audience and finally it helps increase
Revenue sales and leads
if you guys are interested in learning
about Facebook ads you can check out our
Facebook ads video I'll add it in the
live chat so you can check it out if
you're interested
now let's have a look at the final
feature Facebook offers to help you with
marketing
Facebook insights I'm sure all of you
have heard about Google analytics let's
just say this is Facebook's version of
that with insights you get information
that can help you refine your brand
strategy by tracking and measuring
results
it can help you determine reach and
engagement actions people who are
viewing your posts when your fans are
online the type of posts that are
working for you and much much more
that brings us to the end of the ways
Facebook helps you with marketing now
let's move on to Instagram
first off we have Instagram business
accounts Instagram business accounts
enable Brands to be recognized as
businesses
now it also has the following benefits
to offer it's only with the business
account that you can get Instagram
insights we'll talk about insights in a
little more detail in a little bit you
can also add a contact button on your
profile enabling users to connect with
you directly you can also specify what
kind of service you offer by adding what
industry you belong to in your bio and
finally you also have the ability to add
links to your Instagram stories now I'm
sure you've all seen the see more option
in your stories so now you know how that
shows up
now if you guys are interested in
finding out how you can increase
followers on Instagram you can check out
our video on the same topic of the same
name I'll add the link in the live chat
next let's talk about Instagram stories
with Instagram stories you have the
ability to grow engagement build brand
awareness and to drive sales you can
also use stories to provide recent
updates about your brand
now some of the advantages of Instagram
stories are that they help businesses
grow Their audience and can enable them
to engage with their audience regularly
with stories you can also Drive traffic
to other websites like your company's
website it can also help diversify your
content setting it apart from the usual
videos and photos next up let's talk
about Instagram DMS or direct messages
DMS help you grow your business by
interacting with customers at a personal
level it can also help build connections
with your users by building a personal
connection with your followers their
loyalty towards your brand is improved
not only that it helps you make or grow
your connections within the industry and
as an extension of the last few points
this leads to easier lead generation and
increased sales
next up we have igtv
now igtv is a platform that's gotten
really famous recently it enables your
brand to get closer to its audience and
enables it to be discovered by new
people
other benefits include greater
visibility of your products and services
having the ability to educate and
entertain your audience
improve engagement and greater chances
of conversions finally it also helps
build a community of a highly targeted
audience
next we have Instagram live
Instagram live enables you to
communicate with your audience in real
time further improving your
discoverability and strengthening your
connection with the audience
moreover it provides a lot of visibility
your followers are immediately notified
when you go on live stream
and finally it helps you interact with
your audience in real time
this helps further humanize your brand
next we have Instagram ads
Instagram ads provides you with control
over advertisements you decide how they
appear and who sees them like Facebook
Instagram has a number of different ad
types to offer
they are photo ads video ads Carousel
ads slideshow ads and stories ads
next up Instagram offers an Instagram
shop
the shop helps you incorporate your
product catalog with your Instagram
profile
at some point even enabling users to
access the shop directly from an image
showing the same product
one of the major advantages of the
Instagram shop is that it provides easy
product discoverability and since it
provides visual marketing it also leads
to more sales
and finally Instagram insights
Instagram's answer to Facebook insights
and Google Analytics
insights is an analytical tool that
provides data on follower demographics
their actions and your brand content it
helps determine engagement Impressions
and reach best and worse performing
content profile visits website clicks
and much more
and there you go that's everywhere
Facebook and Instagram can help you with
marketing
now we've laid out the facts for you
keep in mind your requirements and make
a wise choice so let's talk about how to
create a YouTube ad so this is going to
require some access to Google ads and
we'll go over that in a few minutes here
but first we need to think about setting
up a campaign and setting up a campaign
goal okay what's the goal of our
campaign to get eyeballs you know we
want to pay cost for 1000 Impressions or
we want to run some actionable type ads
to get people over to our website so
that really is step one we need to
identify what the goal of our campaign
is then we need to create the ad so we
want to be able to create a video ad
here that is going to show on YouTube
and to our target audience so or whether
it be a bumper ad that's only gonna be
six seconds long we need to be able to
figure out what type of AD we want to
run so here I am in Google ads if we're
going to run a campaign on YouTube we
need to make sure that we here choosing
a display campaign and so remember the
first step is you know setting up that
campaign setting up that campaign goal
so we're going to go ahead and select a
new campaign here we're going to run a
new campaign and so what's the goal of
our campaign so if we're just out to
generate brand awareness and reach
that's certainly fine if it's all about
sales or if it's all about leads then
you know the type of video run is going
to be a little bit different so if we
select brand awareness and reach okay
here we're going to select the campaign
type and so if we select video basically
what we're doing is we're going to tell
Google we want to go ahead and set up
some video ads on YouTube and so here
you can see the different types of video
ads we discussed today you know we got
your bumper ads you got your skippable
in-stream non-skippable so the
difference being that if it's
non-skippable somebody has to watch the
entirety up to 15 seconds okay so we
have our out stream which is basically
our viewable CPM model so we're going to
go ahead and you know check one of these
types of campaign types or ad types so
we're going to click continue and then
once we do that you know we're going to
get prompted to you know move forward
with selecting our ad so you can see
here after I set up my campaign now I'm
just going to go through some of the
settings for my ad and I'm going to give
it a campaign name a budget okay when it
starts or ends the bidding strategy so
again we're going to focus on cost per
1000 Impressions and then here's the
network so this is an important
selection here so we're dealing with
YouTube videos so we'll also have the
option to select video Partners on the
Display Network so that means that if
you want your video to show on websites
that want to host ads in video format
then you can select this option here
notice you also have this option
available if you're running certain
types of ads on YouTube we're running
those bumper ads so bumper ads aren't
available on search results so I'm going
to stick with the video Partners okay
YouTube videos and here we can get into
some other specifics like language
country the type of inventory so here
you can see the default is standard
inventory so that means that this is
what Google recommends we want to show
our ads on content that's appropriate
for most ads okay so we can go expanded
or limited so we're going with the
recommended here okay and then when we
go down we're going to have an ad group
so when you create an campaign you can
have an ad group so with an ad group
that means that we can have a more or
less a video in every ad group we have
but we have to have at least one ad
group so we're going to go ahead and set
up you know this ad group here and
here's where it gets interesting and
important because here is where we can
start targeting in our audience so here
we got demographics okay so we can
choose gender age parental status
household income okay we can focus in on
audiences if we want to so we can we can
choose a specific audience that we've
set up we can get some ideas or browse
specific audiences we could also choose
a specific placement so here you have
YouTube videos or we can go with YouTube
specific channels okay or we can even be
on apps okay we have to set a bid for
our Target CPM and once we do that
basically it's all up to now for us to
add our video ad and so remember we're
in this example we're going to Bumper
ads and we're looking at about six
seconds and once we do that then that's
pretty much the campaign but I just want
to stress here that when you're setting
it up ahead of time you want to make
sure you identify what the campaign goal
is and then that's going to align with
the type of video you're going to run
and then once you choose that type of
video then it just comes down to where
you want that ad to be and who you're
targeting so it's really crucial here
that you go through these steps and
these options very closely so because
you want your video to show in front of
the Right audience on the right place
now so let's talk about how you can
optimize your YouTube ads so once you
get your campaign set up once you select
your Channel or the type of videos where
you want your ad to be and you select
your target audience and you're off and
running with your video ad well we're
going to give you some tips here that
you can focus on for optimizing Those
ads and so going back to what I was just
saying on the setup you want to
carefully Define your metrics and goals
okay so that's step one so when you're
setting up the campaign remember you
have that option to choose the type of
goal for your campaign that can be brand
awareness it could be a sale it could be
a lead so to me that's the you know a
very critical step one so you want to
make sure you align your goal with your
video and then the second is track low
performing ad placements so if we just
ask Google to place our video ads
anywhere they want then it's up to us
then to go through and choose the ad
placements and remove them okay so let
me show you an example of what that
means so if I'm back in Google I'm going
to go to my campaign and I'm going to
select placements and here I could see
placements but then I'm going to select
where my ads show and so this is
important you want to be able to scan
the list of placements where the ad was
shown so if you don't like one of the
placements on YouTube you can always
select it edit it and exclude it from
the campaigner at group so that's really
the key is you want to be able to manage
your placements properly and when we say
low performing ad placements we mean
really what what's your goal if your
goal is to get sales or leads if you're
that placement is not converting sales
or leads then you need to remove or
exclude that placement so it's all done
within the Google ads platform and then
you know you can also use a custom
thumbnail image and your ad as well it's
always helpful in terms of optimization
so a couple of other pointers here to
help you optimize okay you want to drive
people to perform a particular action
with the appropriate CTA so again
depending on the ad type you know if
it's a true view ad 20 seconds long you
want to have a call to action you want
to maybe even have your domain name at
the end of the video so at least
somebody knows where to go so you always
want to have a call to action with your
video ad you want to use negative
targeting specify who gets to see your
ad and who doesn't Okay so that goes
back to your settings so you can pick
and choose who your target audience is
you can pick and choose who you don't
want your audience to be okay as an
other setting and you can use closed
captioning in your ads to make it more
interactive so that way people can
actually see or read what the ads all
about just to make it a bit more
interactive you can always perform a b
testing on your ads so if you have one
ad version you can create another one
just to see what it which one performs
better testing is always a positive okay
so if you're paying too much maybe think
about reducing your bids so if you
remember we set a 10 CPM bit that may be
too much maybe we don't need to pay ten
dollars so we can always reduce our bids
at the ad group level so reduce bids in
areas where you see lower performance so
in other words you don't want to pay a
lot for poor performance you can also
use remarketing to re-engage with
customers so if somebody views your ads
and doesn't take action you can always
retarget that person uh to show your ad
another even another ad format it could
be text ads or display ads but if
somebody looked at your video and they
didn't take the action you preferred
them to take then you can always
retarget them with another ad so that's
a good way to optimize okay so we want
to make sure the ad has content that
what viewers would find relevant okay
that really you want to make sure that
your ad is you know is with the end
viewer you don't want to put out an ad
that isn't going to give somebody you
know a good feeling after they watched
it okay so you want to make sure viewers
find the content relevant so if they
don't find it relevant then that means
your engagement rate and your engagement
is probably going to be low so you want
to take a look at those metrics that we
viewed earlier engagement rate
engagement and if they're low then you
probably need to look at the content of
the ad so try to make sure your ad
conveys your Brand's message in the
first six seconds so that's why bumper
ads to me are so critical because you've
got to get the entirety of the ad and
make it impactful and so with any AD you
run any video ad you're on you really
want to make sure that that message is
conveyed at the very beginning early as
possible otherwise you know people are
going to be turned off or not engaged
and just going to go ahead and skip it
anyway so you want to make sure you get
the purpose of it right up front and out
of the way okay you can also include
Visual and auditory components in your
ad that can make it more memorable to
the viewers okay meaning music or other
cool visuals okay so again you want to
be able to play around and test
different ads and you want to be able to
you know measure the ad Performance
Based on the metrics we discussed I mean
click-through rate engagement rate all
of those are indicators whether the ad
is of good quality or not with the end
user and when I say good quality I mean
do they find it engaging do they find it
interesting or so they're going to click
and if you don't have good click-through
rates or good engagement rates then you
definitely want to try doing something
different to the ad like adding those
audio components or other visuals that
could be appealing to the end user so go
ahead and and test some of those out
with a B testing because you have
nothing to lose but higher or lower
engagement rates or lower click-through
rates so you want to be able to improve
those metrics improving those metrics
means trying some different components
on different ads so let's take a look at
a case study if you will and let's focus
on super dry so they're a good success
story on YouTube it says super dry
leaned on some YouTube advertising to
help lift one of their products so in
September last year 2018 super dry if
you're not familiar with the brand
they're you know centered some Asian
markets European markets and they focus
in on clothing uh all different styles
and sizes and genders uh from jackets to
jeans to t-shirts and so they're a
global brand they really wanted to take
a different approach here and their
approach was they wanted to focus in on
sales they wanted to see if video can
help lift them with sales and so what
they've done is they set up some
campaigns on YouTube and their focus
here was on jackets and jackets to
specific ages across the board all
genders and interests and so what they
did was they wanted let's take advantage
of all the different ad types that
YouTube had to offer and let's take a
look at one of those ads here so if we
go to YouTube and let's just take a look
at this one minute ad here 53 second ad
by super dry
um
the jacket You'll Play how I'm posing
you'll take five in this jacket you'll
want to find this jacket
what's the jacket
is your dust out of meats take away 3am
plates catch your breath not your death
in this jacket it's the jacket your
cream is
to jacket you're hiding you're vibing
love live and praise you
this is the jacket the jacket that will
get you through
foreign
so that's the video that's super dry ran
you could see that you know it was it
had some particular goals there and so
super dry is pretty well known said
probably wasn't built around brand
awareness per se it was probably growth
consideration and interest and also
driving action okay it's a pretty cool
video it was definitely not a bumper ad
because bumper ads are six seconds so it
was definitely a true view probably take
action and so whatever ads they actually
did run specifically they did see a lift
and so we kept pulse on superdry's
account and these videos actually had
you know 4.8 million views and so cool
video ran for 53 seconds not a long time
not a short time was able to you know
Target Their audience a younger crowd
you noticed in the ad they had different
jackets both female and male different
gender types so they were messaging a
very broad audience of gender some
younger people is who they were
targeting so younger people tend to
slant on YouTube and so they were able
to get some nice views out of it 4.8
million but the more important thing is
because these videos were to drive
action and so they were able to see a
four to one ratio on return on
investment and as a result these jackets
saw a 138 percent increase in brand lip
I mean the jacket ad so it's a pretty
successful campaign see as well
choreographed good audio good video just
well professionally done and they
probably were able to now get a few more
loyal customers under their belt because
of this at alone so that's the power of
video okay so you're able to know who
your target audience is you can go out
and Target them with a cool video and
given that YouTube is vast then you can
really take advantage of a lot of their
ads so what they probably did again was
those true view in stream ads with a
cost per view through a skippable video
ad format may they also use the
shoppable ad format so that is another
option on YouTube so they took advantage
of all YouTube had to offer in terms of
who they were trying to Target the
length of the ad and given that their
product or selling a product or
promoting a product they will take
advantage of the trueview shoppable ad
format which basically lists your
products alongside the actual video ad
and so this is just a good case study
you super dry we'll probably do this
again a based on the numbers that
they're reporting and so basically
that's the power of YouTube getting out
in front of your audience with a really
good video ad targeting an audience
taking advantage of different formats
today we're going to talk about how to
increase Instagram followers today's
webinar we're gonna have some tips and
and best practices for you to take
advantage of to increase Instagram
followers so let's get started and talk
a little bit about Instagram so
Instagram is not really an up and coming
platform it is already up and coming a
lot of users in fact 500 million daily
active Instagram users 500 million daily
May the user base growth of more than
300 year over year so it's growing and
growing and growing it's become more and
more popular ever since it's launched
back in 2010 and then there's more than
100 million photos uploaded daily so
it's a platform where you can upload
photos tag those photos even use and
Implement videos and photos have become
very popular with the Advent of mobile
technology that the Instagram app makes
it easy for you to post your photo so
there's no surprise there's a growth
there's no surprise there's a lot of
users there's no surprise that there's
100 million in photos plus uploaded
daily and then there are 400 million
stories posted daily so when you post
something you can create a story out of
it and there's 400 million of those per
day and then there's more than 50
billion photos shared to date so since
2010 platform Nat which is now owned by
Facebook has become really really
popular a good place for you if you have
your own company if you have your own
brand if you have your own product it's
a good place for you to really showcase
that service that product that brand
because of the user base how easy it is
to use and the wide reach it has for you
in which to tell your story so imagine
there are lots of photos shared today
close to seven billion dollars revenue
generated through Instagram mobile so on
top of everything I just said there's a
lot of e-commerce going on here too so
Instagram is a platform in which there's
e-commerce integrated within the
platform so as a business who offers a
products you can actually generate
revenue for yourself on the flip side
Instagram which is owned by Facebook has
an opportunity to sell advertising space
on Instagram so Instagram is an
e-commerce platform to say the least in
fact Instagram is because it's so
popular because it's part of Facebook's
advertising platform they're more than
two million advertisers on Instagram so
amongst all those stories videos and
photos and hashtags you'll see some ads
and then because you'll see ads because
you'll see users you're going to see
businesses it's just good place to
really set up shop and really tell your
story through the world of photos and
videos so 25 million plus businesses
have already migrated over to Instagram
and that's growing and growing and
growing so it's an opportunity for you
to work with other businesses so the
arrow is definitely pointing up on
Instagram there's a lot going on here
easy to use application especially when
it comes to photos and videos so we're
going to go through some tips and tricks
today and we're going to talk about
everything there is to know about
Instagram and how to increase your
followers so let's take a look at tip
one here so because Instagram is an
application everything you do on it is
through the application now you could
certainly view a web page version on it
but you really can't do much out of that
so if I go to my Instagram account for
example using my desktop I could see my
profile and I can edit my profile to a
degree but everything you're doing is
through the application so when it comes
to that tip one here is take advantage
of your bio so regardless of what
industry you are you're in who you are
you really want to have a clear and
concise and compelling bio why because
this is your introduction to the world
you want people to know who you are and
because if you don't really become very
clear to people they're not going to
follow you so this is where it all
starts you need to take advantage of
your bio have a clear and concise bio
and have a link to your website or some
contact information so to me this is
where it all starts you gotta have a bio
because that's what people are going to
look at and they're going to decide
whether to follow you or not based on
primarily that bio that's where it all
starts so make sure you have a good bio
that's tip number one so you'll have to
make sure that your landing page is also
mobile optimized since most Instagram
users are on mobile so if you're going
to put a link to your website and
somebody's on the Instagram app and they
see your bio and they like it and you
have a link to your website make sure
that Lanny pays they go to is mobile
optimized so tip number two everything
you do on Instagram when it comes to
posting evolves around hashtags so
that's the backbone of the platform just
like most platforms out there social
media platforms like Twitter or Facebook
Pinterest you're gonna have hashtags
accompany those posts so Instagram's
note different but in this case you
really really want to take advantage of
the hashtag so hashtags are there to
help users find your content so you want
to start out by using hashtags that are
relevant to your business so if you're
in the food industry you're going to
post something related to food do the
appropriate amount of research to find
hashtags to describe your brand and also
are being searched on Instagram so what
does that mean that means do a little
bit of homework on Instagram you know
see what searches or see what other
brands in your industry are using for
hashtags don't be afraid to use the same
hashtag but mix it up hashtags are
important so don't be afraid to put a
hashtag in there that really defines
what your business is about but if it's
relevant use other hashtags that are
popular or people are using to find
information so mix it up but the key
here is relevancy you want to make sure
you align your Hashtags with your
content and making sure the connection
between the hashtag and the content 10
is relevancy so using the popular tags
on your photos or videos might get you
some immediate engagement but it may not
help with future goals like long-term
engagement new interested fires and
sales so here really what I'm trying to
say is look pick and choose your
hashtags carefully because if you use
something broad or something
non-relevant yeah you may get that click
to your Instagram page but that doesn't
necessarily mean somebody's going to
follow you or that doesn't really mean
somebody's going to be interested in
what you have to offer so if you use
something really popular and Broad yes
you're going to get short-term
gratification but not long-term interest
tip number three post your content at
the right time so according to sprout
social which is a social media
scheduling platform among other things
so they deal with a lot of people using
their platform and posting content via
their platform they have data and
they're telling us based on the data
they've collected that the best time to
process between 2 and 3 P.M and the best
data post is Thursday now that may be
all fine and true according to a sprout
social study and so you may want to go
with this 2 to 3 P.M and this is
probably local in case you're wondering
what time zone you're referring to so
this is all local to you so go ahead and
try that out try two to three p.m on
Thursday the thing is what you're gonna
have to do eventually is figure out what
the best time to post is okay so if
you're putting out a lot of content and
you're putting out content throughout
the week at certain times of the day or
throughout the day you're gonna have to
determine which time of day and what day
is generating the best engagement for
you who's looking at your post at what
point of the day what day of the week
and so you're going to really have to
lean on a social media platform to help
you determine that because they're going
to have the data that you need to
determine what the best time of day to
post is okay so we'll talk about social
many platforms here shortly we just know
that when you post post with some
rationale in mind ask yourself before
you even push that publish button or
before you even schedule that post this
time of day in this day of the week
makes sense so you always want to post
at the right time because you could be
missing your audience so remember when
you do this you're going to be working
with some platform and Instagram also
has some analytics for business accounts
so Instagram will also give you some
feedback as to how you're supposed to
perform it and we're going to talk about
that here shortly as well so let's move
over to tip four here so steal followers
from your competitors okay so if you're
dealing in a very competitive industry
and your competitors have a lot of
followers it's very very easy to see
who's following them so the easiest way
to do this is just interact with your
competitors followers you could follow a
user like or comment on their photos and
so the more you engage with people the
more you stand to gain from them so you
could see who your competitors followers
are and you can add them as a follower
just by following them so start engaging
with them if they're liking your
competitors brand then what the chance
of them like in your brand could be
great so check out who your competitors
followers are if they seem like somebody
who you would want to be following your
brand then go ahead and interact with
them and how you interact is again you
can like something that they post or you
can comment on something that they
posted okay engage with them okay it
doesn't take that much time it's a good
way to gain followers so if we're on
Instagram we can simply just click on
the Brand's followers so here I can see
the Sprint has 127 followers and here I
can see all the followers and what I
could do is simply just click on one of
the followers and I can go to their
profile and from there I could see what
they've posted in terms of videos and
images and I can like or comment so just
doing something as simple as this gets
you an opportunity to engage with
somebody who can then turn around and
follow you so tip five pay for sponsored
posts and product reviews so a number of
ways you could do this here so pay for a
sponsored post so you can find an
influencer satisfies a couple of
requirements they have large following
and an email address in the profile so
you can connect with them and ask them
for sponsored post pricing so it's as
simple as that as reaching out to
somebody who has a large following okay
so if you do this then it's going to put
shoe in front of a large number of
people and so by doing this it'll help
expose your brand to that larger
audience and help build your credibility
because you're connecting with somebody
who has a large audience as well so do a
little bit of homework find people out
there in your industry who has a large
following and make sure they have that
email address in their profile so you
can contact them and when you contact
them you know ask them for for sponsored
post pricing so if the influencer has an
email address then they're open to
sponsored post or shout out so that's
the key so they gotta have that email
address and when they do then it's all
about asking them and connecting with
them on being a sponsor to one of your
posts okay you want to get yourself out
there in front of people this is the
quickest way to do that okay so tip six
we want to use geotags for easier
discoverability okay so tag your images
videos or stories by tagging the
location City or venue where it was
posted from so very easy to do as you're
posting just go ahead and and there's an
option in there to say hey where are you
located or what city are you located in
so locations have their own feed and
stories which you can contribute to so
go ahead and add that extra element to
your tags so if somebody's in that
location the chance of them engaging are
going to be great and it's good for
local businesses because if you're local
and you're posting your location then
again somebody in that location is
likely to engage with you so tip 7 use
Instagram stories to track followers and
grow your user base So Stories a really
big feature on Instagram so what stories
could be used for is just show footage
of an environment so it could be your
office it could be your home it could be
you know the playground it could be the
golf course it could be anywhere that
you want to show vintage of so you want
to post new relevant to your industry so
if you're in the food industry hey why
not go in the back into the kitchen and
post a story about how a particular
bread or cake is made okay show off your
products so if you are in that food
industry and say you're in the pizza
making business perfect opportunity to
show people via an Instagram Story how
to make that pizza and how you make that
pizza what ingredients you use how
unique is your particular product and
that's really what you want to get
across when you do a story you want to
show something unique and relevant
that's going to grasp people's attention
you can promote a company event so if
you're celebrating say 200 000
subscribers create a YouTube video or
you can create an Instagram story it
works just as well so you can endorse
your company's blog posts you can post
positive user reviews so these are all
features of a story increased
interactivity with polls sliders Etc and
then you can also mention other
companies that work with or follow you
so great use of Instagram stories is do
a shout out to somebody else so
Instagram stories is a really big
feature with Instagram check it out you
know you just do a search for Instagram
stories in fact let's get some of you
users involved what best practices do
you have when creating Instagram stories
why don't you go ahead and share your
Instagram story with us by putting that
Instagram story in the comment section
below so we want to get everybody
involved here because there's a
thousands upon thousands of great
Instagram stories out there to be shown
and viewed and engaged with so go ahead
and share your Instagram story if you
have any other tips or tricks then go
ahead and put those in the comments
section so that everybody can benefit
from them so the only thing to keep in
mind when you're creating these stories
is what are your followers interested in
seeing so your stories could teach or
promote something to your user base so
always keep that in the back of your
mind you know for me I always go back to
what industry are you in if you're in
the food industry hey you know people
who are following you are interested in
food if you're a pizza company you know
show off that pizza if you're a bakery
show off how you make your Breads and
goods baked goods whatever it is you
have show it off because if somebody's
following you that's what they're
interested in so tip number eight
highlight important stories so you want
to highlight highlights serve as the
easiest way to create a first impression
for a potential follower so with
highlights can be used to tease what
your content's about create a trailer
for what your brand offers promote and
promote your product so highlights are
there it's a good feature it's a first
impression for potential follower so it
teases what the content's about it
creates a trailer so to speak for your
brand and promote your product so use
highlights and again any users out there
who have good examples of highlights go
ahead and put those in the content
section or comment section uh right
below this video so remember stories
have only a 24-hour lifespan so
highlights can be used to give them a
second wind okay so highlights serve a
purpose it teases what the content's
about it promotes the product and it
really kind of accentuates that story
tip number nine ask for followers so
sometimes people need a little push
before they can follow you on Instagram
even if they enjoy your content so you
can ask users to become your followers
in the caption the comment section or
even work it into your content so in
other words when you're posting
something don't be afraid to say hey
follow me you know I got some good stuff
here be confident you don't want to do
it for every post of course but you know
pick and choose if you feel you have a
really good post you know really good
image that you think is going to gain a
lot of followers and engagers then you
don't necessarily need to put a caption
in there but if if it is popular then go
ahead and say hey this is a popular post
you know think about following me or put
something in the comment section you
want to do it kind of succinctly you
don't want to be begging but just
working into some degree okay but don't
be afraid have some confidence in asking
for followers so when you do this it's
very similar to how we do it on YouTube
so you can ask viewers to subscribe to
their channels at the end of the video
so it's if on YouTube basically you're
saying hey if you like what we have go
ahead and subscribe it's no different on
Instagram if you have something you've
posted just go and said hey you like
this you know go ahead and follow us so
that's simple so tip number 10 take on
the latest trends to get more followers
so align your content to cater to trendy
topics or hashtags to improve engagement
and discover ability so really what
we're trying to say here's your
competitors follow influencers what are
the latest trends and you can get an
idea of the latest trends by you looking
at hashtags so what hashtags are
trending which ones are people using the
most so really what you want to do is
whatever's trending in your industry you
know ride that wave so to speak now it
doesn't have to take on your entire
profile but there's nothing wrong with
one or two posts if something's really
taking on popularity then go ahead and
post about it as well you know for
example in the wine industry if there's
a new wine that really came out that's
really gaining some popularity go ahead
and post about it with the same hashtag
and with the unique hashtag so don't be
afraid to you know ride the wave of
popularity so to speak because it shows
that you know you know what you're
talking about it adds some credibility
and it's going to get some you know
viewers over to your Instagram profile
so keep in mind you need to keep your
content relevant because if you're
audience is interested in what you have
to offer then they're going to be
engaged however you know if you're
joining the discussion in a relevant
manner keeping in mind whether your
audience would interact or not is
important but just always keep in mind
you always want to stay within your
industry and relevancy for your target
audience so tip number 11
test and giveaways and
Facebook I mean Instagram is no
different you can increase reach and
exposure by running contests since most
followers would tag their friends to let
them know about it it's a good idea to
run contests and so it's an idea of a
contest well again if you're running a
pizza parlor you know you could say hey
what's your favorite pizza or give me
your favorite pizza ideas and you can
run a contest and you know you can have
people even create their own pizza and
post an image of it you can have people
create stories on the best ways in which
they create pizza or their experience in
another pizza parlor there's lots of
things you can do to create a contest
and you don't always have to give
something away you could just do
something for fun especially if you have
a lot of followers if you have a lot of
followers and somebody's going to take
part in it so don't be afraid to run
contests just to make it fun and light
it up a little bit so each tag can bring
you a new audience member who could be a
potential follower so anytime you run a
contest people are gonna tag their
friends to let them know about that
contest so those friends are gonna come
over and likely engage so that's the
beauty of running a contest or giveaway
is chances are words gonna spread and
it's gonna get you some new followers so
that's the the end benefits so to speak
but the real benefit is keeping your
audience engaged so tip number 12 we
want to stay consistent with posts so
having a consistent pace and theme for
your post can have a huge impact to
convert visitors so when we say
consistent you know if you're again that
pizza parlor stay within Pizza you could
Branch out a little maybe and talk about
salads or talk about beverages to you
know as a complimentary factor to the
pizza okay but don't talk about
hamburgers if you're focused in on pizza
so we wanted to stay consistent with
your theme this method involves less
effort with a faster production of
Instagram content so they mean what
we're really trying to say here is focus
stay focused on who you are if you do
that if you're consistent and you're
gaining some followers and that's what
people are coming to you for the content
that you're good at for the industry
you're in okay so if you start varying
it and branching out then it's going to
muddy the water supposed so to speak and
you're probably going to get less
engagement so set a theme on Instagram
by maintaining consistency and your
personality filters colors and layouts
and really what I'm referring to is post
and when you have post something you're
you're really creating a personality for
yourself okay so if you're in fashion
for example and you're in the jeans
industry well jeans jeans jeans right
that's your personality accentuate it
with different outfits related to jeans
but you know when you start talking
about dresses and shoes and and that
kind of blurs your your personality a
bit so if you stay consistent within
jeans and outfits that go with jeans
then I think people are going to start
to pick up on that personality so tip 13
keep track of your Instagram following
so you can analyze the growth of your
Channel with tools like socialblade I
could tell you how many followers you
lost over time and how engaged they are
okay so you can use data gather from
here and from Instagram business account
to diagnose where you're faltering so
let's take a look at socialblade as an
example here so if I go over here I'm
going to go to socialblade here I can
enter in basically any account after a
register and I could see how that
account has performed you know where
they rank you know how many uploads they
have what concert they focused on one
industry and the beauty here is I could
see and I'm looking at YouTube as an
example I could see you know how my post
to perform well you could do this for
Instagram you could do it for Facebook
so you can really get an idea of how
your account's performing so socialblade
is a great platform form for measuring
and again you do also have Instagram
business insights so with Instagram
business insights basically what you're
going to do is you're going to go to
your app right and then from the app you
could basically look at your insights
from there so in the app itself you're
going to click on the upper right three
lines and from there you're going to see
insights and when you go to insights
you're also going to see you know what
your reach is how many Impressions and
some engagement metrics terms of your
audience where they're located the age
range okay you're gonna also see some
content related information so there's a
lot you could see from the the Instagram
insights analytics insights but you can
also see additional information from
socialblade so the key here is when
you're looking at your data you want to
look for patterns in post what post
receive the most amount of Engagement so
if you see something working obviously
replicate it you know you don't want to
replicate it immediately but make note
of it and use it for future content so
tip 14 use Instagram ads so Instagram
ads give you complete control over
advertisements so how they appear and
who sees them so with Instagram ads you
can run photos you can run videos
carousels slideshows stories so we
mentioned this on other webinars for
Facebook advertising it's worth
repeating so if I go back into say
Facebook ads manager I can pick and
choose my placements and really what I
want to do is pick and choose for
example Instagram and so I have
Instagram feed I have Instagram stories
so and I could see what the video
requirement or the media requirement is
for running on Instagram so with
Instagram you can run stories you can
run videos single image ads you can run
Carousel Sue really you could put your
best forward meaning take the post
that's performing well and maybe you
want to advertise that promote it so
you're going to run this through
Facebook ads manager and it's going to
tell you you know what your audience
size is your potential reach okay what
your daily results would be so you're
going to get all that information when
you run your ads on Facebook ads manager
but it's a great opportunity for you to
really push forward you're running a
promotion it's really an opportunity for
you to push forward that promotion other
advantages scalable pricing self-serve
and instant robust reporting and highly
refined audience retargeting so all of
that is in the Facebook ads manager you
can get all the reporting you this you
need meaning you know who saw the ad did
they click on it okay you can refine
that target audience you can go back
into Facebook ads manager and refine who
your audience is so lots of flexibility
here on advertising on Instagram but the
key here is if you want to run
advertising on Instagram you know think
about what it is you're trying to
promote if you feel something needs to
get promoted then go ahead and you know
you can either again reach out to
somebody and have them sponsor it or you
can run it as an advertisement so let's
move on to tip 15. so we want to create
visually attractive and eye-catching ads
so if you are going to run ads you know
here's some things to keep in mind okay
you want to use images that are natural
and seem native okay you don't want to
use any stock photography first off you
want to use something that you've done
okay you want to minimize the amount of
text so let the image do the talking you
want to ensure your caption relates to
the image and resonates with your
audience okay so you have an opportunity
to add some text below the image okay so
make sure it resonates and then of
course use hashtags to show your ads to
Target your audience but a wider
relevant audience so hashtags do play a
role here as well so these are some tips
if you're going to create ads you want
to take these into account the whole
point of the ad is to get people over to
either web page or to your profile page
okay so that they can engage and take
action so Instagram ads will help
showcase your product service or brand
in a way that's memorable and unique so
if you really want to get your vision
your brand your product out there in
front of a lot of people then
advertising on Instagram is a good way
to do that so since we've been talking
about pizza throughout this webinar it's
a good Instagram a profile here about
pizza you know I'm getting hungry just
looking at this hopefully this is an
example for all veg and non-veg pizza
consumers I mean you can see this
profile here they got the website you
know they got the handle okay so they
have a lot of followers so you know if
I'm in the pizza industry I can go ahead
and you know click on their followers
and see who who's following them who
they're following so some really good
shots of pizza here it looks like you
know a lot of people are wearing were
involved in this you could see lots of
different examples here some cute ones
you know some funny ones some humorous
ones so you know just taking a look at
something like pizza which you know most
people enjoy you know most and you can
kind of appreciate you know how much of
an advantage Instagram can be because it
really you can accentuate photos you can
have fun with it you can really run some
contests here you know give us your best
pizza photo so here you know you could
say use daily Pizza as a hashtag for
feature okay so they're even encouraging
you to use a specific hashtag so you can
really do a lot here on Instagram this
is just a good example of what you can
do and have fun with you know with an
example like pizza just to give you some
ideas so let's move on to tip 16 take
advantage of Instagram tools so you can
use scheduling tools like later
HootSuite and buffer so I can't stress
this enough you know when it comes to
measuring the engagement of your
Instagram post you're definitely going
to need a social media tool so you're
also going to need it if you do a lot of
you know posting on Instagram so let's
take a look at an example we'll use
later.com so if I go to later here I can
see you know I can use this to upload my
images to my profile so here you can see
it's scheduled throughout the day of the
week so that way we're not overlapping
you know we're scheduling based on the
times of the day that people are going
to look at this so you know here I could
see you know particular stories if any
stories are posted okay I can look at it
from a weekly or monthly preview I could
see what's been posted okay and more
importantly as a schedule tool I can
also see the analytics I could see you
know how many were posted how many
followers so this is really important
because you know if my profile is
growing I want to be able to see what
post perform best what the audience was
like you know by gender by age by
location so again I can look at it by
post performance story or hashtag
analytics as well so later really goes
into details about you know what's
driving engagement so here you can see
some hashtags this become particular
company is using on Instagram so here
you can see how many posts with this
hashtag you know and what and kind of
Engagement did they receive do they
receive likes comments Impressions how
much reach do they get how many saves
and it really just does go into detail
so later does a good job I like this
platform especially for Instagram it's
great for scheduling but more important
you know in addition to the Instagram
analytics you can really lean on you
know this particular platform to get a
really good idea as to you know how
particular posts are performing remember
if a post is performing you want to
reuse it at a certain point in time okay
learn from Best Practices learn from
what's working learn from what's not
working if something's not working then
don't do it again so you can really get
a good breakdown in here and later.com
so remember these tools place an
emphasis on automation okay enabling you
to automatically post at a scheduled
time so you want to lock it in at a
certain period of time and not have to
worry about it so it allows you to
really hone in on that particular time
of the day and day of the week so that
you're really maximizing your chances of
getting good engagement okay so develop
your own signature style so set up a
style and content theme so that you're
able to stand out amongst the various
competitors so you know again just going
back to our pizza example lots of good
photos of pizza you know but this is
their style this is who they are you
know they're not a particular brand
they're just you know people who like
pizza okay and they're having fun with
it okay so that's their style you know
their posting really good shots of all
this different types of pizza different
styles different toppings just to give
you an idea of how popular pizza is and
what you can do with it okay so again
this is a good basic example
um of what you can do with something as
simple as pizza so don't be afraid to
experiment you know try something
different with your profile you know do
something different you don't always
have to follow what everybody else is
doing that's the great thing about
Instagram it allows you to be free and
creative in fact if anybody has any
styles that have worked for them you
know feel free to put something in the
comment section we'd love to hear your
thoughts so tip 18 use user engagement
to your advantage so I just mentioned
that using the later example so we want
to be able to learn from what's working
and not working so user generated
content shows off your brand to be
authentic and improves your relationship
with your followers so you know you want
to be unique with the content that
you're posting so if you do that you're
likely to build that relationship and
you know increase your followers and you
want to be able to see of that user
generated content that ugc which is
performing which is not outperforming
okay so basically your followers and
your audience are telling you what's
working and not working so take
advantage of that remember going back to
hashtags you can set up your own unique
hashtag and ask your users to post
images or videos relating to that which
you can post in your Brand's account so
just like the whole pizza thing they're
saying hey look you know use daily pizza
for a feature okay that's a good example
of something you can do as well so you
could set up a unique hashtag and say
hey use this hashtag and that'll help
you gain some followers that'll help you
gain some notoriety and some visibility
on your platform tip 19 use high quality
images and videos just like on YouTube
just like on Facebook Instagram's no
different images must be of high quality
authentic and original I mean again one
more time going back to the pizza these
images look to be pretty high quality I
mean if you have a decent mobile phone
that's all it takes a mobile phone with
a camera that is that's all you usually
takes you know you want to be able to
get that that right shot you don't want
to use anything that's of low quality
because it really is going to take away
from you know the story you're trying to
tell so you don't have to be
professional per se just make sure what
you're posting whether it be video or
whether it be an image is of high
quality and remember videos needs to be
fun and informational about causing the
user to lose interest so you know if
you're going to create a video you know
go ahead and you know you can make it
short make it fun okay you can see here
these guys are just showing you how
pizza's made doesn't take a long time
they're just going through the motions
they're not boring you with details
they're not talking really quick and
easy just to give you an idea it doesn't
have to be as serious it can be fun so
video content needs to be fun and
informational without causing users to
lose interest that's the key short sweet
unique authentic and fun have fun with
it so worth repeating don't use stock
images on Instagram am because you know
they don't really bode well for your
particular brand you know it's Instagram
it allows you to post original content
that's the whole purpose of it okay and
on the video side be concise high
quality and informational enough okay so
you have to hold the user's attention
here so when we say concise you know
don't make it a five minute video
obviously make it high quality relevant
to what you're trying to offer and if
you could do that you're likely going to
hold the user's attention so tip 20
promote your Instagram page and other
social media channels so Facebook and
Instagram are part of the same family so
this seems like a natural but you know
don't be afraid to promote it on other
channels like Pinterest or or YouTube
The whole idea is to get users to your
Instagram page and encourage them to
follow it so you know you can always put
that URL in you know other platforms
like YouTube nothing wrong with that at
all okay you can also promote your pay
page offline with print ads and during
other relevant events and then I would
even take that as to further as you
probably see you know an Instagram logo
on a web page along with other social
media icons so you always want to help
promote Instagram on your web page as
well but you can do it for offline with
print ads so you can simply just put you
know whatever your your slug is for
Instagram whatever your ID is whatever
you're using on Instagram that's what
you can use don't be afraid to promote
it offline or online today we're going
to talk about how to increase Twitter
followers so welcome and let's get
started so with Twitter it's all about
tweets it's actually a verb now uh when
you do something on Twitter you actually
tweet and there are a lot of people out
there tweeting in fact Twitter has over
1.3 billion accounts so a lot of tweets
going on in the world of Twitter so as
of the third quarter in 2018 last year
Twitter had 326 million Global monthly
active users okay so active meaning
every day using the platform on a daily
basis so a lot of people using Twitter
it's very easy to use as you'll find out
and what you're going to find out today
is how to increase followers on your
Twitter account so they can see more of
your tweets okay a little bit more about
Twitter there are 500 million tweets
posted every single day that's a lot of
tweets so you can imagine with every
tweet is a hashtag that accompanies that
tweet so a lot of information being
disseminated across the platform so
tweets with videos so Twitter does allow
videos as well as images attracts 10
times more engagement than other forms
of content so if you watched our YouTube
videos and some of the other videos we
had out there regarding Facebook or
Instagram you'll know that videos do
perform bad better Twitter is no
exception so if you have a video even if
it's done on YouTube or if it's not
unpublished on YouTube use it with
Twitter you're going to get more
engagement so Twitter has 75 percent of
its users use the platform for news Okay
so people go to Twitter to get their
news that's where they go they don't go
to a regular website content based
website they get their news via Twitter
it's just very easy to digest because
it's so few characters 75 of B2B
businesses Market on Twitter so not only
is it a b2c or business to Consumer
platform it's a B2B business to business
platform so a lot of businesses are on
Twitter basically promoting either a
product service or trying to establish
themselves in the industry using the
platform so let's take a look at Twitter
and let's take a look at some of the
ways in which you can increase your
followers it all starts with your
profile wow you always want to make sure
you have a complete profile your name
obviously the Twitter platform that you
have is going to have a handle okay in
this example here it's a totally real
person at totally real person is the
Twitter handle and that's what you're
going to want to use to disseminate your
Twitter profile to others so you want to
make sure that you have a good image you
have a real name and a good handle that
people can associate with and remember
so you want to be able to set up this
profile with a key word friendly bio
okay a link to your website and a
picture that represents your brand
always helps so make sure it's complete
you can even take a step further by
customizing the color scheme of your
profile you can add a header image that
sticks to your theme that will help your
profile stand out and so let's take a
look at an example here so if I go to
Twitter here if we go to Simply learn
it's Twitter account okay their handle
is simply at simply learn okay they've
customized the header they use their
logo now if you're an individual you
probably want to use a nice profile pic
here where they're based a little bit
about them so just a you know customize
complete profile goes a long way you
don't have to go overboard with an
elaborate design so to speak but just
make it stand out make it associate with
who you are as a person and a brand
those are best practices in getting that
profile up and running you don't want to
use something Bland and generic you know
take the extra step create something
unique make sure your profile is unique
you have a good image okay make sure
it's complete with you know telling
people who you are and what you're all
about that's really the first step on
really any social media platform so you
want to promote your Twitter profile to
drive users from other social media
platforms so when you actually get that
Twitter account set up and you actually
do have your handle go ahead and share
it that's the first step in getting
followers if you're already on Facebook
if you're already on Instagram then use
those platforms to announce that you're
on Twitter you can also take that a step
further and you know send out an email
to friends or family or like I said if
you're on Facebook go ahead and set up a
post say hey guys I'm on Twitter you
know come follow me so you could also
use business cards advertisements
marketing materials and events to put
that Twitter profile on okay so it
doesn't have to be within the social
media sphere it could be even on your
website it can be even in email so you
can basically promote that profile again
you want to make that profile that
handle easy to remember so totally real
person is the profile in this example
we're going to use that profile every
weekend whether that be offline or
online you don't don't be afraid to use
it on a business card especially if it's
easy I can just simply go to Twitter and
type in that handle so you want to stay
active on Twitter with regular retweets
replies and favorites and that's just
it's just so easy to retweet and reply
and add favorites so let's take a look
at that on Twitter so you could just
simply I'm logged in as me and if I want
to retweet something that's simply
learned in I can just simply click on
the retweet button and I can add a
comment if I want to and then I'm going
to retweet it's that simple so now that
tweet is going to show up on my profile
my handle and I could simply like it if
I scroll down here okay top 10 it Trends
shaping 2019 notice a simple tweet
supported with an image so I'm just
gonna like that so I can even comment on
it I can click on the comment and click
a reply here okay and that's going to
show up in this tweet here just like if
I click on this I'll be able to see what
other people have written and so it's
that simple if I want I can just click
on the email button and even send a
message to somebody right from that
tweet the point is I can do everything I
need to do right in the platform but to
get started if you don't have any tweets
you know go and find other companies
similar to you look at their tweeting
and you can always retweet that that's a
good way to get going with tweets that's
what I started doing when I started on
Twitter in 2008 I didn't know what to
write particularly and I didn't know how
to write it particularly well so I
looked at what other people wrote and
and tweeted and just retweeted those
that's a good way to get your Twitter
account started okay so engaging with
users is a great way to get more
followers so on simply learn I retweeted
one of their tweets I liked another one
of their tweets and it's probably going
to get their attention somebody at
simply learned is going to say okay Rob
Sanders went ahead and liked us and you
know what we're gonna go follow this guy
he seems to be somebody who's an
audience member who likes what we have
to do likes what we have to say like
what we're tweeting let's go ahead and
follow him and so that's a good way to
get going with your Twitter account is
to really start retweeting and liking
other tweets from other users so you can
find an appropriate time to post your
tweets to increase exposure retweets and
followers and you want to do this you
could do it within Twitter or as I'll
mention later you can do it in a social
media platform like Sprout social or
HootSuite or later or buffer and there's
plenty of social media platforms out
there for you to schedule tweets point
is you want to be able to schedule those
tweets when it's the appropriate time so
you don't want to do it in the middle of
the evening because what's going to
happen is likely by the morning other
tweets are going to bury your Tweet so
you want to be able to find the
appropriate time to post your tweets so
according to a survey conducted by
HubSpot the best time to post is between
12 and 3 P.M and why is that well most
people are usually on lunch checking
their phones yes Twitter has an app and
in fact most people use the app just
like like on Instagram just like on
YouTube the app is very popular on
Twitter so it's very easy for somebody
to check tweets especially during the
lunch hour and then from 5 to 6 p.m that
that in between time when when people
are wrapping up work or heading home
okay so weekdays have shown to have the
maximum amount of Engagement so during
the week when people are working highly
engaged with whatever they're doing
depending on what industry you're in
they're likely going to check the
Twitter and react during those times
okay so that was a survey conducted by
hotspot but really what you want to do
is you want to be able to use one of
these social media platforms like a
HootSuite or later and find out exactly
when are people engaging with your
tweets when a what time of the day and
what day of the week are you getting the
most retweets or the most likes okay
that's what you want to do so you can
use this as a starting point as a best
practice but eventually you're gonna
have to cater to your audience based on
when you're getting in your tweets
engaged so you want to increase
followers by following more people it's
that simple and so it really is that
simple let me rephrase that so it really
is that simple so if I go back to
Twitter you know Twitter's always going
to recommend somebody for me to follow
and normally those are people that are
similar as myself okay so they're not
just going to choose random people
they're going to choose people who are
following people you're following so
there's going to be a connection to some
degree or they could be people who use
similar hashtags tweeting the same
content so you want to go ahead and
follow people the rule of thumb on
Twitter is if you follow somebody on
Twitter chances are they're going to
follow you back you know I was once told
when I was using Twitter that hey you
want to give somebody about three days
to follow you back so that's always what
the rule I stuck to you know wait about
three days start following people you
can see here 833 people that or accounts
Twitter accounts that simply learns
following and over ten thousand nine
hundred followers to Simply learn's
Twitter account so for me I don't mind
having a nice balance myself I have just
as many followers as I do following and
that's a good thing so because you want
to be able to keep up with what people
are tweeting and so you can retweet at
the same time you want to be following
people as well because they're going to
follow you back okay and that's how you
can build up your Twitter followers by
following people and it's as simple as
clicking on a follow link so the key
here is to follow people who follow your
content people who are followers of your
followers and you can use Twitter's who
to follow list and upload your email
contacts to Twitter okay since they know
you they're more likely to follow you
back okay so you can use Twitter's who
to follow list and so if we go back to
Twitter here's the who to follow list
and so this is what Twitter is going to
recommend but you can click on this link
here are fine people you know okay so if
I click on find people I know then I can
upload my contacts from Outlook or Gmail
and they're gonna find people who are
already on Twitter based on who I'm
connected with so generally that's how
it works that's a quick way to get more
followers is to connect with people you
know by the way I'm gonna follow simply
learn because I wasn't following them
prior so now I just clicked on the
follow button now I am following so now
I'm going to see simply learns Tweets in
my feed so let's take a second to look
at a brand okay so it's time for a brand
watch let's have a look at some of the
best Tweets of 2018. now remember there
are a lot of active users millions of
active users that's a lot of tweets so
what we did we scoured Twitter from 2018
and we went ahead and picked out some
tweets that we thought were pretty good
and so the first one is Wendy's now I
don't know if any of you have actually
eaten at Wendy's I used to eat at
Wendy's a while ago I know their
frosties are pretty good so what they've
done is they Incorporated that Frosty as
part of a giveaway okay so basically
they're saying hey grab yourself a free
Frosty with any purchase in our app so
they're encouraging people to use our
app and then they're following that up
by saying hey and then join us on Twitch
from two to five eastern as we unlock
all that Frosty goodness so they're
promoting something that's going to
happen on a specific point in time this
is of last January they're encouraging
people to use their app and they're
using that Frosty as kind of a carrot if
you will okay as a catch it's a giveaway
so they were able to you know basically
wrap a bunch of things into one so get
encourage people to take part and I'm
sure a lot of people went ahead and took
part of this but we could definitely see
that 206 retweeted this tweet 302
basically commented on it and over 3
1000 like the Tweet so the Tweet was
good and it basically engaged with users
who doesn't like a free giveaway
especially free Frosty so that's why
this particular tweet really does some
justice for the target audience Their
audience they're they're giving
something away to Their audience just by
allowing them to you know use their app
okay so this tweet combines a lot into
one and I like it apparently a lot more
people than I did 3000 plus also like
this tweet and so moving on to how to
increase your followers on Twitter you
want to mention other people in your
tweets to increase engagement so what do
we mean by that so let's look at Twitter
so go back if we look at simply learn
just take a look at some of their tweets
what they're doing if we scroll down
here they have hashtags so they are
mentioning specific hashtags but you can
also mention handles as well so the
hashtag is always going to start with
either the pound sign but if we scroll
down here if you use the that symbol
you're actually mentioning somebody so
in this case we're mentioning Matt
Bailey so Matt Bailey says is Matt
Bailey's handle and so if you get a
shout out to somebody they're gonna pick
up on that and then they're going to
probably follow you okay who doesn't
appreciate getting recognized for
something especially something as small
as a tweet okay notice I can go ahead
and click follow if I want to follow
Mount Bailey but it's not a bad idea to
add people into your Tweet and you
simply do that by just using the at
symbol and using their Twitter handle
it's a good way to get recognized by
that Twitter follower it also increases
engagement because it's adding validity
to the tweet and it definitely catches
the attention of the person mentioned
remember if you use that person's handle
they're going to see that that you
mention them okay and what it's likely
going to do is start some type of
Twitter relationship okay they're gonna
then follow you you're gonna follow them
and chances of them retweeting you in
the future or mentioning you in the
future is probably going to increase and
overall that increases engagement so
another important thing you want to do
is find and use hashtags that are
relevant to your brand and audience so
this is a must this is mandatory on
Twitter you need to use hashtags
Twitter's all about hashtags every tweet
that goes out should have a hashtag okay
so what you can do is figure out what
hashtags are trending so here what
Twitter does is a trends for you so
these are all specific hashtags that are
trending it's Mother's Day Happy Mother
hey Sunday morning whatever works for
you these are trends that happen to be
moving meaning a lot of people are using
them clicking on them okay so you can
use a popular hashtag what I would also
recommend is you use a unique hashtag
the rule of thumb is usually about two
hashtags in a tweet but that's a rule of
thumb but rules are made to be broken do
what's best for you if you want to
include more than two hashtags go for it
the only thing I'm recommending is
include a hashtag so find out what's
trending you could just look right in
Twitter or you could just create your
own unique hashtag it works both ways
but when you have a hashtag in your
Tweet and somebody clicks on it then
they're going to go to that particular
handle that hashtag and so when they
look at the hashtag you're going to see
all the tweets with that hashtag in it
so that's the idea behind hashtags you
want to have hashtags okay so if
somebody clicks on a hashtag that you've
used then they're likely going to see
your Tweet in that hashtags feed okay so
that's how hashtags work you want to use
hashtags okay but you want to use
hashtags that are relevant to your brand
and audience that's really the key so
hashtags help your tweets to be found
through Twitter search thus improving
your reach and increase the visibility
of your post so that's another benefit
Twitter has search functionality so
somebody can simply go in and start
searching on Twitter so if I go back to
Twitter I can just do a hashtag and
start typing in something like Spanish
and I'm gonna get some of the most
popular Spanish hashtags or Hashtags
with the word Spanish in it and so this
is an idea for me that if I wanted to
use a hashtag with Spanish in it these
are some ideas but they're certainly
searchable on Twitter okay so if I just
click on Spanish okay I'm gonna be able
to see all the Hashtags with the word
Spanish in the hashtag so definitely use
hashtags it's the most beneficial
feature of Twitter Bar None So some
reasons why using hashtags also a good
idea well you're gonna get more
engagement and you're likely to get
retweeted as well so when you get
retweeted then that means more eyeballs
because if somebody sees your Tweet and
retweets it they're retweeting it for
Their audience and so it could go viral
so to speak on Twitter and that's where
the engagement comes in so if you're
using a hashtag that's trendy well
somebody might like that okay if you're
behind a specific movement or you're
following a specific baseball or
football team or cricket team or
whatever team you're following then if
you use that team and the hashtag that
could also get you some some likes so
don't be afraid to use hashtags mix it
up play around a little use something
unique use something that's trending
just use something but make sure it's
relevant to the Tweet find out what
works for your competition what works
for them might work for you too so you
know I work with simply learn but you
know simply learn has a good Twitter
account you know they have lots of
followers they're doing a lot of
tweeting so if I wanted to be just like
simply learn well I could simply just go
to their Twitter account and see what
they're doing okay see what they're
using as hashtag so what kind of tweets
they're implementing and see who's
following them so I can simply just
click on the ten thousand nine hundred
followers that they have and what I
could do is I can go through and start
following the people that are following
them so just mimic your competition to
some degree or mimic others in the
industry you know look at what they're
tweeting again start out by retweeting
some of the stuff they're retweeting if
it's good stuff if it's like a tweet
don't be afraid to retweet even your
competitors tweets okay use unique
hashtags use the hashtags they're using
look at who's following their brand so
you can really learn a lot from others
in your industry including your
competition because what works for them
again might work for you especially when
it comes to hashtags or people who's
following them again people who are
following them would likely follow you
if you're in the same industry so it's
as simple as looking at who's following
them and following those same people
remember the rule of thumb is if you're
following somebody they're likely to
follow you back so again you can analyze
things like the number of followers they
have the frequency of their tweets what
their profile looks like how they
respond to the competition of customers
okay what are they tweeting about what
types of content brings them more
engagement meaning of all the tweets
which one is getting the most likes or
retweets get some sense of what they're
doing and again when I say mimic I mean
what I'm saying is pull best practices
from that Twitter account this will give
you an idea what you need to do to get
more followers so it's always a good
form of flattery when you can mimic what
somebody else is doing just like every
other social media platform following
Twitter influencers who belong in your
industry is always a good idea so if
you're in the food industry and there's
these star chefs out there probably not
a bad idea to follow those star chefs
you know if you're in the technology
industry well probably not a bad idea to
you know follow Bill Gates or Elon Musk
or Richard Branson or somebody else and
that's a big influencer who has an
influence on a lot of people okay but
make sure they're in your industry
that's the key if you can make sure
they're in your industry and you follow
them chances are if they look at your
Twitter account and see you're posting
or maybe retweeting some of their tweets
they're likely to follow you and if
they're following you your tweets are
going to show up on their handle on
their feed and so don't be afraid to go
out and connect and follow those
influencers it's a good way to boost up
your followers so again this will help
you gain followers since you can
replicate what they've done with their
profile so again just like the
competition mimic what your influencers
are doing okay so people tend to follow
people who follow influencers so you're
all of one like mine so to speak okay
influencers might retweet or share your
post if they find you retweeting
favorites and replying to their posts so
remember if you're following a retweeter
or excuse me an influencer and you
retweet their post chances are they
might retweet one of your posts and
again put you in front of a large number
of people since they're influencers so
all of these are good valid reasons to
follow influencers because if you're out
to increase your reach and exposure it's
hard to ignore influencers in your
industry okay you want to use images and
videos while tweeting remember videos
get multiple multiple times more
engagement than not using them at the
very least use images but you use images
don't use stock Photography use images
that are relevant so one of these tweets
caught my eye here from Simply learn so
if I click on you know here it was
further down here it looked like you
know these are people who are engaging
in a conference and it might have been
one that Matt Bailey was at so it was a
retweet from Matt Bailey as a matter of
fact but you could see what simply
learns doing is they're including either
a video or they're including an image in
every tweet and so that's likely to
boost up engagement so according to
buffer which is a another social media
platform adding a relevant high quality
and image in your tweets can help you
gain more than a hundred and fifty
percent engagement okay videos are six
times more likely to be retweeted so if
you have an Arsenal video or even one
video don't be afraid to use it my
recommendation is trying to use images
as much as you can in almost every tweet
images go a long way and again it's
going to help improve engagement meaning
more retweets more followers okay more
followers more eyeballs so it's a
Snowball Effect just by using images
Okay so let's take a look at another
brand from 2018 okay Pizza always my
good example to use on these webinars I
like pizza here this just says it all
you know they're talking about art and
they're using Pizza in the form of art
so they didn't really have to say much
else here this pretty much says it all
and they did get some retweets they get
some just some likes so sometimes you
don't have to say a lot to make your
point sometimes just the image itself
will do the job this was actually not
from 2 2018 this goes all the way back
to 2016. so still holds true if you use
an image that image is going to get
engagement okay so on Twitter just like
most other social media platforms you
can promote your Tweet so you can use
Twitter ads to do that so you can
promote your Tweet and what you do by
promoting it is putting it up above so
that most people will be able to see it
okay so see if we can find an example if
I go here I could see this person is
promoting their handle but if I go down
here I can see a promoted tweet by
Constant Contact so they're promoting
their tweet here so it's not a bad idea
if you have some Media budget to go
ahead and either promote your Tweet or
advertise on Twitter so what that's
going to do is put you in a more
prominent position and get your tweets
out there and the whole idea for that is
to get people to engage here you can see
a call to action from Constant Contact
so if I click on that I'm going to go to
probably a landing page on their website
and so the whole idea when you advertise
on Twitter is really just like any other
social media platform you want to put
yourself in front of the Right audience
and so Twitter's no exception so with
Twitter you could put yourself in front
of the Right audience so what you could
do is you could promote a tweet you know
do promoted Trends or you could do
promoted accounts so you have a number
of different advertising options on
Twitter what we just looked at was you
know looking at promoted accounts and a
promoted tweet so when you do advertise
there are advantages you have to pay
only after achieving your marketing
objective so that's a benefit of Twitter
the cost per click it's a cost per click
model so it tends to be fairly low you
could tail your audience so again you're
picking and choosing who you want your
promoted tweet or Trend or account to be
in front of and it's targeting is based
on either engagement or it's based on
keywords I.E hashtags so really you
could tailor who you want your Tweet or
your handle to be in front of and so
that's the really the benefit of Twitter
if you have a lot of active users on
Twitter you can really put yourself in
front of those active users if they're
your relevant audience at a low cost per
click so it's definitely worth the test
so you want to offer Twitter support to
your users okay so I can't stress this
enough okay so what you want to do is
when users have questions about your
product they're more likely to tweet you
for support hence they're likely to file
your account so don't be afraid to use
the messaging option as well so we go
back to Twitter okay chances are
somebody might have a question for you
here you can look at big ads it's great
connecting with PPC experts can't
believe tax season is here we've got
some great insights so what they're
doing is they're using the messaging app
but they're offering that messaging app
and the 4 form of customer service so
don't be afraid to use you know direct
messages to reach out to people in the
form of support what you don't want to
do is buy Twitter followers chances are
you're going to get the wrong followers
so even though it may boost your Twitter
follow account these Bots cannot use or
buy your products or services so stay
away from all sorts of buying of Twitter
followers you want to build your Twitter
following naturally Twitter is also
cracking down on bot followers so a lot
of Bot accounts that were paid to follow
users were shuts down shut down by
Twitter so just my point is everything
we've mentioned today is what you want
to take advantage of okay if you want to
pay for something pay for a promoted
tweet reach out to influencers look at
what your competition is doing use
hashtags okay these are all best
practices in organic ways to build
followers so don't get involved with
anything that's going to involve Bots
and adding thousands of followers to
twitter.com out because chances are it's
just going to lead to no engagement so
create useful and relevant content so
what we started out by saying is hey if
you're not sure what to do retweet
retweet which somebody else is doing you
know look at your competition's Twitter
account see what they're tweeting get
some ideas as to what you want to tweet
so you want it to be useful and relevant
to your industry okay you want somebody
to engage that's the whole idea behind
Twitter the whole idea is if you're
going to Tweet something you want to get
somebody to engage with it so use
Twitter polls your old recent blog post
brand news industry news and events and
highlight customer stories I mean all of
those are ideas that you can do to put
content out there okay so for me one of
the things I do is I'm definitely one
for industry news so if I'm in the
industry of digital marketing if Google
did a recent algorithm update I'm going
to likely tweet about it or retweet it I
also am a blogger so I'm my particular
website if I blog I'm gonna make sure
that blog gets over to Twitter so those
are some ideas in which you can create
useful and relevant content on your
Twitter account you definitely want to
get that content out there but you want
to make it useful and relevant quality
over quantity because you want people to
engage so bring variety to the type of
content you share so I'm in digital
marketing I deal with pay-per-click SEO
but am I gonna just do pay-per-click and
SEO no I know that analytics I know that
you know Google tag manager I know that
they'd be testing all of those are
elements of digital marketing so I'm
going to Branch out and talk about some
of those things that support digital
marketing so that's an example of
bringing variety to the type of content
you share so don't just stick to one
thing you know feel free to reach out a
little bit shake things up by sharing
other forms of updates like engaging
quotes and questions these work best
when complemented by an image and act as
a great discussion starter so good point
here even if you want to Branch out of
your industry and just throw in a nice
useful quote it's always a good way to
gain some attention and get some
engagement okay let's look at another
brand and see what they've tweeted about
so we're looking at Forester here so
think about emotional qualities and
their implications so here you can see
customers that feel surprised or
grateful or appreciated they're sharing
that Insight with you and so this was
interesting when I saw this so what I
did was I simply you see the hashtag
here for digital basically if you want
to look at this particular study I just
went to Twitter and I typed in that
hashtag and now I'm going to be able to
see you know some of the other studies
that they've done here you can see top
10 it Trends shaping 2019 so I'm just
following the Twitter handle that they
used so Forester does a lot of good
research a lot of good insights and so
what they've done here that makes this
tweet look so good is they've actually
put an image of the results in the Tweet
so they used an image to help gain
engagement or increase engagement notice
they also gave a shout out to somebody
as well as used some good hashtagging so
good tweet this was back in 2016 but
again a good use of the image with the
Tweet so you want to organize tweet
chats to interact with your users and
bring in new followers so you know you
basically want to be organized when
you're dealing with with chats so tweet
chats enable you send out tweets on a
particular topic using a designated
hashtag so during a certain time to
interact with your your followers and
other users so you could do it at a
specific time to really get out a
specific topic but you want to be able
to stay organized so that you know you
what you're chatting about is reaching
the Right audience and you're getting
the right following and the right
engagement okay you can also also pin
your best updates and tweets to your
profile so you can just use that pin and
what that's going to do is pin it to the
top and keep it there so that you know
people who go to your Twitter handle are
going to be able to see that best tweet
that you've done so what you want to do
here is use the one that's most engaging
so pinning your best update or tweet
meaning the one that's really had a lot
of Engagement meaning retweets and
followers and likes you want to do that
you want to pin that to your profile and
that will enable first-time visitors to
see it and if they could see something
that other people engaged with and
that's going to encourage them to share
and probably follow you so and and
that's always what you want to do you
always want to put your best foot
forward so pin your best tweet to your
profile so I mentioned this earlier use
tools to schedule when to publish your
tweets so here's some of the most
popular platforms you know I.E Sprout
social so if we take a look at Sprout
social hey here I'm in Sprout social I'm
connected to my Twitter account I can
simply just start tweeting about
something here so you can see it's going
to let me know how many characters I
have remaining so 280 to start out with
when I'm done tweeting notice I can add
an emoji I can upload media I can tag a
specific location okay I can even you
know call out a specific Twitter profile
now I can schedule this myself or I can
use the schedule below I can pick and
choose a time to schedule the Tweet now
again you want to be able to use the
Sprout social whatever social media tool
you're using to figure out when the best
time of day and the day of the week to
actually tweet when are you getting the
best engagement so ideally that's what
you want to do you want to tweet when
you're likely to get the best engagement
when those eyeballs are actually going
to look at that tweet okay but you also
want to separate out your tweets so
they're not on one on top of another
because if you actually Tweet back to
back then those tweets are just going to
get buried so if you spread them out a
little bit then you're likely to
maximize your number of Impressions or
eyeballs on that tweet so if you
schedule a tweet multiple Tweets in the
same day then post them a few hours
apart or an hour apart so that way
you're always going to get that maximum
visibility so these social media
platforms really help you and not only
scheduling but figuring out what tweets
got the best engagement and when and
then that way you can replicate that
success so again it's not just Sprout
social HootSuite buffer they'll help you
determine the exact time your audience
is most active and schedule post to
increase traction so you know most of
these social media platforms do the same
thing so really what you want to do is
you really want to nail down that exact
time your audience is going to be most
active Okay that's the whole idea behind
using it and when you actually do tweet
you are going to get results and these
social media platforms are going to
share those results with you and then
when you understand based on your
audience behavior when they're engaging
when they're not engaging that's when
you're going to fine tune your
scheduling so what you also want to do
as you're doing these tweets as we
looked at earlier with Wendy's is run
contests or giveaways remember Randy's
gave away that free Frosty you know be
afraid to give away something if it
means more engagement more eyeballs
which could lead to basically future
customers so contests can help increase
your reach and exposure and each new
participant can be considered as a
potential follower so it also gives your
followers an opportunity to tag their
friends who would be interested in
participating so really come up this is
a great way to be creative come up with
a good idea to get your your audience
involved because what's likely going to
happen is your audience is going to
share this contest with others that
aren't following you and so it's going
to happen is when they share it you're
going to get more followers you're going
to get more eyeballs and again
potentially more customers so embed your
Twitter updates on your website you
could simply do that uh it's very simple
but when you do then people to your
website will be able to see your tweets
so if I just go to my website here if I
scroll down we actually have you know
Twitter embedded on our website as well
because we want you know people to see
what we're tweeting about and you can
see I just retweeted the simply learned
tweet at the beginning of this
particular webinar and it's showing up
in my feed here so that's when people
actually go to my website they'll be
able to see what I retweeted and that's
going to help simply learn out because
simply learn is likely to get some
clicks on this particular tweet from my
website so it's also a good way to keep
your website fresh and updated because
if you're an active Twitter user and
you're tweeting a lot then hey that's
going to show up on your website and
it's going to show that hey you're fresh
you're engaging you keep up to date day
it's just gonna make it look good and
make your website feel fresh and not
stale so embedding your Twitter updates
will help you add new followers as well
because it's people who are coming to
your website that may not even know you
have a Twitter account so you can also
do this in a blog post and a newsletter
and other forms of communication media
so it doesn't necessarily have to be
just your website but I would definitely
recommend it because it will give a
boost to your Twitter account so now
let's take a look at the final brand
watch let's take a look at another tweet
that caught our attention when this is
from PlayStation so PlayStation is
mentioning hey we got a multi-view on
Apple TV today with support for up to
four live channels on one screen okay so
you know they're promoting a new feature
that they have with PlayStation and you
can see they supported that with an
image and they got some really good
engagement here so they're basically
saying hey look what happened to us
today you know check out this new
feature that got support it on Apple TV
so you never know what's going to happen
with a tweet when you tweet good things
are likely going to happen whether that
be somebody liking it retweeting it or
somebody adding you as a follower
something good is going to come out of
tweeting Twitter is an easy platform to
use and if you take into account all
these best practices you are going to
increase your Twitter followers
after watching this video you should be
prepared to explain why the human
tendency to daydream can be interrupted
using a storytelling marketing approach
to list three key benefits of
Storytelling when it comes to Consumer
engagement to realize that different
consumers are looking for different
relationships with your company and to
explain the difference between
storytelling and story sharing let's
begin lesson one why storytelling is
essential in Social marketing when we
think about the way that our company or
our brand or our organization is
represented to the world it's easy for
us to be focused in on things like
quality and credibility and whether or
not someone wants to buy from us but
it's also important to understand that
for a lot of consumers the very idea of
who you are is also important it's not
always just enough for people to know
the name of your company or product
they're interested in understanding what
the story is behind your brand and that
might be something like how you came to
be or why you exist or what your mission
is or it might be something about the
person reality and sort of the lifestyle
that's represented by your individual
company now the storytelling movement
has been an area that we've really seen
a lot of growth and a lot of improvement
in the last several years in social
media with more and more Brands moving
towards this idea of sort of humanizing
their companies by telling the stories
that come out of the company itself out
of the use of the product or even out of
the consumer stories that you know share
how products benefit their lives or
again just what goes on in that
interaction and that dynamic between the
organization and between the customer
side of things now when it comes to
storytelling there's several different
ways in which this approach offers value
to a business and one of the key ones is
on the emotional side we've talked a lot
in the social sharing dynamic in some of
the other areas of you know the the
spread and the viral concept about how
emotion is one of the most powerful
things that impacts people's decision
making and engagement with the brand so
when it comes to creating that emotional
connection or leaving people with some
type of emotional response storytelling
is one of the most powerful ways to
impact that it gives you an opportunity
to sway the emotion of consumers in
terms of how they look at or view or are
receptive to your brand now another
thing that storytelling can really do
that adds a lot of value is the idea of
making you credible because a lot of
times the way we tell stories especially
when we're incorporating in true to life
examples or you know consumer stories
there's an implied credibility that
comes through that storytelling and
comes through those third-party
experiences that can help people feel
more secure about doing business with
you not just more emotionally positive
but actually feel that security of
trusting that what they think they're
going to get or what they're hoping to
get that there's going to be enough
follow-through and enough other people
have had a positive experience for them
to really trust that that's what's going
to happen now another area that
storytelling brings a lot of value into
a company is the in the idea of making
you memorable
because human beings are wired for
stories we are much more capable of
recalling broad ideas and Concepts and
emotions when they're communicated via a
story so if we give someone a list of
facts a list of selling points you know
a list of reasons why to do business
with you the ones that touch them
emotionally or that you know problem
solve those tend to stick with them but
a lot of the data gets lost but when we
put it in the format of a story and
someone is sharing what their experience
was our brains literally archive it and
categorize it differently and our recall
level goes up so again along with
building trust and along with creating
that that emotional impact the fact that
people are better able to recall the
information that's communicated to them
via that story helps make it a very
powerful marketing tool now in addition
to that it's important to keep in mind
that on average people tend to be
daydreamers in fact study after study
shows that if our minds aren't occupied
with an important task if we're not
truly focused on something we tend to
drift off and when we look at that
concept of daydreaming the average human
spends literally half of their waking
hours daydreaming we average 2 000
waking drifts per day with an average
length of about 14 seconds so you do the
math on that two thousand times times 14
seconds that's a pretty good portion of
our day where our brain is drifting off
but when they look at the brain's
ability to stay focused versus having
those drifts we stay focused during a
story if we're reading a book if we're
watching a movie if someone is telling
us an engaging Story We Are Better
equipped and better able to put those
drifts off and really stay focused on
what's Happening so that's one of the
other sort of scientific and concrete
reasons why that memorable Factor comes
into play when we present things via
stories now stories also allow us to
connect in one of the easiest ways
possible again because our brain is
going to be a little more focused on
being able to receive that message so by
using stories to spread your brand
message or to explain your offerings or
to demonstrate how they work you
increase the chance of keeping your
audience focused on you and giving them
enough recall that they can come back at
a later point to actually do some
business with you now think of
Storytelling from sort of the mindset of
how we meet and engage with other people
so in general when we're meeting up with
a prospective friend or a job prospect
maybe we're coming for an interview a
service workers even just a stranger on
the street any conversation that goes
past just hello how are you doing and
the cursory you know kind of polite
responses it tends to be a story this is
what we do when we meet we're naturally
wired to seek out insight and Common
Ground in information about who another
person is and in those interpersonal
relationships the types of questions we
ask you know the words we use they're
indicative of the type of relationship
we want to build so clearly if you know
if you're single and you see someone
else that you know you hope might be
saying well that might be one of the
early questions you ask and then based
on whether you know there's a romantic
interest there you're probably going to
ask different questions than if it's a
interview Prospect for a job or if
you're meeting up with a you know
co-worker for the first time the
relationship that we're looking for
denotes the type of information we want
and that's one of the important things
for us to keep in mind when it comes to
storytelling is we also have the ability
to tailor our story to the audience so
we can put those different features up
front we can weave them in in a
different way if we're appealing to a
group of 60-something females that love
to sew versus a group of 20-something
Millennials that love whiskey tasting
it's a different message that gets put
together with different focuses and
features there's also different of
things that we're going to put forward
if we're proposing you know million
dollar contract versus a 25 impulse buy
that someone can you know click and
order online and have delivered the next
day now on the business side of this we
need to think about what the story that
we need is because a lot of times we get
so focused in business on getting the
conversion that we forget that sometimes
part of getting that conversion is
creating those emotions building that
credibility and trust you know helping
them have exposure to what's possible
and for a long time this has been done
through education we might put up videos
or articles that aim to educate and to
demonstrate the story side of it brings
that more social interaction and
environment into the mix and that's
something important for us to keep in
mind so a quote that I really love about
this concept that sort of lays the
foundation of why it's so important
comes from the chief content officer
over at digitas and he says the
challenge is clear by now intrusive
interruptive self-centered marketing no
longer works the way it once did and its
Effectiveness will only continue to
diminish in the social age because again
the way that we share information back
and forth with each other and the ways
that that messages spread it happens
differently in the social media age than
it did before when it was more
advertising focused and where marketing
really was more about you know pushing
the advertised pushing the message and
sort of the Don Draper style of you know
if you don't like the conversation
change the conversation and tell people
what you want them to hear because so
much marketing is now driven by
consumers through that conversation we
need to be able to approach it in a
different way now another side of that
is the idea there's a difference between
storytelling and story sharing and some
of it boils down to semantics but some
of it also does need to be kind of taken
into account when we look at how we
might put our message together because
semantically consider the difference
between telling and sharing so to tell
is to communicate information facts or
news to someone and spoken or written
word it's to order instruct or advise
someone to do something that second part
that I want you to keep in mind but to
share is to give a portion of something
to another to tell someone about
something especially something personal
it's a again it's a slight semantic
difference but it's a huge difference in
terms of our approach and I love this
Seth Godin quote that really pairs up
with that idea the best part of Show and
Tell has never been the telling part
it's been the showing letting someone
see and experience and inviting them
into that shared experience and that's
one of those things that makes the
social version of Storytelling really
more like story sharing especially if
you want to do it in a way that creates
that back and forth consumer engagement
story telling in its traditional sense
is more the stories that we've put into
commercials and advertising and there's
a place for that there's a place to put
that together in the social realm and
it's very important but the other area
that that we're just starting to kind of
merge into and that really needs some
exploration by Brands is that idea of
the social sharing where it really is
about engaging back and forth with your
audience and inviting them to be part of
an experience with you and with your
brand so ask yourself do you want to
tell your story to people or do you want
to share it with them and let them share
their story with you and how do you meld
those two together and what does that
look like within your particular company
or among your target audio
so now that we've laid the foundation of
why storytelling is so important and
sort of what type of impact it can have
the next thing we need to do is look at
the business side of telling your story
what does it look like to create a
narrative or something that's
representative of either your business's
story or sort of the lifestyle or
concept or ideas that you want to
promote to people now there's tons of
questions you could ask yourself to
start building your story but we can
focus in on a couple key areas as a
starting point to build from
and one of the first ones is the idea of
whether or not you have a Founder's
story now for a lot of Brands the story
of their founder is so interesting or
inspiring that it catches the eye and it
makes people take a second look at the
product so think of the companies that
are sort of iconic in terms of who their
their founder or their leader is so
whether that was Steve Jobs and the role
he played at Apple or Walt Disney and
the inspiration and the role he brought
to you know the entire Disney complex or
loads and loads of other businesses
there are lots of examples out there of
how the brand itself was so tied to the
person who was sort of leading the helm
that that became part of their story and
people were really interested in it now
we can find loads of examples of
different brands where the founder
really plays a critical role in
representing who they are now a great
example of this is Spanx the founder
Sarah Blakely has really embraced the
story but both of how she came up with
the idea which was basically she was
trying to fit into a pair of cream pants
for a party and they didn't fit quite
right and she knew that when she put her
pantyhose on everything seemed to lay
nicer so she literally cut the feet out
of a pair of pantyhose and put them on
and that's what launched the brand you
know she loves to sort of tell that
story but she also loves to tell the
story you know from her tagline of
putting her own butt on the line pays
off because the way that she made her
first sale to Neiman Marcus is that she
literally dragged the buyer into a
dressing room and she went in and she
put on a pair of white pants and came
out and said you know here's what I look
like without them and went back in and
put her pair of Spanx on under the white
pants and came back out and said now
here's what happens when I'm wearing
these and the buyer from Neiman Marcus
ended up placing a huge order and it was
the first major sale that she got that
put her in place somewhere so those
stories and sort of the yeah this is how
it happened you know this is literally
what a difference makes that becomes
part of the brand and sort of Sarah
blakely's Journey as an entrepreneur and
you know moving her way up into the you
know the Forbes list of uh you know
highest earning females in the United
States all of that plays a huge role in
how they promote the brand itself and in
sort of the
the storyline and the lifestyle line
that they want to promote to the people
that might buy the product
now on a completely differently themed
vein we have fast food chain Wendy's in
the US and Canada where Dave Thomas was
the founder and even though he's you
know passed away several years ago
he's still a critical part of the brand
and of the story because basically it
was the idea that A working class guy
makes good and continues to act like a
working class guy while building a
massive charity because it wasn't
uncommon even when he was CEO to see him
show up at a store somewhere and start
working behind the counter or sweeping
the floor somewhere he always played
that role that made it clear to his
employees that he wasn't above them that
he was one of them and part of them
and has a huge huge ongoing charity
effort for adoption because he was
adopted as a child and so all of that
plays Into The Narrative of Wendy's and
who they are and what their brand
message is and and the lifestyle that
they want to promote to customers in
fact if you if you go there now and you
buy a meal and you get your cup all of
the Cups have stories of kids when they
were finally adopted and what it meant
to them when they were adopted or you
know what their first experience was
having a new family so again that plays
into the story just because people are
interested in the start of where how it
came to be
so looking at you know what the stories
are from within your team and it doesn't
always have to be that founder story
sometimes it's just someone who works
there
um Post Cereal paired up with Burns
group and use real factory workers to
create a round of Honey Bunches of Oats
commercials and let's let's take a quick
look at what one of those actually look
like so you can kind of see the
storytelling in action here
I get out of work and I go to the store
and somebody's smelling around I smell
cookies that's all you know you just
smell me I just got out of work that's
honey bunches oh that's all I said don't
eat me now
[Music]
another short simple easy stories
there's nothing complex to them they
more just make you smile and laugh but
they're the types of stories that come
from listening to the people who work at
your company from thinking about how
your company and their experience
impacts the world around them
now another question that we can look at
is does your company or group solve a
problem now this isn't about the reasons
you think you're great or the reasons
you think people should buy from you
it's about that unique way that you
solve an issue that consumers or on the
B2B side of things you know the the
buying agent is looking at that they're
trying to fix
now great example of this is Airbnb or
you could look at Uber or Lyft on a
similar vein allowing people to
experience travel
in a new and affordable way but also
letting you know owners or drivers earn
extra money
you know from something that might have
been sitting there empty anyways you
know that idea that when you're
traveling you don't have to stay in a
bland expensive hotel in fact when I
travel for business pretty much any
place I go I always book via Airbnb
because you know if I can have a bedroom
and a living room and a kitchen
especially for traveling as a family and
there can be you know separate bedrooms
as opposed to having my kids all stay in
the same room with my husband and I it
just makes sense but there's also the
story side of that of its different
experiences and that's one of the big
things that people talk about is how the
experience changes and even on the side
of trying to recruit people to put their
properties it becomes about the freedom
and the lifestyle that's enabled and
there's tons of examples on YouTube of
people sharing how you know leasing out
that you know their vacation property
the rest of the year when they're not
there you know pays for the vacation
property and more or you know the people
who now travel full-time because they're
able to lease out you know their
apartment or their home or something
else on Airbnb the story side comes from
the problems that are solved for people
now another great example of a company
that focuses on their story from that
side is Dollar Shave Club they basically
took a problem everyone complains about
and they made it go away you know the
idea that razors cost a ridiculous
amount of money that you always forget
to buy new ones until it's too late so
you're shaving with a dull Blazer and
it's just inconvenient so all of their
messaging focuses in on that idea of we
make it cheap we make it easy and you
know it shows up right at your house and
you don't ever have to think about it
anymore
and their commercials all tell the same
story with kind of a you know funny
modern Millennial focused way so let's
take a look at one of those as an
example
as a founder of my own club I'd love to
know how does yours work Dollar Shave
Club presents what the fact it's simple
you choose from one of our three great
razors we'll give you a free reusable
handle and each month we'll send you
replacement cartridges for just a few
bucks that means you get to shave with a
fresh blood anytime you want which feels
amazing
will I be locked into a contract no we
wouldn't lock you into anything that's a
relief how long for delivering I've got
a conjugal visit next week
well what if I don't have to shave that
often no problem after you sign up you
can choose to get replacement cartridges
every other month you sound like my mom
I like that
ew
what's this I hear about Dollar Shave
Club selling more than just razors you
heard right we make all our own high
quality grooming products like Dr cover
shea butter Boogie's hair gel and big
cloud daily face moisturizer with
sunscreen now you know what the fact is
up with Dollar Shave Club so join the
club today
[Music]
now before we get into the tips and
tricks let's take a refresher on what
exactly is social media marketing
social media marketing which is one of
the most commonly used and lucrative
forms of digital marketing
is a methodology that has Brands
creating and sharing content on social
media
oh if you've ever been on any form of
social media be it LinkedIn Facebook or
Instagram you've probably been exposed
to some form of social media marketing
remember that Burger King video
advertising their new whopper or about a
marketing tool that can help you
visualize your team's workload better
than any other in the market right now
now these are just some of the many ways
that you've been marketed to
the objective when it comes to social
media marketing is to achieve the
Brand's marketing and branding goals
now this could be increased engagement
more clicks conversions and so on
so how do they do it
with text and image updates videos or
any other form of content that can
attract the user's attention and can
drive engagement from them now alongside
publishing quality content it also
involves analyzing your data and running
social media advertisements now some of
the more popular social media platforms
right now are Facebook Instagram Twitter
LinkedIn and so on
next let's talk about some of the
advantages of social media marketing
first up social media marketing provides
great brand awareness now with the help
of interactions with people on social
media brands are able to build up their
reputation as a business and with each
interaction each post each share the
brand is exposed to a larger network of
potential customers who might be
interested in the products or services
offered
next it gives you more traffic to your
website
marketing your products or services on
social media will also attract customers
to your website
outside your usual custom Pace
next it improves your Brand's search
engine rankings
now although this isn't a direct
correlation social media marketing does
have a part to play when it comes to
helping your pH rank higher up in search
engine rankings now if you start posting
high quality content people will start
liking and sharing it this will in turn
bring it to the attention of influencers
within the industry who will be willing
to write about your business
and then this gives you backlinks which
as you know will help you improve your
search engine rankings
next it will give you improved
conversion rates
now with your brand being much more
visible and interactive on social media
every text image video or comment could
potentially Drive users to your website
social media also humanizes your brand
now this leads to more customers
trusting a brand and being more
interested in your products and services
then we have improved customer
satisfaction
when your customers interact with your
brand on social media it provides you
with an opportunity to show compaction
for your customers
personal messages to customers
addressing their concerns will be viewed
in a positive light and can go a long
way when it comes to humanizing your
brand
social media marketing is also cost
effective
now compared to other forms of digital
marketing social media marketing offers
some of the most flexible and relatively
low cost options available
now this opens your budget for more
marketing and business expenditures now
if you do get into paid advertising a
good strategy will net you a great
return on investment
and finally it will help you become
thought leaders
now with your high quality posts
communicating with your audience sharing
content and promoting your Authority you
can have your followers look up to you
now this will allow you to become a
figure of expertise in your industry
now let's go into the social media
marketing tips and tricks
number one set up your goals
now what good will your actions do if
you don't have a goal in mind
the goal of your marketing strategy will
be the driving force behind every
decision that you make
now this is exactly why setting up codes
is very important moreover your
marketing efforts have to align with the
goals of the organization
now here are some things that you need
to keep in mind while setting up your
goals
first of all your goals need to be
quantitative for example you need to
have thousand conversions by the end of
the quarter or 5000 followers on
Instagram by the end of the month and so
on
number two you need to stick to a
consistent deadline this gives weight
for each of your actions
number three make sure your goals are
smart
now smart refers to specific measurable
attainable relevant and time-based
now let's go to number four like I
mentioned earlier your goals need to be
aligned with the marketing strategy
now alongside these goals there also
needs to be the North Star metric
now what is the North Star metric
this represents the main goal or a fixed
reference point that will ensure that
your team is on the right course
this not star metric will also give your
team Clarity and focus
now let's have a look at some popular
North Stars there's increased engagement
greater conversion rates more leads
generated app downloads and so on
now let's go to number two
understanding your audience
social media enables you to interact
engage and build relationships with your
audience
Now by understanding what they need want
and desire you can deliver content in a
way makes your product or service the
answer that they're looking for
now there are also other ways you can
understand them better this could be
surveys to determine the issues that
bother them the age demographics of your
Audience by conversing with them in
forums responding to their comments on
blogs and social media taking up their
feedbacks or suggestions into
consideration and acting on them and so
on
now here's an example of different
channels and the audiences that use them
now here we take in a personal example
here they simply learn now simplulon's
audience is predominantly working
professionals and graduates
an academy has high school graduates and
the baijus app has high school students
as users
now let's go to number three
data mining the right social media
platform
now while performing social media
marketing choosing the right platform is
really important
now while selecting them you need to ask
questions like why you're using that
particular platform who you'll reach
with this platform what content could
work best on the platform and is there
any content that was unique to that
platform for example YouTube and then
there's videos on it
now answering these questions will help
you zero in on a platform for you
now while there are several platforms
available for you to choose from let me
tell you about some major ones this
LinkedIn Facebook Instagram and
Pinterest
let's talk about the purpose of each of
these platforms
now LinkedIn is a professional Network
that's best suited for B2B audiences
now for Facebook just about everyone has
an account on it
content that's related to news or
entertainment usually finds success on
Facebook
then we have Instagram
visual content works best on Instagram
now although it works well for static
images and short form videos it doesn't
drive a lot of traffic to your website
then finally we have Pinterest Pinterest
is also limited to static images
however it's highly effective at driving
traffic to your blog
now let's go to number four
setting up a social media calendar
a social media calendar determines the
message you want to convey to your
audience
it also consists of information
regarding the different kinds of content
that will go up on the social media
platform
now let's have a look at some of the
most popular types of posts on social
media first off we have competitions now
I'm sure all of you have seen posts like
tag a friend who does this or comment or
like to win something and stuff like
that competitions like these provide
great opportunities for engagement with
the audience now they can be used to
encourage your followers to share your
content it could be also for them to
create their own content along with the
predefined hashtag
competitions help grow your presence on
social media then we have polls or
service
polls can help you with data collection
that also encourages followers to take
action and interact polls and surveys
also provide opportunities through which
you can learn from customers to
understand what they like about the
product or service or what they don't
and to receive their feedback
then we have videos and live streams now
although we'll be covering this in a
little more detail further on visual
storytelling along with videos and live
streams goes a long way to drive
engagement among your audience
now please help get your followers
attention increase trust and credibility
and have a high response rate and so
much more to offer
live stream with its live nature and
having a human face alongside your
business humanizes your brand and by
extension helps increase customer
loyalty and Trust
then there's infographics articles and
images
social media calendars are successful
because of their ability to increase
collaboration within the team help
understand what works and what doesn't
and in distributing resources in an
effective manner
next up we have number five using social
media marketing tools
social media marketing tools align to
the goals of your organization
with it you can create high quality
content attract new potential customers
and driving engagement
it also helps you with the planning
process you can plan create and schedule
posts on your social calendar
now some of the more popular social
media tools include buffer HootSuite bus
Sumo if Triple T and much more
now these tools also help with
generating leads creating email lists
finding a relevant audience to show your
content to creating buyer personas
providing you insights on what works and
what doesn't and giving you templates
for different kinds of posts
now for number six
visual storytelling
now visual storytelling involves passing
out a lot of information in the simplest
of forms visually
using pictures and videos your followers
are able to grasp the message quickly
and remember it for a long time
afterwards
visual storytelling is also not limited
by language barriers this helps it
become interesting and entertaining to
anyone watching it this can help your
audience stay interested and engaged
grab the attention of potential clients
and so much more
but it also has some other advantages it
helps you build a bond with your
audience visual storytelling connects
with your audience methods like live
streaming help humanize your brand and
help grow customer loyalty and Trust
it helps the audience quickly grasp the
intended message thanks to its simple
nature and finally most importantly
content like images and videos are what
go viral with visual storytelling you
increase the chance for your content to
be seen by more potential customers
have a look at some of our videos
so here's what is machine learning data
science in five minutes and AI in 5
minutes
now these are some of our most viewed
videos on our Channel and now you know
why visual storytelling if you guys are
interested in watching these videos you
can check them out on our Channel
homepage we also have similar videos
about blockchain devops and Six Sigma
now back to our list
let's go to number seven
paying for advertising
this is a method that helps you find
Target and reach your audience with ease
it can greatly help with achieving your
organization's marketing goals
this can help you improve your reach and
improve your Brand's visibility it's
pay-per-click model ensures cost
Effectiveness while providing great
results and return on investment it also
helps improve targeting by letting you
control who sees your ad you get to
choose from a number of different
factors like interests Hobbies
personality types and so on alongside
the basic use of demographics like age
occasion gender and so on now since most
social media platforms have native
analytics you also get to assess and
Define the performance of your ad
campaigns
now as great as it sounds there are
certain pitfalls that come along with
paid advertising
first of all your audience could get
exposed to your posts too many times and
tune out your content disregarding it in
the process
second it could get really expensive for
smaller businesses or startups to manage
a campaign to its maximum effectiveness
third people could pass off your content
as irrelevant and unimportant
you'll also have to deal with a whole
lot of competition smaller companies
with lesser budgets have an uphill
battle to deal with better funded
organizations
next we have number eight news jacket
new stacking is a method that involves
using current events to promote your own
Brands products and services now it's a
popular method that's used to improve
brand awareness
newsjacking uses the popularity of the
current events and drives it to your
brand it also helps shine a spotlight on
your products it also helps you show off
that you are up to date with current
events in the industry and that your
product is relevant by extension it also
improves engagement and website traffic
now for number nine a b testing
a b testing is a popular method for
comparing copies creatives and ctas or
call to actions of the posts that you
put on social media now since audiences
would react differently depending on the
content a b testing helps determine
which of the variants your audience
engaged with the most
a b testing can also be performed on
variations of location age gender
education your audience interests and so
on
next up number 10 community and
influencers
joining communities helps your brand
link up with like-minded people and
other companies belonging to your niche
it'll also help you establish your brand
as an authority within the industry now
actively participating in these
communities can help create your own
audience of potential brand Advocates to
group up with
on the other hand partnering up with
influencers helps promote your products
or services to a brand new audience it
helps provide an additional layer of
authenticity in YouTube which is also a
social media platform if you don't know
here are some very very popular
influences we have Marcus Brownlee unbox
therapy Mr who's the boss and Linus Tech
tips each of them with more than 4
million subscribers
and finally we're at number 11 measuring
and analyzing results
accurately tracking and measuring your
marketing efforts are an important part
of the process
it ensures that you're making the most
out of your campaigns
now it's really important that you find
key metrics that are crucial for your
brand
now these metrics can be tracked weekly
monthly or in a quarterly basis and
based on these results appropriate
actions can be taken
on Facebook you could look out for reach
and engagement on Twitter you could look
out for Impressions clicks and
Impressions and interactions on LinkedIn
likes comments and mentions on Instagram
and engagement and Impressions on
Pinterest
some of the most popular tools used for
this purpose are Sprout social buffer
HootSuite Google analytics and so on
now before we get into the tips and
tricks let's take a refresher on what
exactly is content marketing
content marketing is a form of marketing
that involves the creation and sharing
of online content to help generate
audience interest in a Brand's product
or services this means providing
information that the audience considers
valuable and relevant in a consistent
manner so that it drives some sort of
profitable customer action
so let's talk about the content that
falls under content marketing there's
options like blogs videos
infographics case studies white papers
and ebooks
so why is content marketing so important
firstly it helps build awareness trust
and loyalty in your brand
the more your brand provides accurate
and well-researched content the more
people learn about and trust your brand
the more the audience trusts a new the
more they're likely to buy from you
creating the content is relatively
inexpensive and can be done in-house
content marketing will also enable your
brand to increase traffic to your site
and get more conversions
it also helps improve other marketing
tactics like search engine optimization
social media and public relations
now let's have a look at the content
marketing process
the first step is to determine what
goals you want to achieve with your
marketing campaign it could be increased
conversions website signups and so on
then you set up buyer personas from
among your audience that can buy your
content
but what exactly are buyer personas now
these are research-based profiles that
represent your Target customer buy a
personas help you describe your Brand's
ideal audience
the decisions they make the challenges
they face their interests and so on
next you'll have to set up content
audits to determine the best type of
content that works for you
you also need to set up a Content
management system like HubSpot
Squarespace Wix and WordPress they'll
help you with increased collaboration
greater support run a B test and much
more
you need to brainstorm for new forms of
content that your audience can enjoy
after that you can zero in on a
particular form of content that would
work the best for you and finally you
can publish and manage your content now
let's talk about content marketing tips
number one remarket your content content
marketing is one of the many ways you
can spread your content to a brighter
audience you can Define the audience you
want to Market to and then tag visitors
who come to your site and using Google's
Display Network you can strategically
position your ads in front of people on
Google or its partner websites who
previously interacted with your website
and advertise to them
through this you can build awareness and
engagement with your audience
here's an example of a banner
advertisement I would be shown if I was
shopping for a MacBook Pro on Amazon and
changed my mind at the last moment
this ad would maybe stay at the back of
my head until eventually I go and finish
that purchase
now let's go to number two answering
complex questions with your content
targeting specific keywords is extremely
helpful with your content this is why
you need to focus on Google's featured
snippet this position also known as
position 0 enhances and draws user
attention on the search engine's result
page
through the featured snippet you can
drive a large amount of traffic to your
website while cementing your position as
an expert in your industry you can have
different forms of Snippets like
definition boxes where a snippet of text
gives researchers direct and concise
definitions and descriptions you could
have tables where data is taken from the
page and displayed in a table you could
have ordered lists where items are
presented in specific order and you can
also have unordered lists
next up number three we have create a
personality for your brand
if you're looking to grow a following
for your content try not to copy how
already established and successful
corporate blogs do things
nowadays audiences tend to prefer
content that has a certain humanness
about it
tend to follow solo influencers they
advertise their brand by being
themselves
in a way they're selling themselves by
being themselves
you need to analyze what is popular and
influential blogs are doing and
incorporate into your Brand's website
thanks to this your audience will
connect with you and come back for more
now here's an example of one of the
largest players in digital marketing
Neil Patel see how he himself is the
brand and if you've gone through his
content you know it's pretty great as
well
that's what you should be striving for
moving on to tip number four ensure that
your content matches your Brand's voice
to make sure of this you need to
constantly review your editorial
standards and make sure your tone and
quality remain consistent you need to
ask your audience questions about how
you can develop and refine your Brand's
voice by answering these questions you
can provide your audience with a more
cohesive and helpful experience your
tone of your brand can vary on the basis
of what type of content you are planning
to post and what the goal you want to
achieve from the campaign next up we
have number five back up your Arguments
for data
using statistics and facts to make a
point by including a link to the
original Source makes it extremely
credible this data can help the audience
grow trust in your brand to persuade
them that your content is valid and
valuable this will also help your brand
grow as an industry expert
at number six we have use specific
keywords now make sure you use specific
keywords in your content this takes care
of the SEO aspect behind your content
this will also help your content have a
greater chance of being found in text
and ranked
it could also help your content rank for
Niche topics within your industry moving
on to tip number seven evaluate the
success of your content with data
earlier we talked about why it's so
important that you backup your content
with data now let's talk about how data
can help you improve
analytics tools will help you learn more
about how well your content is doing the
age demographics of the people enjoying
it who doesn't their locations the best
time to post and much more with this
data you can make sure that your time
and money are being used in the best
possible way
some of the most popular tools in the
market are bussumo Evernote HubSpot
Trello and WordPress
these will help you find topics and
influencers within your industry you can
capture organize and share notes
collaborate with team members create
sales funnels and much more
now we've reached Midway right now so
I've got a question for you
do you guys have any tips for Content
marketing that we haven't covered yet
let me know in the live chat
alright so let's get back to our list
tip number eight is to be consistent
with your content
post your best performing content and
make sure they follow a consistent
schedule
finding a balance of the different types
of content to be posted with the help of
a Content calendar will show your
audience that you're committed to
providing them helpful and informative
content
this will also establish your brand as
an authority and thought leader between
your Niche it will help your audience
depend on you for quality content and
give them a reason to return tip number
nine is to make your content actionable
providing actionable steps or
information in your content will coerce
your audience to take a particular
action quickly it can help you create
valuable content and fix pain points
faced by your audience build a strong
relationship with them and earn their
trust it also leads to increased
engagement and a positive brand
experience
it provides users with real value and
solutions leading them to take action
here we have an example from Trello
where we see a pop-up with a call to
action asking interested users to input
their email IDs to sign media today
involving more than 200 marketers more
than 49 percent of them felt content
marketing was really important to their
digital marketing campaigns and more
than 25 percent of their budgets are
used for visual advertising content like
images infographics videos and other
forms of rich media will help you
enhance the message of your brand and
reach a wider audience here's an example
of advertising by Coca-Cola
although there's not a lot of text in
the ads you can immediately recognize
the unmistakable branding and the
message they're trying to send moving on
to tip number 11
create trending and Evergreen content
creating content that's Evergreen and
trending with your own unique angle
statistics and research will be a huge
advantage since you'll have to update it
every now and then you'll get a great
deal out of the work without having to
do a lot of work
here's an example of one such Evergreen
article people are never going to stop
wanting to learn how to do SEO so with a
little tweaking every few months to
reflect new changes that Google may have
done you'll have an article that you can
get considerable mileage out of next up
tip number 12 is to understand content
that works for you
you need to analyze what content works
on different social media platforms for
example you all know YouTube is the best
place for video content Instagram and
Pinterest for visual content Twitter for
smaller Snappy content and so on
understanding what works and what
doesn't will help you better spread your
content across the internet
tip number 13 is to understand your
target audience
now like I mentioned earlier your
marketing campaign isn't going to bear
fruit without targeting a specific
audience
understanding who your audience is is
one of the most important steps for this
you can find this out by asking
questions like who you're engaging with
online their age location language
Etc
by using social listening to find out
what audiences are talking about your
brand using tools to research what
social channels your audience is using
and so on
after understanding them you can set up
buyer personas for your audience
tip number 14 is to perform a b testing
now ABS testing will help you understand
what your audience likes or doesn't what
content works for you and much more you
can do a b testing on headlines and
title tags call to actions content
formats image types content length and
much more it can also help you make
better decisions in the future
and finally our tip number 15 is to
reach out to people sharing similar
content
one of the best ways to build your
audience is to get people or influencers
who already share content within your
Niche to share your content
now since these people already have a
trusting audience they would be a lot
more likely to enjoy your content
content marketing strategy so buckle up
and let's get right to it and we're
gonna get right into some of the best
practices some tips some methodologies
some things you should be doing with
content marketing so right out of the
gate let's start talking about knowing
your audience okay so content is all
about writing for a particular audience
so it's just like speaking except when
we're speaking to somebody we're
speaking directly to them content is
very similar and so we have to be able
to know our audience ahead of time so
what you can do is collect demographics
of your target audience based on who's
coming to your website so you can get
that data in Google analytics under
audience email subscribers I mean who is
subscribing to your emails who do you
already have in your email database and
you can look at social media I mean you
look at Facebook you can look at the
people who are already connected to you
okay these are just some three three of
many examples you could be doing to
gather data on your audience okay you
have to know who your audience is before
you start writing you know for a
successful content marketing strategy
you really just need to know your
audience and basically you're going to
segment them based on their interests so
that content is going to be catered to
that audience okay so if it's lines that
likes a specific you know product uh
that you offer or feature that's part of
that product that you offer then that's
the segment you're going to be writing
about so you need to collect your data
on your audience ahead of time then
you're going to segment that audience
okay so you're not gonna write content
for everyone because the shoe doesn't
necessarily fit for everyone okay the
the shoe has to fit for specific foot
and in this case we're talking about an
audience we need to be able to segment
our audience out and you could certainly
segment them out by age by gender by
education level by income by interest I
mean these are just some of the examples
again it could be new returning or new
root users versus returning users it
could be users who are purchased from
you in the past versus users who haven't
purchased from you in the past it could
certainly be an age range it could be
even going further on interest level or
a combination thereof okay so for
example you can get that demographic
information using Google analytics you
just got to go in analytics under
audience under demographics you're going
to see age and age is broken out by age
range and they're going to see gender so
you're gonna see a breakdown of gender
and use that to your advantage so if
you're going to you know write some
content and you know 99 of your traffic
is female the age of 18 to 24 then you
know that contents May catered
accordingly so you could certainly go to
Facebook page insights and get some
really good demographic data there
because Facebook is all about
demographics okay so you could see
exactly you know how many fans you have
broken out by Man versus women and then
you can see again same thing as Google
analytics you could see an age range
breakout you could use Twitter analytics
I mean Twitter has share some really
good insights into education level so
you know if you're dealing with you know
highly sophisticated people who have
master's degrees or even higher or let's
just say even on LinkedIn you know that
majority of the people you're trying to
Target are sea level meaning CEOs or
CFOs or CMOS you know Chief marketing
officers or chief executive officers
then you're going to cater your message
a little bit different than say
mid-range managers or or you know even
high range managers or even VPS so use
your audience information that you
collect on these various platforms to
your advantage okay so let's jump into
number two we want to create high
quality content now I know this sounds
like a given but and I say but heavily
there's not a lot of high quality
content out there on the internet so
separate yourself first and foremost
always always always always create high
quality content it's going to result in
a lot of things are going to benefit you
you know one you're going to come across
as you know somebody who knows what
they're talking about and that's going
to help increase your brand awareness
okay when you increase your brand
awareness people know about you so it's
likely going to increase traffic to your
website or if you're on social media you
know if you produce good high quality
content people are going to share that
content okay so from an SEO perspective
it can improve website ranking meaning
if you have good quality content you
know and it's really focused in on a
specific topic or a certain set of core
words keywords then you're going to rank
improves website dwell time meaning hey
you've got good content people are gonna
hang around to see what else you have to
offer okay so it's no secret that you
know good content you usually leads to
you know quality engagement and then
certainly last but not least you can
gain a lot of leads here meaning hey
somebody likes what you have to say
whether it's a video or blog post or or
infographic you know people are going to
become more interested more engaged
spend more time and that's all going to
funnel through to somebody taking that
next step in the funnel and becoming
more interested in yourself service or
even purchasing one of your products so
creating high quality content involves
brainstorming topics and terms you know
you got to do The Upfront work due
diligence is at work here so brainstorm
some topics use a keyword research tool
to gather results so if you have a topic
you know one of the benefits of quality
content is rankings go to Google's
Keyword Planner understand how much
quality and and understand how much
competition each keyword has or
understand how much volume each keyword
has that's what's available in Google's
Keyword Planner or any really any
keyword planning tool you always want to
create original content okay so you
don't want to plagiarize or take
somebody else's content and then you
want to support that content with
compelling headlines so if you have a
piece of content you got to get
somebody's attention write a nice
headline that's going to grab their
attention Okay so give valuable content
to your creators and add resources from
well-known sites so if you you do borrow
say a data point from another source
then you know cite that Source you also
want to create engaging and
thought-provoking content get somebody
to think I mean people are going to raid
your content because they not they don't
know the subject matter their interests
in the subject matter and they want to
be able to spend the time taking
something away from that content follow
a logical structure and use relevant
images I can't stress this one enough
you know just throw things on a web page
you know put some structure to it maybe
you have to break it out if you feel
like you have too much content there's
no harm in breaking it into part one
versus part two get people uh tease them
a bit get them to come back and read
part two okay use different content
forms in case somebody's interested
maybe you want to capture some data you
know prefer short paragraphs to make the
content readable remember if you're
talking to c-level folks you you know
maybe you don't have to dummy down the
content so to speak but if you're
dealing with you know folks or people
that are right out of high school or
still in high school then adjust your
content and format and paragraphs
accordingly and then update the content
as well just because you publish it
doesn't mean that it's done I mean when
we're talking about a web page we're
talking about something that is actively
changing or can change the medium that
is dynamic okay so if a data points
change go back in and update that data
point and then let people know about it
because they may want to come back and
and you know check in to see how much
that data points changed so these are
all you know good takeaways for creating
high quality content you know some other
things that you should be aware of you
know grammatical mistakes you know you
need to avoid those there's no reason
for grammatical mistakes today's
technology doesn't allow for it and hey
listen we all have friends we have
colleagues my desk is sitting next to a
colleague who's more than happy to read
something before it gets published so
take advantage of the resources you have
available no reason for it because if
you have a grammatical mistake you just
lost a lot of credibility you know don't
be afraid to add a clear call to action
at the end of your content if somebody's
interested in reading it they're
probably going to be interested in
taking the next step whatever that next
step is okay so creating content that
fulfills viewers requirements meaning if
somebody's searching for something and
your content shows up in the search
results then they're actively looking
for you what are you offering them is it
fulfilling their requirements you know
don't be afraid to use examples
throughout your content in fact work in
or integrate some case studies in there
show clear examples to stress your
points
and then just don't put words on a web
page you know to break up that content
with an image that's going to be
visually appealing okay and you can add
images from public domain sites meaning
stock imagery if that's what's going to
help create visually appealing content
and then give more information to your
audience and we say prefer to give more
information meaning hey going back to
the content I was saying about breaking
it up organizing it if you have more
information you know don't withhold it
have them come back and read a secondary
blog post or secondary piece that
supports the original now we want to
move from high quality content to
running a B test maybe tests so
important why because with a B split
testing you can increase your conversion
rates okay so four elements to test in
your content marketing strategy so if
you have content say a Blog and you're
testing that blog you test out the
images shifts test out the forms do you
have a long form or short form you know
test out the content length you can have
a variation that is a lot shorter than
the original does that increase or
decrease bounce rates play around with
call to actions your call to actions do
matter you know do you want to use a
softer call to action a softer tone or
do you want to use something very direct
and strong you know test call to actions
to see what's going to get people to
move closer through the closer to
purchasing and through that funnel so a
b testing to me is something that should
be naturally done with Google optimize
it's free so with images you know you
could test a lot of different variations
of images anything from people to you
know outlandish image rates or just
something very stock and neutral but
just make sure that those images are
relevant to the post you know test the
length of that content you know again if
you know that your average time on page
is very low you know don't write
something very long write something that
you think is going to stick with that
time of page but on your A B test create
something maybe a little longer if it's
engaging enough maybe somebody's gonna
stay a little bit longer on the page so
you know create a variation is going to
play with that length Okay so use
analytics to your advantage to figure
out as a baseline what amount of content
is getting people to stay on the page
then see if you can push the envelope
one way or the other okay improving the
page with sign up forms really what you
want to do is create a user friendly
experience so when you have sign up
forms and don't make them non-intuitive
don't make them difficult you know link
maybe up to Facebook or Google so if
they're creating an account they can
create an account via Google or Facebook
or you know don't put too many forms on
the page and then on those ctas as I
mentioned play around with the tone you
can also play around the color I mean I
test color all the time believe it or
not color does matter don't use red use
green people react to different colors
but again you have cultural variances as
well so you got to take that into
account if you're in the Middle East or
the Far East Asia you know color schemes
and what you say matters and it changes
versus say you know Europe or the West
okay so keep that in mind when you're
making changes on color or tone or
placement and things of that nature so
you want to conduct a competitor
analysis so we're talking about creating
high quality content testing that
content you know brainstorming some
topics you know looking at your audience
you're doing all this work you might as
well take the next step and figure out
what it is your competitors are doing so
you can opt for competitive analysis by
identifying your competitors top
performing content for specific topics
okay and so really what we're trying to
do here is and improve our conversion
rates so what are your competitors doing
what are their baselines we can maybe up
that any I mean that data is also
available in Google analytics so you can
look at benchmarking reports in Google
analytics to get some form or fashion
you can also go to Facebook and look at
your competitors Facebook pages and see
what's performing in terms of Engagement
but what you want to do is find out your
strongest competitors by using search
engines or check which websites are
competing with you and again that could
include Facebook as well or maybe even
LinkedIn so you go with the search
engine route you can always type in that
coveted keyword that you want to be
found for see who's ranking ahead of you
and you can see the metadata meaning the
title tag in The Meta description you
can actually see hey what are these guys
writing that's getting them recognized
in the search engine rankings so you can
certainly if you go to search engine
route you could certainly leverage an
SEO platform form like search sem rush
or Moz or something like that that's
going to allow you to get some good
Insight on competitor information so
keep in mind there are SEO platforms
that will give you information on your
competitors and that's what these SEO
platforms are good for so number five
moving on choose a suitable content
format so now we've done all this
homework we know what we want to say we
know who we want to say it to we're
ready to do some testing but we need to
find a format because it's not always
about a web page per se meaning content
on a web page there's not always about a
blog post with content in that blog post
okay we need to decide the type of
content that's going to fit what we're
trying to say so again you can go the
traditional route with just posting a
blog post and nothing wrong with that
because with a blog post you can
incorporate video and imagery you can
also go more harder route when I say
harder more I say official rub with an
e-book or case study something that a
user is going to be able to take away
with maybe download something more
official
um something more in-depth something
with a harder stamp on it so that that
shows individuals that you've taken the
time you've done this homework you've
done this research you've done some
really in-depth analysis and now the
proper format for that is not a blog
post it's an e-book now if you're into
talking like I am then you can certainly
do a podcast and podcasts are always
popular depending on the topic so you
got to be aware of the topic now videos
are always always a good option you got
the likes of video and video and YouTube
and some other you know video platforms
out there that allow you the ability to
get found very quickly especially with
the likes of YouTube you know people you
use YouTube before they go on to
purchasing a product so think about that
so if you're trying to get somebody if
you're trying to sway an audience to
move from being a brand awareness and a
loyal you know customer to taking the
next step okay to purchasing more or
purchasing for the first time and so
videos kind of help convey that now if
you're trying to convey a lot of
different points then an infographic
might be your best option instead of
having to write out all those points you
know try using an infographic to convey
those points visually now again with
blog posts it should have valuable
content that can be shared by your
website visitors on social so that's the
key make sure you have those shareable
social icons now with ebooks it should
have longer and in-depth content so and
it shouldn't be published frequently so
maybe if this is something you're doing
annually then ebook could be the format
with a case study what you should have a
customer story that succeeded and and
you solving that customer's problem so
the case study is always there for you
know somebody to get an idea of what
you're all about infographic is just
visualizing data in a more organized way
in more visual way so somebody
understands what you're trying to convey
now with that podcast again suppose your
audience doesn't have an interest in
Reading again it could be a certain age
certain gender a certain culture hey
everybody absorbs information
differently so think about it ask
yourself is a podcast the best way to
communicate to my target audience and
then videos are highly engaging they're
also shareable on blog posts and pretty
much most if not all social media
platforms so once you've done that once
you choose the proper format you want to
choose a Content management system
that's going to work for you so so you
want to be able to choose something
where you can plan appropriately produce
manage publish and measure results all
in one place there are plenty of content
Management Systems out there that will
help you do all of those things okay so
some examples are WordPress HubSpot
binder I mean we can list hundreds if
you're into blogging you know WordPress
is the way to go if you're into building
out landing pages that you want to you
know share you know HubSpot could be the
way to go okay there are lots of
available options out there so moving on
number seven Target your audience using
emails okay so what are we talking about
well we all know what emails are emails
help us to communicate directly with our
target audience and convert them to
leads so email is a good way to follow
up with your audience so if you've done
a podcast follow up with an email you
know maybe get them to you you know fill
out a survey via email based on that
podcast or if you create a podcast about
some data that you talked about in that
podcast follow up that with with them
via email with an infographic perhaps
okay built into the email okay there's
lots of ways that all these formats can
complement themselves via email okay you
could certainly take a blog post and
package it into an email and have a link
pointing back to the blog post maybe as
a teaser or if you're doing a series a
series of blog posts you know you could
tease that in an email so an email is a
good way to you know follow up with your
target audience indirectly or directly
when we say indirectly you know you can
collect emails and send out those emails
with you know certain information or
what you should be doing is targeting
and segmenting your emails just like you
are your content so if you're producing
content for a certain audience then May
make sure that particular audience gets
that same email now some of the email
content that you could share with your
target audience or newsletters okay
seasonal emails promotional emails
automated messaging and what we mean by
automated messaging hey if somebody just
purchased from you send them a thank you
email maybe follow up a couple days
later with another email with a survey
or what you could do is if you know who
your lawyer customers are you know
Target them with a promotional email so
there's lots of ways to slice and dice
content via email okay just make sure
you know your target audience is there's
lots of things you can do in email again
you can complement lots of different
formats within email as I mentioned
before with a podcast or a blog post so
keep all that in mind email is a good
way to communicate with your audience
okay the last point we want to make here
is use native ads okay so we talk about
Native ads it's one of the smartest ways
to connect your audience with your brand
so for example this is a native ad on
BuzzFeed okay it's about 15 bands that
probably wouldn't exist without Led
Zeppelin okay so for you folks out there
that don't know who Led Zeppelin is a
rock group from the 70s late 60s 70s
okay disbanded in 80 81 82 early 80s
okay but you know people grew up like
myself listening to Led Zeppelin okay so
you could see the headline here 15 bands
that probably won't exist with the
outlet Zeppelin you know I'm interested
in who those bands might be even if you
don't know who Led Zeppelin is okay you
might be inquisitive to say okay who is
this Led Zeppelin group and what are
these 15 bands the key here is not
necessarily the headline or Led Zeppelin
per se but it's a native ad and it's
sitting next to content talking about
music okay so according to Forbes online
audiences are 20 25 percent more likely
to look at a native ad than add a banner
and so that native ad in this case we're
talking about music needs to be sitting
or companyed alongside content talking
about in this case music you know would
help if it was rock music just music in
general might get enough to get Peak
people's interest okay so if you're
going to create content you know align
that content with something that's you
know naturally going to fit and that's
why we call them native ads because
they're native to the content that
they're associated with so finally after
all that said and done when all you've
done is create good content follow up
the emails targeting your audience and
associating that content with you know
content natively then you can always
measure your content performance so this
is my favorite part of it all you go
into analytics going to Facebook
insights you know you want to go in and
check out how that content is performing
and you want to do that because you want
to be able to see what's performing
what's not performing the key here is
associating the content with kpis that's
really the key so measuring the right
metrics can help you understand whether
your content is engaging or not so again
measuring the right metrics okay so when
we're talking about a video you're not
necessarily going to look at page views
you're going to look at video views so
you know some of these basic metrics of
users and sessions and Pages bounce rate
you know dwell time that's all great but
you just need to make sure that you're
aligning the right metric with the right
asset so for example if you have a case
study and ebook you want to make sure
that you're measuring how many downloads
the ebook or the case study received
again with the video you want to measure
video views now if your pack packing up
emails and sending them out to your
target audience you want to make sure
you look at open rates and click rates
okay so a lot of things you can be
looking at so make sure you choose the
right metrics because there's hundreds
and hundreds of metrics to choose from
so just be aware all the different
metrics that are available you know if
you're in it for search okay how much
traffic getting from search where are
you ranking so there are a lot of things
you need to think about so think about
the content that you're producing and
think about how you want to be able to
measure that content so let's go back
over our checklist here so what you
could do is create an editorial calendar
in fact I would highly suggest you
create an editorial calendar in order to
keep track of all the content you've
done over a period of time are you
making your content worth reading that
means are you checking the results of
that content what we just went over
measuring the content is it worth
reading have a column set up in that
editor our calendar you know performing
or not performing if it's not performing
don't do it again okay create your
content okay you always wanna you know
make sure you're reusing or using or
adding to the content that you've
created guest post on influential
blogger websites you want to add
statistics numbers and quotes to your
content make it engaging make it look
like you've done your homework you could
share all your content not just on
social media but you know platforms like
SlideShare now you can share it on all
social media platforms I'd highly
recommend it and again you can even
repurpose it as a blog post so if it's a
podcast then you know you can recite
that podcast in the form of a Blog okay
so get some testimonials that support
some of your content again create a
podcast you can send out an email with a
survey or trying to solicit some
testimonials or if you post something on
Facebook you know leverage the feed bag
you get from Facebook in the form of a
testimonial okay and then you want to
promote your blog post for maximum
success and a lot of that means SEO so
make sure you do your due diligence and
get the right keywords in that blog post
okay so you can create personas for
different user audiences okay so
remember it's all about tone okay so if
you're going to create a blog post make
sure your tone is aligned with that
Right audience whether that be young
middle aged or older are you choosing
the right type of content okay you'll
know based on the results okay you want
to add H1 and H2 tags on your web pages
why because when we're talking about
content we're talking about organizing
the content and H1 and H2S help you
organize the content appropriately
customize the metadata metadata is title
tag and meta tag descriptions and even
all tags okay all of that is for search
so you want your content to show up in
search whether that video infographic or
blog post all of it can be shown in
search results so make sure you write a
good title and make sure you write a
good meta description because that's
what people are going to see when they
search okay so you want to create a
detailed summary and title and again
that goes along with the title tag and
meta description and then you want to
make it easy for the audience to ask
questions and comment on your blog so
don't be afraid like I'm gonna do right
now in this video is if I'm missing
anything from this checklist feel free
to comment hey I've written my fair
share content but I could be talking to
an audience that is just as qualified as
I am and they may have some tips so feel
free to comment underneath this video
now don't be afraid to ask just like I
just did people are always willing to
provide constructive feedback so don't
be afraid to ask for it and make it easy
so to me every blog post needs to have
some form of a comment box because blog
posts are out there to solicit
engagement now let's recap everything we
talked about because we certainly
covered a lot and there's a lot to cover
when it comes to content marketing so
one know your audience again you can
lean on Google analytics you know
demographic data whether it be age or
gender you could do the same with
Facebook and Twitter and Linkedin you
know every platform has some data you
could take away create high quality
content when I mean high quality content
brainstorm some topics has it already
been written to death about or is this
unique you know don't write something
your competitors are writing okay don't
copy what your competitors have written
organize your content support it with
good imagery all of these are tips to
creating high quality content okay when
you create that content think about
running some a b tests you know run some
variations and switch out the image
switch out the call to action see what's
going to get people to react and engage
with the content conduct competitor
analysis so lean on the Facebooks of the
world to see what your competitors are
posting see what's engaging for them
okay you can also lean on these SEO
platforms like sem rush and Moz all you
got to do is plug in a domain and
they're going to give you some
information about where particular
competitor ranks for keyword or how many
backlinks and what websites are linking
to them so all that's available in these
SEO platforms okay so you want to choose
a suitable content format we listed a
few from ebooks to case studies to
podcasts to infographics to blog posts
to videos it's up to you what you think
is best for your audience just keep in
mind you need to be able to measure it
and so that's the important thing if it
doesn't work the first time out then you
might want to consider changing out the
content format choose a Content
management system
um you know plenty out there WordPress
is a good one if you're going to be a
blogger okay blogging allows you to you
know post optimize that blog post you
know you could have the ability to share
that blog post across social platforms
and you can also have that blog post
show up in search engine results so you
can't do any of that without a good
content management system so you want to
Target your audience using emails okay
so email is a good way to again further
communicate with that particular
segmented audience and again you could
use it to send out promotional emails to
Loyal followers or you can use
systematic emails to send an email a
thank you email somebody purchases and
then another follow-up email and again
you can repurpose some of the content
you've done in another format in the
form of an email so you know if you
created a video you know put that video
in the form of an email sent out to your
audience to make sure they're not
missing out on that video you just
created so lots of ways to use email
take advantage of email it's your ally
here okay use native ads okay don't be
afraid to put that content and hear it
with some other content on another
website it's been proven people are
going to engage in an ad that they see
based on the content they're currently
reading because the ad if it's native
it's going to be similar in nature to
the content they're currently engaged in
and then measure your content
performance I can't say this enough make
sure you're leveraging Google analytics
okay with Google analytics or Facebook
insights or Twitter or LinkedIn or any
other platform you're running on they're
gonna have data on what you've posted so
take advantage of it align your kpi so
if it's an ebook or case study don't
measure just traffic measure how many
people actually got downloading them
okay if it's a video you know how many
people like the video how many people
are commenting how many people are
sharing the video how many people are
subscribing to your playlist based on
that video content okay so these are all
things you can measure okay so every
platform from WordPress to YouTube to to
Reddit has some form of analytics
associated with it today we're going to
talk about how to get traffic to your
website so thank you for joining and
let's get started so let's imagine
you're setting up your own website okay
you're clicking away You're developing
using some good tools you're developing
you're designing you're doing some QA
you're testing you're sharing with
Friends and an alpha version and then
finally your website is all set out
congratulations well when you hit enter
and your website is finally published
what's gonna happen well a few days
later you're checking on your website
and you're looking at analytics and you
notice your traffic's very low okay well
you're scratching your head because
you've done all this work with your
website but you're not getting any
traffic so the reason is you spend all
your time developing designing the
website to make it look good but you
didn't do anything or any planning or
any strategy around bringing users to
your website so the two go hand in hand
you just can't build a website without
thinking about how to drive users to the
website and so before I tell you how to
bring traffic to your website let me
tell you why this is so important okay
why do we want to bring users to our
website I mean it has to be on equal
ground as web development and design is
somebody who goes to your site and then
does something when they get to your
site so you have users and when there's
users get to your site they're
generating page views and traffic and
you want to turn that traffic into
engagement okay so each Page's traffic
is configured independently of all their
pages so when you go when somebody goes
to your website they look at a page
that's a page view and certain pages on
your website you want to turn that page
view into a conversion okay whether that
be you know looking at a video or
purchasing something so think of these
pages on your website as sales people
they're trying to convert visitors who
come to your website but first we need
to get the visitors to your website so
when you get visitors to your website
again you can generate sales which means
revenue or you can increase brand
awareness or you can earn Revenue
through sponsored posts and
advertisements so if you have for
example a lot of content on your website
you can turn that in to revenue by
hosting ads on your website so when
somebody clicks on that ad you're going
to earn a percentage of that click okay
what that click is worth so having a
website means a lot of good things for
you but first you got to get the traffic
there and so what we're going to do is
we're going to tell you how to drive
traffic to your website so there's lots
of different ways in which you can bring
traffic to your website well the first
is paid advertising so paying to
advertise your products services with
ads it's one of the easiest ways to
drive traffic to your website so some of
the options available are search ads
social media ads or display ads so
search ads or ads that are displayed in
the search engine results so when a user
types in a keyword a query you want your
ad to show up based on that keyword
query okay so an example is digital
marketing course somebody types in
digital marketing course and simply
learn is the first app that shows up how
do we know it's an ad because you could
see the word ad next to the domain so
when somebody clicks on that link simply
and learn is going to pay Google so
that's how search advertising works okay
the next is social it's a social media
marketing involves increasing traffic or
engagement or brand awareness a lot of
different strategies but you're instead
of doing this on search you're doing it
on a social media platform okay okay so
for example you can advertise on any
particular platform and the way you
advertise could be with an image it
could be with a video so in this case
you could see cobrio is doing a
sponsored ad here how to succeed with
Google ads and then another form of
advertising is display so display means
creating ads that are placed on specific
websites so with display unlike search
you have a choice in the ad format with
search you only have text ads but with
display you have text Edge image ads
rich media ads video ads so you have
lots of different options in which you
can advertise on other websites so the
idea here is to get your ad in front of
the Right audience when they could see
your display Banner your banner ad then
it's going to be more visual more
appealing generate some brand interest
and hopefully you can get somebody to
click on that ad and over to your
website so that's paid advertising again
through search through social through
display but you can also promote your
site on social media so once your
content has gone live you could take
advantage of different social media
platforms I mean it really depends on
what you're trying to promote because
what you're trying to promote needs to
align with the appropriate social media
platform so Facebook is best suited for
Industries like food and Beverages and
news and media and if you're selling a
product so you fall into one of those
categories and Facebook could be the
right platform for you if you're
involved in again beauty or food and
beverage or e-commerce then you can also
leverage Instagram which is part of
Facebook's ecosystem so if you advertise
on Facebook you can also advertise on
Instagram and or Instagram so it doesn't
have to be and Facebook and Instagram it
could be Facebook or Instagram you also
have LinkedIn as a platform LinkedIn is
great for B2B so if you're trying to
promote industry news or or tips and
best practices or job postings then
LinkedIn is the place for you it's a B2B
platform it's great for targeting
specific Industries targeting specific
job levels or job descriptions okay so
LinkedIn is great if you're into B2B
focusing on the business side of it so
you also have YouTube now YouTube is
part of Google's ecosystem YouTube is a
video platform okay so it's great if
you're trying to promote gaming or
entertainment or if you're a vlogger
okay so YouTube's a great way to promote
your site by getting your product out
there in the form of a video and then
you have Twitter Twitter to me
encompasses a lot of different
Industries Beauty and fitness news and
media entertainment okay you have
limited number of characters but a lot
of people are active on Twitter and it's
a great way to generate some awareness
and get some clicks over to your website
so these are just some of the most
popular social media platforms of course
there are plenty more out there the
third way in which you can drive traffic
to your site is guest plus blogging so
most of you already know what blogging
is all about well if you're blogging for
your own site you can jump on somebody
else's site and blog on their behalf so
having the opportunity to guess post on
another website can be very helpful
because one that other blog could have
lots of traffic and have a a well-known
brand so if you're blogging on another
blog it's going to build your brand
awareness and potentially increase
traffic to your blog or website so it
exposes to you to targeted traffic so if
you're going to guest blog guest blog on
a site that's very relevant to your
business or industry that way you're
targeting the Right audience okay you
can expand your personal Network so
getting yourself out there getting
getting your brand out there in front of
a different audience and then obviously
for serves because it generates a
backlink so serps search engine ranking
Pages means that hey if you want to rank
organically you're going to have to
generate some backlinks so guest
blogging isn't a way to generate some
backlinks to your site and in effect
that's going to help you get your pages
ranked higher because Google is going to
recognize the relationship from one blog
to your blog and build up your relevancy
so some other benefits here to guest
blogging is you can grow your social
media following because you can then
promote that on social media that you're
guest blogging okay again you can
improve your online Authority okay
because when you're guest blogging and
you have recognition on that Guest block
if it's a popular blog then it's going
to help your domain and Page Authority
for SEO and then the end result is going
to improve your backlink score so a lot
of benefits to guess ball vlogging to me
at the end of the day it's just about
reaching out to your audience using
another platform to do that in the form
of a Blog and the results of that is
going to mean more brand awareness for
you and turning that traffic from that
other blog into qualified leads so you
can also interview industry thought
later so that's another way an
interesting way to generate traffic to
your site so reaching out to thought
leaders for interviews okay could
generate some credibility for you and
the other person so it's reciprocal so
it means that you're active in the
industry that you're in and it allows
you to engage with other leaders in the
industry and the indirect net result of
that could be increased traffic because
if you do the interview and you record
it or if it's via video then you can
obviously post it on other platforms and
that could in turn Drive traffic to your
website obviously just like guest
blogging it's going to increase your
reach so getting yourself out there
nobody knows who your brand is and they
know who the thought leaders are and
they say you're interviewing the thought
leaders then that's going to put you in
front of these people and so it's going
to increase your reach another way to
drive traffic to your website is just to
make sure your website's responsive and
what do we mean by responsive well we
mean does it work on multiple devices
specifically mobile so depending on the
device your website hides shows shrinks
enlarges or moves content so that it
conforms to the browser that that
person's looking at on your web for your
website so if somebody's looking on
mobile at your website you want to make
sure that your website adjusts
accordingly so you want to be able to
you know test to make sure it's
responsive and so as content arranged
based on importance okay does it work
across different browsers on different
devices and do the images text and
everything else align just like it does
on desk desktop so there are plenty of
tools out there on the web all you need
to do is just do a search for you know
check my website for responsiveness you
know so you you can use plenty of tools
to check to see if your website is
responsive towards multiple devices why
is that important because if somebody
goes to your website Via Mobile and your
site doesn't align properly or the
content's all stretched out and somebody
has to maneuver their browser just to
see your website then chances are
they're not going to come back chances
are they're not going to convert okay so
you want to be able to revise your
device browser combinations you want to
make sure that everything works
accordingly you want to be able to test
those fonts make sure they look good and
then you also want to make sure that
people can navigate so if they're on
mobile are they going to navigate just
as easy as they can on desktop and if
you have any pop-ups you want to
probably make sure they're removed so
that way when somebody's looking at your
website they're not getting interfered
with on mobile and then of course you
want to make sure that these Pages load
okay so they load just as quick on
desktop as they should on mobile and
vice versa so this should not take a
long time to load so moving on from
responsiveness a mobile to building a
brand community so brand community
refers to a group of people who identify
your brand and use your brand as a
platform to exchange ideas and
contribute content some advantages of
how any brand Community are promoting
brand evangelism and loyalty it can be a
source of feedback loyalty and ideas so
build a community build a brand
Community who you know identify with you
okay so continue to you know treat these
people as loyal customers okay maybe
give them a promotion uh to use
specifically just for them that they can
use on your website or talk directly to
them because you know that their
followers they're repeat customers they
purchase for you multiple times so talk
to them differently as well you know who
these people are and that's what
building a brand is all about it's about
identifying your brand with other people
okay and identify people who identify
with your brand and messaging and
talking to them as if they're part of
your own Community your own family so
you can use user generated content that
provides future marketing strategies so
the feedback you get from your own
Community could it be in turn used to
promote or used in future marketing
strategies I.E advertising I.E post on
social okay it can also provide PR
opportunities so it's a chance for you
to you know put out press releases based
on the community that you built so any
brand regardless of who it is should be
able to identify with your audience
their target audience and that target
audience eventually going to become part
of a community these are group of people
who identify with you what you're trying
to sell what your cause is what your
mission statement is what your services
they identify with you so leverage them
and reciprocate identify them talk to
them separately give them the what they
deserve the respect and loyalty that
they deserve as well because they're
communicating and they're following you
as a brand so the next thing you could
do to drive traffic is Be Active in the
comments section so engage in relevant
and thought-provoking conversations on
other blogs and sites it doesn't
necessarily have to be another blog per
se it could be other sites like Reddit
or core or Mania sites that have a lot
of content that are broken out by
industry that allow you to engage in
conversation and allow you to either
upvote or share or respond okay so be
active because when you're active people
are going to see that hey you're a
leader in the industry you know what
you're talking about you have some some
brand Equity you have some thought and
some knowledge on the specific topic and
subject so it just puts you in a better
light when you can respond and be active
on these different platforms okay let's
turn our attention to search engine
optimization also known as SEO or
organic search so in order to drive
traffic to your site you're going to
have to implement an SEO strategy why do
you want to implement an SEO strategy
because it can help you improve your
overall searchability and visibility on
search engines and obviously that comes
with advantages one of those advantages
is obviously more traffic to the site
search is still King in terms of volumes
of people using search on a daily basis
so you have a great opportunity to be
found and all also builds trust and
credibility because still a majority of
the people who do a search click on an
organic search listing and so if you're
found organically and you're ranked
number one then chances are somebody's
going to click on your listing and it
provides increased engagement and
traffic and so what that means is more
traffic more engagement and engagement
is something you define it could be
again a download of a document or the
clicking on the play button of a video
or or submitting a form or signing up
for a newsletter or calling these are
all forms of Engagement so the amount of
traffic you drive from organic search to
your website is only going to improve
engagement okay so you can also provide
and improve user experience and what do
we mean by that well if you're getting
lots of traffic from organic search you
have a really good opportunity to do a b
testing and when you do a b testing you
can improve user experience meaning
you're showing one variation against the
other from people coming from organic
search and so this is helpful in that
you know if you're running an A B test
the variation has a chance to improve or
outperform the original and if it
outperforms the original you're
improving user experience and then it
helps Target quality traffic so SEO to
me or all search is the only medium in
which you're meeting somebody halfway
you're you're addressing what they're
looking for so somebody's looking for a
pair of red women's Nike shoes the 2019
model and you have that particular
product to offer well you have a chance
of showing up via organic search
somebody types in you know women's red
Nike shoes size whatever at the year
2019 model then of course they're gonna
probably likely click on your listing
because you have what they're are
looking for and and that goes with any
keyword any industry any business any
segment any type of product you're
selling so again you have a chance to
really be visible for what people are
looking for and so that's the beauty of
search engine optimization you have a
really good opportunity here to meet
people halfway to drive quality traffic
to get them to enjoy a good user
experience all the while generating
engagement and along with SEO we want to
be able to build backlinks so SEO is a
two-pronged approach meaning you have
two strategies in one on page and off
page and so off page involves
backlinking so backlinks are just links
that direct users from other websites to
your own website so with that inherently
it's going to drive traffic qualify
traffic to your website because if
somebody's on a relevant website that's
linking to yours and they click on that
link and go to your website it's likely
going to be qualified meaning they're
going to be relevant and so backlinking
because it's an off-page strategy why
isn't an off-page SEO strategy because
if Google crawls that other site that
has a link to you then that's going to
give you credit because Google will say
hey this site's getting some links from
some relevant sites we must think
they're relevant and therefore we're
going to trust the site so by Google
trusting your site it's going to improve
your organic ranking and with the
organic rankings being approved meaning
it's going to mean faster indexing so
what does that mean so you want to be
indexed by the search engines and so the
quicker Google can find your pages even
if it's on somebody else's site then
that means they're going to follow that
link go to that page on your site and
take that page back to their servers to
be indexed okay so the quicker you can
get index the quicker you can get found
and then it helps with the referral
traffic so again we noticed that our app
efforts are on SEO organic search but if
you're getting traffic from another
website hey that still counts that's
referral traffic okay so that's a side
advantage to having backlinks is good
traffic from other sites okay so those
those are inherently the some of the
reasons to do backlinking okay never
hurts I mean there's brand awareness
reasons to being on other sites as well
there's industry leadership meaning if
you you post content on Reddit okay
you're coming across as an industry
leader but yet generating a backlink
which helps with SEO and referral
traffic so there's a lot of benefits to
building backlinks and the opposite of
backlinks are internal links so you want
to do internal linking and that just
means connecting one page on your site
to another and why is that beneficial
because it can help direct visitors to
other Pages they wouldn't normally
otherwise find via your navigation so if
you're active on a Blog don't be afraid
to include multiple internal links you
want to move people through your site
you want the flow of traffic to go from
one page to another to another and so
when you do internal linking just like
with backlinks it's going to improve the
indexing of your website Google's going
to follow those links and index those
pages and Google does give credits from
an SEO perspective from an internal
linking perspective so if one page is
linked to another and that page has
really good relevance in the eyes of
Google then the other page is probably
going to benefit from that the other
reason you want to do internal linking
again you want to move people from your
one page of your site to the other and
when you do that it's going to reduce
bounce rates so bounce rate is simply
the rate at which people land on a page
and then leave so if I have a hundred
people in on my home page and only one
person went to another page and the
other 99 left the site then that's a 99
bounce rate so by putting internal links
in place your helping people move from
one page to the other and thus reducing
the bounce rate and that's what you want
you want to keep people on your site you
want to be greedy it also drives traffic
to older posts so again when we say
older posts we're really referring to
blog posts so if you have a relevant
blog post and you're writing a new blog
post then link the two together if it's
relevant link it I don't you know
regardless of how old it is you know you
want to show Google about these older
blog posts just because they were
written a year ago it doesn't mean
they're outdated and old-fashioned okay
or useless you want to keep them alive
by linking to them so to me that's a
good strategy for internal linking link
to older blog posts you know show people
you're an industry expert you've been
doing this for a while and then you have
lots of content to share okay so the
longer you can keep somebody on your
website the more likely it is they're
going to engage and convert and some
other inherent benefits improves page
rank so what we mean by Page rank is
simple play just a rank that Google
gives pages so the more internal linking
you have the better off you are and then
it helps spread link juice across
websites and what we mean by link juice
again just like backlinking it builds
relevancy so just keep all these
inherent benefits in mind to internal
linking the end result is keeping the
flow of traffic on your site and all
these other benefits will fall into
place okay so another way in which you
can really hone in on traffic to your
website is long tail keywords and long
tail keywords to me are more than just
one or two keyword phrases okay so there
are usually three or longer keywords in
a phrase okay so long tail keywords
really nowadays account for most web
searches people really take the time to
even post questions as a search query
it's a likely somebody it's unlikely
somebody's going to go into search and
just type in the word shoes they might
type in red shoes but that's unlikely
but they're probably going to type in is
you know red Nike running shoes 2019 or
some variation of that okay that's a
long tail keyword and some of the
advantages of using long tail keywords
to be found for are less competition so
if you're using broad keywords like red
shoes then who doesn't want to be found
for Red Shoes well you don't necessarily
you don't want to be found for riches
because it's too broad you don't know
what type of shoes somebody's looking
for you just know they're looking for
Red Shoes it could be running shoes it
could be work shoes it could be you know
boots it could be slippers okay it's too
broad so long tail keywords help narrow
it in and the more narrow and focused a
keyword is the less competition is going
to have and when something's not
competitive in the form of a keyword
then that means your chances of ranking
for that keyword are going to be greater
and the chance of you ranking faster are
going to be greater and then of course
if somebody's looking for exactly what
you have to offer then you have a higher
chance to convert that person so if you
have exactly those 2019 red Nike women's
running shoes and somebody does a search
for that and that's a long tail keyword
and they click on your organic listing
if you have the right price then they're
probably going to convert so you have a
really good chance of converting
somebody using long tail keywords so my
point here is if you're looking for
keywords to use focus on longer tail
don't focus on one or two keyword
phrases what it also does is brings
targeted traffic so even if somebody
doesn't convert hey they could be back
because it's exactly what they're
looking for and if you're focusing on
longer tail keywords like I just
mentioned stay away from the shorter
ones it's just easier to optimize your
page for SEO so remember SEO is a
two-pronged approach on page and off
page we talked about off page with
internal linking and backlinks on page
is all about making sure there's
keywords you choose are integrated in
with the page you want to be found for
and so if you're using a long tail
keyword it's just easy to work that
keyword in so it enables easier on-page
optimization okay let's switch away from
SEO to email marketing so what's focus
on email marketing as a form or method
of driving traffic to your website so
email marketing has been around a long
time in terms of digital marketing why
because it provides an effective way to
convert leads into sales why because you
can send personalized emails to a target
audience so when you send an email to
somebody on a regular basis you know who
that person is so what are you doing in
the email you're writing a specific
message to that person well email
marketing is the same thing except
you're just sending an email to a larger
group of people and when you send an
email to a larger group of people you're
still going to personalize the message
right you're not going to send a generic
email to 1 000 people people okay
nobody's gonna do that so make sure your
email is targeted if it's targeted it
could be cost effective why because
sending large amounts of emails or let's
just say an email to a large amount of
people or a large group of people is
going to be cost effective it's not cost
per click you know it's not cost per
open okay so email usually depending on
the the email provider you're using
really is a flat fee so just really
depends on how many emails you're
sending or how how many people you're
sending the email to as well so but
email generally tends to be more cost
effective than other forms of marketing
so look at the email content provider
you're using and just get a sense of
what they charge when if you look at it
and do a comparison email generally is
cheaper than say doing pay-per-click
because with pay-per-click you're paying
for each click okay so that could be
expensive depending on the keywords so
email marketing is also time saving okay
meaning it's it's a one-time thing and
done so once you send the email it's
just a matter of you know watching and
looking at the metrics and learning
what's going on so you don't make the
same mistakes again but it is time
conducive meaning you send out one email
and that's it with pay-per-click you're
constantly measuring and managing the
campaigns and it provides real-time
marketing so when you do send the email
more than likely a majority of the
people on day one or the day you send
the email are gonna be able to view it
open it click on some of the links and
convert so that's normally what happens
in email majority of the people open it
on day one and it kind of tails off from
there so think about it as real time so
when you send that email and if you have
a thousand people on your email
recipient list break it up send the
first 500 first with a different subject
line and then you can see the data come
in and if you don't see the good results
from the subject line or the body of the
email or you know the page they're going
to then make adjustments before you send
the other email to the next 500. so
that's a great thing about emails you
can break up the email into two groups
the first group and then the second
group with different subject lines and
you can probably send them a little bit
of time apart that way you can learn
from the first email because with email
you are generally going to get results
right away okay within the first 24
hours so that's a great thing about
email okay so the other thing about
email it's less intrusive so normally
people who are going to get the email
are the ones who sign up for the email
so they're almost expecting your email
so when they get your email again as
long as you're not sending an email on a
daily basis normally most companies send
it monthly or bi-weekly it's not going
to be as intrusive okay and then it also
helps build credibility increase
visibility and brand awareness meaning
you're going to build your brand in that
email you're going to put content in
that email that's going to to show off
your credibility meaning you could put
some testimonials in the email you can
put some good affiliations you can put a
good article to an industry article you
just wrote so email is going to
inherently continue to build brand
awareness for you okay and it's an easy
way to track Roi so if your e-commerce
it's pretty clear you send the email
somebody opens it clicks on it checks
out and purchases something it's easily
trackable because you could track it
right from that email so one thing I
want to say there is just if you do send
an email make sure you're tracking that
campaign and you want to be able to use
an analytics program like Google
analytics okay if you use Google
analytics you're going to be able to
track when you send the email who clicks
on it and who converts so you want to be
able to measure an Roi for these emails
and you can that's the beauty of email
marketing okay let's move away from
email marketing to webinars so webinars
great method for Effective so social
media promotion it's a great way to
bring traffic to your website so why do
we recommend webinars well because it
provides direct content contact within
your target group what do we mean by
contact with your target group well
you're going to host a webinar and
you're going to invite this targeted
group of people who are interested in
your product or service so if you have a
Facebook Community you can do a Facebook
live event or you could do a YouTube or
you know you can even set up a webinar
and another platform but promote it on
social media and if you're pronouning
something on social media you're
probably promoting it to people who are
already following you or like you and so
that's what we mean by direct contact
with your target groups you're going to
be able to create a webinar and talk
directly to that group and that's going
to help build brand awareness and
credibility and the great thing about
webinars is you don't need some fancy
software I mean I'm talking to you on a
webinar right now and so web webinars
are free all you need is a video camera
and a recorder that's all and that's all
built in with software so there's plenty
of software out there that allows you
just to do a webinar really quick and
easy there's lots of opportunities in
software so and a lot of them are very
cost effective so if you want to build
create a webinar you can do that by
spending very little money in webinars
again allow you to talk to your your
targeted group your community maybe
prospective clients it helps build
credibility and in effect Drive traffic
to your website and when somebody does
attend a webinar they're likely going to
be highly engaged because you're
inviting them they're going to opt into
the webinar and the great thing about
webinars is even if they don't attend
the webinar the day you have it it's
going to be recorded so they can always
go back and watch it so whoever watches
the webinar is going to be engaged
because it's going to be a topic they're
interested in and then users are likely
to become prospective customer so having
a webinar talking about something
inherently interesting to maybe a larger
group of people you can promote that on
social media and potentially get
prospective customers to sign up and
watch the webinar and if you do they're
going to be engaged and then take the
next step oh I like what this guy this
person has to say they seem to be
credible I like their personality I like
their brand I like their product I'm
gonna go check their web out their
website okay so webinars allow you to
kind of pull in more people as well as
just your community because you can
promote the webinar and you can promote
it in advance and you can leverage
social media for that okay so something
related to webinars incorporating video
content so videos have been proven to be
a really good way to attract new
visitors and it just it makes your
website very engaging when you have
videos on your website as well so if you
create video so you have an opportunity
to post it on various video platforms
like YouTube or Vimeo okay there's
plenty of video platforms out there or
just embedded in a blog post or embed it
in a Facebook post or a tweet okay so
you can do a lot with video and having
video on your site is going to increase
engagement okay when you increase
engagement good things happen that's
going to lead to increased conversions
and sales or or Roi or just like we
mentioned the webinar can help build
trust with your audience even that
webinar you could post on your website
so you want people to engage by watching
this video they watch the video they're
going to gain trust in you because
you're talking directly to that person
that user that audience that visitor to
your website and when you get Bell trust
it's going to increase engagement and
that's the beauty of video unlike text
or imagery videos really do engage with
the audience and so the more video you
could do the better off you are because
again you can leverage social to draw
attention to your brand and product and
service and then you can have that video
on your website to increase engagement
which in turn increases conversions and
sales and improves Roi so always think
video there's plenty of video software
out there that you can leverage and the
great thing about video two is hey most
people are using mobile phones these
days smartphones and so video works just
as well on mobile as it does on desktop
so keep that in mind you know video is
going to be engaging regardless of what
device somebody uses and then of course
if they're watching the video on
Facebook or YouTube then chances are
they're going to share that particular
video which is going to bode well for
your brand and traffic okay so video if
somebody likes a video it's very easy to
share video especially from a mobile
phone so YouTube just makes it so easy
to share or like or subscribe to our
Channel it just it becomes that much
easier things can go viral and chances
of them going viral with video are going
to be greater okay so other ways to
drive traffic to your website is submit
your content to content aggregators so
what's a Content aggregator well content
aggregators like Reddit that provides a
great platform for you to post your
content so that's what a Content
aggregator is really a site like Reddit
or medium or quora where you could post
content to a large number of people okay
so with Reddit people are either going
to upvote it or download it so the more
upvotes you get are thumbs up or likes
or people who encourage that content the
more of a chance it has to be found and
so first thing out of the gate if you do
provide content to a Content aggregator
like Reddit make sure it's good quality
content that's interesting and that
should be a case the case around across
the board whether it's a social post or
blog post make sure the content's unique
professional and interesting and then if
you do say put something on medium or
you do put something on Cora and it is
professional and interesting and thought
provoking then people are going to react
to it and then that again could lead to
traffic but even if it doesn't lead to
traffic it helps build brand awareness
so if you have content just like videos
leverage it put the content out there
okay and when you put content out there
it's only gonna especially if it's good
content put it's going to put you in a
good light so don't be afraid to share
your content on the likes of Reddit or
medium or core or some of these other
content aggregator websites because good
things are only going to happen and
again referral traffic SEO brand
awareness conversions so all these are
inherent benefits of just sharing your
content okay and then finally we want to
learn from analytics okay so what do I
mean learning from analytics so there
are plenty of Analytics platforms out
there one of the most popular is Google
analytics so you want to make sure
you're tracking traffic on your site
with Google analytics so all you have to
do is just go to Google analytics via
search sign up add the analytics code to
your website and voila they're doing all
the heavy lifting they're going to track
traffic coming your website and not only
they're going to track traffic but
they're going to tell you how that
traffic engaged and so the benefits of
it Google analytics is hey you can
figure out where users are coming from
are they coming from that email campaign
that I sent out to a thousand people are
they coming from YouTube based on that
video I posted or they coming from
Reddit based on the content I just
posted there or they come in from
organic search it is so Google analytics
can help us understand how much traffic
we're getting from organic search so
it'll help us measure our SEO efforts
and then with Google analytics you could
segment so we could segment by mobile we
can segment by desktop return earning
user new user by campaign by Page by
Language by city by region I mean
there's so many ways in which to segment
your audience and segmenting simply is
breaking up the entire group of people
who come to your website into different
segments based on what you want to say
so if you want to look at you know
females between the ages of 18 to 24 who
come from mobile via organic search
that's a segment and you can look at
that information and analytics if that's
your target audience then you could see
how they're performing okay so Anna
there are a lot of benefits to Google
analytics definitely want to take
advantage of segmenting in Google
analytics you could look at your
competition so there's a benchmarking
report the great thing about Google
analytics you can also look at content
and how your content is performing once
somebody lands on your website are they
what page are they spending time on what
page are they engaging on the the most
okay what pages have the highest bounce
rate or the lowest time on page so you
can really determine what pages work
best and then of course the end result
in analyzing all this data is you want
to be able to fine-tune your website so
take advantage of the data that Google
analytics or any other analytics
platform has given you by learning once
you learn what's going on with your
website you can make adjustments to your
website to improve user experience okay
so we went over a lot of different ways
to drive traffic okay you can
incorporate all this to your website
immediately welcome today we're going to
talk about email marketing tutorial so
buckle up and let's get started with
email marketing tutorial and so let's
start out asking the question why email
marketing so Linda is the owner of an
e-commerce company and basically she
isn't able to take her leads the lead
she's collecting per day per month and
convert them into customers okay so
customers sign up but they don't buy her
product so she's left scratching her
head wondering what to do so how's she
going to solve the problem of converting
the lead she gets into paying customers
well look no further than email market
so you can boost your sales funnel with
the help of email marketing so email
marketing leads to email campaigns that
lead to website visits that can lead to
product purchasing email markings also
in a it's a very good way to generate a
high return on investment so Linda
thinks this is too good to be true your
telling me is a very efficient way to
generate a return on my investment how
expensive is email marketing well email
marketing is neither expense offensive
or time consuming that's the beauty of
email marketing and so Linda is now very
interested we've piqued her interest she
wants us to explain email marketing to
her in detail and that's exactly what
we're going to do we're going to talk
about email marketing in detail so for
everyone out there listening what's in
it for you why are you going to invest
your time in listening to Simply learn
and me talk about email marketing
because we're going to talk about
everything there is about email
marketing in today's webinar so what is
it for those that aren't really familiar
with the intricacies of email marketing
we're going to talk about how to set up
email marketing we're going to discuss
all the benefits of email marketing
we're going to get into a b testing
we're going to get into the automation
of emails the types of emails how to
engage New users and we're going to give
you a demo so there's a lot lot going on
in this webinar like I said buckle up
and let's get started and talk about
what is email marketing so as I
mentioned to Linda it's an efficient way
to convert leads into sales why because
we can send personalized emails to a
specific audience a targeted audience if
somebody's interested in our product we
can reach out to them via email it can
also be used to remarket pre-qualified
leads so anybody who's pre-qualified we
can go ahead and communicate with them
as well so email marketing is a very
effective at different stages in the
funnel okay so when I say funnel
customer life cycle so we have awareness
consideration purchase retention and
advocacy okay so let's talk about each
one of these parts of the final or
customer life cycle if you will so let's
start with awareness at the very top so
email marketing allows customers to
recognize their problems after which you
can educate them them on how your brand
can solve them okay just like any other
marketing channel somebody's looking for
something in need of something and we
can come to the rescue in this case
we're going to come to the rescue with
email and we can go ahead and educate
them on on what their need is and how we
can collaborate with them help them
educate them solve their problems with
our product okay so that's what email is
going to do we're going to communicate
with them via email and we're going to
bring awareness to the problem by
solving the problem that's what email is
good for okay good for generating
awareness for our brand for example we
can share a newsletter with our
customers so we're running a Cosmetics
company we can basically educate them on
the five important skin care products
that everyone should have okay so we can
get them to click on the call to action
to learn more so if somebody's having
some skin care issues or not sure what
products to buy you know any email can
cover that okay the next step in the
customer line cycle is consideration so
customers focused on searching for
Relevant products and compares the
products with similar ones okay so
they're definitely looking they're a
little further in the process they're
educated they know what they're looking
for so we can really hit them with the
right email we can send a relevant email
to promote our product okay discover
that perfect moisturizer for your skin
that perfect skin moisturizer Smooths
hydrates and contains SPF 20. so we got
the perfect product for that person
who's further along the funnel and
really is ready to purchase that product
so we can hit that person up with the
perfect messaging let's talk about
purchase the next step in the life cycle
well purchase well with purchase we can
send an email that encourages that
customer purchase our product by
offering them something okay by giving
an offer for example when you can give a
discount discounts always tend to work
so that moisturizer that that particular
customer was considering buying well
they can move from consideration to
purchasing because we're going to offer
them a discount they can't refuse okay
so you know it could be for a specific
date okay it could be you know something
that's going to get them excited to buy
the product 20 off a moisturizer is
pretty good deal and especially if that
percentage off is better than the other
products they were considering buying so
getting somebody that extra incentive to
purchase the product goes a long way via
email okay we want to take that next
step in the life cycle and nurture our
relationship with customers to ensure
they're loyal okay they've already
purchased how do we get them purchased
again that's retention we want to retain
our customers we want to get them back
to buy the same product or similar
products or completely different
products in their inventory so what do
we do we're going to send an email we're
going to see an email to active
customers okay we're gonna give them an
offer just for them exclusively just for
them in this example we're gonna give
them a combo pack a facial kit at just
39 and get a sunscreen worth ten dollars
for free so you can come up with all
sorts of different combinations on
offers he is the offers exclusively just
for those who you want to Target and
retain as customers because if you just
get somebody to purchase once it's not
gonna work those people have already
taken the that step in the relationship
where they trust your product they
purchase your product now you want to go
ahead and treat that customer special by
giving them an exclusive offer and then
what we want to do is advocacy last step
in that customer lifestyle we want to
convert that active customer into brand
Advocates okay we want that customer to
talk about our brand for us we want them
to promote it and talk about it with
your friends so for example we want to
send an email to those customers to
promote our products okay so for example
we could say hey the sales of our
products for this particular day or for
this month is going to go to our
favorite non-profit could be educating
for children or cleaning up plastic in
the ocean or saving animals we want to
be able to get them to speak on our
behalf and say look guys this is a
really good company you know they're
offering me products exclusively they've
offered me discounts in the past they
have good products they have a lot of
different products and on top of all
that they help they help the environment
they help the needy okay they care and
so we can go ahead and provide a call to
action for these customers that are
loyal to our brand and have them share
the email with their friends to spread
the word on you know what we're trying
to accomplish for our non-profit or or
if anything just get them to promote it
maybe give them a discount for every
friend that they get to buy a product
okay it doesn't have to necessarily be
you know just sharing with Friends it
can be that extra incentive of giving
them a discount if they do share with
friends and their friends buy okay so
this is the customer life cycle and
examples of different emails that you
can use at every step along the way in
the life cycle so let's talk about the
benefits of email marketing so what are
some of the benefits well we've already
mentioned to Linda that it's cost
effective it's time saving real-time
marketing less intrusive builds
credibility increases visibility and
brand awareness and it's an easy way to
track Roi these are all the benefits for
email marketing we're gonna go talk
about some of these now so basically
when we talk about cost effective you
know some email marketing platforms
charge based on the number of of users
who you send the email to time saving
well you saw how quick it took me to set
up that email campaign the key is
figuring out who you want to send it to
can we talk about real-time marketing
you know we're sending this email out
basically in real time trying to meet
our customers needs at the right time
it's less intrusive because we can
customize the emails okay we can as you
saw I can put first name in there to
make it more personal so when
something's more personal it's less
intrusive especially if it's a segment
that already knows your brand okay
builds credibility hey we gain
credibility when we offer exclusive
offers to repeat customers or you know
try and build advocacy by working with
non-profits okay it increases visibility
and brand awareness why because you know
we could send our email out to a large
group of people and that's a good way to
generate brand awareness and as you saw
we can easily measure you know not only
open rates click rates but Roi so how
many people from that email went on and
purchased so we can measure that it's
very easy to measure email today we're
going to talk about affiliate marketing
so let's jump right into it and take a
look inside an office environment right
now we have Chuck here Chuck's doing a
little bit of pacing John walks in the
office hey man what's with all the
pacing everything all right Chuck
responded hey I'm just worried that I
might have exhausted every way we can
advertise our product I mean I've done
SEO I've done paid search I've done
email I've done social man nothing's
working I got to come up with something
new ASAP well John responds hey don't
worry I think I've got your solution for
you man hang tight relax take a load off
here's my solution affiliate marketing
first off before you ask the question
and what's affiliate marketing let's
talk about why we need affiliate
marketing so let's dig into affiliate
marketing so John's just taking over now
and he's gonna let Chuck know everything
there is to know about affiliate
marketing so the first question John
answers for Chuck what is affiliate
marketing so affiliate marketing is a
form of digital marketing that involves
a merchant it involves a merchant paying
commissions to a website or other
entities so if I'm selling a product
basically somebody else sells that
product for me I'm gonna pay that person
a commission for selling my product it's
that simple that's what affiliate
marketing is okay so basically what
these Merchants are doing or other
entities they're advertising your
product so they're advertising your
product with a referral so they're
passing on their own customers to you so
that they can buy your product and again
the exchanges you give that way website
or other entity a commission that's more
or less what affiliate marketing is so
John's gonna have us take a look at each
of these components of affiliate
marketing in detail take it away John so
John says first we have the merchant AKA
The Brand the seller the Creator the
founder the owner the inspiration the
innovator hey this is the person who
came up with this brilliant idea This
brilliant idea has to get out there
we're the merchant we're trying to get
this brilliant idea out to the masses so
this is the component of affiliate
marketing that creates the product the
merchant could be anyone okay so it
could be startups it's a large
multinational companies International
companies non-profits for-profits
individuals independent contractors
Freelancers a group of people who have a
passion for something okay it could be
anybody there's no limit the affiliate
aka the publisher so the affiliate is
basically that third party website or
entity which promotes the Merchant's
products and tries to convince potential
customers of the merchants products
value so this affiliate's going to
represent the merchant on their behalf
and try and get their clients to
basically purchase that particular
Merchant's product so the affiliate
could be incentivized based on you know
registrations email sign ups sales and
subscriptions so it doesn't always come
down to you know sales you know if I'm
just trying to get you know build my
email list then hey I can incentivize
that affiliate to push email signups if
I'm got this big you know offline you
know promotion that I'm doing at this
particular mall and I want to get people
there well I can get an affiliate and
incentivize that affiliate to drive and
help me drive registrations for this
event so it doesn't always have to be
sales per se so in effect you the
merchant and the affiliate work out some
type of commission deal based on what
you're incentivizing so the relationship
between the affiliate and the merchant
is made possible with the help of an
affiliate Network so that's the third
component here we need somebody to bring
the two together that Merchant who has
This brilliant idea and the affiliate
who has potential customers that could
potentially Drive registrations sales
signups Etc to the merchant so the
affiliate network is the one who brings
the two together so the affiliate
Network in effect acts as the middleman
the person in between the merchants and
Affiliates it allows Merchants to find
and collaborate with not just any
affiliate but the affiliate best suited
for their particular brand and product
because you want to find somebody who is
going to be passionate who's relevant
who has your prospective customers in
mind because they're the ones that are
going to help those protective customers
purchase your product so that's what the
affiliate network does it helps bring
the merchants and Affiliates together so
that the affiliate can help advertise
and sell on behalf of the merchant so
with the affiliate Network Merchants can
use tools for tracking and Reporting and
processing payments for Affiliates so
really that affiliate network is the
glue that holds it all together they're
not just one to introduce a merchant and
affiliate they offer it all so as a
merchant you want to be able to manage
your Affiliates so you're not going to
have one affiliate you're going to have
multiple Affiliates so you want to be
able to use the appropriate tools
available to you in the affiliate
Network to see and track how sales are
going and when sales happen okay or
commissions happen you want to be able
to use that affiliate Network to
compensate that affiliate appropriately
and then finally the customer customer
aka the consumer is the most important
component of all of this take it away
John so the consumer is the final and
most important component without
customers to buy products the merchant
would not have any revenue and the
affiliate would not get any commission
so we need customers so John what is the
process of affiliate marketing well John
says let's have a look at the process so
it's affiliate marketing time so we're
going to use a tool or platform like
Commission Junction Commission Junction
is a popular you know platform that
affiliate Network platform that brings
merchants and Affiliates together so the
merchants can use those Affiliates to
advertise their product so let's take a
look at Commission Junction as a good
digital marketing tool for affiliate
marketing so we're going to use
Commission Junction as an example here
remember at affiliate marketing it's an
ecosystem between Publishers and
Merchants so remember Merchants are
selling products Publishers are selling
those Merchant Pro products on their
site and so Commission Junction is the
middleman so to speak okay so Commission
Junction just known as CJ now is the
middle person they're introducing the
publisher and the merchant and so let's
go ahead and log in here so when you log
in like any other digital marketing tool
any other platform you're going to have
your own settings and whatnot so really
the whole idea behind any affiliate
marketing tool is really there to manage
your Publishers who do you want as a
publisher who do you want selling your
product you obviously want somebody
who's relevant somebody who's going to
be able to sell the product somebody who
has a targeted audience that's similar
to yours okay so we go into cj.com we're
gonna log in and here you can see a
Publisher's link so we're going to click
on the Publishers link and remember when
you sign up Publishers you have to
program terms and so if we click on
Publishers program terms we're going to
be able to see all the different program
terms available so here we could see the
different program terms we have set up
for certain Publishers so if we just
click on that we'll be able to see
that's the default program term so
remember you could set up your own
program term for any publisher so as a
best practice if you have Publishers who
are actually performing well who are
selling your products maybe you want to
offer them a little bit more on the
commission side maybe you want to
sweeten the deal maybe you know These
Guys these Publishers get better program
terms versus say other Publishers who
don't and so here we can see the program
terms basically you could see what the
terms are the action and the different
policies here so everything you need to
do to manage that publisher in terms of
payment is done under the program terms
now if the program terms are are met the
publisher actually sells your products
CJ is the broker they're the ones who
are going to initiate the payment based
on the program terms so be careful in
the program terms you want to be able to
set them appropriately CJ has templates
CJ has some default program terms that
you could use and offer up to different
Publishers So based on the program terms
that's how your Publishers are going to
get paid and so here you can have as
many different program terms as you want
There's No Limit here you want to be
able to align and reward program terms
again based on performance and so here
we can see what Publishers are under
what program terms so again if your
publisher is performing well sweeten the
deal offer them a better program terms
and so you can align Publishers with
different program terms and so that's
the whole idea be behind program terms
is you want to be able to align
Publishers with that so when you sign up
a publisher they're going to get a line
with the program term meaning what are
they going to get paid for selling your
product now if we want to manage by
status instead of by program terms we
could see all the different
organizations we have in our Network
these are our Publishers we're the
affiliate we're the ones selling the
product we want to know who's selling
who's not selling and so we can look at
all our Publishers by program terms or
by status okay so basically you can see
here the term status whether it's active
or not earnings basically what they've
sold over the last basically seven days
or three months so you could look at
basically how your Publishers are
performing just by clicking on manage by
status here in cj.com so when you're
looking at reports in cj.com or really
any other affiliate program you might
see the acronym EPC this stands for
earnings per click actually it's a
little misleading it's actually earnings
per 100 clicks so basically CJ
calculates you know how much are
publisher is actually making per click
you know just like paid search we're
paying Google X amount per click it's
the same thing here we can't or these
Publishers can't make any money if they
don't generate clicks so that's why you
have an EPC model or metric so to speak
so you can measure earnings per click CJ
does it over seven a period and over a
three month period so you could sort
based on seven day or three months to
see who's earning the most per click in
terms of Publishers now you can select
under Publishers groups now you can
group your Publishers Okay so so if you
have say a group of Publishers in a
specific region like the United States
or India or if you're just focused on
the United States and say you have
Publishers in different states like
Texas California Missouri Arkansas well
you can group those Publishers into
different groups and you can look at
your different group names here so here
we could see Canada and so we have our
Publishers grouped into a group called
Canada why because they're based in
Canada makes sense so you want to be
able to organize your Publishers because
the whole idea Beyond affiliate
marketing CJ is you want to be able to
get the best Publishers available for
your network and so as you get more
Publishers for your network you'll be
able to basically start grouping them
where it makes sense now the example I
gave you is by geography you could do by
geography or you you could do by
publisher status meaning my best
performing Publishers go into a group if
they're in a group then they get a line
with a certain program term so you could
group your Publishers Any Way You Want
by status meaning they're selling more
these are our best performing Publishers
or by region or you know by promotion I
mean how you group your Publishers is
totally up to you however take advantage
of the option to create publisher groups
because the whole idea again I'm going
to repeat it is you want to get
Publishers and you want to start
building your base of Publishers because
the more Publishers you have the more
chance you are to sell your product
remember if nobody clicks on your
product then nobody's gonna buy your
product so if you have Publishers who
are promoting your product for you then
you have a good opportunity to sell it
so the more publishes you have on board
the better the opportunities so now once
you have Publishers you can start
grouping these Publishers accordingly to
whatever makes sense it's a business
decision just know the options available
in CJ to group Publishers now when
you're in CJ and you're starting out
okay you want to start recruiting your
publisher so you click on recruit and
based on your settings based on what
you're selling CJ is going to try and
put you in front of some good Publishers
and so here we could see if we click on
recruit we're going to get a list of
Publishers and this search results list
of Publishers that we can recruit into
our Network are all listed here and you
can actually see what's interesting you
can see the name of the publisher and
you can see the URL and then you could
actually see if they're a good performer
or not so you could actually see their
history as a publisher just by looking
at their Network earnings and then also
looking at their seven day earnings per
click or three month earnings per click
and so if a publisher has a very high
earnings per click EPC then they're
probably a good publisher somebody
you're probably going to be interested
in so if I see a publisher with you know
three month earnings per click of 105
then that means say if that's my
publisher I'm paying 105 or 106 dollars
over seven days you know they're
generating some clicks for me and
they're generating sales you can't
deliver commission if they don't sell
and so to me I want to be able to look
at the seven three month earnings per
click for these Publishers and so I can
just click on any one of these
Publishers here and get some more
insight about that publisher right here
in CJ so here I can see the particular
URL well the company some other URLs
that they have associated with them in
CJ I could see the category that they're
in again I can see the seven three month
EPC here you can see description okay
you can see some other promotional
methods that they'd use when promoting
products and you get some program
performance from this particular
publisher just by pulling down the pull
down menu here I'm going to look at this
year and see what the performance is and
why I'm waiting for that to load I could
see hey they're also in other countries
as well so I can get a good snapshot of
a particular publisher by recruiting
Publishers seeing what their
performances over a period of time and
potentially you know recruiting that
publisher to be part of my network
because if they're part of my network
then hey if they're selling products if
I'm selling products and I want my
product on their site and they're doing
a good job of selling other products
then I want them to be you know part of
my ecosystem part of my network now
remember CJ is doing the introducing
here they're introducing you to recruits
so you want to be able to again take a
look at the site does do any of the
sites that a particular publisher has
interest you you know again we can just
click on it go to the specific site take
a good look hey Virgin Atlantic okay do
we want them selling our product maybe
maybe not
um so you want to take a look at the
website make sure it's not spammy make
sure it aligns with your business goals
it makes your lines with your product
your target audience remember a lot of
things you want to make sure the website
aligns with because they're representing
your brand okay very important here very
important and so that's what you want to
be able to do and you could do all that
just by looking at the publisher detail
in CJ and then again take a look at that
earnings per click if they're selling
products for other merchants and they're
doing a good job maybe you want them
selling your product as well okay so you
can also you know sort by country you
can also do Network earnings and you can
really filter here so we want you know
choose High Network earners in a
particular country a particular State
you know we could definitely filter in
on a particular type of publisher okay
so you want to be able to hone in on
somebody to line with your geography or
you know definitely you want to align
with somebody who's a high Network owner
now when you get all your Publishers set
up you're going to need to provide them
with some good promotional materials
some good banners
um you know it could be text links some
messaging okay so you're the one who's
going to provide the Publishers with you
know the information they need now as a
best practice remember you can get on
the phone with these Publishers have
monthly calls or quarterly calls see
what they need you know reach out to
them via email or reach out to them via
the CJ platform figure out hey you know
how's your banners working for you do
you need new banners so you want to be
able to constantly you know push new
content out and so if I click on links
here and manage I'll be able to see
everything that I have available for my
Publishers to use okay and then you can
actually look at banners that have
actually produced for you in terms of
EPC or you know if it's a specific
promotion okay you could set that up
here so you could be able to see it here
you can see all the banners you can see
some text links in here so all the you
know advertising that you want these
Publishers to have is gonna be situated
under links and so you can see what the
active ones are you can look at archived
you can look at again text links content
links or banners and as a best practice
if I click on a banner as a best
practice ideally what you want to do is
use UTM tracking okay so you want to
have some type of tracking in place
however CJ does a lot of the tracking
for you so they're going to be able to
tell you how many times a Banner's been
clicked and how many times a Banner's
been seen okay they'll also tell you
more importantly Not only was that
Banner click but did it generate a sale
and so here I can see that I have three
Publishers using this particular banner
I could see over this period of time 412
Impressions meaning 412 people viewed
the banner and I received one click on
it so you can get some in-depth detail
about your different marketing materials
and how they're performing okay okay you
can also see what Publishers are using
them okay so the key here is you want to
be able to communicate with your
Publishers give them the promotional
material and that they need to promote
your product now you could set up
specifically you could set up a unique
Banner for a publisher or you could set
up a banner for a group of Publishers
that's where the group comes in so you
have some options here and then as a
best practice what I would try and do as
you can see here is come up with
different Banner sizes so you can see
here we got a 728 by 90. okay you gotta
have 160 by 600. you got a 300 by 250
okay so you want to have different
Banner sizes and you also want to mix in
some text
um ads as well okay you want to be able
to give your Publishers some options in
terms of what to use on their websites
so that's the whole idea because a
publisher may not have space on the home
page they may only have enough space for
you know a text ad or a 300 by 250. so
you want to be able to mix it up and
then also mix up the messaging as well
so you can have the same 300 250 Banner
but you can have different messaging
just like you see here 300 by 250 got
this messaging here and we got a
different set of messaging with the same
Banner size so the more options you
present for yourself the more of an
opportunity you have for the publisher
to use that messaging that Banner that
text that on their website and then that
gives you a better opportunity to get
the click get the conversion that you
seek out so that is links so you want to
be able to continue to push out
different banners and text ads now CJ
also has a great feature in here if
you're selling a lot of products you
have a large inventory of products you
you could actually upload a product feed
to CJ so you can see in this example we
don't but if you did let's just say you
have a hundred products that you want to
sell you can go ahead and upload that
fee to CJ and then the publisher will be
able to use that entirety and it's of
the feed or pick and choose different
products to use and sell so let's jump
over to reports and CJ you have reports
so this is really the bulk of where you
want to be spending your time because
you want to be able to you know not only
recruit those Publishers but after you
recruit them you want to be able to see
the performance how are things moving
are are Publishers moving product are
they generating clicks are they selling
your products so go no further than
reports right here at the top navigation
we're going to click on performance
reports and so we want to be able to see
over a period of time you know are we
selling our product and and here you can
see over the last 30 days you can see
how much commission was paid out
remember CJ gets a fee they're the
broker okay so that's part of the
program terms okay so it's based on
program terms who's selling okay what
program term are they associated with CJ
gets their commission okay so you can
see the total commission and then the
sale amount okay so we could see how
many sales were generated how many items
were sold how many clicks were generated
how many Impressions so I can get a good
sense here day by day over who's selling
who's not selling and it's all broken
down at the very end to earnings per
click so that's my performance report so
we want to be able to see over a period
of time you know are we selling now I
can go into detail if I click on
transaction here from the pull down menu
I can look at a specific order I can
choose a specific publisher or website
and I can get details about that
specific order publisher website Etc
just be look by choosing transaction so
I can get really granular about the data
I see for specific transaction that's
just by clicking reports transaction now
you can also click on promo codes and if
you're running a promo codes for your
Publishers you'll be able to see how
many conversions those promo codes
delivered and the total sale amount over
the last 30 days so building a network
is all about recruiting the right
Publishers giving them the materials
they need measuring the performance of
the Publishers and then communicating
it's just so key so CJ has a nice
message Center built in so you can
actually you know look at the messages
you're getting from your Publishers and
turn around and communicate with them so
communicate seamless honestly
inefficiency right in CJ here so I just
clicked on mail and we could see the
messages we have so you can also click
on email campaigns and if you have any
email campaigns that you want to run you
can look at them right here in CJ so CJ
offers up some email campaigns then we
can see how many people we targeted you
know how many people opened it and how
many people joined in this case joined
our Network so here we have you know a
breakdown of each of the email campaigns
that we've run over a period of time and
their status and how many people were
targeting and opens deliveries Etc so if
you want to run an email campaign right
in CJ it's available to you as part of
the platform so if we move over from
mail to placements we have an
opportunity to place some promotional
material on a Publisher's website okay
and so here we could see a breakdown of
different Publishers who basically will
offer up some promotional material that
we can leverage okay so here you got
this particular promotional placement
it's a one month placement and review
page with your ad so we can actually you
know take advantage of what Publishers
are offering up on their own website so
the whole idea here is if it's in a
prime position on their website then we
can take advantage of that so then what
we want to be able to do is if we like
what they're offering up you can see hey
this particular publisher is saying they
have a creative the placement is a home
page Banner or full page review provide
an email with a copy of the ad that
you'd like to be displayed and we're
going to email this person here so if we
want to take advantage of a specific
promotional placement on a Publisher's
website then we can do that just by
clicking on place and we'll be able to
see who's offering up what notice
there's a fee involved so it just gives
you an opportunity to reward a publisher
that's performing well for you and if
they turn around and offer you a better
placement for a little bit more money it
might be worth it so the whole idea is
to take advantage of placements because
if your product isn't placed properly
then nobody's going to see it if nobody
sees it then you know they're not going
to click on it and then you're not going
to get sales so that's a whole idea here
is take advantage of what Publishers are
offering up in terms of promotional
opportunities so CJ also has a pay per
call click model as well pay model so
basically your paper performance is
based on calls so basically the whole
point here is a CJ points out you want
to promote more High ticket and
consultative products and services you
want to expand your reach and you want
to get more qualified sales then you can
offer up a pay per call and the beauty
here is CJ tracks the calls so you will
be able to see the actual phone number
and calls so instead of offering up say
you know Banner with a click you can
offer a you know promotional number and
have CJ track the calls from the
publisher and that just opens up another
opportunity for you to give your
Publishers an option to have people call
if they call then great you know it's
another way for somebody to get in touch
and purchase the product so the
pay-per-call method is available under
CJ as well so if we want to get more
insights about how our program is
performing we just click on the insights
CJ is going to take us to this overview
this dashboard if you will with some
really good data based on a time frame
okay so we're comparing July through of
July of 19 through July of 2018 we're
able to see revenue and and commissions
paid out and how many clicks average
order value so it's kind of an overview
dashboard if you will about how our
overall program is performing there are
other similar tools and resources to
include you know Max Bounty trade
doubler Amazon Associates there's plenty
of networks out there you want to find a
network where you're going to have
Affiliates that are going to be
passionate and going to be relevant and
have the prospective audience that you
need to sell your product so do your due
diligence on the number of different
platforms out there
hey guys welcome to this video in this
session we'll be covering some of the
most important marketing books for
entrepreneurs digital marketing is a
field that will probably never go out of
style and thanks to this there is always
going to be people searching for new
Innovations and techniques to make the
process easier which means that
alongside causes tutorials and your own
work experience you will need a little
more to bring about true Innovation
that's where marketing book comes in so
let's ask the most important question
probably on your mind why should I be
reading these books the marketing books
that we are going to talk about here and
the marketing books in general are a
collection of data and experiences from
goliaths within the industry
these books provide a window to the time
period they were written in and help you
understand how marketing is still in
some ways extremely similar to how
things were back then albeit with more
technology nowadays
you will also soon see that the books
that we Revere the most when it comes to
marketing are the ones that were written
in the period of the early 60s to 90s
and you know where the lives we live now
would have been impossible to imagine
that's what makes these
special the time period and some of the
methods may have changed by the concepts
and rules covered in these books have
stood the test of time and are Timeless
let's now start with number 12
Contagious by Jana Burger on New York
Times bestseller this book is perfect
for someone looking to understand how to
spread ideas increase brand awareness or
even to grow their customer base
it goes on to explain why certain ideas
products and stories get shared and grow
in popularity why only certain emails
and videos get forwarded and much more
contagious also goes into detail about
the six basic principles that contribute
to content becoming viral or contagious
from products initiatives YouTube videos
and more it also provides actionable and
specific techniques to spread
information designing messages and more
now let's talk about Jana Berger he is a
marketing professor at the Wharton
School at the University of Pennsylvania
he's an expert in Concepts like Word of
Mouth
how consumer Behavior can be influenced
how stories ideas and products catch on
and much more he's also been a keynote
speaker in several prominent events and
consults companies like Google Apple
Nike and more now let's have a look in
number 11 hooped by nirayal this book
called a critical work in the field of
psychological marketing is one that
delves into how habit-forming products
can be built years of analyzing startups
have led nerve to understand the
customers can be influenced
this led to the creation of the hook
model
this book talks about how the hoop model
which is a four-step process can enable
companies to subtly encourage particular
customer Behavior it also provides
practical insights into how the hook can
be used to create user habits that will
get them further hooked onto your
product
the book also provides steps to create
such a product
finally the book also provides examples
as to how companies like iPhone Twitter
and Pinterest hope their users now let's
talk about niral starting off as carrier
in the game thinking and advertising
industry Nev created different
techniques through which he could
motivate and manipulate users he also
helps create behaviors that can benefit
users while educating people to build
healthy habits he's also an active angel
investor in companies like canva ever
bright kahoot and more
now for number 10 we have the conversion
code by Christmas this book recommended
by digital marketing Guru Neil Patel is
one that focuses on helping users to
increase sales in this internet-driven
era
guides users on tips to perform online
lead generation and inside sales it also
details the many ways companies can
engage with their consumers be it Media
Mobile apps and blogs and how to be
effective at it
the book also focuses on leveraging the
strengths of social media apps and blogs
to capture more leads for less money
like I mentioned earlier the main focus
in this book is to convert more internet
leads into real world prospects and
sales appointments
let's now talk about Chris Smith he's a
best-selling author and co-founder of a
Blog called curator which is a social
media digital marketing and coaching
company his work has been featured in a
number of major Publications like ad
week and folks he is also a in-demand
keynote speaker and is often on real
estate industrialists as one of the most
influential people within the industry
next up number nine designing brand
entity by Alina wheeler called a
comprehensive pragmatic and easy to
understand resource for brand builders
by the global brand leader of Deloitte
this book mainly focuses on the
fundamentals processes and case studies
behind creating a brand it covers more
than 100 grinding subjects checklists
tools and diagrams the book also acts as
a compendium for tools that can make the
branding process a success and some of
the best practices that will get you
some inspiration
the book also has 50 case studies
describing goals processes strategies
Solutions and results
now let's talk about the author Alina
wheeler Elena wheeler is a prominent
speaker who guides themes with
everything brand related from Brand
fundamentals processes best practices
and much more she's also been coaching
Business Leaders and Design
consultancies and has worked with more
than a hundred companies within the
private and public sector
now let's go to number eight get Scrappy
by Nick westergard called a digital
marketing Bible by Publishers Weekly
this book helps smaller companies with
lesser resources to develop Powerhouse
results it also aims to help teams to
think like underdogs and to leverage the
right social networks and the
appropriate digital marketing tools and
to effectively Reach people it also
focuses on integrating the marketing
strategy across touch points for a
unified brand experience both online and
off
now let's talk about the author Nick
westergard
Brands Drew from small businesses
Fortune 500 companies took President
Obama's jobs Council
he's also a regular contributor to the
Howard Business Review U.S news and
World Report entrepreneur Forbes
Mashable and more he is also a member of
the boards of the University of Iowa
school of Journalism and mass
communication
Iowa City area Chamber of Commerce and
film scene
next we have number seven
How to Win Friends and Influence People
in the digital age by Dale Carnegie
published in 1936 the book has been
number eight on the list of the top
checkouts of all time but New York
Public Library despite its age the many
concepts are still relevant and have
been updated to fit modern requirements
the book lays out powerful and Timeless
principles of human Communications that
have impacted Millions
Essentials of Engagement affirming was
good connecting with core desires and
other concepts are elaborated on
the book also explains how to make a
lasting impression to Merit and maintain
trust in how to lead change
now let's talk about Dale Carnegie
he's a writer and lecturer and the
developer of courses dealing with
self-improvement salesmanship corporate
training public speaking interpersonal
skills and much more by the time of
Carnegie's death in 1955 his book had
sold 5 million copies in 31 languages
and there had been 4 lakh 50 000
graduates of his Dale Carnegie Institute
now for number six
positioning by always and Jack trout
this book released in 2001 called one of
the most popular marketing books ever
released still keeps up with the current
marketing landscape
it details how Brands can make their
product and industry leader it explains
strategies that can capture a large
market share and to build their
strategies around the competitors
weaknesses
also helps to analyze and incorporate
data from trends now let's talk about
alries and Jack trout alries is an
author and marketing professional
credited with resurrecting the idea of
positioning and marketing
track trout was a marketer who was one
of the founders and Pioneers of
marketing Warfare Theory and positioning
Theory
next for number 5 epic content marketing
by Joe Polizzi this book called one of
Fortune magazine's top 5 Business book
must reads explains how to attract
customers and lead them to your
businesses by creating relevant content
the book helps determine what your
Brand's content Niche is and what you
need to do to keep that attention
the book can help discover and develop
your content marketing mission statement
and to set up a process to create and
curate content
it also explains how to leverage social
media and email channels to create and
grow your audience
now let's talk about Joe Polizzi he's an
author and an authority when it comes to
content marketing he founded the content
marketing Institute and launched several
events one among them being content
marketing world
he also won the 2014 John Caldwell
Lifetime Achievement Award by the
content Council
next up we have number four crushing it
by Kerry van hope on New York Times
bestseller this book helps people build
personal brand and how to achieve their
goals
the book explains the many ways social
media platforms can be taken advantage
of by organizations to make a personal
brand for themselves it provides tricks
and tweaks to enhance these strategies
it also provides tactical and
theoretical advice on how to become a
star on social media and podcast
Services it also details examples from
real life scenarios and how they were
handled
let's talk about Gary when hook he's an
investor and advisor for several
startups across the world he's also an
expert on Fortune 500 companies he also
runs vaynermedia a digital marketing
agency that helps companies like GE
PepsiCo Hasbro the New York Jets and
more
now for number three Ogle way on
Advertising by David or Kilby
this book written by David or gilby who
was known as the most sought after
wizard in the industry by Time Magazine
was released in 1983. this consists of
Concepts that remain valid to this day
it covers a number of different phases
of advertising and covers the four
foundational principles of advertising
it also covers the author's experiences
working with many prominent brands of
the era
let's take a look at David o'kellby
he was a British advertising Tycoon and
the founder of ogilvue and mathur
he was called the father of advertising
he introduced the concept of branding to
advertising and focused on the
importance of the creative copy and
campaign themes
now for number two
the 22 immutable laws of marketing by
alries and Jack trout
this book covers 22 Innovative rules
that help with understanding and
succeeding in an international
marketplace
the book provides insight into several
Concepts that are still relevant today
it also details 22 superlative tools and
Innovative techniques for the
international market leads and now for
number one
scientific advertising by Claude C
Hopkins
this book released in 1923 has been
cited as the must read book by several
advertising personalities like David
Ogilvy Gary Halbert and J Abraham
it's credited with providing the
original description for split testing
and copen-based customer tracking and
loyalty programs
it also details an advertising approach
that ensures reduced losses from
unsuccessful ads and gains from
profitable ads are multiplied
now let's talk about the author clotsy
Hopkins
he was known as an advertising Pioneer
and was known as leader in the creation
and development of modern day consumer
brand advertising and direct response
marketing
he was inducted into the advertising
Hall of Fame in 1957. now let's get
started with marketing hacks
first you need to make personalized
messages
one of the most important things you
need to make sure of is that you
understand your audience things like
what they expect from your brand what
products they are interested in what
they like what they don't and so on then
provide concise and understandable
content this content should be of the
form that users feel like they have
gained something valuable each time they
interact with it you also need to make
sure you practice transparency and
respect your users privacy all of this
can be made possible with the help of
Behavioral segmentation or dividing your
audience into groups based on actions
like card abandonment repeat purchases
page views without conversation and so
on
here we have an example from the popular
food delivery application zomato
now for number two using data to drive
creatives
the combination of the right ad images
and their corresponding copies are now
just as important as ad placement and
audience targeting to do it right you
need to use a data-driven approach to
the process of Creative Design you need
to analyze the metrics of the creatives
you're using currency identify what's
going wrong and make Corrections or
create new designs to address the issues
and improve non-performing metrics in
fact in organizations like Google and
Facebook algorithms are being used to
determine what combination of AD copies
and creatives can bring the best
conversion rates and click-through rates
none of which would be possible without
a data-driven approach
next for number three we have to focus
on original research
you need to perform your own research on
latest Technologies and Trends with data
represented in a creative manner like
with the help of graphics
some of the biggest advantages of having
your own proprietary data enables you to
provide data in a unique angle and makes
it easy to share
moreover with this data being easily
shareable this improves a number of
backlinks generated from high Authority
websites it would also let you loads of
subscribers
let's now have a look at number four
you need to update your content the
content you have already published will
over a period of time see a decreasing
amount of traffic coming to it which is
why it needs to be updated regularly
with simple tweaks and updates to ensure
it doesn't Decay and is refreshed in
Google rankings doing this is also
significantly cheaper than creating a
piece of content from scratch updates
also help increase organic traffic and
to introduce new customers to your
websites or content
at number 5 we have performed guest
blogging
perform guest blogging by having people
with blogs or an audience within your
industry create content for you first
off you can take advantage of their
expertise and drive traffic to your
website moreover having them to do this
introduces Their audience to your brand
this brings you new users you can
eventually turn into leads and then into
customers
here's an example of a guest blogger for
the d-zone website done properly this
can ensure traffic can be driven to your
website
next up at number six you need to use
video
s are now seen to be one of the most
successful forms of advertising so why
not capitalize on it videos like
tutorials testimonials and behind the
scenes footage can improve your
relationship with your audience and
increase the probability of them
investing in your product or services
they also help humanize your brand
adding doses of genuineness to
interactions with your audience on that
note might I suggest you check out our
video on digital marketing if you are
interested in learning about it I'll add
a link in the live chat
next up at number seven you need to
perform live streams
live streams offer you a free form of
content that doesn't take too long to
create and give significant amounts of
authentic interactions with your
audience moreover live streams give you
a greater number of Impressions than the
traditional types of content that you
can post
next up for number eight making
explainer videos
with your such make complex Concepts
easier to understand can be of great
help to your brand or website for
starters your content gets a boost from
Google thanks to its preference for
video content this content also improves
SEO and marketing opportunities for your
website you can take this one step
further and even create your own video
series that you can put up on YouTube or
other learning platforms
law for number nine hosting or joining
podcasts
podcasts give you a platform to interact
with an audience that can return each
week you could join an existing podcast
series or start your role each of these
methods help improve traffic to your
website and increase brand awareness
involving yourself in established
podcasts within the industry will draw
audience interest to your brand or
product if the podcaster has a large
audience his or her trust in your brand
will become the audience's trust in your
brand thus bringing you a brand new
audience that can enjoy your content
next up number 10 focusing on local SEO
prioritizing the Google my business tool
will enable you to manage your Brand's
online presence alongside Maps and
search results
by focusing on local SEO you are making
sure your brand is in front and center
when users search for related terms in
searches it also helps increase your
exposure to local audiences and can
increase the number of leads you can
gain
law for number 11 setting up automated
email campaigns
automating email campaigns can reduce
the amount of time you spent on the task
of manually sending email and increases
the number of emails that you can send
this helps you increase the conversion
rates it can also provide you with more
customization options stuff like a b
testing infographics time zones call to
action buttons and much more
next up number 12 we have test augmented
reality
augmented reality provides additional
personalization that enables greater
interactivity from the users this by
extension increases their interest in
your brand making them more likely to
convert augmented reality can also give
users the opportunity to preview your
product or Services giving them an
opportunity to try it before they can
actually purchase it
here we have an example of an AR
application through which users could be
a part of the launch of the smartphone
OnePlus not
for number 13 you have to use Smart
bidding
with smart bidding Google uses machine
learning to analyze your data so that it
can optimize your bits in real time with
this you enable Google to learn from
past data to optimize your ad spend you
choose an appropriate bit strategy see
how it works out and keep optimizing
finding the right combination can help
you acquire leads and convert them into
customers
next up for number 14 you need to take
advantage of your user generated content
with user generated contents you get
constant updates from your customers and
this tells Google that your content is
updated constantly thus helping with
improving your rankings comments and
reviews from users can also improve the
uniqueness of your content
and finally at number 15 we have
gamification
gamifying your content with loyalty
programs and competitions can greatly
improve your audience's engagement with
your brand gamification also encourages
your audience to perform a particular
action like liking sharing or commenting
on content
here's an example of a Rewards program
that gives users credits called Stars
they can use as currency at a number of
different locations the more products
you buy from Starbucks the more stars
you will earn before we get on to
talking about mobile marketing let's
have a look at some stats related to
mobile marketing
first off mobile devices are used for
over 40 percent of online transactions
next we have marketers and advertisers
put 51 percent of their budget into
Mobile ads
and finally mobile is responsible for an
average of more than 40 percent of
Revenue in leading B2B organizations
what is mobile marketing
mobile marketing is a digital marketing
strategy that started all the way in
1992. remember sms's that advertise
stuff that's what mobile marketing
started off as the main objective with
mobile marketing is to advertise
products and services to a target
audience through multiple channels on
smartphones tablets and other mobile
devices
this is done through websites emails SMS
social media in-app notifications and
other applications
so here are key concepts related to
mobile marketing first we have focusing
on the customer and personalized
marketing
in mobile marketing the primary focus is
on the customer want them to increase
brand loyalty give customers special
offers or show them personalized ads
based on their location and purchase
history
basically by focusing on the customer it
gives them the feeling that the brand is
directly interacting with them and as a
result their loyalty towards the brand
greatly increases
next we have identifying Trends with
data by leveraging data different Trends
can be identified from there you can
create customer profiles and then with
predictive and behavior analysis you get
an understanding of what will better
grab the attention of a customer
then we have testing
testing provides insights and learnings
that would be extremely important to the
success of the campaign for example say
you do an A B test with that you'll get
the optimal variant of the two as well
as further understanding of what works
and what isn't
and finally understanding mobile
analytics having some experience with
mobile analytics with some of the
metrics that need to be focused on like
engagement ratio cost per install and
average revenue per user are very
important for mobile marketing
experience with mobile analytics tools
can also help with insights that would
help future decisions and experiments
so if you're interested in getting
certified in mobile marketing you have
options like mobile app marketing 2020
ASO advertising and monetization by
udemy and you also have digital
marketing specialist certification by
simply learn
now let's go to number nine CRM or
customer relationship management
here are some interesting stats
it is stated that towards the end of
2019 86 percent of customers are willing
to pay 25 percent more for better
customer experience
also CRM marketing will be worth 73
billion dollars in 2020.
finally businesses that leverage CRM
software see sales increase by 29 sales
productivity increased by 34 and sales
forecast accuracy increased by 42
percent
now that we have looked into these stats
let's understand what CRM is all about
CRM is a technology with which an
organization's relationships and
interactions with existing or potential
customers are managed
it's basically a collection of
strategies tools and Technologies and
crms aim to develop new customer
relationships retain them or require new
ones
along with that it also helps companies
with sales marketing and service
management
crm's mainly store data like purchase
history personal information and
purchasing patterns
so here are a few areas to focus in CRM
first we have data analytics crms
provide a number of different metrics
that can be analyzed and whose results
can be incorporated into forthcoming
campaigns now although what metric you
focus on entirely depends on your
requirements here are some of the
commonly used metrics
this customer shown which is basically
customer attrition there's NPS which is
a measure of how satisfied your
customers are less customer retention
cost and first Contact resolution rate
which is the percentage of customers
support tickets that get resolved at the
first short
next understanding how different CRM
tools work
there are loads of options to choose
from when it comes to crms that
Salesforce HubSpot CRM Zoho CRM
Microsoft Dynamics and much more
it is really important to have
experienced at least the most commonly
used ones since each of them have their
own nuances advantages and disadvantages
now let's have a look at some of the
certifications
we have options like Salesforce
administrator certification training
course by simply learn Dynamics 365 by
Microsoft and finally HubSpot Academy
sales professional credential by HubSpot
so now let's go to number eight
at number eight we have designing
like usual let's have a look at some of
the stats
did you know that 32 percent of
marketers say visual images are the most
important form of content for their
business with blogging in second
well 70 of companies in Western content
marketing which could include visual
marketing strategies
so now let's take a closer look at
designing
with designing the objective is to
communicate as well as promote the
products or Services the brand is
advertising in a visually appealing
manner
designing goes hand in hand with a great
copy though
even if you had the best looking
creative in your ad it's possible it
won't catch on if the copy accompanying
it isn't good you might wonder what does
designing have to do with digital
marketing plenty actually if you have an
understanding of Designing yourself in
the scenario where graphic designers are
unable to bring your idea to life you
could do it yourself Desiring for
yourself what the content will convey
not only that you might be able to
provide some insight in the designing of
the creator for the ad
next let's have a look at Key concepts
of Designing
firstly a basic understanding of design
philosophies are necessary which means
you need to know about Concepts like
using attention grabbing and relevant
images the golden Point Rule and much
more
then there needs to be an understanding
of tools like Adobe Photoshop and after
effects
these are some of the most commonly used
tools for creating creatives and even
the basic experience with these software
could be extremely useful later on
now let's have a look at some
certifications
we have certifications like graphic
design by Coursera introduction to
graphic design by LinkedIn and
fundamentals of graphic design Again by
Coursera
next at number seven we have listening
now let's talk about social listening
social listening is a method through
which a brand can learn about what
customers are saying about them and the
industry online by monitoring digital
conversations
the brand social media channels can
track analyze and respond to
conversations and feedback improving
their relationship with the users who
may become potential customers and thus
increasing loyalty of present customers
and it's a proven fact that customers
are drawn towards brands that are prompt
in response
now let's have a look at some key
Concepts understanding how different
social media platforms work how is each
platform different from the other
whereas most of your audience come from
which platform is better suited for your
content those are the questions that
need to be answered
then experience with popular social
listening tools like HubSpot and
HootSuite these platforms can help with
a number of different situations like PR
crisis respond to customer complaints
find user generated content to obtain
competitive intelligence take
suggestions and much more
next at number six we have copywriting
first let's have a look at some stats
it has stated that 64 of B2B marketers
Outsource their demanding copy needs
next It also says that a compelling copy
draws 7.8 times more side traffic and
produces brand recall which brings
higher engagement rates
now let's talk about what is copywriting
copywriting is an act of creating
promotional texts that could be
advertised in brochures notifications
Billboards emails and so on
the primary objective here is that the
written content called copy or sales
copy increases brand awareness and
Pursuits individuals to take a
particular action be it signing up to a
website by a product and so on
now let's have a look at some key
concepts of copywriting first
understanding the customers and the
competition so from the customers
several bits of Vital Information can be
obtained like what kind of writing gets
the maximum amount of Engagement what
kind they dislike and much more likewise
from the competition you can find out
what kind of writing they have success
with what they are doing better from
your brand and so on
this one goes without saying but to have
success with copywriting you need to be
well versed with grammar and have
sufficiently good writing skills
get some certifications now
here we have the creative copywriter
Academy then we have the IDM award in
digital and copywriting by The Institute
of data and marketing and finally we
have American Writers and artists
copywriting course
next up number five email marketing
first let's have a look at some stats
according to statista in 2019 Global
email users amounted to 3.9 Million by
2023 this is set to grow to 4.3 billion
next it also states that 81 smbs rely on
email as their primary customer
acquisition Channel and 80 for retention
next Again by statista it states that 49
of consumers would like to receive
promotional emails from their favorite
brands
so now let's have a look at email
marketing
email marketing is a method for
performing digital marketing by using
emails to promote products and services
to a highly targeted audience in a way
email marketing could nurture the
relationship with your customers or
completely drive them away
with email marketing customers can be
communicated with directly with
personalized emails helping them stay
updated with items or offers
it also serves a purpose of informing
people about your brand or keeping
existing customers engaged between
purchases
now let's have a look at Key Concepts
first we have focusing on
personalization and automation emails
can be set up in such a way that
customers are regularly sent emails on a
regular basis to keep in touch with them
inform them about new products and other
forms of Engagement
then we have complying with data privacy
rules
privacy has been the talking point for a
while now most recently the gdpr brought
about a number of restrictions that have
to be adhered to by organizations
so it's absolutely necessary that these
privacy guidelines are followed or would
you rather spend 10 million pounds
next experimenting with different kinds
of content
emails can have images gifs or videos
attached to them and each of them can
impact your customer base in a different
manner depending on their requirements
so different kinds of content need to be
experimented with to determine the one
that works best for you
and finally understanding popular tools
and metrics to be successful at email
marketing it is absolutely necessary to
be experienced with tools like HubSpot
and MailChimp
these platforms come with a number of
features like contact segmenting
autoresponders service and app
integration a b testing and much more
next up we have certifications
here we have certifications like HubSpot
Academy email marketing by HubSpot then
email and affiliate marketing Mastermind
by udemy and finally Advanced email
marketing certification training by
simply learn
so now that we have reached Midway I
have a question for you guys what do you
guys think is in the number one section
let me know in the live chat I'd like to
know what you guys think
if you enjoy watching informative Tech
videos like this one consider
subscribing to Simply lunch channel to
stay up to date on the trending
Technologies and hit the Bell icon to
never miss an update in the future
now back to number four social media
marketing
before we go in let's have a look at
some stats
according to statista nearly 50 of the
world's population uses social media
73 percent of marketers believe social
media marketing has been somewhat
effective or very effective for their
business
lastly 90.4 percent of Millennials 77.5
percent of Generation X and 48.2 percent
of baby boomers are active social media
users
so now let's have a look at Social Media
Marketing
social media marketing involves a usage
of social media platforms to build a
brand Drive traffic to your website and
increase sales
this helps marketers achieve their
marketing and branding goals by creating
and sharing content on social media
activities like text and image updates
video and other content that can drive
engagement social media marketing also
enables marketers to perform paid
advertising with this your Brand's
content like articles videos and images
are exposed to a high quality targeted
audience
next let's have a look at some key
concepts of social media marketing
first understanding how to work with
different social media platforms is
necessary
every social media platform comes with
its own kind of audience nuances
advantages and disadvantages so it's
important to have experience with them
so that the one that best suits your
requirements can be selected
next we have monetization
on YouTube which is also a social media
platform you could monetize your videos
to get some income out of them other
options include affiliate marketing
influencer marketing events and much
more
then we have analytics experience with
social media marketing tools like buffer
and busumo can help organizations by
providing anodes based on keywords brand
names links domain and much more
among other things it also attracts
competitors and analyzes their content
to determine what they are doing better
then we have knowing your Brand's user
base and optimizing your content it's
important to understand your Brand's
user base to determine what they like
the most on your social media page and
then optimize it
now let's have a look at some
certifications
here we have advanced social media
certification training by simply learn
then we have social media marketing on
LinkedIn learning and finally HootSuite
social marketing certification by
HootSuite
and now for the top three number three
payoff Lake of PPC first let's have a
look at some stats
33 percent of people click on paid
search ad because it directly answers
their search query
it also states that paid ads have a
11.38 CTR on Google
and finally according to google
businesses make an average of two
dollars in income for every one dollar
they spend in Google ads
now let's talk about PPC
it is a form of online advertising in
which advertisers spend a certain amount
of money each time their advertisement
is clicked this process if done properly
can drive people to your website without
having to get them organically
search engine marketing is one of the
most popular methods to perform PPC
for PPC most search engines are part of
an automated process performed by the
search engine to determine how relevant
and valid they are to appear in the
search engine results page
now let's have a look at some key
concepts of PPC
first it's important how different
search engines and their advertising
works each of them have their own but
somewhat similar rules prices
restrictions and so on
then we have Google ads one of the most
popular and lucrative layers among the
search engines Google ads provides
marketers with a sizable chunk of the
internet to advertise to
it is important to properly understand
how Google ADS works and how its many
features and functionalities can be used
efficiently
for more on Google ads why don't you
check our introductory video on it I
link it in the chat
next analytics different metrics like
CPC or cost per click clicks
click-through rate and quality score
need to be understood so that optimal
and well-informed decisions can be made
finally we have copywriting and visual
design ability as I mentioned earlier
either of these don't work without the
other which means the experience in both
these Concepts would be greatly
beneficial for the individual and the
organization
now let's have a look at some
certifications
we have Google ads certifications by
Google then Advanced pay-per-click PPC
certification training by simply learn
and finally we have Microsoft and
Excellence program by Microsoft
now for the top two search engine
optimization
let's first look at some stats
according to zero limit web on the first
page alone the first five organic
results account for 67.60 of all the
clicks
and according to Google where to buy
Plus near me mobile queries have grown
by over 200 percent in the past two
years
and finally according to HubSpot 57 of
B2B marketers stated that SEO generates
more leads than any other marketing
initiative
so what exactly is search engine
optimization
search engine optimization or SEO refers
to the method adopted by an organization
to grow the quality and quantity of
website traffic by making it more
visible to the users of a particular web
search engine
this is possible with the help of
organic search results SEO improves
unpaid results and doesn't count traffic
obtained from Paid ads
next let's have a look at some key
concept of SEO
technical SEO the technical side of SEO
like server side settings site Maps
server Response Code rewrites and so on
will help you take advantage of both
page level and server level optimization
to ensure they are found by search
engines this by extension helps generate
traffic and conversions
next content marketing it is important
to be well versed in content marketing
as both SEO and content marketing cannot
exist without the other
content marketing provides high quality
content and SEO provides the appropriate
keywords that would help it get noticed
by search engines
next link building
process of search engine optimization
can only be successful if there's a
combination of both external link
building and internal link optimization
one builds links with credible websites
and the other performs link optimization
on your own properties and social media
platforms
now we have site usability SEO must
focus on good site usability this is an
indication of how objects are placed in
your website and if the information
provided is useful for the users
it also indicates if the site is easy to
use and navigate
then you need to have experience with
tools like Moz and Google analytics to
take appropriate inferences from the
data obtained
and finally we have Google analytics and
Google webmaster
Google analytics will help with tracking
and Reporting website traffic Google
webmaster will help track your website
search performance with the help of
Google search console and additional
resources
now let's have a look at some
certifications
here we have SEO training caused by Moz
which is provided by udemy and we have
search engine optimization training
course by simply learn and finally we
have HubSpot SEO training course
provided by HubSpot
finally number one it's data analytics
data analysis is a process which looks
into collecting and organizing data by
doing so helpful conclusions are drawn
these conclusions can be incorporated
into the upcoming campaigns of the
organization
the information that is analyzed is
collected with the help of analytical
and logical reasoning
here are some key concepts of data
analysis first understanding popular
data analytics tools like Apache Spa
Tableau and SAS can be greatly helpful
in the process of data analysis
then we have Google analytics Google
analytics is a tool that helps
businesses analyze their website
intercourse activities of users visiting
your website along with additional
information like their age gender and
interests
this is then sent to the Google
analytics server and then can be used by
you to make decisions regarding upcoming
campaigns
then we have data visualization
data visualization enables data to be
translated into a chart graph or other
visual component understanding data
visualization would help with
understanding data in a quick and clean
manner it enables Brands to identify
emergent Trends and to respond to it
quickly
with it the Brand Story can also be
shared with others thanks to being able
to create a narrator with graphics and
diagrams
and finally a clear understanding of
data structures fundamentals and basic
statistics can greatly ease the process
of data analysis
now let's have a look at some
certifications here we have introduction
to data analytics for business by kosera
then we have data analyst Masters
program by simply learn and finally we
have micromasters program and marketing
analytics by edx hey guys welcome to
this video on digital marketing career
jobs resume salary skills roles and
responsibilities
so without further Ado let's jump right
into it
the 21st century has given us many
things to be thankful for from
technology to healthcare our lives have
greatly improved for the better and many
of these things wouldn't have been
possible without the internet
not counting about the several ways it
has improved Our Lives the internet has
also made the life of marketers a whole
lot easier
earlier unless you had lots of money or
were very popular your Brand's
popularity would be limited to your
locality
but thanks to the internet you can
advertise your content to anyone
anywhere in the world the whole world is
now your Marketplace
and that is because of digital marketing
which is the process of advertising
Goods services and your brand with the
help of digital channels like websites
social media platforms search engines
and so on digital marketing has the
following types
search engine optimization content
marketing social media marketing search
engine marketing affiliate marketing
native advertising marketing Automation
and email marketing
but you might be wondering who can
ensure these digital marketing concepts
are incorporated into a grants marketing
campaigns to ensure the best possible
output
a digital marketer of course
so now let's talk about everything
related to a digital marketer but before
we can get started let's go to a more
familiar setting on where a digital
marketer belongs and strives
the office now let's start by talking
about who is a digital marketer
a digital marketer is someone whose
objective is used digital channels like
search engines social media platforms
Affiliates and other opportunities to
generate leads and build brand awareness
everything the digital marketer is aimed
at helping the brand grow
but that's not where his or her
responsibilities end a digital marketer
is also responsible for developing and
managing marketing campaigns this means
that the success of the entire marketing
efforts of a brand or an organization
entirely depends on how competently a
digital marketer develops the marketing
campaign the work doesn't end there
though the digital marketer also needs
to manage the campaigns
next like we mentioned earlier he or she
needs to acquire leads and drive traffic
to the Brand's website taking advantage
of the digital channels we mentioned
earlier alongside providing high quality
content
the digital marketer also needs to
perform competitive analysis and
Industry benchmarking to understand what
kind of content works best within your
industry the kind of content that your
competition posts and what works for
them
they are also responsible for using
tools like buffer HootSuite and
sproutsocial to measure and optimize
marketing campaigns Based on data
obtained from the tools
and finally they are responsible for
improving brand awareness by advertising
the organizations or Brands content on
digital marketing channels
let's now talk about the skills required
to become a digital marketer
now let's have a look at the different
types of digital marketing their search
engine optimization content marketing
social media marketing search engine
optimization affiliate marketing and
email marketing
let's talk about search engine
optimization first
search engine optimization is the
process of improving the overall quality
and quantity of the organic traffic
coming to your website via search
engines
with SEO you're able to attract visitors
who would be actually interested in the
products or services that your brand is
offering without having to pay a single
penny
the process of SEO has two parts
on page and off-page SEO let's have a
look at each of them in detail
first let's have a look at on page SEO
on page or on-site SEO is a method of
search engine optimization that involves
the optimization of elements on a
website like its content or HTML code to
help increase the amount of traffic
coming to your website and improve its
search engine rankings
it also helps users easily understand
what page is all about and whether or
not your page addresses their search
query
on page SEO is possible with the help of
keyword research technical audits
on-site optimizations and enhanced user
experiences
next we have off-page SEO off page or
off-site SEO refers to actions taken
outside your website to affect your
rankings in search engine resolved pages
it involves promotional methods to
improve search engine and user
perception of your site's popularity
relevance trustworthiness and Authority
off-page SEO can also be performed with
the help of Link building which is
getting other websites to link back to
your website
the popular SEO tools are Moz Google
Keyword Planner semrush and ahrefs
next up we have content marketing
content marketing refers to the process
of marketing that focuses on creating
and sharing valuable relevant and
consistent content like blogs videos
infographics and case studies to bring
the attention of a targeted online
audience to the Brand's products and
services
the process of content marketing
involves firstly to decide what goal you
want to achieve with your marketing
campaign do you want more subscribers
more conversions increased leads
that's what you need to decide here
then you need to set up buyer personas a
buyer Persona is a profile created based
on Research that represents the Target
customer that might enjoy your products
or services
with this you can identify the ideal
audience that might be interested in
your content
next you'll need to perform a Content
audit it involves taking a look at all
the content on your website and
assessing its relative strengths and
weaknesses in order to prioritize your
future marketing activities
then you need to choose a Content
management system of your choosing there
are a number of options available like
WordPress MailChimp and square size
you'll need to keep brainstorming for
new forms of content that'll attract the
attention of new audience
you will need to focus on a particular
form of content you want to focus on and
finally you will need to publish and
manage your content
now let's talk about popular content
marketing tools there's buffer basumu
follower wonk and HootSuite
let's now talk about the next type of
digital marketing that is social media
marketing
social media marketing refers to a form
of marketing that involves the usage of
social media platforms to connect with
your audience to build a brand to
increase sales and to drive traffic
you'll need to listen to and engage with
followers analyze results and run social
media advertisements the process of
social media marketing involves like
before you first need to determine what
goal you want to achieve you will need
to determine whether you need increased
conversions email signups lead
generation or any other marketing goal
at this stage you'll need to determine
what your audience enjoys the most
you'll need to find out which files get
the most amount of Engagement likes or
shares then you'll need to research
about your competition within your niche
see what kinds of content they post what
content of theirs receives the most
engagement from Their audience and how
you can make similar content
you will then need to perform a social
media audit through which you can
analyze content on your social media
profile and understand their strengths
and weaknesses to determine what kinds
of content you can post
then you will need to create an account
on a social media platform of your
choice like LinkedIn Facebook Instagram
Twitter or YouTube and start creating
marketing strategies on how to make the
most out of them
you should also take into consideration
other brands that have already
established themselves in social media
for inspiration
you can analyze what kind of content
they post and how you can replicate the
same you will then need to create a
social media calendar these are
spreadsheets or applications that will
enable you to plan your social media
posts in advance
you can plan when content will be shared
manage them and track the deadlines
finally you will need to keep testing
evaluating and making adjustments to
your marketing campaigns to finally
reach the sweet spot where you have a
perfect social media marketing campaign
here are some of the popular social
media marketing tools there is HootSuite
tweet deck Sprout social and buffer just
to name a few
next up let's have a look at search
engine marketing
search engine marketing or sem is a
marketing process that involves websites
increasing the amount of traffic as well
as their visibility on search engine
result Pages by taking advantage of paid
advertising
let's now take a look at the process of
search engine marketing
first off as usual is to determine what
goal you want to achieve with your sem
campaign more leads conversions
subscriptions you decide
then you will need to research what
kinds of keywords you want to advertise
on
this is a really important decision that
carries a lot of monetary weight as
choosing the wrong keywords may have
your brand competing against large ones
in a bidding battle you have no chance
of winning
you will then need to decide on what
keywords you want to advertise and then
start bidding on them to ensure that the
user sees your ad when they search for
that particular keyword
you will need to set up a headline for
your ad campaigns as a well-written
headline for your ad can make the
difference between a potential customer
coming to your website and buying your
products and then being completely
turned off by your brand
you will need to monitor your campaigns
and measure how well you're doing so
that you can make the appropriate
adjustments and finally you will need to
make sure you make regular optimizations
and adjustments based on the data you've
collected and retarget potential
customers to renew their interest in
your brand
some popular search engine marketing
tools are Google ads Facebook ads
manager ad role and binge ads just to
name a few next up let's take a look at
affiliate marketing
affiliate marketing is the process of
paying an affiliate who could be a
particular website or other entity to
advertise a Merchant's products the
affiliate usually promotes the product
and earns a commission for each sale
they make
this is usually done using referrals via
registrations email signups conversions
and subscriptions here's the process of
affiliate marketing first you will need
to decide the affiliate Network you want
to choose the affiliate network is like
a favor for both merchants and
Affiliates here a merchant gets to
decide which affiliate they want to work
with and vice versa
Merchant you will need to set up
specific rules guidelines image
specifications commission costs and
other details that an affiliate needs to
accept before they can apply to
advertise for you
after this Affiliates apply to advertise
on the Merchant's behalf
the merchants decide which affiliate
they want to go with and would be the
best representation of their brand
now once an affiliate has been selected
he or she places ads on their website or
the platform of their choosing
advertising the Merchant's products
interested customers then click on these
ads and are sent to the Merchant's
website
if customers make a purchase the
affiliate Network makes a note of it the
transaction is then validated and
credited to the affiliate and finally
the affiliate is given his or her
commission and likewise the process
repeats itself
here are some of the popular affiliate
marketing tools we have CJ affiliate
volume
even and has offers just name a few
again
now we are having a look at the last
type of digital marketing and that is
email marketing email marketing is the
process of using personalized emails to
convert prospective users into potential
customers here's the process of email
marketing first you decide on what goal
you want to achieve with your email
marketing campaign then you decide what
kind of emails you want to send is it a
welcome email a newsletter a lead
nurturing email a re-engagement email
that's what you've got to decide here
next you can choose an email marketing
tool of your choosing these tools can
help you with templates for emails
create email lists Track Performance and
do much more you will then need to
attract users with a reason to subscribe
to your emails with attractive opt-in
advantages like exclusive access to
sales discounts and so on
you will need to plan emails and their
respective follow-ups with an email
calendar
you will also need to create an
attractive subject line and copy that
will attract the attention of potential
customers
but the job isn't done after creating an
attractive subject line in copy your
email also has to have an attractive
design and finally you will need to
perform a or b tests and use analytics
to measure how well your campaign is
doing
based on this you can make the
appropriate adjustments to make sure the
upcoming campaigns are a success
popular email marketing tools are
MailChimp HubSpot send in blue and
Marketo just to name a few now let's
take a look at some digital marketer
carriers
here are some of the most popular job
roles you can have we'll be talking
about the salaries of these job roles
courtesy of Glassdoor first we have
digital marketing manager a digital
marketing manager earns approximately 75
000 per annum in the US in India he or
she can earn approximately 7 lakh rupees
per annum next we have SEO manager in
the United States and SEO manager earns
approximately 62 000 per annum whereas
in India an SEO manager earns
approximately 5 lakhs per annum then we
have search engine marketing or PPC
expert a PPC expert in the US earns
approximately 74 000 per annum whereas
in India a PPC expert can earn
approximately 4 lakh rupees per annum
next up we have the social media manager
in the US a social media manager earns
approximately fifty thousand dollars per
annum in India he or she can earn
approximately 5 lakhs per annum and
finally we have the content marketing
manager a Content marketing manager can
earn approximately 65
000 in the United States in India he or
she can earn approximately 5 lakh rupees
per annum let's have a look at a sample
digital marketer resume first off you
start off with the usuals like name
address and the other stuff following
this you will need to add a brief
summary three of your years of
experience and the different important
skills you have experienced with in this
case this person has two years of
experience in just about every important
type of digital marketing
your summary can vary based on the job
role you're looking for you give them
links to your socials and then add
experience
this is the part where you can highlight
your achievements during your years of
work
here you can see how this person has
brought growth in just about every
channel he's gotten into the most
important part to remember here is that
the stuff you add here must be
quantitative with actual stats about how
your work brought growth to your
organization
again depending on the job role you're
applying for you can choose to elaborate
on some of your achievements over others
then you can cover the different tools
you've got experience with make sure you
add relevant tools related to this job
role you're looking for for example for
the role of a sem expert having
experience with Google ads and Google
analytics is mandatory so that has to be
a part of this list
you can add concise details about your
education and then talk about the
courses you've completed having
completed the right courses can have a
significant impact on your higher
ability
and with that we have come to the end of
this digital marketing full course for
2021. I hope it was informative and
interesting if you have any questions
about the topics covered in this video
please ask away in the comment section
below our team will help you solve your
queries thanks for watching stay safe
and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here